gold I love it and the hair tone to
match yes thank you thank you
guys how you doing I'm doing real good
I'm just grateful to live this moment
yeah this is a big moment for you
tonight yes indeed so how have you been
all day is it are you nervous or there
excitement are you just chill we've been
chilling in the hotel we've been um
getting ready and real I mean I'm real
I'm saying about the nomination you want
won I won you yeah we're celebrating
come on smile smile bigger than that you
we are smiling we are smiling so how
does it feel to be a Grammy winner it it
feels great it feels awesome it's a
dream come true now you can exhale and
just have fun tonight right yes yes
we're celebrating now with my beautiful
girlfriend right here and you look
amazing you didn't want to come up here
look she didn't want to come up here but
she look so good when she walked out
what were you like no she uh she looks
amazing you looks amazing oh thank you
so much so much thank you so this is um
you had your first tour in the US last
year with I I don't know what like 50
something sold out shows yeah it was it
was a great tour and this tour is going
to be bigger I love what is that like
when you walk out and you see the house
is just so full and they're there for
you I don't know I'm just real thankful
with people that hears and supports my
music every day and I know they're
waiting for a for a for a new album and
for new music so wait what are you going
to do at Coachella what can they expect
from that performance it's going to look
great it's going to look awesome you
have to be there yeah yes so I know
people are waiting for new music are you
in the studio are you writing are you
are you recording already I'm doing
everything at the same time I'm I'm just
working and keep grinding and I think it
says here that your third album Genesis
was the most streamed um first day music
Urbana album on Spotify already like you
had the most streams yeah I think so
yeah I'm I'm just I'm just happy to be
here you know well I mean there's so
much happening for you this year now
time has Time Magazine has named you one
of the 100 next big artists so do is
there a pressure to like live up to all
of these things that are happening no
pressure no pressure at all I'm just
living my life loving to make music yes
okay who's on the collaboration front
for you now who's the next person you
say okay I'm I want to do something the
person I'm going standing next to so do
you get it do you make music together
yes we make music together sis come on
and it's a song coming out what is the
song's name oh you have to wait for that
look see there you go you have a good
you're going to have to wait for
that Taylor where's Travis tonight
where's Travis Taylor you look
incredible can we get
[Music]
away
he
T
CH
[Applause]
[Music]
t
l
come on
[Music]
right Che
right
[Music]
right to your right Tay Tay to your
right tayor tayor to your right to your
right Tay
Tay
[Music]
come on come
on
[Music]
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say finally here yeah okay so you can
exhale now how does it feel we're
celebrating tonight yeah yeah it feel
good you know what I'm saying finally to
make it here um and be here for my own
purpose you I mean you've been nominated
four times you win tonight now can you
just relax and enjoy the show and what
are you most looking forward to seeing
um I'm just here to experience it I'm
saying it feel good to be here got my
wife with me this bad I mean when she
walks out looking like this what do what
are what are we saying cuz good God
never let go of
hand I love that so much is there
anybody that you know that's performing
tonight that you're that you like are
excited um I'm honestly uh excited about
the whole show you know what I'm saying
like I say it feel good to be here yeah
you you were just in Kanye and taala
sign's video right so I mean when you're
making music with them like I what's the
what's the process like um just to sum
it all up Evil Genius because it's the
lead single to his upcoming album so
you've seen it and I mean he's been
teasing what we're going to get and he
is I think those are great words for him
Evil Genius Evil Genius Evil Genius sh
out exactly he recently posted on IG I
think tell Dirk to activate tell Dirk to
activate his IG it's time to drop I'm a
couple days late but since we got the
good news I had to yeah yeah yeah so
what what did you did you post already
I'm post I got to post I got to post
these outfits tonight uh the wars
tonight so I'm feeling good tonight I
was going to say what does the night
bring cuz y'all look too good to just go
home um it's a change of plan we got to
go back to the drawing board since we
won right it was going to be low ke but
now you like no I got to celebrate my
baby yes yes I love that so much so good
to see you congratulations what's the
next I mean you know you got yay and
but who's the next collab or who's the
next person on your list somebody that
we wouldn't think that you would want to
work with that you really want to work
with um I want to say who y'all think I
wouldn't but I'll say Morgan wall really
that is somebody I didn't think you
would say yeah it's going to be a cloud
outb soon okay so you guys are going to
work together that's interesting vaps so
so so that mean I'll see you again next
year know you see what I'm saying Come
on talk your stuff I love it so much you
guys have a great night tonight who okay
who did this look by the way
la la shout out La Roach Oh La Roach did
it love it love it well you look
spectacular good luck have a great night
tonight guys okay good to see y'all
okay hold on you just won yes I just won
what the heck like it's crazy it's crazy
okay what does this mean though to win
this award for a song that everyone
loves I mean this one over
here
always what' I tell you H it's amazing
it's I'm so proud of myself so proud of
South Africa Africa it's a win for us
all so I'm just super blessed have any
has anybody called you yet from Africa
that is watching from South Africa
everybody blowing you up my phone it's
it's crazy my phone is blowing up yeah
it's blowing up everybody calling
everyone celebrating it's a huge moment
it's amazing did you just see JT Jam in
the water did you see that that just
Timberlake was I never see that yes yes
he
was everybody loves this song justtin
Timberlake I'm singing JT yes I did see
that that's crazy that's crazy you saw
it yeah I saw it it's amazing I I I
can't believe it I'm a lost for words
Janet Jackson was vibing to it Oprah
like it's God
it's gone okay when you made this song
what did you think when you made the
song when I made it I knew it was
special I knew like I loved it my family
loved it I had a dream about the song so
I feel like I knew in my spirit that
this was the one how are you celebrating
tonight hey I'm going
out we have to we have you have to and
then you have to go home and celebrate
in South Africa everywhere I'm going I'm
celebrating now yeah show One More Time
come on come on me make
me yes got she got it she needs to teach
me how to do the dance cuz I okay hold
on okay will you teach her cuz she does
she does it all the time so
it's wait this way or this way there you
go I'll give you private L she's like
keep trying this I'm going to give you
the private Lon congratulations
congratulations will you tell us about
the dress real quick yes so I'm wearing
custom
faace cute um I love it I L working with
them on the design and yeah it just came
out perfect I couldn't have asked for a
better outfit for my first
Grammys yeah congratulations it's it's
the hit of the year I mean everybody
loves that
song come on you want them take over
take the mic hello don't say anything
crazy hello we're at the Grammys Janelle
Monae and I wonderful wonderful night
you know what I love this there is
nothing better than a family night at
the Grammys and what does it mean to
have your mom here to enjoy this well
one I could not imagine winning a Grammy
and my mom not be there like it was so
important as you can see she's a ball of
energy she's my she's my foundation so I
was like if I win a Grammy I want my
mama here so it's a beautiful thing to
have her with me yes it is album of the
honor it's an honor right yes Prince
will be so
happy album of the year though what is
that Progressive yes but when you put
that album together it you said you're
going to do something different and
you're going to do it your way and you
did that's what I'm saying she's
creeping up on that isn't she yeah
listen I I I try my best in my art to
represent um my community in a in a deep
way in making music and art for us and
most of the time it was rooted in
Seeking Justice for us yes this time
around I wanted joy for us Justice and
joy it can coexist and that's what the
age of pleasure was about uh making sure
that we felt safe enough to feel free
enough to be ourselves even more and
unapologetically and so I'm just so
happy that me being here represents a
community of marginalized folks who are
smiling who are happy who are working
through the pain you know uh of of of of
the the the Pains of life and and
finding Solace and finding love in one
another I think that you are one of the
voices out there especially among black
women who are telling things
authentically their way and it's been
important because you've freed up a
whole Community has come out I I might
be in love with your mama I'm going be
honest with you I love I love your love
the real star I need my own talk show
guys I am so
funny we G to get you your own talk show
so much it is the uh my other uh
producers who worked on the project I
want to go take some photos with them
cuz some it's their first time here I've
been here a couple times so I'm going to
run over there really fast tell me about
that dress real quick thank you it's mon
PR Couture uh it's custom and I'm just
so I feel so good I feel so Timeless I
feel futuristic I Feel Like Me Mama did
you just touch my
Bo your mom is the great you might stay
here I might keep your mom right here I
might keep your mom I might give your
mom right
here did you see that they were singing
your song on SNL last
night
I saw the clip and I I was watching I
was like where does the song come in and
then all of a sudden she burst into song
O capella and I was like this is awesome
there's been a couple times that they've
shouted me out this year so thanks guys
isn't that kind of special though that
people are recognizing your music your
career on such a large platform yes well
and I mean all these years later as well
like I'm just so grateful that my music
has spanned kind of the test of time
it's a classic and that's what I'm going
to continue to do okay so you were
nominated tonight you guys didn't win
but it was still great to be here and be
yes I mean to get nominated once is an
honor and then all this time later for
my peers to think that something of mine
is worthy to be nominated again is is
incredible so I'm grateful and how was
it working with King and Country how was
that easy it was so easy they are the
most kindest men that I've ever met
their wives as well their whole team
they've just been so great so they were
texting me earlier today like oh we
can't wait to see you so hopefully
they'll pop up here in a second I don't
know where they are but they were
amazing to work with okay so since I've
known you since you've been a young
woman when you made made your last video
with your husband a very grown and sexy
video yes what was that what was the
conversation like at home to when you
decided to make that video it was
actually my idea was it yeah I was like
it's time for you to show that sexy side
that I see to the world and so I feel
like we did that and it worked it worked
it worked it worked the internet will
tell you just go to YouTube and you'll
see it worked um what does it mean to
have someone that is there to support
you and Champion you each and every day
I mean it's please don't get me
emotional I already had to like get
everything together earlier but um I've
never had someone who supports me the
way that Dana supports me he honestly
wants to see me do the best that I can
do he puts me on his shoulders every day
he's like babe what about this what
about this what about this you should do
this he encourages me when I'm like I
don't know he pushes me outside of my
comfort zone like he's a great dad he's
a great an anr he's a great manager he's
all the things a great husband yeah this
one keep and I always love the way he
shows the sexy side between the two of
you that you you know you got children
but that ain't stopping the loving right
how you think the kids got here come
on I mean he's right he's not wrong all
right fun to be here tonight tell me
about this dress this is digmon and I
found it last minute at this amazing
showroom called The Show Must Go On and
yeah I put it on and just felt beautiful
and I felt that it represented where I
am now like I'm still a flower but don't
mess with me don't mess with you okay um
next videos what what is going to come
with the next videos go ahead babe not
me I I'm taking a break I'm taking a
break y'all can have her I'm going take
a break and we'll get another love
interest or something else it's stresses
about being in front of the camera can't
you see yeah that's a that's a lot he he
should be though you see this face he
should
be
[Music]
made it
happen
[Music]
come on come
on
[Music]
you look amazing my guy the long all of
it is working for me you did you are you
growing it for a project or did you just
decide like let me just I don't know
well to be honest like I was when I knew
that I I was going to have a baby yeah I
always wanted to have like that picture
of me with long hair I don't know just
you know like holding my baby and it's
like so organic so grounded I don't know
I just I just let my hair grow because I
feel I feel grounded right now in my
life I just like it like that I love the
How is suzan how's she doing she good oh
she's gray my baby's is growing pretty
fast in her in her mom's belly
everything is doing great are you I know
you said everything's great in light but
are you ready for this are you ready for
fatherhood well to be honest I I don't I
don't think you're always ready you know
I I would say like kids they don't come
with any manual so I just go with the
flow I really I really love her and I
and I love what I'm living right now I
can't imagine what's going to happen you
know but you're also having a girl and
you know what they say that does to a
man like you're done you're done yeah to
be honest that was a big Karma you know
you know I was like kind of refused when
I when I knew that I was going to become
a dad I kind of I was feeling that that
thing that I don't I didn't want to have
a girl you know because I knew that that
was going to be a Karma but I'm just
kidding I I love what's going on right
she's going to have you wrapped up so
tight that little girl is going to have
you that's what my dad tell me to
because I have a sister and all the
sisters so she's always like my daddy's
always like wait for wait for Paris to
be born man you're going to know what's
real love I love that you guys already
have decided what her name is going to
be did you was that just always in the
in the in the world yeah the thing is
that that's more like cultural you know
what I mean like there in Colombia we
think about names before we we know that
we're going to have babies you know so
I don't know and also a crazy fact is
that we actually had that moment in
Paris so Paris was yeah that's what he
is Paris yeah I love that so much okay I
know you got to go but it just um you
just recently made history you were as
the first urban uh
Urbana I can't talk Urbana artist to be
number one on both the Latin AirPlay and
also the regional Mexican charts come on
like is there nothing that you touch
that doesn't turn to Gold well yo thank
you well thank you very much I really
appreciate that the only thing I'm going
to say is that I'm going to miss not
winning the the Grammy you know what I
mean because I was nominated I'm
nominated today as best L album pop and
and it's I just wanted to Happ in my
arms so let's see if next year we're
going to have the chance to be nominated
again and maybe taking it home and then
you can come with Paris and your whole
family and it'll be all family going be
nice too you know I'm not in a rush I'm
just enjoying in my life enjoying the
moment that I'm living well have an
amazing time tonight it's always good to
see you my man and congratulations on
everything
okay hi Mommy hi I'm so I'm so happy for
you and you you know what I love about
it h is like you just like you radiate
this goodness and you just seem like you
are on top of the world right now is
that is that the case that is truly the
case I'm so excited to be here tonight
I'm like I'm with my boo I'm like having
the greatest time Bo your boo he was
just holding hand yeah yeah yeah I love
but yeah so it's date night y'all like
you got to take these when you can get
them because now that you're new parents
you're not going to get all those date
nights anymore so what does date night
bring for you guys oh my gosh we're so
excited to see the performances to chill
and to just be nominated is an honor so
I just can't believe I'm in this room
tonight yeah well you here baby you're
not going anywhere who are you um
excited to see
on the stage cuz there's going to be a
lot of iconic moments oh wow I'm so
excited to see everyone honestly I mean
I heard sciss performing so I can't wait
to see that the list could go on your
color purple sister frantasia is doing a
tribute to Tina Turner oh tonight be
amazing how has this run been for you I
know there was I was disappointed that
there was not a best picture nomination
that there was not a best picture
nomination for you guys for The Color
Purple I think you deserve it's one of
the best movies of the year but so how
has this ride been for you and now is it
like okay I really I kind of have the
acting bug so I'm going to do this for a
minute yeah I'm G to keep going I mean
acting has been so much fun for me a
beautiful new outlet and I'm excited to
take on more projects so now you're
about to break the internet with this
dress cuz the people are going to say
how she just have a b look at this how'
you just St back how' you just have a
baby I mean why when you saw this dress
what was it about it that made you say
this is it for this night oh I really
love this dress Gucci made it for me and
I feel confident I'm really excited I
think I was excited to kind of step back
and wear start wearing form fitting
stuff after pregnancy so it's it's been
really fun do you do you feel different
being a mama like is there is there an
added confidence is there just what what
changed for you yeah I definitely feel
more powerful and like more womanly you
know yeah I love that I love that so
well you guys are the cutest little
family have a good night listen you and
your sister shut down everybody here
tonight cuz she walked in here like I'm
having
my and she was so excited for us to call
her auntie oh yeah thank I love it have
a good night tonight good to see you
[Music]
baby hello love how are you oh honey
these earrings great to see baby hold on
a second I'm just Kidd they're
ridiculous okay I just feel like you and
David get a need to just do just do an
album I know I told him I said David
come on bro let's do an Al no but you
know what we're working on it seriously
you guys have the the sauce together so
we do we do but we we know it's it's a
it's a LoveHate relationship more in
love but he called me his annoying
little sister and I was like excuse me
if I'm your annoying little sister then
you're my annoying older brother right
there you go you want the old mon man
yeah exactly I think maybe sometimes
that's the best way to make music you
know what I'm saying when it's like you
know you get on my nerves you get on my
nerves but then here comes the magic
that's the best that's the best music
yeah yeah I love it so much so tonight
um what I love about the Grammys are
those collaborations or what we see on
happening on the stage anybody that
you're like okay this is I'm I'm excited
honestly I'm excited to see daa I got to
support her my Albanian Queen um I'm I'm
excited to see Lana I just saw her pass
by and I just think her music's so
amazing and I think it's finally Lana's
time to shine um so I'm really excited
for her honestly the girls listen you
okay you took the words right out of my
mouth I was talking to Billy Joel ear oh
my gosh how was that well first of all I
God I just cracked I had to say to him I
said um I have to admit that I'm nervous
right now because you're it's you but
he's performing for the first time in 30
years on the Grammy stage tonight and I
said to him like who do you love right
now and what he said is Olivia Rodrigo
Billy ish Taylor Swift like like d and
that's what he said he said something
about what the women are doing right now
is special is another level why do you
think that because I believe it too I
just feel like we're in an ER what you
what's the girls doing let me think let
me think about this answer I just feel
like the girls are just doing what they
want yeah you know what I mean the more
empowered that we get the more power
that we get like like we're just kind of
standing in our own and it's time like
you know I have such like I want to see
who oh it's Carol oh I got to go say hi
but yeah but anyway
Caesar anyways sorry no but I love this
is like on the I actually do have it
like on the red carpet is not good it's
like a family reunion here though it is
you get to see people you haven't seen
you get to hang out again I love I want
you to enjoy every minute of this night
I love seeing you okay tell me a little
something what's the drama you're giving
us for this look I all black everything
Robert W like black widow Vibes I'm
newly
single okay call me all right are we are
we taking suitors are we taking time uh
uh fun okay I like the I like I like
single you I like single you cuz there's
a sass there's a confident you stand a
little tall leg up and this face is beat
thank
you number one album in the country
you're rolling here and you you're a
superstar tonight but what does that
mean to have the number one album in the
country uh it just feel good like got my
hard work paying off and the nominations
tonight also to be recognized because we
know for a long time the Grammys will
Overlook artists right we know that but
to do the work and then have it
recognized what does that mean to you it
feel good it's a good feeling yeah yeah
for sure okay great collaborations right
but if you win tonight where's the party
W I'm going probably party at my hotel I
don't really like party lay low yeah you
laying low tonight yeah but it's also
got to be cool like Lenny krait's right
there rolling with seeing all the stars
and everybody would you ever collab with
Lenny yeah for sure a legend he's a
right right that's what I'm saying hold
on watch wait wait we're going to tell
him we're going to tell him right now
let's tell Lenny grait that you need to
do a collab hold on one second we're
going to tell him hold on we're going to
tell him right now cuz he need if
anybody needs to be on his next record
is you we appreciated it so so much
Nelle Nelle right thank you Nelle tell
Lenny 21 Savage wants to be on your next
record he's losing
his what's happening man
let's do it good yeah let's do it let's
do it you too all right man yeah for
sure see we're we're working out things
here this is what the Grammys are about
this is a collab we're waiting for right
21 Savage and ly KRA sure that's a
collaboration that we need don't play we
need this right I'm for real all right
get it can you do something for me
21 all right tell me about SNL oh yeah
I'm doing SNL on the 24th yeah on the
24th but what do you what do you got
planned nobody goes to SNL and just
surprise who's going to be with you will
you have anybody with you what I'm going
have some people with me oh you're
bringing some folk yeah like who come on
I can't tell you but it'll be something
special yeah for
sure I haven't had a chance to
congratulate you first of all since the
Emy I've have not seen you come on in
here come on it's a it was a family win
she perfect everybody you should have
congratulated you because no but let me
tell you why you should have
congratulated you and people didn't
mention this that people told you you
couldn't do serious stuff that people
told you that you were just a funny lady
you should be off to the side do your
funny thing and stop yeah and you said
damn it I'm going to show you I got to
show you I got to show you something and
you showed the whole world and it's been
thing after not one but it's been thing
after thing after thing after thing so I
just make me cry my fake eyelashes off
I'm at the Grammys but I was just so
happy for that moment because you
manifested that you said I'mma go and
show y'all you know I had a wonderful
support system and uh and we were able
to bring home that award and I've been
I'm still floating you should be
floating by the way where is the award
at home in in the front actually in the
front door soon as you walk soon as you
walk in it sings to you it's like wo
right there with my big bouquet that I
got from Oprah yes yes this really isn't
your night it's your night cuz you're
the musician in the family so what is it
that makes the Grammy so special oh
being able to be among so many amazing
musicians and artists and uh people that
I've looked up to for over the years so
I'm excited to be here Kevin I I love
that I got invited on a DAT normally I'm
like hey come with me to this thing and
now she's like you want to go to the
gramy I'm like
okay I'm going to take you yeah you're
my day um I also want to talk about
origin because it has been doing well in
the theaters it expanded to a to more um
audiences now why is it so important for
people to see this movie wow for such a
time as this it it it it opens your mind
it invites you to think differently and
to unlearn some things so it it's
definitely a must SE it's a must SE it
really is a movie that will change it's
not like we go to movies to escape and
have fun but this one it changes your
life forever absolutely very powerful
message I think it's a masterpiece so I
enjoyed
[Music]
it
e
[Music]
okay so first of all mom Night Out how'd
you get away and are the what are the
babies doing I was just with them they
are at home just playing together it's
so sweet so feel so blessed and so lucky
how is motherhood because I know you
were ready you waited you know and then
what does it mean to you to finally be a
mother especially because of the love
that you have for your mom my life just
feels so complete my husband my two
beautiful babies just feels like all my
dreams come true and I just feel so
filled and just happy at life okay Paris
the DJ is here tonight though right
you're Paris the DJ what is it what are
you looking for tonight and who are you
excited to see I'm just excited to see
so many of my favorite artists I'm
excited for Miley's nominated six times
she is such an icon and I'm just so
excited for my second album C is
executive producing it what can you okay
so what can you tell me about the album
the album is mean a lot of amazing
badass females on it and a lot of
surprises and it's all about my journey
and everything that I've went through in
my life and I'm just so excited and
honored to have CA executive producing
and writing all the music with
me okay so do your kids love it when you
play music for them do you play music
for them what do you play for them my
kids love music Phoenix just got a
little piano for his first birthday so
he's been playing on the piano and he
loves stars are blind it's his favorite
lullabi since he was born man Paris this
has been such a crazy journey I mean I
can think back to way way back in the
day and all the trials and tribulations
and all that stuff and when you think of
that what would you if you could whisper
in your ear and tell yourself something
what would you say say you're going to
go through a lot in life and one day
you're going to have the most beautiful
perfect life and family so keep going
girl you kept going you kept going it's
good to see you anything else parents
that's coming up um just everything
about to release my 30th
fragrance and wait wait a minute your
30th 30th
yes I know what does this one smell like
it's just the most beautiful unique
scent I've ever smelled before it's my
favorite perfume ever won't you get into
the baby clothes business or something
doing children's stuff too yes we have
children's furniture and children's
clothing and doing a huge deal with
Walmart so everything will be out very
soon wow so when can we see that stuff
that will be out by this fall with my
new clothing line and Jewelry and
Handbags damn Paris you do every you
never stop do you there is no slowing
you down is there there's nothing
slowing me down can you tell us a secret
about your fashion tonight tonight well
I'm wearing this gorgeous mermaid gown
and then I had this custom made for my
handbag line cuz I'm representing Hilton
tonight CU they're a big part of the
awards and just wanted to represent
Hilton for the
stay you really went all the way in
Queen right you will Market one thing
you will do is Market something right I
invented
it that's real actually some people
copied right some people copied you but
you it's nothing like the original how
has it been living life in the Paris
Hilton Fishbowl but you guys have a very
normal life you have kids now so
everything has to be normal it's just
amazing watching Paris be a mom we love
to just stay home play with the babies
watching her mother is pretty awesome
yeah and what is Paris Hilton the mom
like uh well let's see the other day I
came home Paris was on a motorized
scooter and Phoenix was following her
around and they were doing relay races
so let's just say she's a fun and a
sliving mom sliving
mom I love it thanks have a great
day okay first of all all the
nominations how how good does it feel to
be that your peers love you it feels
incredible like I never expected for
nomin ations and I'm just just so happy
like I'm so excited yes okay um are you
excited for the Super Bowl commercial I
am I am shout out to Star they held it
down period what was it like shooting a
Super Bowl commercial how big is it
going to be cuz that's the biggest day
of the year the commercials are better
than game half time yeah they are um I
don't know I'm just really excited the
commercial was fun it was my second
commercial ever and um yeah it was it
was a little bit of a challenge filming
but we got why because lemon lime wasn't
actually present so I was talking to
nobody really but oh so you kind of just
talking to the green screen we was just
you know getting our little acting out
more music coming right yes album
dropping this year y 2K tune in when
when when is it dropping
2024 that's all you can tell me come on
now yes that's all okay tell me about
collabs or anybody that's on there I
can't let that be known yet but my fans
will be very pleased 2023 was an insane
year so to cap it off now with the
Grammys in 2024 what would that mean to
you it just means everything I'm just so
happy to be acknowledged and you know
it's a big deal to
me okay I don't know what was happening
I don't know what's going on there's a
lot going on there's a lot like your
2023 yeah exactly enjoy the night okay
all right and good
luck on did you know that this song was
going to blow up like it did like it was
going to take the World by storm no no I
mean one lives in Hope but uh no I had
no idea I was seeing P now I'm like Pam
red pam pam can you explain bam to me
please well within the within the song
it's the heartbeat you
know but Pam took on a you know a myriad
of uh of
meanings and at the time when it came
out first came out it was a greeting it
was a farewell it was who knows what
whatever you
like and it is such like people lose it
in clubs when they play it have you had
a chance to be in like do you sometimes
sneak into the club and you hear it and
everybody's goes crazy well I had a few
moments when we were doing listening
parties and just the place erupted I was
kind of faux DJing like literally just
press play but I was quite comfortable
there yeah I do what does it also mean
to stay relevant with folks in
generation after generation after
generation which is very very cool well
obviously means a lot to me me but I
feel like this current moment for myself
is beyond me that others might look at
what I've achieved and and go hey that's
you know she's broken a fair number of
rules in her time and and you can it can
be done you can achieve anything you
want anytime yeah I mean of course you
know it's uh we we never stop working
but it's it's a great moment and I think
I've been doing this long enough to
really actively be cognizant that this
this is a great moment amongst the
madness I'm I'm is it that as we get
older we start to realize how precious
these moments are is that what it is
entirely yeah so to still be here to to
um to have won tonight do you know that
I won hold are you won I
won wait a minute oh you won well I
didn't know you this when I first like
yes I got two
now
wow where where are you going to put
this Grammy next to the other
one I thought you'd build like some kind
of special place for this uh it'll it'll
come back to Australia with me okay tell
me your speech cuz we didn't get to hear
the speech so tell me there was it was
in the pre-show and I was getting ready
so I got the news in my uh robe my
dressing gown kind of ready I screamed I
cried I was shaking and I had to stop
before you went to the ugly just like
trying we've just she's ready don't undo
it all with with tears but I was so were
you watching were you watching the
stream or were you getting a you got a
call I I my manager came to the came to
the door and came in saying two time
Grammy that's all she got out I I I
screamed it it's all it's on my it's on
my Instagram yeah you just lost it I
lost it it was a great moment and then I
had to get back to focus cuz you look
great right now so clearly you pulled it
back together and got everything I I
brought it back from the brink yeah okay
well Kylie Mano two time Grammy winner
have an amazing night great to see you
thank you tell us about this dress yes
um well I thought I'd come put d red and
it's do gabana my good friends and if ID
facted in the rain I might have done
without the the train situation but just
get a little wet that's that's all right
bam badam to you okay by
thank you all for joining us here on ET
for all of your coverage from the 2024
Grammy Awards and never forget you can
always catch us on etonline.com take
[Music]
care
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say am I a member because I got the
memo come on now
great I got the
memo I think I think I just joined
pentatonics
everybody well y'all know first of all
y'all know that you do the music does it
for me all the time so I mean it does
it's first of all it's like music is
healing anyway but your music is so
joyous and it's just like a feast for
the ear so it just makes me happy and I
mean everybody thinks that you're here
because you're nominated again so of
course oh my gosh yes we can't believe
we're nominated for an album we put so
much heart and soul into it's a it's a
world holiday album where we celebrated
all these different cultures and learned
about their music and their culture and
how they celebrate the holidays we
collaborated with the most iconic
artists from all these different
countries and it was so fulfilling and
such a beautiful Journey making this
album so to see it celebrated by our
peers in this way it's just surreal it's
the only word I can think of do y'all
ever feel like us like if you're in the
studio you're recording something then
you hear like oh damn we just did that I
mean seriously do you ever feel like
that DN yeah sometime especially because
we're such fans of each other too you
know so like when I hear a certain thing
it's not things Kevin it just inspires
us to keep going and keep pushing
further and so it's it's like we feel
like kids in the playground like they
get to play in the sandbox you know okay
how do you decide like when you hear
your name called who gets to say who
gets to speak give the speech of oh we
haven't even talked about it now I'm
creating problems we're figuring it out
right here right
now I think I'd be so nervous and like
shocked so I would probably Mama's got
diamonds so Mama should be able to do it
oh yeah just going to go here well
hopefully they won't leave me behind
because I'm going to have to Shimmy
Shimmy onto the guys are part of the
opening ceremony for the premiere
ceremony yeah with like Jordan Sparks
and Jay Ivy and all of that what was
that moment oh my gosh it was so good we
did Prince Let's Go Crazy everybody was
just unbelievable it's so cool to see
such diversity of Talent on one stage
and that's what I think makes the
Grammys so just unbelievably iconic that
all these artists from completely
different walks of life can be on the
same stage and showcase their talent but
it all is working harmoniously together
it's it's just the coolest thing I feel
so blessed that we get to do this each
other everyone was so kind we were all
like hyping each other up and it was
just such a fun song and a fun way to
like start our Grammy day all right so
what's coming up next that's a great
question you know I think what we've
talked about a
lot baby girl come I Sheila E bust into
your interview come
on we just perform together we just
talking about
it we were just talking about how cool
it was for all these different talents
to get together open up the ceremony
kind of celebrate music and celebrate
each other oh absolutely it was amazing
I had a blast I mean I get to play with
them come on
really she she gave a master class on
energy like I it was amazing to watch
you perform and like taking the the the
mic and everything and just I did the
simp like master class thank you thank
you thank you something happens to her
when she gets on those
Dr what oh my gosh yes it was
unbelievable well thank you guys so much
Sheila you stick
around find each other in like a very
similar G up no we're like sparkles
sparkles you know yes and this is giving
tonight so was it when you saw it on the
rack when you put it on what was it
about it this is a custom dress by k um
that was made for me um I feel very
excited to wear it I feel very strong in
it it's definitely a heavy like metal
dress so I was like feel very
jonok no but for real yes well listen
You' had a very strong year I'm having
I'm having fun so the last time I talked
to you at the Golden Globes you were
telling me about your new music and you
were saying you know this record is
about understanding your wor and
different chapters of your life so on
the 15th we're getting this on okay so
what are you what are you giving on the
so on the 15th like you said a new so I
mean it'll be late in the evening on the
15th but um a new song which is just
about kind of knowing how
to it's almost like not expecting PE to
for people to like love you right yeah
you know yeah you're just like preach
baby training seon's over you know
you're done teaching people how to do
things right exactly come correct or
don't come at all or don't come at all
exactly that's the vibe that's the vibe
I love that so much I can't wait cuz it
does feel like this record is going to
be a very personal one for you I'm isn't
it it you know I I got to do most of the
record at home in
London um I just felt like and I feel
like with every album I get to grow more
and learn more about myself and I become
more free as a songwriter and as a
performer and as an artist so this one
I'm just like digging deeper and deeper
I love it I'm I'm proud of this part of
you as an artist that says I'm a little
nervous because this year for you like
has been in the stratosphere as far as
music is concerned you know what I'm
saying and I mean just career in General
but is there a part of you that's like
okay now I got to follow up with like
just an incredible year that I I mean
there's always pressure there's always
pressure but I think for as long as I'm
doing things that I'm proud of things
that I love things that I feel like I'm
pushing myself and trying out something
different and I'm growing as an artist
and as a person then I'm good you know
but the groomies is also about the
performances and what's going to happen
on stage so what can we expect oh we got
something special for you guys tonight
she gives the smile like the biggest
smile I'm really really excited about
this performance like more more so than
any three words give me in three words
what this performance is going to oh my
God we we have it's
like it's intense okay uh it's
strong and uh it's dony okay I love it
so you you have two nominations tonight
dance the night away we're still dancing
to it so I mean when you think about
that song when you were making it did
you think okay I got
I got something here like this is I mean
I know you didn't know what it was going
to do but but were you like okay yeah I
got something here yeah I mean in the
moment again it goes back to that thing
for as long as I feel like I'm having
fun or making something that I'm really
proud of and I'm in the moment then I'm
I'm exactly where I'm supposed to be and
I feel that way with you know when we
were making Dance T night we were having
such a great time in the studio it felt
so good to be a part of such an
incredible project it felt so good to do
it with my friends that whole experience
as a whole was really special so
um yeah I'm I'm happy that that's like
way out into the world now and like had
its own life and it's it's been great
well finally I was in London didn't get
to talk to you there but I was there for
Argy you have this movie coming out it
is fun fun fun in so many ways and you
get to cut up a little bit in this movie
and get a little dancing going on I did
get to do a little bit I mean I have a a
small role but I'm I loved working on a
film set and for Matthew Vaughn to give
me that opportunity I'm so grateful for
it and I had fun with my co-stars with
Henry caval and John Cena and are you
and John the new Hollywood Duo that we
didn't know we needed uh I don't know if
our acting career will continue together
um but I anytime I see him it's an
absolute pleasure and I I loved working
with him and he's so wonderful so who
knows he told me he was so embarrassed
because he had to sing off key to you
and he was like why am I doing this to
myself he was he's such a good sport
honestly he wasn't even off key I think
he just so humble that he's just you
know it's it's it was wonderful
really it was what made this year
possible we decided it before we even
recorded that it was going to be a
limited time and it's part of why we've
like given so much to this we can't
sustain this level of doing personally
yeah boy Genius opening up about their
Hiatus after winning at the 2024 gramys
the Grammy goes
to not strong enough Bo it's just like
isn't
real uh yeah thank you uh thank you to
our band uh thank you to everyone that
uh contributed to the record I just want
to say well music saved my life everyone
can be in new bands love this band is my
family ahead of the award show the trio
snagged a trophy ET getting their full
reaction on the red carpet amazing
amazing we were like rushing getting
dressed when the live stream was on so I
had to play it cool I was like oh yeah
cool but it was amazing like wait wait
wait shut up like you I thought someone
had like dropped a vase or something
like and we were like and then we
screamed yeah the band's Big Win comes
just days after they announced at a
secret show they're going on Hiatus
we're all just going to go chill and
it's made it like really special like
knowing that the shows are limited and
and we have a plan we have a plan to
watch Paddington 2 which everybody has
told us is amazing and we've been like
planning to watch it together for years
so we said after all this we're going to
watch Paddington too as for what this
means for the future of the Indie band I
mean I'm not convinced how do you know
how do you know meteor is not going to
crash into Earth tomorrow you know what
I'm saying like but I don't know we're
going to be friends just be H I'm
telling be satisfied with like what has
happened and not just like more more
more yeah it's been a question since our
first week of promoting the album what
are you guys doing next and we're like
what do you mean it's just that like
stay here in the moment yeah I think
it's like maybe the finitude will help
people realize that like the thing that
we give is enough the album is enough
we're proud of it it's a recording you
can go listen to it anytime yeah it's
there
Grammys I know never gets old for you
the night of this it's like it is
music's night right it's definitely
music's night and I love seeing all the
different looks come on the carpet
seeing how everybody went all out
exactly so what you know for me it's
about the collaborations that we see on
stage is there anybody that you're
looking forward to seeing perform
tonight uh oh my gosh I'm trying to
think who's performing that I I guess
like uh duala I want to hear she just
left and she said oh I got something for
y'all
tonight and as far as look I can't wait
to see what doer cat is going to wear
you know she's going to come with
something iant guard look she might walk
out here with nothing on as far as they
say it's going to be a little art it's
going to be a work of art I can't wait
to see it I believe it I believe every
minute about it okay so what's happening
with Escape right now you guys still
performing I know I've seen you on a few
dates where are you just staying on
tours we're putting together a tour
right now for later this summer M if you
need somebody else I mean Tiny's
daughter if y'all need another member
killing it right and She's Not Afraid we
put her on stage and it's a whole Arena
full of people and she can just belt it
out yeah you know the the question on
everybody's mind is what's happening in
Atlanta and are you going to be back and
do we know what I have been trying to
figure that out for myself to be honest
with you and um I don't know I'm
thinking
that I'm thinking I might just say is it
time I been going back and forth and I
think because they gave us such a long
break I had a lot of time to do other
things and I got some big announcements
to make coming soon so yeah I was like I
mean I love the girls they're my friends
I'm still going to see them and hang out
with them and Bravo as my family I love
them as well but you know okay I'm going
to drill down are you making an
announcement right now that you are
going to take a break from Atlanta now
you done put the pressure on but I guess
yeah okay yeah cuz I mean somebody asked
me recently they were like well why do
you um keep doing it and I was like to
be honest with you I think because I've
been doing it 14 years and so now I feel
like it's it's I do it because I I'm
used to doing it but with all the other
things that I got going on I just like I
might just yeah I don't know if I could
imagine the show with without you but I
couldn't either at first but I think
when they decided you know like they
were like okay we you know we taking
this break to you know rearrange the
cast and all this other kind of stuff
and then it's like it gave me time you
know I never had time I never had
time yeah and I still was working don't
get me wrong I still had a lot of stuff
going on but it was like I had more time
to pick up my kids I had more time to be
in the studio so I've been writing a lot
and I had more time to work on these
other projects that y'all going to see
okay well listen you keep saying that so
you got to give me something cuz you
keep saying I'm going to have a big
announcement I got to work on these
other projects well I mean you know I'm
doing Broadway and I already had um you
know we have the Wiz that's I'll be
there March 13th in New York to see the
show and I'll be there February 13th in
LA to see okay thank you yeah be here so
yeah um so I'm excited for that and then
I got some more things to announce in
that lane as well and you know too much
too I don't want to talk too much ahead
of time but yeah it's maybe more
Broadway maybe more that but I know
you're working on that OT you said it
you manifesting it you ready to do I'm
still I'm manifesting yeah so something
in that realm for sure like um because I
I don't want to give away too much that
I have to come I mean I'll just say I
have some big things coming so keep stay
tuned but um I do love the franchise but
it's just you know you know when
everybody kind of keeps you like at
limbo for so long you start making other
plans you're the longest running
housewife to date at this point that's a
oh Lord Jesus you know I love the house
you know I love you so I'm getting
palpitations from this I understand it
though I do get it I do understand it
and like if this is you know Andy might
say maybe it's a pause for you yeah
that's what he called me okay and
because I I've talked to him about it
and he said well I don't he's like I
don't know how I feel about this and I
said well honestly I don't know how I
feel about it either but he was like
well you do realize this are this is
your family like if you just want to
just come back next year that's fine and
I'm like I mean I love you guys and I
appreciate like it's it's my family you
know what I mean so yeah I'm always a
part of them you know okay they're
always a part of me you have given you
I'm gagging right now I
love
[Music]
on
hello how are you my goodness I have not
seen you in so long and you come through
here looking like the supermodel that
you are you look stunning here I'm going
bring you turn you around a little bit
more like this so we can see your whole
face okay you look stunning tell me
about this look from head to toe tonight
head to toe it's just Seline Mama it's
all all Seline Head To Toe with my my
own jewelry and um covered all the
tattoos I was going to say Paris I know
you have tattoos and I don't see
anything what did how long did that take
took a few hours it took a few hours
yeah why did you do it was it because
you just wanted to go like super Glam
tonight super Chic tonight well I like
switching things up I love my tattoos I
love my piercings I love all the body
modification stuff art and also
sometimes I don't want it to distract
from the art that is the fashion I'm
wearing and kind of it just gives it
gives the dress its own moment it's
giving for sure um I wonder because you
have you got new music coming out um and
it's uh just a couple couple months um
so I haven't decided when yet but when I
was on tour with Incubus I dropped a
single that I just did with Linda Perry
and so she and I just she's like my
Aries twin flame so we're we want to
keep working together sometimes talking
to a lot of other um celebrities or
children of celebrities they really want
to kind of figure out their own lane and
don't want to you know they love their
parent and love everything theyve done
but they want to figure out their own
lane and make their own path well it
depends on how meta you're getting if
you want to go on a much Universal
Collective Consciousness thing I think
we're all one so depends on how how far
you want to go with that like okay so
what is this new music what is it giving
like what are what um what were you in
what era were you in when you were
making it or what like what's your
inspiration um inspo is usually um pain
and love and the space between um but my
record ex EXA Monty thinks that Linda is
my muse soind can't go wrong with Linda
Perry we cannot wait for this new music
who are you looking forward to seeing
getting on this Grammy stage tonight
every single human every single one
every single one you want it all all
right this thank you so much I
appreciate it
okay
okay first of all um you're DJing at the
Super Bowl right all week long you have
a residency in Vegas so what do I need
to do to get tickets to get in to see
you right uh be my best friend and I can
get you in how exciting is that though
because the town will be buzzing
especially this week but to be in Vegas
it's a lot of energy it is I love Vegas
and I have a home with the wind now I'll
actually be playing there all year long
and I am just so grateful to them
they've really like treated me like
family and there's no better place to be
in Vegas than the win okay tell me about
the podcast and what actually goes on
because there are things y'all can tell
people and there are things you know so
how far do you go in this podcast we go
pretty good do you you know what H so
it's called sorry we're stoned for a
reason although she does not partake so
she keeps us all together so if I'm
starting to spill too much tea she's
like Mom zip it pull it in Pull It in
rain it in Miley's performing tonight I
think flowers is such a little Bop and
people love that that song but it feels
like it also tells a lot about her life
and her story when you listen to that
song what do you know that I don't know
you know what you got to dissect those
lyrics I think the fans know more than
anybody knows they absolutely do they
dissected that pretty well for us I
think I did I I mean people opened up
those lyrics like they were reading a
book like it was a memoir you know what
there were some taken pretty far so I
like yeah but over over all like I think
Miley had so much fun making that song
and like she you know she says it over
and over like no expectations of it just
from her heart putting it out and to see
it see its success has been so
incredible you know and also there's
just so much talk about how this is like
the next iteration of Miley you know and
so it's like she continues to have
success at every level as she grows how
cool is that to watch her success it is
so incredible but as her mom it's
watching her grow into this woman she's
become at at 30 and once she just 30
remember that just 30 exactly 31 but
it's so crazy to think she's only 31 and
everything that she's achieved but as a
person she's just the most incredible
human being I I'm so proud of her okay
real quick how many Miley songs do you
play during your DJ set minimum three a
minimum of three minimum of three I like
the family okay do you have a favorite
family song um I mean right now flowers
just goes off so hard also Noah did a
song with Diplo a couple years ago and I
played that one quite a bit also oton
Road's always a hit like Metro station I
play Shake It The Crowd Goes Crazy it
really I I like to represent my family
y'all got hits y'all got y'all got hits
all right remember when I'm standing at
the door I'm calling your name I'm
calling you all right for super for
Super Bowl
[Music]
weekend listen We're Here Sell
celebrating though because you guys have
already won six nominations tonight
you've already won one does it take a
little like now you can exhale a little
bit and just go into the rest of it like
no 100% I was like okay okay we're good
like that's fine if if nothing else
happens the rest of the night that's I'm
100% fine with that I am so like excited
for all the nominees I'm like happy to
be here we got one we're out it's all
good we're great if we hadn't it would
have been fine too right we're chill do
you still get nervous do y'all still get
nervous we always joke that like you
kind of you kind of are like you know
what everyone's amazing you know whoever
wins that's crazy but they're like the
not they like they're like
congratulations much apprciate oh my god
um um anyway they say they say the award
goes to and your heart starts you know
pounding moment it's like everything
before that is like we're chill and then
it's like the moment that like envelope
or like the yeah the Grammy goes to it's
it's like it's like in your throat it's
this cuz um you know swarm was my thing
like I loved it so for real and I'm like
this girl's good like will there ever be
a time where you say Let me let me stop
with music for a second and really kind
of dig deep into the acting for
sure is it happening soon I don't know
girl because listen well but a critic's
choice you said to us yes I got music
coming I don't know how much I can talk
about it yet but I have music coming I
do have that that is for sure on the way
very very soon didn't you say it's about
8 5% done oh no it's it's like
99 it's right there yeah I know we've
been saying that for a long time but we
can't give too many details cuz then
people get excited then they get mad
okay then just give me three words of
the vibe of the
album it
is that's not that's not alcol
musical no it's like I was saying the
other day that it's like a I think it's
a perfect representation of like natural
progression of like
I don't
know you are so oh you are so terrible
of where you are okay well where are you
in life maybe that'll give me a CH an
indication of where the music yes is it
like you're chill are you chill are you
like in a real happy era a real it's all
over the place it's a lot of feeling
it's a lot of um it's like some whatever
relax girl jeez all right listen Okay so
we've got you can't take a break because
after the Grammys we have the a you guys
are nominated will you be
performing I mean I think we're required
to I don't know you could say no I don't
want to but hell yeah no way dude I'm
are you kidding me performing at the
Oscars is like I'm I'm literally like
please like I'm yeah it's the coolest
thing in the world I mean y'all could
just have a whole Barbie section because
Ry Ryan said he wanted to perform too oh
yeah I can't wait to hear yeah God all
right so do we think have we already
started thinking about this like what
going to go into this performance what
it'll look like what it'll feel like for
the Oscars you've been working on the
Grammy performance we're here working on
that one Grammy one yeah yeah I mean
it's just you know we're here we're
doing Barbie we're doing we're doing it
you are you are I love you guys
congratulations have a great night I
can't wait to see what you do by the way
besides your performance tonight anybody
you just can't wait to see on that stage
honestly I don't even know like who's
even all here which I'm I'm sound cheing
that was
tight so excited I'm I'm geeked to see
Luke Colmes and Tracy Chapman get on
stage and do fast car together like that
for me cuz that's my I'm dating myself
but that's like my My Generation uhhuh
yeah I'm excited I like try not to know
what's going to happen because I like to
be surprised so we'll
see there is so much still to come from
the Grammy Awards stick with ET we have
so much more coming after the
break
come on come
[Music]
on
a
[Music]
the glitz the Glam and the outrageous
listen the Grammy Awards red carpet it
never disappoints there's always
something that will surprise you yes
indeed and here are a few of our
favorite moments from the night did the
rain wreck your look because we know
let's be honest that rain will wreck a
hair absolutely not you know the best
things happen when I'm Singing in the
Rain so maybe it's a good luck charm
okay five nominations I mean I hear you
were asleep on the plane when the
nominations came through and you had no
idea I was fully asleep and I thought
that by the time I landed that's when I
would find out cuz that's when it would
be announced I completely got the time
change wrong I woke up to my phone
blowing up with text messages and that's
when I knew but I was the last to know
what did that feel that moment feel like
when you started looking at the phone
and seeing the nomination after
nomination after nomination what really
took me out was the five everyone kept
mentioning five five five I was like
what does that mean and when I finally
landed and I got to call people back
that's when I just lost it that's got to
be a great moment though it's got to be
a great it's so beautiful um it's just
refreshing to see you reap the benefits
of all the time you know your hard work
you you worked hard this isn't a you
know overnight success story you worked
your butt off so that's got to be that's
got to feel it feels great to have not
given up but also it feels better to
promote a timeline that took a while you
know I'm not I'm not afraid of that I'm
not ashamed of that and I want to
continue to give younger black women
this reminder that if it takes a lot of
time that doesn't reflect on your value
it doesn't reflect on your worth it
doesn't reflect on the possibility of
you still getting where you need to go
just let time be time and you do you and
you do you okay tell me about this dress
cuz it's a dress this is a dress right
here um I'm really really happy that I
got to wear something that reflects me
I'm sparkly on the inside and um I just
want to shine tonight and I want to be
in the moment and just feel everything
around me Coco you always shine When
Heaven you shine thank you so much all
right I'm going to ask you a couple I'm
going to ask I'm going to name a couple
of song titles you tell me whether there
is a Taylor Swift song or a candle scent
okay or a candle scent okay okay sure
ready with this first one how about this
one endless weekend that's a candle
scent damn it you're good okay hold on
let's I got another one for you how
about this one
Afterglow that's a Taylor Swift song
okay hold on okay you're on fire right
now how about Wildest Dreams Taylor
Swifts okay how about thousand wishes
candles Cent you cannot fool
Co let's do a song together
babe hello to you hello to you I am a
little nervous if I am if I'm being
honest because there is a legend
standing in front of me right now
where really can I see I I just had to
be honest okay listen I heard part of
the song the other day I didn't get the
whole thing they would give me the whole
thing but it it made me feel so good it
is quintessential Billy Joel Piano Man
Brilliance why now since you haven't
released a song for us since
2007 basically cuz it all came together
very recently MH and uh I've resisted it
for a long time and this time I just
said ah what the hell I who am I to
fight this yeah and you're going to give
us a you're going to get on that stage
tonight now are we are you just doing
the new song or is did we get a medley
what is it what do we what are we going
to get well I know I'm doing the new
song I don't know if I'm doing anything
else yet okay you can make up your mind
just make it up on
the what are they going do throw me off
I do another one ever ever so you've
been nominated 23 times you've won six
times what is Grammy KN like for those
nominees those young nominees who you
know maybe it's their first time
there do you remember the your first
nomination I was in Paris when I won my
first Grammy and we won two that night
and they kept waking me up in
Paris uh which was fun it was a nice
place to be and you're you just
announced that your residency at Madison
Square Garden is going to end in July ju
is there a chance you could extend is
there a chance that we could get more
are you saying like I I'm I'm good well
I never said I'm never going to play the
garden again it was just in this
particular run of the
residency that's the end of that for now
we could do the garden again I could
play other venues in New York where I
haven't played for the last 10 years so
it opens up a whole new world um there's
so many artists who look to you that
you've been inspiration for them one of
them is Olivia Rodrigo she came by your
show last year and sang a couple D she
really is you know who is there anybody
in today's music that you look at and
you say I I really like what they're
doing like in Olivia it's a lot of
people I like what um Olivia is doing I
like what Taylor Swift is doing I like
what Billy Alish is doing it's like a
women's thing now women are really
coming to the front speaking of women
when she walks out in this dress and
looking like this what do you say
yeah you say yeah you say turn turn
those lights off that's what you say not
back on turn those lights off I love it
you look amazing I can't even imagine
how many diamonds are in this necklace
it's all on loan from Camila Deets
collection in New York and I'm very
thankful to them okay tell us this does
Billy Joel listen to Billy Joel at home
no we do not our children do yes so we
have a lot of Taylor Swift Billy Joel
Olivia Rodrigo but they're his biggest
fans so yeah they want to hear it all
the time you know what I dig that so
much because you know so many times we
think our kids we embarrass our kids and
that but your kids thinking that you are
the coolest and like loving your music
and playing your music that's got to be
maybe they're doing it because they dig
it but I think they're doing it to annoy
me they keep playing piano man it drives
me nuts I can never hear ano Man Too
Much you said that you were bringing
your mom to the Grammys and you made
good on that promise you know what we
hired a woman to play my mom she
couldn't make it but she's here how cool
is it to come with your child just the
Grammy Awards of all places it is
unbelievable right and I made him
promise me when he was 12 so I 15 years
later I'm like it's my time so were you
the there last night for the performance
at Clive Davis yes and he was fantastic
I was so nervous for you oh my God it
was great how was that watching him
perform and knowing that the crowd was
vibing loved it I was thrilled and just
I was so proud and he you did such a
great job thanks Mama Clyde Davis party
launches stars that is the place for
stars to be launched so how important
was it to be last night and now to hear
that people loved you well it's always
tough to go look out into a crowd and
see Forest Gump looking back at you uh
it puts a little bit of added pressure
on uh but I just had fun I knew my mom
was there and I knew that you know the
people there wanted to see something
good and I tried to do my best to make
that happen for them and I had so much
fun and um I was nervous but just being
surrounded by Legends and honored like
that was a dream come true and I got a
meet Green Day which was sick was there
a moment for you when you were on was
there a moment where you just like oh my
God yeah the the very beginning I was
like close to pissing my pants like for
real like it was it was almost bad uh
but once I was halfway through I was
like oh my gosh I'm just storing again
and it felt like I was on stage at an
open mic in front of nobody else it was
you did your thing and you did your
thing I did my best I hear Olivia
Rodrigo wants to doet with you have you
talked to her about that Olivia and I
have spoken about that uh we've kind of
played some back and forth in the Press
but uh I think we both just want to make
sure the time is right and that it's
something that we both can truly cherish
and I would love to work in the room
with Olivia cuz she's such a talented
writer so that was the press release
answer now tell me the real answer
what's going on behind the scenes is it
going to happen hell yeah I'm hitting
her up we're making it happen I got you
we're going to make it happen I'm sure
she'll be here in a few minutes so if
you see Olivia if we see her we'll set
it up okay Mom what are you looking
forward to tonight and how will it be
what when you hear your child's name
called in there when they announce the
best new artist well Noah's already won
in my mind so whatever happens tonight
is is just going to be extra special but
I'm just so excited to hear the music
and see the people and I'm thrilled to
be here and by the way there was a show
where they had the moms of rock stars
you know they were talking about their
lives what is one moment when you knew
that your child was different and
special I think he's always been playing
music his entire life but I think it's
when I saw him perform and other people
were kind of freaking out and then I was
like wow he is really good you
know no congratulations you've already
won you brought your mom that's the win
that is the
win last time I saw you we were golfing
were golfing I'm not going to say who
golf better but we were golf right right
right right right I will say this who
would have thought we'd have went from
Top Golf to the Grammy red carpet okay
you said that it's going to be an
emotional night for you it's going to be
an emotional night will it it's
emotional if I lose you know just being
here this is unreal man being recognized
by the academy and uh being here to
represent Nashville and being here to
represent country music and my slice of
America that's often not spoken for it's
a lot of people that have never been
represented that are represented here
tonight we didn't come to win we came to
represent baby and you talked about that
that you came to represent your
community how many folks did you bring
with you and how many folks are at home
watching well I I would hope there's a
lot watching but most importantly I
brought my daughter my 16-year-old
daughter Bailey and my wife Bunny's
behind us um we're walking this red
carpet together which is just makes a a
dream even better this is uh special
Louis Vuitton right from forel Custom
Louis Vuitton from forel baby I couldn't
believe it P P dress me himself man it's
the first time I've ever wore designer
come on come on it's cool man
you talked about your mom when you got
these nominations will she be watching
tonight she's watching dude she wanted
to come but we just couldn't I I was
worried have her having a wheelchair
getting her in and out and the carpet
and stuff but um she's watching from
home man and and I mean she's she's
FaceTime me 10 times today already
really she's fired up come on come on
face let's FaceTime come on can we
FaceTime your mom let's FaceTime your
mom let's FaceTime your mom right now
she'll answer she'll answer she'll love
it too okay she's on she's going on
we're going to put her on ET right
now
oh no there we go hey Mama I'm on the
red carpet with ET how you doing
Mom are you we are good we wish you were
here tonight I do too I I wish I could
have been there too everybody's asking
about
you she say she's in Nashville holding
it down I love you I'll FaceTime you
later mama
bye come on that is pretty cool she's
been waiting on that FaceTime all day
I've been FaceTime her all day she's
excited yeah she's excited okay she's
excited about the Grammys I also I mean
I'm hearing that you're in a Super Bowl
commercial with some folks oh man listen
the rumor is true now I can't tell you
the folks but I can tell you I am in a
Super Bowl commercial and shout out to
UB and let me just say you something we
know who the folks are and there's some
there's some big big folks in that one
to be in that kind of company commercial
it's huge to be in that kind of company
now what what does that say you know cuz
you think about those folks that you're
in there with and they're saying you are
on par you're a superstar too right I
think it's unreal just to even some of
the conversations I'm having and some of
the people that even know I'm a human is
unreal man this is just
unbelievable and also you talk about how
far you've come and how you've changed
and how you're helping the change people
you were just talking about Fentanyl and
pushing that and trying to give people
help that you continue to help folks why
is that so important
I mean God has blessed me so much I just
want to be a blessing you know I think
that's the that's the Pay It Forward
mentality man I came from a place where
there wasn't a lot of blessings so to be
blessed now I want to bless as many
people as I can all right I got to let
you go but where's the jelly jelly roll
party tonight if you win oh dude listen
if I win if I'm going to all the parties
if I lose but if I win I'm having one
party at the Rainbow Bar and Grill come
see me I'm serious I'll be there at the
rainbow with jelly roll
rolling
face
[Music]
ch
come on
[Music]
on
he
[Music]
who is June Carter Cash she's about us
I've never known a life different than
Show Business Johnny Cash was not Johnny
Cash was out June Carter she was an
incredible artist in her own
right
[Music]
you look stunning you look stunning man
listen you didn't come to play with us
tonight on this red carpet Best New
Artist nominee what a weird sentence I
mean how has the morning been how are
you feeling are you good are you settled
I feel mellow I feel just so overwhelmed
to be in this room but I I did not
expect to be included this year at all
and so to be in this room screaming for
my friends who are up for awards um
screaming for My Heroes that are
performing that have been gracing us
with their presence forever I just am so
I'm so I feel so blessed to be here we
were just talking about the best new
artist category and I don't know if I've
ever seen it so stacked I can't call it
you all like and but I guess that's the
great thing about music and what you've
all been doing like anybody you can't be
like oh man I can't believe that
everybody is just phenomenal and there
somehow like even better people than
they are artists I really mean it like I
I haven't gotone to meet all of them but
over the past week I think that's what's
been the most spectacular part for me
selfishly about this week is is getting
to cross paths with the other artists in
this category and getting to you know
learn about them as human beings and
they are so kind and it feels like no
like true support of one another who did
you get to meet this I've well Noah KH
is a friend who I really love and um
Warren treaty I I'm obsessed with them
and they are they were so warm and so
generous and so kind and Coco Jones who
I I literally fell I fell in love with
her watching her like w mag ASMR last
week fell in love with her and met her
yesterday and um got to tell her that to
her face I love to hear that I just
really I'm just I'm just everyone's
biggest fan the gammies for me are also
about the collaborations that we see on
stage which I think are cool so is there
anybody you're looking forward to seeing
that you've heard that's performed I
mean Joanie Mitchell is my like North
Star artist um I have
been uh I I don't there's not been a day
that I haven't listened to her music
since I learned about her as a small
child so I I'm just really nervous I'm
that's what I keep like getting a hot
flash about it's going to be a moment
the first time in 24 years she's been
battling her way back and she's gracing
that stage tonight I I can't
imagine what that's going to we're just
so lucky we're just so lucky so I know
your girl Taylor will be here tonight
you'll get to reunite with her and hang
out with her now you know swifties are
going crazy right now because her
website has been shut down and they
believe that reputation TV is going to
be announced
wow wow she
says I love her fan base dearly they are
the greatest and I was lucky enough to
get to know them up close and personally
this summer um they have the greatest
imaginations of any group of people I've
ever known can we have a little fun play
a little game before I lose you okay so
because everybody loves all things
Taylor and we think there could be an
announcement we're going to play a
little game it's called a popular Taylor
Swift song or a popular candle scent so
I will say one to you and you will tell
me if it's a Taylor song or a candle S I
think you might be good at this better
be okay Wildest Dreams oh that's a
Taylor song it is last kiss that's a
Taylor song that is a Taylor song
endless weekend that is not a Taylor
song that is a scent right forever
winter that is also not a Taylor song
that is a Taylor song no stop
it what yes thousand wishes I'm never
allowed back on the a tour we'll edit
that one thousand wishes that that isn't
a Taylor song no it's a scent great in
the Stars that's also a scent that's a
scent yes Chasing Fireflies that has to
be a scent that's a scent also are these
real sents yes they like can real I'm
going to like seek that out tomorrow
morning and after glow oh that's Taylor
all day she's perfect everybody no
Taylor is not
me I'm saying congratulations all right
we celebrating yes yes we are
celebrating yes indeed how does that
feel now like it's is it an exhale
moment yes yes I think I'm still
processing the fact that I've won a
Grammy it's it's very very very bizarre
but so cool how how did you find out
were you at the ceremony already okay so
you were there yeah I was at the
pre-ceremony I performed uh my song and
then right after that it was announced
so it was a maybe the most stressful six
minutes of my life but um but now the
most exciting six minutes of my life
what was that moment like when they open
the envelope and right before you here
what is that moment I think I blacked
out I don't really remember it I was
just still running on such a hive from
the performance um but it was so cool so
wild and this is well this is Chanel
tonight now was this done for you no
this is um it is not dumb for me but it
is still very pretty you so you are
performing with Billy Joel tonight okay
he was just here and I was saying to him
like he hasn't had a done music for us
since 2007 new music for us so why was
now the time and now I think are you
processing how much of an iconic moment
this is to be on stage it's again just a
string of iconic moments today but yeah
to get to play with Billy and I'm
playing cello so I kind of get to you
know take put the singing to to the side
and just do kind of what I practice
growing up is so special I was telling
him hearing the new song it is so
quintessential Piano Man Billy Joel
comfort music for me it's so it's so
incredible to to get to play with him
and he is just such a good musician like
I think forgets like how much craft
these musicians put into their work and
practice and just seeing and play and
even just like jamming in between in
rehearsals just jamming in between in
rehearsals is just very inspiring this
is his first Grammy performance in 30
years so how did it come about that you
number one were able to do this
performance with him and I
mean well um my friend Freddy Wexler uh
co-wrote a song on my album that uh just
won the Grammy and and um he wrote the
and produced the a song with Billy Joel
so he he was like do you want to play
You're a chalis right do you want to
play and I was like that's what I went
to school for so let's put it to work I
mean sis I cannot wait to see this I
love this for you this is a huge night
for you you're a winner already and now
you're about to step on the stage with
an icon and do a performance it's a I
mean you don't have to do anything else
I I already feel like I've won life at
this point I love it so wonderful to
meet you you look beautiful you I see
you I love it enjoy every minute of this
night really enjoy
[Music]
this I haven't had a chance to
congratulate you first of all since the
Emmy I've not seen you come on in here
come on it's a it was a family win yes
it
is you should have congratulated you
because no but let me tell you why you
should have congratulated you and people
didn't mention this that people told you
you couldn't do serious stuff that
people told you that you were just a
funny lady you should be off to the side
do your funny thing and stop yeah and
you said damn it I'm going to show you I
got to show you I got to show you
something and you showed the whole world
and it's been thing after not one but
it's been thing after thing after thing
after thing so I just do not make me cry
my fake eyelashes off I'm at the gramys
but I was just so happy for that moment
because you manif invested that you said
I'm going go and show youall you know I
had a wonderful support system and uh
and we were able to bring home that
award and I've been I'm still floating
you should be floating by the way where
is the award at home in in the front
actually in the front door soon as you
walk soon as you walk in it sings to you
it's like w right there with my big
bouquet that I got from Oprah yes yes
this really isn't your night it's your
night cuz you're the musician in the
family so what is it that makes the
Grammy so special oh being able to be
among so many amazing musicians and
artists and uh people that I've looked
up to for over the years so I'm excited
to be here Kevin I I love that I got
invited on a date normally I'm like hey
come with me to this thing and now she's
like you want to go to the gramy I'm
like
okay I'm going to take you yeah you're
my dick I also want to talk about origin
because it has been doing well in the
theaters it expanded to a to more um
audiences now why is it so important for
people to see this movie wow for such a
time as this it it it it opens your mind
it invites you to think differently and
to unlearn some things so it it's
definitely a mustsee it's a must SE it
really is a movie that will change it's
not like we go to movies to escape and
have fun but this one it changes your
life ever absolutely very powerful
message I think it's a masterpiece so I
enjoyed
it thank you all for joining us here on
ET for all of your coverage from the
2024 Grammy Awards and never forget you
can always catch us on etonline.com take
[Music]
care
people are always was coming up with new
ways to hurt themselves especially
around
[Music]
here we got to get him out
now don't make me write you up for
insubordination you're not my boss no
I'm not your
boss if it was my life in someone else's
hands you are the only person I would
trust to do
this we got a snake on the plane
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Music]
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say am I a member because I got the
memo come on now he was
great I got the
memo I think I think I just joined
pentatonics
everybody well y'all know first of all
y'all know that you do the music does it
for me all the time so I mean it does
it's first of all it's like music is
healing anyway but your music is so
joyous and it's just like a feast for
the ear so it just makes me happy and I
mean everybody thinks that you're here
because you're nominated again so of
course oh my gosh yes we can't believe
we're nominated for an album we put so
much heart and soul into it's a it's a
world holiday album where we celebrated
all these different cultures and learned
about their music and their culture and
how they celebrate the holidays we
collaborated with the most iconic
artists from all these different
countries and it was so fulfilling and
such a beautiful Journey making this
album so to see it celebrated by our
peers in this way it's just surreal it's
the only word I can think of do y'all
ever feel like us like if you're in the
studio you're recording something and
then you hear like oh damn we just did
that I mean seriously do you ever feel
like
that yeah some especially because we're
such fans of each other too you know so
like when I hear a certain thing it's
got things where Kevin it just inspir
Ires us to keep going and keep pushing
further and so it's it's like we feel
like kids in the playground like they
get to play in the sandbox you know okay
how do you decide like when you hear
your name called who gets to say who
gets to speak give the speech up oh we
haven't even talked about it now I'm
creating problems we're figuring it out
right here right
now I think I'd be so nervous and like
shocked so I would probably Mama's got
diamonds so Mama should be able to do it
oh yeah M just going to oh yeah well
hopefully they won't leave me behind cuz
I'm going to have to Shimmy Shimmy onto
the these are part of the opening
ceremony for the premiere ceremony yeah
with like Jordan Sparks and Jay Ivy and
all of that what was that moment oh my
gosh it was so good we did Prince Let's
Go Crazy everybody was just unbelievable
it's so cool to see such diversity of
Talent on one stage and that's what I
think makes the Grammys so just
unbelievably iconic that all these
artists from completely different walks
of life can be on the same stage and
showcase their talent but it all is
working harmoniously together it's it's
just the coolest thing I feel so blessed
that we get to do this each other
everyone was so kind we were all like
hyping each other up and it was just
such a fun song and a fun way to like
start our Grammy day all right so what's
coming up next that's a great question
you know I think what we've talked about
a
lot baby
girl Sheila E bust into your interview
come
on we just performed together just
talking about
it we were just talking about how cool
it was for all these different talents
to get together open up the ceremony
kind of celebrate music and celebrate
each other oh absolutely it was amazing
I had a blast I mean I get to play with
them come on
really she she gave a master class on
energy like I it was amazing to watch
you perform and like taking the the the
mic and everything and just I did the
simp like master class thank you thank
you thank you something happens to her
when she gets on those
S oh my gosh yes it was
unbelievable well thank you guys so much
Sheila you stick
around find each other in like a very
similar G no we're like sparkles
sparkles you know yes and this is giving
tonight so was it when you saw it on the
rack when you put it on what was it
about it this is a custom dress by k um
that was made for me um I feel very
excited to wear it I feel very strong in
it it's definitely a heavy like metal
dress I was like feel very
jonok no but for real yeah well listen
You' had a very strong year I'm having
I'm having fun so the last time I talked
to you at the Golden Globes you were
telling me about your new music and you
were saying you know this record is
about understanding your worth and
different chapters of your life so on
the 15th we're getting this on okay so
what are you what are you giving on the
so on the 15th like you said a new S I
mean it'll be late in the evening on the
15th but um a new song which is just
about kind of knowing how
to it's almost like not expecting PE to
for people to like love you right yeah
you know yeah you're just like preach
baby training people's over you know
you're done teaching people how to do
things right exactly come correct or
don't come at all correct or don't come
at all exactly that's the vibe that's
the vibe so much I can't wait cuz it
does feel like this record is going to
be a very personal one for you it is and
you know I I got to do most of the
record at home in
London um I just felt like and I feel
like with every album I get to grow more
and learn more about myself and I become
more free as a songwriter and as a
performer and as an artist so this one
I'm just like digging deeper and deeper
I love it I'm I'm proud of this one part
of you as an artist that says I'm a
little nervous because this year for you
like has been in the stratosphere as far
as music is concerned you know what I'm
saying and I mean just career in general
but is there a part of you that's like
okay now I got to follow up with like
just an incredible year that I I mean
there's always pressure yeah there's
always pressure but I think for as long
as I'm doing things that I'm proud of
things that I love things that I feel
like I'm pushing myself and trying out
something different and I'm growing as
an artist and as a person then I'm good
you know the gammies is also about the
performances and what's going to happen
on stage so what can we expect oh we got
something special for you guys tonight
she gives the smile like the biggest
smile I'm really really excited about
this performance like more more so than
any three words give me in three words
what this performance is going to oh my
God we we have it's
like it's intense okay uh it's
strong and uh it's Dy okay I love it so
you you have two nominations tonight
dance the night away we're still dancing
to it so I mean when you think about
that song when you were making it did
you think okay I got I got something
here like this is I mean I know you
didn't know what it was going to do but
but were you like okay yeah I got
something here yeah I mean in the moment
again it goes back to that thing for as
long as I feel like I'm having fun or
making something that I'm really proud
of and I'm in the moment then I'm I'm
exactly where I'm supposed to be and I
feel that way with you know when we were
making D night we were having such a
great time in the studio it felt so good
to be a part of such an incredible
project it felt so good to do it with my
friends that whole experience as a whole
was really special so um yeah I'm I'm
happy that that's like way out into the
world now and like had its own life and
it's it's been great well finally I was
in London didn't get to talk to you
there but I was there for Argy you have
this movie coming out it is fun fun fun
in so many ways and you get to cut up a
little bit in this movie and get a
little dancing going on I did get to do
a little bit of I mean I have a a small
role but I'm I loved working on a film
set and for Matthew Vaughn to give me
that opportunity I'm so grateful for it
and I had fun with my co-stars with
Henry caval and John Cena and are you
and John the new Hollywood Duo that we
didn't know we needed uh I don't know if
our acting career will continue together
um but I anytime I see him it's an
absolute pleasure and I I loved working
with him and he's so wonderful so who
knows he told me he was so embarrassed
because he had to sing off key to you
and he was like why am I doing doing
this to myself he was he's such a good
sport honestly he wasn't even off key I
think he's just so humble that he's just
you know it's it's it was wonderful
really it was what made this year
possible we decided it before we even
recorded that it was going to be a
limited time and it's part of why we've
like given so much to this we can't
sustain this level of doing personally
yeah boy Genius opening up about about
their Hiatus after winning at the 2024
gramys the Grammy goes
to not strong enough forus this just
like isn't
real uh yeah thank you uh thank you to
our band uh thank you to everyone that
uh contributed to the record I just want
to say well music saved my life everyone
can be in a band this band is my family
ahead of the award show the trio snagged
a trophy ET getting their full reaction
on the red carpet amazing amazing we
were like rushing getting dressed when
the live stream was on so I had to play
it cool I was like oh yeah cool but it
was amazing wait wait wait shut up like
you I thought someone had like dropped a
vase or something like and we were like
and then we
screamed yeah yeah the band's Big Win
comes just days after they announced at
a secret show they're going on hi atus
we're all just going to go chill and
it's made it like really special like
knowing that the shows are limited and
and we have a plan we have a plan to
watch Paddington 2o which everybody has
told us is amazing and we've been like
planning to watch it together for years
so we said after all this we're going to
watch Paddington too as for what this
means for the future of the Indie band I
mean I'm not convinced how do you know
how do you know meteor is not going to
crash into Earth tomorrow you know what
I'm saying like but I don't know we're
going be just be I'm telling myself
be with like what has happened and not
just like more more more yeah it's been
a question since our first week of
promoting the album what are you guys
doing next and we're like what do you
mean it's just that like stay here in
the moment I think it's like maybe the
finitude will help people realize that
like the thing that we give is enough
the album is enough we're proud of it
it's a recording you can go listen to it
anytime yeah it's
there Grammys I know never gets old for
you the night of this it's like it is
music's night right it's definitely
music's night and I love seeing all the
different looks come on the carpet
seeing how everybody went all out
exactly so what you know for me it's
about the collaborations that we see on
stage is there any that you're looking
forward to seeing perform tonight uh oh
my gosh I'm trying to think who's
performing that I I guess like uh
dualipa I want to hear she just left and
she said oh I got something for y'all
tonight and as far as looks I can't wait
to see what DOA cat is going to wear you
know she's gonna come with something AV
vantard look she might walk out here
with nothing on as far as they say it's
going to be a little art it's going to
be a work of art I can't wait to see it
I believe it I believe every minute
about it okay so what's happening with
Escape right now you guys still
performing I know I've seen you on a few
dates where are you just staying on
tours we're putting together a tour
right now for later this summer M if you
need somebody else I mean Tiny's
daughter if y'all need another member
killing it right and She's Not Afraid we
put her on stage and it's a whole Arena
full of people and she can just belt it
out yeah you know the the question on
everybody's mind is what's happening in
Atlanta and are you going to be back and
do we know what I have been trying to
figure that out for myself to be honest
with you and um I don't know I'm
thinking
that I'm thinking I might just say is it
time I me going back and forth and I
think because they gave us such a long
break I had a lot of time to do other
things and I got some big announcements
to make coming soon so yeah I was like I
mean I love the girls they're my friends
I'm still going to see them and hang out
with them and Bravo is my family I love
them as well but you know okay okay I'm
going to drill down are you making an
announcement right now that you are
going to take a break from Atlanta now
you done put the pressure on but I guess
yeah okay yeah cuz I mean somebody asked
me recently they were like well why do
you um keep doing it and I was like to
be honest with you I think because I've
been doing it 14 years and so now I feel
like it's it's I do it because I I'm
used to doing it but with all the other
things that I got going on I just like I
might just yeah I don't know if I could
imagine the show without you but I I
couldn't either at first but I think
when they decided you know like they
were like okay we you know we taking
this break to you know rearrange the
cast and all this other kind of stuff
and then it's like it gave me time you
know I never had time I never had
time yeah and I still was working don't
get me wrong I still had a lot of stuff
going on but it was like I had more time
to pick up my kids I had more time to be
in the studio
so I've been writing a lot and I have
more time to work on these other
projects that y'all going to see okay
well listen you keep saying that so you
got to give me something cuz you keep
saying I'm G have a big announcement I
got to work on these other projects oh I
mean you know I'm doing Broadway and I
already had um you know we had the Wiz
that's I'll be there March 13th uh in
New York to see the show and I'll be
there February 13th in LA to see the
show okay thank you yeah be here so yeah
um so I'm excited for that and then I
got some more things to announce in that
lane as well
and you know too much too I don't want
to talk too much ahead of time but yeah
it's a great so maybe more Broadway
maybe more of that but I know you're
working on that OT you said it you
manifesting it you ready to do and I'm
still I'm manifesting yeah so so
something in that realm for sure like um
because I I don't want to give away too
much that I have to come I mean I'll
just say I have some big things coming
so keep stay tuned but but um I do love
the franchise but it's just you know you
know when everybody kind of keeps you
like at limbo for so long you start
making other plans you're the longest
running housewife to date at this point
that's a oh Lord Jesus you know I love
the house you know I love you so I'm
getting palpitations from this I
understand it though I do get it I do
understand it and like if this is you
know Andy might say maybe it's a pause
for you yeah that's what he called me
okay and cuz I I've talked to him about
it and he said well I don't he's like I
don't know how I feel about this and I
said well honestly I don't know how I
feel about it either but he was like
well you do realize this are this is
your family like if you just want to
just come back next year that's fine and
I'm like I mean I love you guys and I
appreciate like it's it's my family you
know what I mean so yeah I'm always a
part of them you know okay they're
always a part of me you have given you
I'm G bagging right now I'm giving I
[Music]
love
hello how are you my goodness I have not
seen you in so long and you come through
here looking like the supermodel that
you are you look stunning here I'm going
bring you turn you around a little bit
more like this so we can see your whole
face okay you look stunning tell me
about this look from head to toe tonight
head to toe it's just Seline Mama it's
all
all Seline Head To Toe with my my own
jewelry and um covered all the tattoos I
was going to say Paris I know you have
tattoos and I don't see anything what
did how long did that take took a few
hours it took a few hours yeah why did
you do it was it because you just wanted
to go like super Glam tonight super Chic
tonight well I like switching things up
I love my tattoos I love my piercings I
love all the body modification stuff art
and also so sometimes I don't want it to
distract from the art that is the
fashion I'm wearing and I kind of it
just gives it gives the dress its own
moment it's giving for sure um I wonder
because you have You' got new music
coming out um and it's uh just a couple
a couple months um so I haven't decided
when yet but when I was on tour with
Incubus I dropped a single that I just
did with Linda Perry and so she and I
just she's like my Aries twin flame so
we're where we want to keep working
together sometimes talking to a lot of
other um celebrities or children of
celebrities they really want to kind of
figure out their own lane and don't want
to you know they love their parent and
love everything theyve done but they
want to figure out their own lane and
make their own path it depends on how
met you're getting if you want to go on
a much Universal Collective
Consciousness thing I think we're all
one so depends on how how far you want
to go with that I like okay so what is
this new music what is it giving like
what are what um what were you in what
era were you in when you were making it
or what like what's your inspiration um
inspo is usually um pain and love and
the space between um but my record ex
Zach Monty thinks that Linda is my muse
so L can't go wrong with Linda
Perry we cannot wait for this new music
who are you looking forward to seeing
getting on this Grammy stage tonight
every single human every single one
every single one you want it all all
right zis thank you so much I appreciate
it
okay okay first of all um you're DJing
at the Super Bowl right all week long
you have a residency in Vegas so what do
I need to do to get tickets to get in to
see you right uh be my best friend and I
can get you in how exciting is that
though because the town will be buzzing
especially this week but to be in Vegas
that's a lot of energy it is I love
Vegas and I have a home with the wind
now I'll actually be playing there all
year long and I am just so grateful to
them they've really like treated me like
family and there's no better place to be
in Vegas than the wi okay tell me about
the podcast and what actually goes on
because there are things y'all can tell
people and there are things you know so
how far do you go in this podcast we go
pretty good do you you know what I so
it's called sorry we're stoned for a
reason although she does not partake so
she keeps us all together so if I'm
starting to spill too much tea she's
like Mom zip it pull it in pull it in a
it in Miley's performing tonight I think
flowers is such a little Bop and people
love that song but it feels like it also
tells a lot about her life and her story
when you listen to that song what do you
know that I don't know you know what you
got to dissect those lyrics I think the
fans know more than anybody knows they
absolutely do they dissected that pretty
well for us I think I did I I mean
people opened up those lyrics like they
were reading a book like it was a memoir
you know what there were some taken
pretty far so I like yeah but over
overall like I think Miley had so much
fun making that song and like she you
know she says it over and over like no
expectations of it just from her heart
putting it out and to see it see its
success has been so incredible you know
and also there's just so much talk about
how this is like the next iteration of
Miley you know and so it's like she
continues to have success at every level
as she grows how cool is that to watch
her success it is so incredible but as
her mom it's watching her grow into this
woman she's become at 30 and once she
just 30 remember that just 30 exactly 31
but it's so crazy to think she's only 31
and that everything that she's achieved
but as a person she's just the most
incredible human being I I'm so proud of
her okay real quick how many Miley songs
do you play during your DJ set minimum
three a minimum of three minimum of
three I like to rep the family
okay do you have a favorite family song
um I mean right now flowers just goes
off so hard also Noah did a song with
Diplo a couple years ago and I play that
one quite a bit also otel Road's always
a hit like Metro station I play Shake It
The Crowd Goes Crazy it really I I like
to represent my family y'all got hits
y'all got y'all got hits all right
remember when I'm standing at the door
I'm calling your name I'm calling you
all right for super for Super Bowl
[Music]
weekend
listen we're here celebrating though
because you guys have already won six
nominations tonight you've already won
one does it take a little like now you
can exhale a little bit and just go into
the rest of it like no 100% I was like
okay okay we're good like that's fine if
if nothing else happens the rest of the
night that's I'm 100% fine with that I
am so like excited for all the nominees
I'm like happy to be here we got one
we're out it's all good we're great if
we hadn't it would have been F too right
we're chill do you still get nervous do
y'all still get nervous we always joke
that like you kind of you kind of are
like you know what everyone's amazing
you know whoever wins that's CRA but
they're like the not they like they're
like congratulations on
dude apprciate man oh my God you um um
anyway they say they say the award goes
to and your heart starts you know
pounding moment it's like everything
before that is like we're chill and then
it's like the moment that like envelope
or like the yeah the Grammy goes to it's
it's like it's like in your throat it's
let me ask you this cuz um you know
swarm was my thing like I loved it so
for real and I'm like this girl's good
like will there ever be a time where you
say Let me let me stop with music for a
second and really kind of dig deep into
the acting for
sure is it happening soon I don't know
girl because listen well but a critic's
choice you said to us yes I got music
coming I don't know how much I can talk
about it yet but I have music coming I
do have that that is for sure on the way
very very soon didn't you say it's about
85% done oh no it's it's like
99 it's right there yeah I know we've
been saying that for a long time but we
can't give too many details CU then
people get excited then they get mad
okay then just give me three words of
the vibe of the
album it
is not that's not alcohol
musical no it's like I was saying the
other day that it's like a I think it's
a perfect representation of like natural
progression of
like I don't know oh wait you are so oh
you are so terrible of where you are
okay well where are you in life maybe
that'll give me a CH an indication of
where the music yes is it like you're
chill are you chill are you like in a
real happy era a real it's all over the
place it's a lot of feeling it's a lot
of um it's like some whatever relax girl
oh jeez all right listen Okay so we've
got you can't take a break because after
the Grammys we have the Oscars you guys
are nominated will you be
performing I mean I think we're required
to well I don't know you could say no I
don't want to but hell yeah no way dude
I'm are you kidding me performing at the
Oscars is like I'm I'm literally like
please like I'm yeah it's the coolest
thing in the world I mean y'all could
just have a whole Barbie section because
Ry Ryan said he wanted to perform too oh
yeah and I can't wait to hear just go
all right so do we think have we already
started thinking about this like what's
going to go into this performance what
it'll look like what it'll feel like for
the Oscars you've been working on the
Grammy performance we're here working on
that one Grammy one yeah I mean it's
just you know we're here we're doing
Barbie we're doing we're doing it you
are you are I love you guys
congratulations have a great night I
can't wait to see what you do by the way
besides your performance tonight anybody
you just can't wait to see on that stage
honestly I don't even know like who's
even all here which I'm soundchecking
that was
tight so excited I'm I'm geeked to see
Luke Holmes and Tracy Chapman get on
stage and do fast car together like that
for me cuz that's my I'm dating myself
but that's like my My Generation yeah
I'm excited I like try not to know
what's going to happen because I like to
be surprised so we'll
see there is so much still to come from
the Grammy Awards stick with ET we have
so much more coming after the
[Music]
break
is
[Music]
thanks for joining us tonight on ET and
we are bringing you the very best from
the Grammy red carpet right yes indeed
we are we had some fantastic moments
with music's biggest stars so check it
out I do not want to cry I don't have
worked so hard and given so much of
yourself to this industry for so long
while quietly being in your ab solute
own League my we've talked about this
happening since the day we met and over
many tour bus sleepovers we did it is
the greatest joy to see the goodness you
have poured into others into your
collaborators I am so incredibly lucky
to be one of them over the years pouring
right back into you happy does not begin
to cover it this is your mother jumping
moment mother jump oh my God I love you
Ari if you're hearing this I love you so
much thank you for being a Believer and
supporting me from the very beginning um
you knew things that other people didn't
know and saw things of me that other
people didn't see and you've just been
so brigh or die so this is my love
letter to you thank you so much I'm
going to tell you in person obviously
but I love
you Mama are matching tonight thank you
so much this is her nap time but she'll
appreciate it later okay well we about
to celebrate cuz you won two already you
have won two babies already I found out
in the car on the way here and I'm shook
I'm like wow what a great start to the
night my song just went number one on
rhythmic radio today I'm like what a day
I mean you are the hardest working quote
unquote overnight success because I know
you've been in the game grinding been
long that's a long night right there and
like right next to you here Verdine
right so Verdine I'm interrupting
because Victoria's right they did the
song
Together how you
[Music]
doing you look amazing she was the first
one that turned me on to you
I have loved you since '90s babies oh my
God that's long thank you yeah you know
congratulations best
album I'm bring out thank you so much
this is good huh it worked out didn't it
I know I I know I know this is good huh
I know
excited oh she's over there she just
went that way holding up she's like na
time I'm ready to get out of
here
all right so Litt mama just went this
way and that way I know you said she she
knows the word Grammy she been working
on her poses how dides she do it was nap
time so it's very like you have to get
her at a specific point in her day like
right after sugar not nap time so this
was like right in that window where
she's like uhuh she's too I get I'd be
like I'm like that and I'm 48 yeah yeah
same it's it's interesting to me because
in this day and time I mean I know you
couldn't have even predicted the success
number one of the album and then on my
mama but then the viral sensation of it
as well I mean I can't turn my head
anywhere without hearing yeah you know
what I always did want to be one of
those people who had a song that
eventually annoys people cuz it's played
so much and I think I don't know maybe
we're like maybe a month out from that
place you're like turn on my mama off
you know what I mean but I'm so happy my
radio team has been killing it my
manager and I really attribute a lot of
the success to the dance um the viral
dances so Sean Bankhead um Aza the
dancers that were in the music video
really brought it to life and everyone
who decided to recreate it and like do
it with their families that's what makes
it a collaborative effort with the fans
um to make it feel very very big so I
appreciate don't see R&B singers and
especially women anymore sing and dance
I mean it hearkens me to the Janet
Jackson's and those like when I watch
You artist yes seriously thank you is
that what did you come into this
thinking like I want to I want to be R
like I want to hearken back to those R&B
people that I love and that we love that
did it all I really think it's just what
I grew up on I feel like even Whitney
Houston the vocalist that she was had
some performances where she was dancing
she was hitting some moves so I feel
like didn't have a real one two step but
she tried she did she did she had some
energy on that stage and certain stage
presence and so I value artists who
really um just put that effort in I I
just a huge fan of dance um it's part of
what performances I adore the most um so
Michael Janet Beyonce uh Chris Brown
Usher like performers who just kind of
incorporate movement into it and I know
how much breath work it takes and
stamina and all how much work goes into
it so I just always really appreciate it
didn't you get a little gift from Miss
Beyonce she did s me flowers I looked at
that card and I was like no no no no no
no and I love white flowers and they
were all white flowers I know she sent
it to a few people who attended her
Renaissance film um Premiere but it's
still the most most valuable thing in my
home so just you know I save the bowl
the flowers didn't make it but I save
the bowl it's now my fruit bowl my
Beyonce fruit bowl I love it I'm trying
to reap the fruits right now I know that
you've got like 50 million things to do
and you're being pulled in 8 million
directions what what is it that keeps
you grounded what is it that keeps you
like good so you don't you know fall off
that Cliff or get too much or have too
much you know what I just really love to
do this I think that um it's not it's
just what I do I guess maybe if it was
more of like a um I don't know something
that I felt braggadocious about like
having it's not really like something
that I have it's something that I am so
I just around existing and loving music
and just wanting to do more you know
okay when you are deciding your dress
tonight and he was it always we're going
to match I did know that I did know that
from the beginning oh look at the tears
she's so she wants her mama you want
Mama John think you can come to
her you come to Mama come to
Mama Hi Pretty hi pretty all anyone with
a 2-year-old understands abolutely
before I let you these dresses you guys
oh my God custom Versace styled by Colin
Carter he's right here he's the man um
I'm so appreciative we're wearing buari
um jewelry and I'm so thankful that they
were willing to do both of our dresses
mommy daughter doess you look pretty
thank
[Music]
you first of all how is it being out I
mean did you escape tonight where's the
baby yes I did Escape because I'm always
on Auntie Duty so I can always Escape I
can be like sis yeah you know so I know
he's in good hands right now how is that
though being a cuz you two are so close
you and your sister are so close yes
we're like this thick as thieves and to
be able to be with her every step of the
process she is just such an incredible
mom I am so proud of her I'm so proud of
her tonight for her nomination for Angel
so I am just here as proud big sis how'
y'all keep this secret for so long how
did y'all do it just like we keep all of
our other
Secrets sisters do
best you had new music is there more
coming yes there's more coming
coachella's coming a lot of exciting
things so what do you got planned for
Coachella tell me about the performance
what do you cuz usually you have
performances yes going all out doing the
most of course and you know just dancing
and singing my heart out really yes all
right so your sister didn't come but you
came she's still going to be here she's
she's on the way she's on the way she's
on the way yes all right we can't wait
to see your sister we cannot wait to
it's so great to you can't wait to see
Coachella anything you can anything else
you want to tell us the preview or
anything else like oh man I'm just here
to prig sis tonight
Angel for the win Angel for the win
Auntie Chloe what we doing what are we
doing no you see you see auntie auntie I
was like I was like what we do Auntie do
I no no this is the grown Mermaid The
Little Mermaid is your sister this is a
grown mermaid it's a grown
mermaid the grown no but for real when
you saw this was you like what was it
about that you said okay I'm about to
step on some some necks my tummy is out
today and so I was like okay yeah let's
do it it and it feels very effortless
and like I feel like a Bronze
Goddess yes who made this dress oh yes
so Timothy styled it and it's like I
love it because it just feels like
molten gold you know that's why I love
it and the hair tone to
match yes thank you thank you
guys how you doing I'm doing real good
I'm just grateful to live this moment
yeah this is a big moment for you
tonight yes indeed so how have you been
all day is it are you nervous or there
excitement are you just chill we've been
chilling in the hotel we've been um
getting ready and real I mean I'm real
I'm saying about the nomination you won
I won you yeah we're celebrating come on
smile smile bigger than that you are we
are smiling we are smiling so how does
it feel to be a Grammy winner it it
feels great it feels awesome it's a
dream come true now you can exhale and
just have fun tonight right yes yes
we're celebrating now with my beautiful
girlfriend right here and you look
amazing you didn't want to come up here
look she didn't want to come up here but
she look so good when she walked out
what were you like no she uh she looks
amazing you looks amazing oh thank you
so much thank you so this is um you had
your first tour in the US last year with
I I don't know what like 50 something
sold out shows yeah it was it was a
great tour and this tour is gonna be
bigger what is that like when you walk
out and you see the house is just so
full and they're there for you I don't
know I'm just real thankful with people
that hears and supports my music every
day and and I know they're waiting for a
for a for a new album and for new music
so wait what are you going to do at
Coachella what can they expect from that
performance it's going to look great
it's going to look awesome you have to
be there yeah yes so I know people are
waiting for new music are you in the
studio are you writing are you are you
recording already I'm doing everything
at the same time I'm I'm just working
and keep grinding and I think it says
here that your third album Genesis was
the most streamed um first day music
Urbana album on Spotify already like you
had the most streams yeah I think so
yeah I'm I'm just I'm just happy to be
here you know well I mean there's so
much happening for you this year now
time has Time Magazine has named you one
of the 100 next big artists so do is
there a pressure to like live up to all
of these things that are happening nope
pressure no pressure at all I'm just
living my life loving to make music yes
okay who's on the collaboration front
for you now who's the next person you
say okay I'm I want to do something the
person I'm going standing next to so do
you get it do you make music together
yes we make music together sis come on
and it's a song coming out what is the
song's name oh you have to wait for that
look see there you go you have a good
you're going to have to wait for
that
Taylor where's Travis tonight where's
Travis Taylor you look Inc can we get
[Music]
away
[Applause]
t
[Music]
literally
SC
oh yeah I can set that
up
[Music]
to your right tayor Taylor to your right
to your right
tayor
she's
[Music]
married
he
[Music]
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say finally here yeah okay so you can
exhale now how does it feel we're
celebrating tonight yeah yeah it feel
good you know what I'm saying finally to
make it here um and be here for my own
purpose you I mean you've been nominated
four times you win tonight now can you
just relax and enjoy the show and what
are you most looking forward to seeing
um I'm just here to experience it I'm
saying it feel good to be here got my
wife with me it's VI I mean when she
walks out looking like this what do what
are what are we saying cuz good God
never let go
[Laughter]
I love that so much is there anybody
that you know that's performing tonight
that you're that you like are excited to
see oh I'm honestly uh excited about the
whole show you know what I'm saying it's
like I say it feel good to be here yeah
you you were just in Kanye and ta dois
sign's video right so I mean when you're
making music with them like I what's the
what's the process like um just to sum
it all up Evil Genius cuz it's the lead
single to his upcoming album so you've
seen it and I mean he's been teasing
what we're going to get and he is I
think those are great words for him evil
genus Evil Genius Evil Genius shout
outly he recently posted on IG I think
tell Dirk to activate tell Dirk to
activate his IG it's time to drop I'm a
couple days lateer but since we got the
good news I had to yeah yeah yeah so
what what did you did you post already
I'm post I got to post I got to post
these outfits tonight uh the wars
tonight so I'm feeling good tonight I
was going to say what does the night
bring cuz y'all look too good to just go
home um it's a change of plan we got go
back to the drwing board since we won
right it was going to be and now you
like no I got to celebrate my
baby yes I love that so much so good to
see you congratulations what's the next
I mean you know you got yay and Ty do
but who's the next collab or who's the
next person on your list somebody that
we wouldn't think that you would want to
work with that you really want to work
with um I want to say who y'all think I
wouldn't but I say Morgan Wilding really
that is somebody I didn't think you
would say yeah it's going to be a collab
album soon okay so you guys are going to
work together that's interesting Vibes
so so so that mean I'll see you again
next year you see what I'm saying Come
on talk your stuff I love it so much you
guys have a great night tonight who okay
who did this look by the way
L LA shout out La Roach Oh La Roach did
it love it love it well you look
spectacular good luck have a great night
tonight guys okay good to see y'all
okay
hold on you just won yes I just won what
the heck like it's crazy it's crazy okay
what does this mean though to win this
award for a song that everyone loves I
mean this one over
here
always right look
look what' I tell you it's amazing it's
I'm so proud of myself so proud of South
Africa Africa it's a win for us all so
I'm I'm just super blessed have any has
anybody called you yet from Africa that
is watching from South Africa everybody
blowing you up my phone it's it's crazy
my phone is blowing up really yeah it's
blowing up everybody calling everyone
celebrating it's a huge moment it's
amazing did you just see JT Jam in the
water did you see that that Justus
Timberlake was I never see that yes yes
he
was everybody loves this song Justin
somebody like I'm sing JT yes I did see
that that's crazy that's crazy you saw
it yeah I saw it it's amazing I I I
can't believe it I'm a lost for words
Janet Jackson was vibing to it Oprah
like it's gone it's gone okay when you
made this song what did you think when
you made the song when I made it I knew
it was special I knew like I loved it my
family loved it I had a dream about the
song so I feel like I knew in my spirit
that this was the one one how are you
celebrating tonight hey I'm going
out we have to we have you have to and
then you have to go home and celebrate
in South Africa everywhere I'm going I'm
celebrating now yeah show One More Time
come on come on me make
me yes you got she got it she needs to
teach me how to do the dance cuz I okay
hold on okay will you teach her cuz she
does she does it all the time so
it's wait this way or this way there you
go I'll give you private lesson she's
like keep trying this I'm going give you
the private lesson conratulations
congratulations thank you will you tell
us about the dress real quick yes so I'm
wearing custom
faace cute um I love it I love working
with them on the design and yeah just
came out perfect I couldn't have asked
for a better outfit for my first
Grammys yeah congratulations it's it's
the hit of the year I mean everybody
loves that
song come on you want the take over take
the mic take don't say anything crazy
hello we're at the Grammys Janelle Monae
and I wonderful wonderful night you know
what I love this there's nothing better
than a family night at the Grammys and
what does it mean to have your mom here
to enjoy this well one I could not
imagine winning a Grammy and my mom not
be there like it was so important as you
can see she's a ball of energy she's my
she's my foundation so I was like if I
win a Grammy I want my mama here so it's
a beautiful thing to have her with me
yes it is album of the it's an honor
right yes Prince will be so
happy album of the year though what is
that Progressive yes but when you put
that album together it you said you were
going to do something different and
you're going to do it your way and you
did that's what I'm saying she's
creeping up on that isn't she yeah
listen I I I tried my best in my art to
represent um my community in a in a deep
way and making music music and art for
us and most of the time it was rooted in
Seeking Justice for us yes this time
around I wanted joy for us Justice and
joy it can coexist and that's what the
age of pleasure was about uh making sure
that we felt safe enough to feel free
enough to be ourselves even more and
unapologetically and so I'm just so
happy that me being here represents a
community of marginalized folks who are
smiling who are happy who are working
through the pain you know uh of of of of
the the the Pains of life and and
finding Solace and finding love in one
another I think that you are one of the
voices out there especially among black
women who are telling things
authentically their way and it's been
important because you freed up a whole
Community has come out I I might be in
love with your mama I'm going to be
honest with you I love I love star the
real star I need my own talk show guys I
am so
funny we gonna get you your own talk
show so much it is good the uh my other
uh producers who worked on the project I
want to go take some photos with them
because some it's their first time here
I've been here a couple times so I'm
going run over there really fast tell me
about that dress real quick thank you
it's hermani PR Couture uh it's custom
and I'm just so I feel so good I feel so
Timeless I feel futuristic I Feel Like
Me Mama did you just touch my
boo your mom is the great you might stay
here I might keep your mom right here I
might keep your mom I might keep your
mom right
here did you see that they were singing
your song on SNL last
night I saw the clip and I I was
watching I was like where does the song
come in and then all of a sudden she
burst into song a capella and I was like
this is awesome there's been a couple
times that they've shouted me out this
year so thanks guys isn't that kind of
special though that people are
recognizing your music your career on
such a L platform yes well and I mean
all these years later as well like I'm
just so grateful that my music has
spanned kind of the test of time it's a
classic and that's what I'm going to
continue to do okay so you were
nominated tonight you guys didn't win
but it was still great to be here and be
nominated yes I mean to get nominated
once is an honor and then all this time
later for my peers to think that
something of mine is worthy to be
nominated again is is incredible so I'm
grateful and how was it working with
King and Country how was that easy it
was so easy they are the most kindest
men that I've ever met met their wives
as well their whole team they've just
been so great so they were texting me
earlier today like oh we can't wait to
see you so hopefully they'll pop up here
in a second I don't know where they are
but they were amazing to work with okay
so since I've known you since you've
been a young woman when you made your
last video with your husband a very
grown and sexy video yes what was that
what was the conversation like at home
to when you decided to make that video
it was actually my idea was it yeah I
was like it's time for you to show that
sexy side that I to the world and so I
feel like we did that and it worked it
worked it worked it worked the internet
will tell you just go to YouTube and
you'll see it worked um what does it
mean to have someone that is there to
support you and Champion you each and
every day I mean it's please don't get
me emotional I already had to like get
everything together earlier but um I've
never had someone who supports me the
way that Dana supports me he honestly
wants to see me do the best that I can
do he puts me on his shoulders every day
he's like babe what about this what
about this what about this you should do
this he encourages me when I'm like I
don't know he pushes me outside of my
comfort zone like he's a great dad he's
a great anr he's a great manager he's
all the things a great husband yeah this
one yeah keep and I always love the way
he shows the sexy side between the two
of you that you you know you got
children but that ain't stopping the
loving right how you think the kids got
here like come
on I mean he's right he's not wrong all
right fun to be here tonight tell me
about this dress this is dig mom and I
found it last minute at this amazing
showroom called The Show Must Go On and
yeah I put it on and just felt beautiful
and I felt that it represented where I
am now like I'm still a flower but don't
mess with me don't mess with you okay um
next videos what what is going to come
with the next videos go ahead babe not
me I I'm taking a break I'm taking a
break y'all can have her I'm going take
a break and we'll get another love
interest or something else it stres out
being in front of the camera can't you
see yeah that's a that's a lot he he
should be though you see this face he
should
[Music]
be we made it happen
guys had
a
[Music]
come on come
on
[Music]
you look amazing my guy the long all of
it is working for me you did you did are
you growing it for a project or did you
just decide like let me just I don't
know well to be honest like I was when I
knew that I I was going to have a baby
yeah I always wanted to have like that
picture of me with long hair I don't
know just you know like holding my baby
and it's like so organic so grounded I
don't know I just I just let my hair
grow because I feel I feel grounded
right now in my life I just like it like
that I love that How is suzan how's she
doing she good oh she's great my baby's
is growing pretty fast in her in her
mom's belly everything is doing great
thank you are I know you said
everything's great in light but are you
ready for this are you ready for
fatherhood well to be honest I I don't I
don't think you're always ready you know
I I would say like kids they don't come
with any manual so I just go with the
flow I really I really love her and I
and I love what I'm living right now I
can't imagine what's going to happen you
know but you're also having a girl and
you know what they say that does to a
man like you're done sir you're done
yeah to be honest that was a big Karma
you know you know I was like kind of
refused when I when I knew that I was
going to become a dad I kind of I was
feeling that that thing that I I didn't
want to have a girl you know because I
knew that that was going to be a Karma
but I'm just kidding I I love what's
going on right now she's going to have
you wrapped up so tight that little girl
is going to have you that's what my dad
tell me to because I have a sister and
all the sisters so she's always like my
dad's always like wait for wait for
Paris to be born man you're going to
know what's real love I love that you
guys already have decided what her name
is going to be did you was that just
always in the in the in the world yeah
the thing is that that's more like
cultural you know what I mean like there
in Colombia we think about names before
we we know that we're going to have
babies you know so I don't know and also
a crazy fact is that we actually had
that moment in Paris so Paris was yeah
that's what is Paris yeah I love that so
much okay I know you got to go but it
just um you just recently made history
you were as the first urban uh
Urbana I can't talk Urbana artist to be
number one on both the Latin airplan and
also the regional Mexican charts come on
like is there nothing that you touch
that doesn't turn to Gold well yo thank
you well thank you very much I really
appreciate that the only thing I'm going
to say is that I'm going to me not
winning the the Grammy you know what I
mean because I was nominated I'm
nominated today as b l album pop and and
it's I just wanted to Happ in my arms so
let's see if next year we're going to
have the chance to be nominated again
and maybe taking it home and then you
can come with Paris and your whole
family and it'll be all family it be
nice too you know I'm not in a rush I'm
just enjoying my life enjoying the
moment that I'm living well have an
amazing time tonight it's always good to
see you my man and congratulations on
everything
[Music]
okay hi Mommy hi so I'm so happy for you
and you you know what I love about it
how is like you just like you radiate
this goodness and you just seem like you
are on top of the world right now is
that is that the case that is truly the
case I'm so excited to be here tonight
I'm like I'm with my boo I'm like having
the greatest time y boo he was just
holding hand yeah yeah yeah I love but
yeah so it's date night y'all like you
got to take these when you can get them
because now that you're new parents
you're not going to get all those date
nights anymore so what is date night
bring for you guys oh my gosh we're so
excited to see the performances to chill
and to just be nominated is an honor so
I just can't believe I'm in this room
tonight yeah well you're here baby
you're not going anywhere who are you um
excited to see on the stage cuz there's
going to be a lot of iconic moment oh
wow I'm so excited to see everyone
honestly I mean I heard scissors
performing so I can't wait to see that
the list could go on your color purple
sister frasia is doing a tribute to Tina
Turner tonight be amazing how is this
run been for you I know there was I was
disappointed that there was not a best
picture nomination that there was not a
best picture nomination for you guys for
The Color Purple I think you very
deserve it's one of the best movies of
the year but so how has this ride been
for you and now is it like okay I really
I kind of have the acting bug so I'm
going to do this for a minute yeah I'm
GNA keep going I mean acting has been so
much fun for me a beautiful new outlet
and I'm excited to take on more projects
so now you're about to break the
internet with this dress cuz the people
are going to say how she just have a b
look at this how' you just s back how
did you just have a baby I mean why when
you saw this dress what was it about it
that made you say this is it for this
night oh I really love the stress Gucci
made it for me and I feel confident I'm
really excited I think I was excited to
kind of step back and wear start wearing
form fitting stuff after pregnancy so
it's it's been really fun do you do you
feel different being a mama like is
there is there an added confidence is
there just what what changed
for you yeah I definitely feel more
powerful and like more womanly you know
yeah I love
that well you guys are the cutest little
family have a good night listen you and
your sister shut down everybody here
tonight cuz she walked in here like I'm
having mying didn't she though and she
was so excited for us to call her auntie
oh yeah thank you I love it have a good
night tonight good to see you
[Music]
baby
hello love how are you oh honey these
earrings great to see baby hold on a
second I'm just kidding they're
ridiculous okay I just feel like you and
David geta need to just do just do an
album I know I told him I said David
come on bro let's do an out no but you
know what we're working on it seriously
you guys have the the sauce together so
we do we do but we we know it's it's a
it's a LoveHate relationship More Love
but he called me his annoying little
sister and I was like excuse me if I'm
your annoying little sister then you're
my annoying older brother right there
you go you want the old monik man yeah
exactly I think maybe sometimes that's
the best way to make music you know what
I'm saying when it's like you know
you're get on my nerves you're get on my
nerves but then here comes the magic
that's the best that's the best music
yeah yeah I love it so much so tonight
um what I love about the Grammys are
those collaborations or what we see on
happening on the stage anybody that
you're like okay this is I'm I'm excited
honestly I'm excited to see Dua I got to
support her my Albanian Queen um I'm I'm
excited to see Lana I just saw her pass
by and I just think her music's so
amazing I think it's finally Lana's time
to shine um so I'm really excited for
her honestly the girls listen you okay
you took the words right out of my mouth
I was talking to Billy Joel ear oh my
gosh how was that well first of all I
God I just cracked I had to say to him I
said um I have to admit that I'm nervous
right now because you're it's you but
he's performing for the first time in 30
years on the Grammy stage
and I said to him like who do you love
right now and what he said is Olivia
Rodrigo Billy eish Taylor Swift like
like du and that's what he said he said
something about what the women are doing
right now is special is another level
why do you think that because I believe
it too I just feel like we're in an are
you what's the girls doing let me think
let me think about this answer I just
feel like the girls are just doing what
they want yeah you know what I mean the
more empowered that we get the more
power that we get like like we're just
kind of standing in our own and it's
time like you know I have such like I
want to see who oh it's Carol oh I got
to go say hi but yeah but anyway
Caesar anyways sorry no but I this is
like on I actually do have it like on
the red carpet is not good it's like a
family reunion here though really is you
get to see people you haven't seen you
get to hang out
again I want you to enjoy every minute
of this night I love seeing you okay
tell me a little something what's the
drama you're giving us for this look h
like everything Robert wound like black
widow Vibes I'm newly
single okay call me all right are we are
we taking suitors are we taking time uh
uh fun okay I like I like I like single
you I like single you cuz there's a sass
there's a confident you stand a little
tall leg up and this face is beat thank
you number one album in the country
you're rolling here and you you're a
superstar tonight but what does that
mean to have the number one album in the
country uh it just feel good like got my
hard work paying off and the nominations
tonight also to be recognized because we
know for a long time the Grammys will
Overlook artists right right we know
that but to do the work and then have it
recognized what does that mean to you it
feel good it's a good feeling yeah yeah
for sure okay great collaborations right
but if you win tonight where's the party
W I'mma probably party at my hotel I
don't really like party you lay low you
laying low tonight yeah but it's also
got to be cool like Lenny krait's right
there rolling with seeing all the stars
and everybody would you ever collab with
Lenny yeah for sure he a legend he's a
right right that's what I'm saying hold
on what wait wait we're going to tell
him we're going to tell him right now
let's tell Lenny gra that you need to do
a collab hold on one second we're going
to tell him hold on we're going to tell
him right now cuz he need if anybody
needs to be on his next record is you we
appreciated it so so much Nelle Nelle
right thank you Bab Nelle tell Lenny 21
Savage wants to be on your next record
he's
losing what's happening man let's do it
good yeah let's do it man good you too
all right man yeah for sure see we we're
working out things
here this is what the Grammys are about
this is a collab we're waiting for right
21 Savage lny
Krav that's a collaboration that we we
need don't play we need this right I'm
for real all right get it done can you
do something for me
21 all right tell me about SNL oh yeah
I'm doing SNL on the 24th yeah on the
24th but what do you what do you got
planned nobody goes the SNL and just
surprise who's going to be with you will
you have anybody with you what I'm going
have some people with me oh you're
bringing some folks yeah like who come
on I can't tell you but it'll be
something special yeah for sure
I haven't had a chance to congratulate
you first of all since the emies I've
have not seen you come on in here come
on it's a it was a family win yes it
is you should have congratulated you
because no but let me tell you why you
should have congratulated you and people
didn't mention this that people told you
you couldn't do serious stuff the people
told you that you were just a funny lady
you should be off to the side do your
fun funny thing and stop yeah and you
said damn it I'm going to show you I got
to show you I got to show you something
and you showed the whole world and it's
been thing after not one but it's been
thing after thing after thing after
thing so I just do not make me cry my
fake eyelashes off I'm at the gramys but
I was just so happy for that moment
because you manifested that you said I'm
going go and show y'all you know I had a
wonderful support system and uh and we
were able to bring home that award and
I've been I'm still floating you should
be floating by the way where is the
award at home in in the front actually
in the front door as soon as you walk
soon as you walk in it sings to you it's
like wo right there with my big bouquet
that I got from Oprah yes yes this
really isn't your night it's your night
cuz you're the musician in the family so
what is it that makes the Grammy so
special oh being able to be among so
many amazing musicians and artists and
uh people that I've looked up to for
over the years so I'm excited to be here
Kevin I I love that I got invited on the
date normally I'm like hey come with me
to this thing and now she's like you
want to go to the gramys I'm like
okay I'm going to take you yeah you're
my day um I also want to talk about
origin because it has been doing well in
the theaters it expanded to a to more um
audiences now why is it so important for
people to see this movie wow for such a
time as this it it it it opens your mind
it invites you to think differently and
to unlearn some things so it it's
definitely a must SE it's a must SE it
really is a movie that will change it's
not like we go to movies to escape and
have fun but this one it changes your
life forever absolutely very powerful
message I think it's a masterpiece so I
enjoyed
it
[Music]
on
he
[Music]
okay so first of all mom Night Out how'd
you get away and are what are the babies
doing I was just with them they are at
home just playing together it's so sweet
and so feel so blessed and so lucky how
is motherhood because I know you were
ready you waited you know and then what
does it mean to you to fin be a mother
especially because of the love that you
have for your mom my life just feel
feels so complete my husband my two
beautiful babies just feels like all my
dreams come true and I just feel so
fulfilled and just happy at life okay
Paris the DJ is here tonight though
right you're Paris the DJ what is it
what are you looking for tonight who are
you excited to see I'm just excited to
see so many my favorite artists excited
for Miley nominated six times she is
such an icon and I'm just so excited for
my second album CA is executive
producing it
what can you okay so what can you tell
me about the album the album is mean a
lot of amazing badass femails on it and
a lot of surprises and it's all about my
journey and everything that I've went
through in my life and I'm just so
excited and honored to have CA executive
producing and writing all the music with
me okay so do your kids love it when you
play music for them do you play music
for them what do you play for them my
kids love music music Phoenix just got a
little piano for his first birthday so
he's been playing on the piano and he
loves stars are blind it's his favorite
love ofi since he was born man Paris
this has been such a crazy journey I
mean I can think back to way back in the
day and all the trials and tribulations
and all that stuff and when you think of
that what would you if you could whisper
in your ear and tell yourself something
what would you say say you're going to
go through a lot in life one day you're
going to have the most beautiful perfect
life and family so keep going
girl you kept going you kept going it's
good to see you anything else Paris
that's coming up um just everything
about to release my 30th
fragrance and wait wait a minute your
30th 30th
yes I know what does this one smell like
it's just the most beautiful unique
scent I've ever smelled before it's my
favorite perfume ever won't you get into
the baby clothes business or something
doing children stuff too yes we have
children children's furniture and
children's clothing and doing a huge
deal with Walmart so everything will be
out very soon wow so when can we see
that stuff that will be out by this fall
with my new clothing line and jewelry
and
Handbags damn Paris you do ever you
never stop do you there is no slowing
you down is there there's nothing
slowing me down can you tell us a secret
about your fashion tonight tonight well
I'm wearing this gorgeous mermaid gown
and then I had this custom made for my
handbag line cuz I'm representing Hilton
tonight cuz they're a big part of the
awards and just wanted to represent
Hilton for the
stay you really went all the way in
Queen right you will Market one thing
you will do is Market something right I
invented
it that's real actually some people
copied right some people copied you but
you it's nothing like the original how
has it been living life in the Paris
Hilton Fishbowl but you guys have a very
normal life you have kids now so
everything has to be normal it's just
amazing watching Paris be a mom we love
to just stay home play with the babies
watching her mother is pretty awesome
yeah and what is Paris Hilton the mom
like uh well let's see the other day I
came home Paris was on a motorized
scooter and Phoenix was following her
around and they were doing relay races
so let's just say she's a fun and a sing
mom sing
Mom I love it thanks have a great day
okay first of all all the nominations
how how good does it feel to be that
your peers love you it feels incredible
like I never expected four nominations
and I'm just just so happy like I'm so
excited yes okay um are you excited for
this Super Bowl commercial I am I am
shout out to Star they held it down
period what was it like shooting a Super
Bowl commercial how big is it going to
be cuz that's the biggest day of the
year the commercials are better than in
game half time yeah they are um I don't
know I'm just really excited the
commercial was fun it was my second
commercial ever and um yeah it was it
was a little bit of a challenge filming
but we got why because lemon lime wasn't
actually present so I was talking to
nobody really but also you kind of just
talking to the green screen yeah we was
just you know getting our little acting
out more music coming right yes album
dropping this year Y2K tune in on when
when when is it dropping
2024 that's all you can tell me come on
now yes that's all okay tell me about
collabs or anybody that's on there I
can't let that be known yet but my fans
will be very pleased 2023 was an insane
year so to cap it off now with the
Grammys in 2024 what would that mean to
you it just means everything I'm just so
happy to be acknowledged and you know
it's a big deal to
me okay I don't know what was happening
I don't know what's going on there's a
lot going on there's a lot like your
2023 yeah exactly enjoy the night okay
all right and good
luck on did you know that this song was
going to blow up like it did like it was
going to take the World by storm no no I
mean one lives in Hope but uh no I had
no idea I was seeing P now I'm like Pam
R pam pam can you explain padam to me
please well within the within the song
it's the heartbeat you
know but took on a you know a myriad of
uh of
meanings and at the time when it came
out first came out it was a greeting it
was a farewell it was who knows what
whatever you
like and it is such like people lose it
in clubs when they play it have you had
a chance to be in like do you sometimes
sneak into the club and you hear it and
everybody's goes crazy well I had a few
moments when we were doing listening
parties and just the place erupted I was
kind of faux DJing like literally just
press play but I was quite comfortable
there yeah I do what does it also mean
to stay relevant with folks in
generation after generation after
generation which is very very cool well
obviously means a lot to me but I feel
like this current moment for myself is
beyond me that others might look at what
I've achieved and and go hey that's you
know she's broken a fair number of rules
in her time and and you can it can be
done you can achieve anything you want
anytime yeah I mean of course you know
it's uh we we never stop working but
it's it's a great moment and I think
I've been doing this long enough to
really actively be cognizant that this
this is a great moment amongst the
madness I'm I'm is it that as we get
older we start to realize how precious
these moments are is that what it is
entirely yeah so to still be here to to
um to have won tonight do you know that
I won hold on you won I
won wait a minute oh you won I didn't
not telling you this when I first like
yes I got two
now
wow where where are you going to put
this Grammy next to the other
one I thought you'd build like some kind
of special place for this uh it'll it'll
come back to Australia with me okay tell
me your speech cuz we didn't get to hear
the speech so tell me there was it was
in the pre-show and I was getting ready
so I got the news in my uh robe my
dressing gown kind of ready I screamed I
cried I was shaking and I had to stop
before you went to the ugly cry just
like trying we've just she's ready don't
undo it all with with tears but I was so
were you watching were you watching the
stream or were you getting a you got a
call I my manager came to the came to
the door and came in saying two time
Grammy that's all she got out I I I
screamed it it's all it's on my it's on
my Instagram yeah yeah just lost it I
lost it it was a great moment and then I
had to get back to focus cuz you look
great right now so clearly you pulled it
back together and got everything I I
brought it back from the brink yeah okay
well Kylie Mano two-time Grammy winner
have an amazing night great to see you
thank you tell us about this dress yes
um well I thought I'd come putam red and
and it's do kabana my good friends and
if ID factored in the rain I might have
done without the the train situation but
just get a little wet that's that's all
right badam padam to you
okay thank you all for joining us here
on ET for all of your coverage from the
2024 Grammy Awards and never forget you
can always catch us on etonline.com take
care
come on come
[Music]
on
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say am I a member because I got the m
memo come on now
great I got the
memo I think I think I just joined
pentatonics
everybody well y'all know first of all
y'all know that you do the music does it
for me all the time so I mean it does
it's first of all it's like music is
healing anyway but your music is so
joyous and it's just like a feast for
the ear so it just makes me happy and I
mean everybody thinks that you're here
because you're nominated again so of
course oh my gosh yes we can't believe
we're nominated for an album we put so
much heart and soul into it's a it's a
world holiday album where we celebrated
all these different cultures and learned
about their music and their culture and
how they celebrate the holidays we
collaborated with the most iconic
artists from all these different
countries and it was so fulfilling and
such a beautiful Journey making this
album so to see it celebrated by our
peers in this way it's just surreal it's
the only word I can think of do y'all
ever feel like us like if you're in the
studio you're recording something and
then you hear like oh damn we just did
that I mean seriously do you ever feel
like that
D yeah some especially because we're
such fans of each other too you know so
like when I hear a certain thing it's
not things Kevin it just inspires us to
keep going and keep pushing further and
so it's it's like we feel like kids in
the playground like they get to play in
the sandbox you know okay how do you
decide like when you hear your name
called who gets to say who gets to speak
give the speech of oh we haven't even
talked about it now I'm creating
problems we're figuring it out right
here right now yeah you I think I'd be
so nervous and like shocked so I would
probably Mama's got diamonds so Mama
should be able to do it oh yeah Mama's
just going to go here well hopefully
they won't leave me behind because I'm
GNA Have To Shimmy Shimmy onto the you
guys are part of the opening ceremony
for the premiere ceremony yeah with like
Jordan Sparks and Jay Ivy and all of
that what was that moment oh my gosh it
was so good we did Prince Let's Go Crazy
everybody was just unbelievable it's so
cool to see such diversity of Talent on
one stage and that's what I think makes
the stagram is so just unbelievably
iconic that all these artists from
completely different walks of life can
be on the same stage and showcase their
talent but it all is working
harmoniously together it's it's just the
coolest thing I feel so blessed that we
get to do this each other everyone was
so kind we were all like hyping each
other up and it was just such a fun song
and a fun way to like start our Grammy
day all right so what's coming up next
that's a great question you know I think
what we've talked about a
lot baby girl m time to come on in I had
Sheila E bust into your interview come
on we just perform together just talking
about
it they were just talking about how cool
it was for all these different talents
to get together open up the ceremony
kind of celebrate music and celebrate
each other oh absolutely it was amazing
I had a blast I mean I get to play with
them come on
really she she gave a master class on
energy like I it was amazing to watch
you perform and like taking the the the
mic and everything and just I did the
simp like master class thank you thank
you thank you something happens to her
when she gets on
those oh my gosh yes it was
unbelievable well thank you guys so much
Sheila you stick
around find each other in like a very
similar G up no we're like sparkles
sparkles you know yes and this is giving
tonight so was it when you saw it on the
rack when you put it on what was it
about it this is a custom dress by k um
that was made for me um I feel very
excited to wear it I feel very strong in
it it's definitely a heavy like metal
dress I was like feel very
jonok no but for real yeah well listen
you had a very strong year I'm having
I'm having fun so the last time I talked
to you at the Golden Globes you were
telling me about your new music and you
were saying you know this record is
about understanding your worth and
different chapters of your life so on
the 15th we're getting okay so what are
you what are you giving on the so on the
15th like you said a new S I mean it'll
be late in the evening on the 15th but
um a new song which is just about kind
of knowing how
to it's almost like not expecting PE to
for people to like love you right yeah
okay you know yeah you're just like
preach baby training season's over you
know you're done teaching people how to
do things right exactly come correct or
don't come at all correct or don't come
at all exactly that's the vibe that's
the vibe love that so much I can't wait
because it does feel like this record is
going to be a very personal one for you
it is and you know I I got to do most of
the record at home in
London um I just felt like and I feel
like with every album I get to grow more
and learn more about myself and I become
more free as a songwriter and as a
performer and as an artist so this one
I'm just like digging deeper and deeper
I love it I'm I'm proud of this heard of
you as an artist that says I'm a little
nervous because this year for you like
has been in the stratosphere as far as
music is concerned you know what I'm
saying and I mean just career in general
but is there a part of you that's like
okay now I got to follow up with like
just an incredible year that I I mean
there's always pressure yeah there's
always pressure but I think for as long
as I'm doing things that I'm proud of
things that I love things that I feel
like I'm pushing myself and trying out
something different and I'm growing as
an artist and as a person then I'm good
you know well the groomies is also about
the performances and what's going to
happen on stage so what can we expect
from oh we got something special for you
guys tonight she gives the smile like
the biggest smile I'm really really
excited about this performance like more
more so than any three words give me in
three words what this performance is
going to oh my God we we have it's
like it's intense okay uh it's strong
and uh it's Dy okay I love it so you you
have two nominations tonight dance the
night away we're still dancing to it so
I mean when you think about that song
when you were making it did you think
okay I got I got something here like
this is I mean I know you didn't know
what it was going to do but but were you
like okay yeah I got something here yeah
I mean in the moment again it goes back
to that thing for as long as I feel like
I'm having fun of making something that
I'm really proud of and I'm in the
moment and I'm I'm exactly where I'm
supposed to be and I feel that way with
you know when we were making Dance T
night we were having such a great time
in the studio it felt so good to be a
part of such an incredible project it
felt so good to do it with my friends
that whole experience as a whole was
really special so um yeah I'm I'm happy
that that's like way out into the world
now and like had its own life and it's
it's been great well finally I was in
London didn't get to talk to you there
but I was there for AR guy you have this
movie coming out it is fun fun fun in so
many ways and you get to cut up a little
bit in this movie and get a little
dancing going on I did get to do a
little bit of I mean I have a a small
role but I'm I loved working on a film
set and for Matthew Vaughn to give me
that opportunity I'm so grateful for it
and I had fun with my co-stars with
Henry caval and John Cena and are you
and John the new Hollywood Duo that we
didn't know we needed uh I don't know if
our acting career will continue together
um but I anytime I see him it's an
absolute pleasure and I I loved working
with him and he's so wonderful so who
knows he told me he was so embarrassed
because he had to sing off key to you
and he was like why am I doing this to
myself he was he's such a good sport
honestly he wasn't even off key I think
he's just so humble that he's just you
know it's it's it was wonderful
really it was what made this year
possible we decided it before we even
recorded that it was going to be a
limited time and it's part of why we've
like given so much to this we can't
sustain this level of doing personally
yeah boy Genius opening up about their
Hiatus after winning at the 2024 Grammys
the Grammy goes
to not strong enough boy it's just like
isn't
real uh yeah thank you uh thank you to
our band uh thank you to everyone that
uh contributed to the record I just want
to say well music saved my life everyone
can be in a band this band is my family
ahead of the award show the trio snagged
a trophy ET getting their full reaction
on the red carpet amazing amazing we
were like rushing getting dressed when
the live stream was on so I had to play
it cool I was like oh yeah cool but it
was amazing wait wait wait shut up like
you I thought someone had like dropped a
vase or something like and we were like
and then we screamed B yeah the band's
Big Win comes just days after they
announced at a secret show they're going
on Hiatus we're all just going to go
chill and it's made it like really
special like knowing that the shows are
limited and and we have a plan we have a
plan to watch Paddington 2o which
everybody has told us is amazing and
we've been like planning to watch it
together for years so we said after all
this we're going to watch Paddington too
as for what this means for the future of
the Indie band I mean I'm not convinced
how do you know how do you know a meteor
is not going to crash into Earth
tomorrow you know what I'm saying like
but I don't know we're going to be
friends just be H I'm telling myself
beud it yeah with like what has happened
and not just like more more more yeah
it's been a question since our first
week of promoting the album what are you
guys doing next and we're like what do
you mean it's just that like stay here
in the moment yeah yeah I think it's
like maybe the finitude will help people
realize that like the thing that we give
is enough the album is enough we're
proud of it it's a recording you can go
listen to it anytime yeah it's
there Grammys I know never gets old for
you the night of this it's like it is
music's night right it's definitely
music's night and I love seeing all the
different looks come on carpet seeing
how everybody went all out exactly so
what you know for me it's about the
collaborations that we see on stage is
there anybody that you're looking
forward to seeing perform tonight uh oh
my gosh I'm trying to think who's
performing that I I guess like uh
dualipa I want to hear she just left and
she said oh I got something for y'all
tonight and as far as looks I can't wait
to see what DOA cat is going to wear you
know she's going to come with some
something ivant look she might walk out
here with nothing on as far as they say
it's going to be a little art it's going
to be a work of art I can't wait to see
it I believe it I believe every minute
about it okay so what's happening with
Escape right now you guys still
performing I know I've seen you on a few
dates where are you just staying on
tours we're putting together tour right
now for later this summer M if you need
somebody else I mean Tiny's daughter if
y'all need another member killing it
right and She's Not Afraid we put her on
stage and it's a whole Arena full of
people and she can just belt it out you
know the the question on everybody's
mind is what's happening in Atlanta and
are you going to be back and do we know
what I have been trying to figure that
out for myself to be honest with you and
um I don't know I'm thinking
that I'm thinking I might just say is it
time I've been going back and forth and
I think because they gave us such a long
break I had a lot of time to do other
things and I got some big announcements
to make coming soon so yeah I was like I
mean I love the girls they're my friends
I'm still going to see them and hang out
with them and Bravo as my family I love
them as well but you know okay I'm going
to drill down are you making an
announcement right now that you are
going to take a break from Atlanta now
you done put the pressure on but I guess
yeah okay yeah cuz I mean somebody asked
me recently they were like well why do
you um keep doing it and I was like to
be honest with you I think because I've
been doing it I 14 years and so now I
feel like it's it's I do it because I
I'm used to doing it but with all the
other things that I got going on I just
like I might just yeah I don't know if I
could imagine the show without you but I
I couldn't either at first but I think
when they decided you know like they
were like okay we you know we taking
this break to you know rearrange the
cast and all this other kind of stuff
and then it's like it gave me time you
know I never had time I never had time
one yeah and I still was working don't
get me wrong I still had a lot of stuff
going on but it was like I had more time
to pick up my kids I had more time to be
in the studio so I've been writing a lot
and I have more time to work on these
other projects that y'all going to see
okay well listen you keep saying that so
you got to give me something cuz you
keep saying I'm G have a big
announcement I got to work on these
other projects well I mean you know I'm
doing Broadway and I already had um you
know we have the Wiz that's I'll be
there March 13th in New York to see the
show and I'll be there February 13th in
LA to see okay thank you y be here so
yeah um so I'm excited for that and then
I got some more things to announce in
that lane as well and you know too much
too I don't want to talk too much ahead
of time but yeah it's a great so maybe
more Broadway maybe more of that but I
know you're working on that OT you said
it you manifesting it you ready to do
and I'm still I'm manifesting yeah so
something in that realm for sure like um
because I I don't want to give away too
much that I have to come I mean I'll
just say I have some big things coming
so keep stay tuned but um I do love the
franchise but it's just you know you
know when everybody kind of keeps you
like at limbo for so long you start
making other plans you're the longest
running housewife to date at this point
that's a oh Lord Jesus you know I love
the house you know I love you so I'm
getting palpitations from this I
understand though I do get it I do
understand it and like if this is you
know Andy might say maybe it's a pause
for you yeah that's what he called me
okay and because I I've talked to him
about it and he said well I don't he's
like I don't know how I feel about this
and I said well honestly I don't know
how I feel about it either but he was
like well you do realize this are this
is your family like if you just want to
just come back next year that's fine and
I'm like I mean I love you guys and I
appreciate like it's it's my my family
you know what I mean so yeah I'm always
a part of them you know they're always a
part of me you have given you I'm
gagging right now I'm giving I
[Music]
love
he
[Music]
hello how are you my goodness I have not
seen you in so long and you come through
here looking like the supermodel that
you are you look stunning here I'm going
bring you turn you around little a
little bit more like this so we can see
your whole face okay you look stunning
tell me about this look from head to toe
tonight head to toe it's just Seline
Mama it's all all Seline Head To Toe
with my my own jewelry and um covered
all the tattoos I was going to say Paris
I know you have tattoos and I don't see
anything what did how long did that take
took a few hours it took a few hours
yeah why did you do it was it because
you just wanted to go like super Glam
tonight super Chic tonight well I like
switching things up I love my tattoos I
love my piercings I love all the body
modification stuff art and also
sometimes I don't want it to distract
from the art that is the fashion I'm
wearing and I kind of it just gives it
gives the dress its own moment it's
giving for sure um I wonder because you
have you've got new music coming out um
and it's uh just a couple a couple
months um so I haven't decided when yet
but when I was on tour with Incubus
uh I dropped a single that I just did
with Linda Perry and so she and I just
she's like my Aries twin flame so we're
we want to keep working together and
sometimes talking to a lot of other um
celebrities or children of celebrities
they really want to kind of figure out
their own lane and don't want to you
know they love their parent and love
everything they've done but they want to
figure out their own lane and make their
own path well depends on how meta you're
getting if you want to go on a much
Universal Collective Consciousness thing
I think we're all one so depends on how
how far you want to go with that like
okay so what is this new music what is
it giving like what are what um what
were you in what era were you in when
you were making it or what like what's
your inspiration um inspo is usually um
pain and love and the space between um
but my record exact Monty thinks that
Linda is my muse so Lind can't go wrong
with Linda
Perry we cannot wait for this new music
who are you you looking forward to
seeing getting on this Grammy stage
tonight every single human every single
one every single one you want it all all
right thisis thank you so much I
appreciate it
okay okay first of all um you're DJing
at the Super Bowl right all week long
you have a residency in Vegas so what do
I need to do to get tickets to get in to
see you right uh be my best friend and I
can get you in how exciting is that
though because the town will be buzzing
especially this week but to be Vegas
that's a lot of energy it is I love
Vegas and I have a home with the wind
now I'll actually be playing there all
year long and I am just so grateful to
them they've really like treated me like
family and there's no better place to be
in Vegas than the wi okay tell me about
the podcast and what actually goes on
because there are things y'all can tell
people and there are things you know so
how far do you go in this podcast we go
pretty good do you you know what I so
it's called sorry we're stoned for a
reason although she does not partake so
she keeps us all together so if I'm
starting to spill too much tea she's
like Mom zip it pull it in Pull It in
rain it in Miley's performing tonight I
think flowers is such a little Bop and
people love that song but it feels like
it also tells a lot about her life and
her story when you listen to that song
what do you know that I don't know you
know what you got to dissect those
lyrics I think the fans know more than
anybody knows they absolutely do they
dissected that pretty well for us I
think I did I I mean people opened up
those lyrics like they were reading a
book like it was a memoir you know what
there were some taken pretty far so I
like yeah but over overall like I think
Miley had so much fun making that song
and like she you know she says it over
and over like no expectations of it just
from her heart putting it out and to see
it see its success has been so
incredible you know and also there's
just so much talk about how this is like
the next iteration of Miley you know and
so it's like she continues to have
success at every level as she grows how
cool is that to watch her success it is
so incredible but as her mom it's
watching her grow into this woman she's
become at 30 and once she just 30
remember that just 30 exactly 31 but
it's so crazy to think she's only 31 and
that everything that she's achieved but
as a person she's just the most
incredible human being I I'm so proud of
her okay okay real quick how many Miley
songs do you play during your DJ set
minimum three a minimum of three minimum
of three I like to the family okay do
you have a favorite family song um I
mean right now flowers just goes off so
hard also Noah did a song with Diplo a
couple years ago and I play that one
quite a bit also oel Road's always a hit
like Metro station I play Shake It The
Crowd Goes Crazy it really I I like to
represent my family y'all got hits y'all
got y'all got hits all right remember
when I'm standing to the door I'm
calling your name I'm calling you all
right for super for Super Bowl
[Music]
weekend listen we're here celebrating
though because you guys have already won
six nominations night you've already won
one does it take a little like now you
can exhale a little bit and just go into
the rest of it like no 100% I was like
okay okay we're good like that's fine if
if nothing else happens the rest of the
night that's I'm 100% % fine with that I
am so like excited for all the nominees
I'm like happy to be here we got one
we're out it's all good we're great if
we hadn't it would have been fine too
right we're chill do you still get
nervous do y'all still get nervous we
always joke that like you kind of you
kind of are like you know what
everyone's amazing you know whoever wins
that's czy but they're like the not
they're like they're like
congratulations on D so appreciate you
man oh my God you um um anyway they say
they say the award goes to and your
heart starts you know pounding moment
it's like everything before that is like
we're chill and then it's like the
moment that like envelope or like the
yeah the Grammy goes to it's it's like
it's like in your throat it's let me ask
you this cuz um you know swarm was my
thing like I loved it so for real and
I'm like this girl's good like will
there ever be a time where you say Let
me let me stop with music for a second
and really kind of dig deep into the
acting for
sure is it happening soon I don't know
girl because listen well but critic's
choice you said to us yes I got music
coming I don't know how much I can talk
about it yet but I have music coming I
do have that that is for sure on the way
very very soon didn't you say it's about
85% done oh no it's it's like 99 it's
right there yeah I know we've been
saying that for a long time but we can't
give too many details CU then people get
excited then they get mad okay then just
give me three words of the vibe of the
album it is
that's not that's not alol
musical no it's like I was saying the
other day that it's like a I think it's
a perfect representation of like natural
progression of
like I don't know oh wait you are so oh
you are so terrible of where you are
okay well where are you in life maybe
that'll give me a CH an indication of
where the music yes is it like you're
chill are you chill are you like in a
real happy era a real
it's all over the place it's a lot of
feeling it's a lot of um it's like some
whatever relax girl jeez all right
listen Okay so we've got you can't take
a break because after the Grammys we
have the Oscars you guys are nominated
will you be
performing I mean I think we're required
to well I don't know you could say no I
don't want to but oh yeah no way dude
I'm are you kidding me performing at the
Oscars is like I'm I'm literally like a
please like I'm yeah it's the coolest
thing in the world I mean y'all could
just have a whole Barbie section because
Ry Ryan said he wanted to perform too oh
yeah and I can't wait to hear yeah God
all right so do we think have we already
started thinking about this like what's
going to go into this performance what
it'll look like what it'll feel like for
the Oscars you've been working on the
Grammy performance we're here working on
that one Grammy one yeah I mean it's you
know we're here we're doing Barbie we're
doing we're doing it you are you are I
love you guys congratulations have a
great night I can't wait to see what you
do by the way besides your performance
tonight anybody you just can't wait to
see on that stage honestly I don't even
know like who's even all here which I'm
soundchecking that was tight can't wait
so excited I'm I'm geeked to see Luke
Holmes and Tracy Chapman get on stage
and do fast car together like that for
me cuz that's my I'm dating myself but
that's like my My Generation uhhuh yeah
I'm excited I like try not to know
what's going to happen because I like to
be surprised so we'll see
there is so much still to come from the
Grammy Awards stick with ET we have so
much more coming after the
[Music]
break
he
[Music]
the glitz the Glam and the outrageous
listen the gramy awards red carpet it
never disappoints there's always
something that will surprise you yes
indeed and here are a few of our
favorite moments from the night did the
rain wreck your look because we know
let's be honest that rain will wreck a
hair dude absolutely not you know the
best things happen when I'm Singing in
the Rain so maybe it's a good luck charm
okay five nominations I mean I hear you
were asleep on the plane when the
nominations came through and you had no
idea I was fully asleep and I thought
that by the time I landed that's when I
would find out cuz that's when it would
be announced I completely got the time
change wrong I woke up to my phone
blowing up with text messages and that's
when I knew but I was the last to know
what did that feel that moment feel like
when you started looking at the phone
and seeing the nomination after
nomination after nomination what really
took me out was the five everyone kept
mentioning five five five I was like
what does that mean and when I finally
landed and I got to call people back
that's when I just lost it it's got to
be a great moment though it's got to be
a great it's so beautiful um it's just
refreshing to see you reap the benefits
of all the time you know your hard work
you you worked hard this isn't a you
know overnight success story you worked
your butt off so that's got to be that's
got to feel it feels great to have not
given up but also it feels better to
promote a timeline that took a while you
know I'm not I'm not afraid of that I'm
not ashamed of that and I want to
continue to give younger black women
this reminder that if it takes a lot of
time that doesn't reflect on your value
it doesn't reflect on your worth it
doesn't reflect on the possibility of
you still getting where you need to go
just let time be time and you do you and
you do you okay tell me about this dress
cuz it's a dress this is a dress right
here um I'm really really happy that I
got to wear something that reflects me
I'm sparkly on the inside and um I just
want to shine tonight and I want to be
in the moment and just feel everything
around me Coco you always shine whenever
you shine thank you so much all right
I'm going to ask you a couple I'm going
to ask I'm going to name a couple of
song titles you tell me whether there is
a tayor Swift song or a candle scent
okay or a candle scent okay okay sure
ready with this first one how about this
one endless weekend that's a candle
scent damn it you're good okay hold on
let's I got another one for you how
about this one
Afterglow that's a Taylor Swift song
okay hold on okay you're on fire right
now how about Wildest Dreams Taylor
Swifts okay how about thousand wishes
candles Cent you cannot fool Coco
all right let's do a song together
babe hello to you hello to you I am a
little nervous if I am if I'm being
honest because there is a legend
standing in front of me right now
where really can I see I I just had to
be honest okay listen I heard part of
the song the other day I didn't get the
whole thing they would give me the whole
thing but it it made me feel so good it
is quintessential Billy Joel Piano Man
Brilliance why now since you haven't
released a song for us since
2007 basically cuz it all came together
very recently MH and uh I've resisted it
for a long time and this time I just
said ah what the hell I who am I to
fight this yeah and you're going to give
us a you're going to get on that stage
tonight now are we are you just doing
the new song or is did we get a medley
what is it what do we what are we going
to get well I know I'm doing the new
song I don't know if I'm doing anything
else yet okay you can make up your mind
just make it up on
the what are they going to do throw me
off I do another one never ever so
you've been nominated 23 times you've
won six times what is Grammy KN like for
those nominees those young nominees who
you know maybe it's their first time
there do you remember the your first
nomination I was in Paris when I won my
first Grammy and we won two that night
and they kept waking me up in
Paris uh which was fun it was a nice
place to be and you're you just
announced that your residency at Madison
Square Garden is going to end in July in
July yeah is there a chance you could
extend is there a chance that we could
get more are you saying like I I'm I'm
good well I never said I'm never going
to play the garden again it was just in
this particular run of the
residency that's the end of that for now
we could do the Garden again I can play
other venues in New York where I haven't
played for the last 10 years so it opens
up a whole new world um there's so many
artists who look to you that you've been
inspiration for them one of them is
Olivia Rodrigo she came by your show
last year and sang a couple she really
is you know who is there anybody in
today's music that you look at and you
say I I really like what they're doing
like an ol it's a lot of people I like
what um Olivia is doing I like what
Taylor Swift is doing I like what Billy
Alish is doing it's like a women's thing
now women are really coming to the front
speaking of women when she walks out in
this dress and looking like this what do
you
say
yeah you say yeah you say turn turn
those lights off that's what you say not
back on turn those lights off I love it
you look amazing I can't even imagine
how many diamonds are in this necklace
it's all on loan from Camila Deets
collection in New York and I'm very
thankful to them okay tell us this does
Billy Joel listen to Billy Joel at home
no we do not our children do so we have
a lot of Taylor Swift Billy Joel Olivia
Rodrigo but they're his biggest fans so
yeah they want to hear it all the time
you know what I dig that so much because
you know so many times we think our kids
we embarrass our kids and that but your
kids thinking that you are the coolest
and like loving your music and playing
your music that's kind a feel maybe
they're doing it cuz they dig it but I
think they're doing it to annoy
me they keep playing piano man it drives
me nuts I can never hear Piano Man Too
Much you said that you were bringing
your mom to the Grammys and you made
good on that promise you know what we
hired a woman to play my mom she
couldn't make it but she's here how cool
is it to come with your child just the
Grammy Awards of all places it is
unbelievable right and I made him
promise me when he was 12 so I 15 years
later I'm like it's my time so were you
there last night for the performance at
Clive Davis yes and he was fantastic I
was so nervous for you oh my God it was
great how was that watching him perform
and knowing that the crowd was vibing
loved it I was thrilled and just I was
so proud and he you did such a great
great job thanks Mama Clyde Davis party
launches stars that is the place for
stars to be launched so how important
was it to be last night and now to hear
that people loved you well it's always
tough to go look out into a crowd and
see Forest Gump looking back at you uh
it puts a little bit of added pressure
on uh but I just had fun I knew my mom
was there and I knew that you know the
people there wanted to see something
good and I tried to do my best to make
that happen for them and I had so much
fun and um I was nervous but just being
surrounded by Legends and honored like
that was a dream come true and I got to
meet green which was sick was there a
moment for you when you were on was
there a moment where you just like oh my
God yeah the the very beginning I was
like close to pissing my pants like for
real like it was it was almost bad uh
but once I was halfway through I was
like oh my gosh I'm just performing
again and it felt like I was on stage at
an open mic in front of nobody else it
was you did your thing and you did your
thing I did my best I hear Olivia
Rodrigo wants to duet with you have you
talked to her about that Olivia and I
have spoken about that uh we've kind of
played some back and forth in the Press
but uh I think we both just want to make
sure the time is right and that it's
something that we both can truly cherish
and I would love to work in the room
with Olivia cuz she's such a talented
writer so that was the press release
answer now tell me the real answer
what's going on behind the scenes is it
going to happen hell yeah I'm hitting
her up we're making it happen I got you
we're going to make it happen I'm sure
she'll be here in a few minutes so if
you see Olivia if we see her we'll set
it up okay Mom what are you looking
forward to tonight and how will it be
what when you hear your child's name
called in there when they announc the
best new artist well Noah's already won
in my mind so whatever happens tonight
is is just going to be extra special but
I'm just so excited to hear the music
and see the people and I'm thrilled to
be here and by the way there was a show
where they had the moms of rock stars
you know they were talking about their
lives what is one moment when you knew
that your child was different and
special I think he's always been playing
music his entire life but I think it's
when I saw him perform and other people
were kind of freaking out and then I was
like wow he is really good good you
know no congratulations you've already
won you brought your mom that's the win
that is the
win last time I saw you we were golfing
were golfing I'm not going to say who
golfed better but we were golfing right
right right right I will say this who
would have thought we'd have went from
Top Golf to the Grammy red carpet okay
you said that it's going to be an
emotional night for you it's going to be
emal will it it's emotional if I lose
you know just being here this is unreal
man being recognized by the academy and
uh being here to represent Nashville and
being here to represent country music
and my slice of America that's often not
spoken for it's a lot of people that
have never been represented that are
represented here tonight we didn't come
to win we came to represent baby and you
talked about that that you came to
represent your community how many folks
did you bring with you and how many
folks are at home watching well I I
would hope there's a lot watching but
most importantly I brought my daughter
my 16-year-old daughter Bailey and my
wife Bunny's behind us um we're walking
this red carpet together which is just
makes a a dream even better this is uh
special Louis Vuitton right from forel
Custom Louis Vuitton from forel baby I
couldn't believe it P P dressed me
himself man it's the first time I've
ever wore a designer come on come on
it's cool man you talked about your mom
when you got these nominations will she
be watching tonight she's watching dude
she wanted to come but we just couldn't
I I was worried her having a wheelchair
getting her in and out and the carpet
and stuff but um she's watching from
home man and and I mean she's she's
FaceTime me 10 times today already
really she's fired up come on come on
face let's FaceTime come on can we
FaceTime your mom let's FaceTime your
mom let's FaceTime your mom right now
she'll answer she'll answer she'll love
it too okay so she's on she's going on
we're going to put her on ET right
now oh no there we go hey Mama I'm on
the red carpet with ET how you doing
Mom how are you we are good we wish you
were here tonight I do too I I wish I
could have been there too everybody's
asking about
you she say she's in Nashville holding
it down I love you I'll FaceTime you
later Mama I love you byee
bye come on that is pretty cool she's
been waiting on that FaceTime all day
I've been FaceTiming her all day she's
excited yeah she's excited okay she's
excited about the Grammys I also I mean
I'm hearing that you're in a Super Bowl
commercial with some folks oh man man
listen the rumor is true now I can't
tell you the folks but I can tell you I
am in a Super Bowl commercial and shout
out to UB and let me just tell you
something we know who the folks are and
there's some there's some big big folks
in that one to be in that kind of
company Super Bowl commercial it's huge
to be in that kind of company now what
is what does that say you know cuz you
think about those folks that you're in
there with and they're saying you are on
par you're a superstar too right I think
it's unreal just to even some of the
conversations I'm having and some of the
people that even know I'm a human is
unreal real man this is just
unbelievable and also you talk about how
far you've come and how you've changed
and how you're helping to change people
you were just talking about Fentanyl and
pushing that and trying to give people
help that you continue to help folks why
is that so important I mean God has
blessed me so much I just want to be a
blessing you know I think that's the
that's the Pay It Forward mentality man
I came from a place where there wasn't a
lot of blessings so to be blessed now I
want to bless as many people as I can
all right I got to let you go but
where's the jelly jelly roll party
tonight if you win oh dude listen if I
win I'm going to all the parties if I
lose but if I win I'm having one party
at the Rainbow Bar and Grill come see me
I'm serious I'll be there at the rainbow
with jelly roll
[Music]
rolling
face
[Music]
come on come
on
[Music]
who is June Carter she's about us I've
never known a life different than Show
Business Johnny Cash was not Johnny Cash
without June Carter she was an
incredible artist in her own
[Music]
right you look stunning you look
stunning man listen you didn't come to
play with us tonight on this red car
Best New Artist nominee what a weird
sentence I mean how has the morning been
how are you feeling are you good are you
settled I feel mellow I feel just so
overwhelmed to be in this room but I I
did not expect to be included this year
at all and so to be in this room
screaming for my friends who are up for
awards um screaming for my heroes that
are performing that have been gracing us
with their presence forever I just am so
I'm so I feel so blessed to be here we
were just talking about the best new
artist category and I don't know if I've
ever seen it so stacked I can't call it
you all like and but I guess that's the
great thing about music and what you've
all been doing like anybody you can't be
like oh man I can't believe that
everybody is just phenomenal and they're
somehow like even better people than
they are artists I really mean it like I
I haven't gone to meet all of them but
over the past week I think that's what's
been the most spectacular part for me
selfishly about this week is is getting
to cross paths with the other artists in
this category and getting to you know
learn about them as human beings and
they are so kind and it feels like no
like true support of one another who did
you get to meet this we I've well Noah
KH is a friend who I really love and um
Warren
treaty I I'm obsessed with them and they
are they were so warm and so generous
and so kind and Koko Jones who I I
literally fell I fell in love with her
watching her like w mag ASMR last week
fell in love with her and met her
yesterday and um got to tell her that to
her face I'd love to hear that I just
really I'm just I'm just everyone's
biggest fan the grammies for me are also
about the collaborations that we see on
stage which I think are cool so is there
anybody you're looking forward to seeing
that you've heard that's performed I
mean Joanie Mitchell is my like North
Star artist um I have
been uh I I don't there's not been a day
that I haven't listened to her music
since I learned about her as a small
child so I I'm just really nervous I'm
I'm that that's what I keep like getting
a hot flash about it's going to be a
moment the first time in 24 years she's
been battling her way back and she's
gracing that stage tonight I I can't
imagine what that's going to be we're
just so lucky we're just so lucky so I
know your girl Taylor will be here
tonight you'll get to reunite with her
and hang out with her now you know
swifties are going crazy right now
because her website has been shut down
and they believe that reputation TV is
going to be announced
wow
wow she
says I love her fan base dearly they are
the greatest and I was lucky enough to
get to know them up close and personally
this summer um they have the greatest
imaginations of any group of people I've
ever known can we have a little fun play
a little game before I lose you okay so
because everybody loves all things
Taylor and we think there could be an
announcement we're going to play a
little game it's called a popular Taylor
Swift song or a popular candle scent so
I will will say one to you and you will
tell me if it's a tailor song or a
candles S I think you might be good at
this I better
be okay Wildest Dreams oh that's a
tailor song it is last kiss that's a
Taylor song that is a tayor song endless
weekend that is not a Taylor song that
is a scent right forever winter that is
also not a Taylor song that is a Taylor
song no stop
it what yes thousand wishes I'm never
allowed back on the ARs tour we'll edit
that one thousand wishes that that isn't
a tailor song no it's a scent great in
the Stars that's also a scent it's a
scent yes Chasing Fireflies that has to
be a scent that's a scent also also are
these real scents yes I can real I'm
going to like seek that out tomorrow
morning and after glow oh that's Taylor
all day she's perfect everybody no she's
Taylor is not
me I'm saying congratulations all right
we celebrating yes yes we are
celebrating yes indeed how does that
feel now like it's is it an exhale
moment yes yes I think I'm still
processing the fact that I've won a
Grammy it's it's very very bizarre but
so cool how how did you find out were
you at the ceremony already okay so you
were there yeah I was at the pre-
ceremony I performed uh my song and then
right after that it was announced so it
was a maybe the most stressful six
minutes of my life but um but now the
most exciting six minutes of my life
what was that moment like when they open
the envelope and right before you here
what is that moment I think I blacked
out I don't really remember it I was
just still running on such a high from
the performance um but it was so cool so
wild and this is sh well this is Chanel
tonight now was this done for you no
this is um it is not done for me but it
is still very pretty you so you are
performing with Billy Joel tonight okay
he was just here and and I was saying to
him like he hasn't had a done music for
us since 2007 new music for us so why
was now the time and now I think are you
processing how much of an iconic moment
this is to be on stage it's again just a
string of iconic moments today but yeah
to get to play with Billy and I'm
playing cello so I kind of get to you
know take put the singing to to the side
and just do kind of what I practiced
growing up is so special I was telling
him hearing the new song it is so
quintessential Piano Man Billy Joel
comfort music for me it's so it's so
incredible to to get to play with him
and he is just such a good musician like
I think one forgets like how much craft
these musicians put into their work and
practice and just seeing him play and
even just like jamming in between and
rehearsal just jamming in between in
rehearsals is just very inspiring this
is his first Grammy performance in 30
years so how did it come come about that
you number one were able to do this
performance with him and I
mean well um my friend Freddy Wexler uh
co-wrote a song on my album that uh just
won the Grammy and um he wrote the and
produced the a song with Billy Joel so
he he was like do you want to play
You're a chist right do you want to play
and I was like that's what I went to
school for so let's put it to work I
mean sis I cannot wait to see this I
love this for you this is a huge uge
night for you you're a winner already
and now you're about to step on the
stage with an icon and do a performance
it's a I mean you don't have to do
anything else I I already feel like I've
won life at this point I love it so
wonderful to meet you you look beautiful
you as you I love it enjoy every minute
of this night really enjoy
[Music]
this I haven't had a chance to
congratulate you first of all since the
Emy I've not seen you come on in here
come on it's a it was a family win yes
it
is you should have congratulated you
because no but let me tell you why you
should have congratulated you and people
didn't mention this that people told you
you couldn't do serious stuff that
people told you that you were just a
funny lady you should be off to the side
do your funny thing and stop yeah and
you said damn it I'm going to show you I
got to show you I got to show you
something and you showed the whole world
and it's been thing after not one but
it's been thing after thing after thing
after thing so I just do not make me cry
my fake eyelashes off I'm at the gramys
but I was just so happy for that moment
because you manifested that you said I'm
going go and show youall you know I had
a wonderful support system and uh and we
were able to bring home that award and
I've been I'm still floating you should
be floating by the way where is the
award at home in in the front actually
in the front door as soon as you walk
soon as you walk in it sings to you it's
like right there with my big bouquet
that I got from Oprah yes yes this
really isn't your night it's your night
cuz you're the musician in the family so
what is it that makes the Grammy so
special oh being able to be among so
many amazing musicians and artists and
uh people that I've looked up to for
over the years so I'm excited to be here
Kevin love that I got invited on a date
normally I'm like hey come with me to
this thing and now she's like you want
to go to the gramy I'm like
okay I'm going to take you yeah you're
my day um I also want to talk about
origin because it has been doing well in
the theaters it expanded to a to more um
audiences now why is it so important for
people to see this movie wow for such a
time as this it it it it opens your mind
it invites you to think differently and
to unlearn some things so it it's
definitely a must SE it's a must SE it
really is a movie that will change it's
not like we go to movies to escape and
have fun but this one it changes your
life forever absolutely very powerful
message I think it's a masterpiece so I
enjoyed
it thank you all for joining us here on
ET for all of your cover from the 2024
Grammy Award and never forget you can
always catch us on etonline.com take
[Music]
care
people are always coming up with new
ways to hurt themselves especially
around
[Music]
here we got to get them out
now don't make me write you up for
insubordination you're not my boss no
I'm not your
boss
if it was my life in someone else's
hands you are the only person I would
trust to do
this we got a snake on the plane
[Music]
[Applause]
what thanks for joining us tonight on ET
and we are bringing you the very best
from the Grammy red carpet right yes
indeed we are we had some fantastic
moments with music's biggest stars so
check it out I do not want to cry I you
have worked so hard and given so much of
yourself to this industry for so long
while quietly being in your absolute own
League we've talked about this happening
since the day we met and over many tour
bus sleepovers we did it is the greatest
joy to see the goodness you have poured
into others into your collaborators I am
so incredibly lucky to be one of them
over the years pouring right back into
you happy does not begin to cover it
this is your mother jumping moment the
jump oh my God I love you Ari if you're
hearing this I love you so much thank
you for being a Believer and supporting
me from the very beginning um you knew
things that other people didn't know and
saw things of me that other people
didn't see and you've just been so Bri
or die so this is my love letter to you
thank you so much I'm going to tell you
in person obviously but I love
you Mama are matching tonight thank you
so much this is her nap time but she'll
appreciate it later okay well we about
to celebrate cuz youve won two already
you had won two cies already I found out
in the car on the way here and I'm shook
I'm like wow what a great start to the
night my song just went number one on
rhythmic radio today I'm like what a day
I mean you are the hardest working quote
unquote overnight success because I know
you've been in the game grind been long
that's a long night right there and like
right next to you here Verdine right so
Verdine I'm interrupting because
Victoria's right here they did the song
together you look
amazing how are you how you doing
[Music]
my you look amazing she was the first
one that turned me on to you you guys
did a moment cover I have loved you
since '90s babies oh my God though
that's long thank you yeah you know
congratulations best
ALB I'm out thank you so much this is
good huh it worked out didn't it I know
I I know I know this is good huh yeah I
know
excited oh she's over there she hold she
just went that way holding up ter she's
like not time I'm ready to get out of
here all right so little mama just went
this way and that way I know you said
she she knows the word Grammy she been
working on her poses how dides she do it
was nap time so it's very like you have
to get her at a specific point in her
day like right after sugar not nap time
so this was like right in that window
where she's like uh-uh she's to I get
I'd be like I'm like that and I'm 48
yeah yeah same it's it's interesting to
me because in this day and time I mean I
know you couldn't have even predicted
the success number one of the album and
then on my mama but then the viral
sensation of it as well I mean I can't
turn my head anywhere without hearing it
yeah you know what I always did want to
be one of those people who had a song
that eventually annoys people cuz it's
played so much and I think I don't know
maybe we're like maybe a month out from
that place you're like turn on my mama
off you know what I mean but I'm so
happy my radio team has been killing it
my manager and I really attribute a lot
of the success to the dance um the viral
dances so Sean Bankhead um AA the
dancers that were in the music video
really brought it to life and everyone
who decided to recreate it and like do
it with their families that's what makes
it a collaborative effort with the fans
um to make it feel very very big so I
appreciate that R&B singers and
especially women anymore sing and dance
I mean it hearkens me to the Janet
Jackson and those like when I watch You
artist yes seriously thank you is that
what did you come into this thinking
like I want to I want to be R like I
want to hearken back to those r& people
that I led and that we loved that did it
all I really think it's just what I grew
up on I feel like even Whitney Houston
the vocalist that she was had some
performances where she was dancing she
was hitting some moves so I feel didn't
have a real one two step but she tried
did she did she had some energy on that
stage and certain stage pres and so I
value artists who really um just put
that effort in I I just a huge fan of
dance um it's part of what performances
I adore the most um so Michael Janet
Beyonce uh Chris Brown Usher like
performers who just kind of incorporate
movement into it and I know how much
breath work it takes and stamina and how
much work goes into it so I just always
really appreciate it didn't you get a
little gift from Miss Beyonce she did
send me flowers I looked at that card
and I was like no no no no no no and I
love white flowers and they were all
white flowers I know she sent it to a
few people who attended her Renaissance
film um Premiere but it's still the most
valuable thing in my home so just you
know I saved the bowl the flowers and
make it but I save the bowl it's now my
fruit bowl my Beyonce fruit bowl I love
it I'm trying to reap the fruits right
now I know that you've got like 50
million things to do and you're being
pulled in 8 million directions what what
is it that keeps you grounded what is it
that keeps you like like good so you
don't you know fall off that Cliff or
get too much or have too much you know
what I just really love to do this I
think that um it's not it's just what I
do I guess maybe if it was more of like
a um I don't know something that I felt
braggadocious about like having it's not
really like something that I have it's
something that I am so I just around
existing and loving music and just
wanted to do more you know okay when you
are deciding your dress tonight and hey
was it always we're going to match I did
know that I did know that from the
beginning oh look at the tears she's so
she wants her mama you want
Mama
John you come to Mama come to
Mama Hi Pretty hi pretty it's all right
anyone with a 2-year-old understands
absolutely but before I let you to go
these dresses you guys oh my God custom
Versace styled by Colin Carter he's
right here he's the man um I'm so
appreciative we're wearing Bulgari um
jewelry and I'm so thankful that they
were willing to do both of our dresses
mommy daughter dresses you look pretty
thank
[Music]
you first of all how is it being out I
mean did you escape tonight where's the
baby yes I did Escape because I'm always
on do so I can always Escape I can be
like sis yeah you know so I know he's in
good hands right now how is that though
being cuz you two are so close you and
your sister are so close yes we're like
this thick as thieves and to be able to
be with her every step of the process
she's just such an incredible mom I am
so proud of her I'm so proud of her
tonight for her nomination for Angel so
I am just here as proud big sis how'
y'all keep this secret for so long how
did y'all do it just like we keep all of
our other secrets sisters do
best you had new music is there more
coming yes there is more coming
coachella's coming a lot of exciting
things so what do you got planned for
Coachella tell me about the performance
what do you cuz usually you have
performances yes going all out doing the
most of course and you know just dancing
and singing my heart out really yes all
right so your sister didn't come but you
came she's still going to be here she
she's on the way she's on the way she's
on the way yes
all right we can't wait to see your
sister we cannot wait to it's so great
to you can't wait to see Coachella
anything you can anything else you want
to tell us the preview or anything else
like oh man I'm just here as a prois
tonight Angel for the win Angel for the
win Auntie Chloe what we doing what are
we you see you see auntie auntie I was
like I was like what we do Auntie do I
no no this is the grown Mermaid The
Little Mermaid is your sister this is a
grown mermaid a grown
mermaid the grown for real when you saw
this was you like what was it about that
you said okay I'm about to step on some
some necks my tummy is out today and so
I was like okay yeah let's do it and it
feels very effortless and like I feel
like a Bronze
Goddess yes who made this dress oh yes
so Timothy styled it and it's like I
love it because it just feels like
molten gold you know that's why I love
it and the hair tone to
match yes thank you thank you guys
how you doing I'm doing real good I'm
just grateful to live this moment yeah
this is a big moment for you tonight yes
indeed so how have you been all day is
it are you nervous or there excitement
are you just chill we've been chilling
in the hotel we've been um getting ready
and real I mean I'm real I I'm saying
about the nomination you won I won you
yeah we're celebrating come on smile
smile bigger than that you we are
smiling we are smiling so how does it
feel to be a Grammy winner it it feels
great it feels awesome it's a dream come
true now you can exhale and just have
fun tonight right yes yes we're
celebrating that with my beautiful
girlfriend right here and you look
amazing you didn't want to come up here
look she didn't want to come up here but
she looks so good when she walked out
what were you like no she uh she looks
amazing you looks amazing oh thank you
so much thank you so this is um you had
your first tour in the US last year with
I I I don't know what like 50 something
sold out shows yeah it was it was a
great tour and this tour is going to be
bigger I love what is that like when you
walk out and you see the house is just
so full and they're there for you I
don't know I'm just real thankful with
people that hears and supports my music
every day and I know they're waiting for
a for a for a new album and for new
music so wait what are you going to do
at Coachella what can they expect from
that performance it's going to look
great it's going to look awesome you
have to be there yes so I know people
are waiting for new music are you in the
studio are you writing are you are you
recording already I'm doing everything
at the same time I'm I'm just working
and keep grinding and I think it says
here that your third album Genesis was
the most streamed um first day music
Urbana album on Spotify already like you
had the most streams yeah I think so
yeah I'm I'm just I'm just happy to be
here you know well I mean there's so
much happening this year now time has
Time Magazine has named you one of the
100 next big artists so do is there a
pressure to like live up to all of these
things that are happening no pressure no
pressure at all I'm just living my life
loving to make music yeah okay who's on
the collaboration front for you now
who's the next person you say okay I'm I
want to do something the person I'm
going sending next to so do you get it
do you make music together yes we make
music together sis come on it's a song
coming out what is the song's name oh
you have to wait for that look see there
you go you have a good you're going to
have to wait for
that Taylor where's Travis tonight
where's
[Music]
Travis
T
CH T
CH
[Applause]
[Music]
over
SC that's all
sad
[Music]
yeah
Taylor to your right to your right
Taylor Taylor to your right tayor Taylor
to your right to your
right come
[Music]
on
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say finally here yeah okay so you can
exhale now how does it feel we
celebrating tonight yeah yeah it feel
good you know what I'm saying finally to
make it here um and be here for my own
purpose you I mean you've been nominated
four times you win tonight now can you
just relax and enjoy the show and what
are you most looking forward to seeing
um I'm just here to experience it I'm
saying it just feel good to be here got
my wife with me it's VI I mean when she
walks out looking like this what do what
what are we saying cuz good God never
let go of
hand I love that so much is there
anybody that you know that's performing
tonight that you're that you like are
excited to see um I'm honestly uh
excited about the whole show you know
what I'm saying it's like I say it feel
good to be here yeah you you were just
in Kanye and taala sign's video right so
I mean when you're making music with
them like I what's the what's the
process like um just to sum it all up
Evil Genius because it's the lead single
to his upcoming album so you've seen it
and I mean he's been teasing what we're
going to get and he is I think those are
great words From Evil je EV genius EV
genius sh
out he recently posted on IG I think
tell Dirk to activate tell Dirk to
activate his IG is time to drop I'm a
couple days late but since we got the
good news I had to yeah yeah yeah so
what what did you did you post already
I'm post I got to post I got to post
these outfits tonight uh the wars
tonight so I'm feeling good tonight I
was going to say what does the night
bring cuz y'all look too good to just go
home um it's a change of plan we got to
go back to the drwing board since we won
right it was going to be low and now you
like no I got to celebrate my
baby yes yes I love that so much so good
to see you congratulations what's the
next I mean you know you got yay and Ty
do but who's the next collab or who's
the next person on your list somebody
that we wouldn't think that you would
want to work with that you really want
to work with um I want to say who y'all
think I wouldn't but I'll say Morgan
wall really that is somebody I didn't
think you would say yeah it's going to
be a collab album soon okay so you guys
are going to work together that's
interesting vibs so so that mean I'll
see you again next year I know you see
what I'm saying Come on talk your stuff
I love it so much you guys have a great
night tonight who okay who did this look
by the way
l l sh shout out uh La Roach Oh La Roach
did it love it love it well you look
spectacular good luck have a great night
tonight guys okay good to see y'all
okay hold on you just won yes I just won
what the heck like it's crazy it's crazy
okay what does this mean though to win
this award for a song that everyone
loves I mean this one over
here
always right look look
yeah what' I tell you oh it's amazing
it's I'm so proud of myself so proud of
South Africa Africa it's a win for us
all so I'm just super blessed have any
has anybody called you yet from Africa
that is watching from South Africa
everybody blowing you up my phone it's
it's crazy my phone is blowing up really
yeah it's blowing up everybody calling
everyone celebrating it's a huge moment
it's amazing did you just see JT Jam in
the water did you see that that Jus
Timberlake was I never see that yes yes
he
was everybody loves this song Justus
Timberlake I'm saying JT yes I did see
that that's crazy that's crazy you saw
it yeah I saw it it's amazing I I I
can't believe it I'm a lost for words
jenet Jackson was vibing to it Oprah
like it's gone it's gone okay when you
made this song what did you think when
you made the song when I'm I made it I
knew it was special I knew like I loved
it my family loved it I had a dream
about the song so I feel like I knew in
my spirit that this was the one how are
you celebrating tonight hey I'm going
out we have to we have you have to and
then you have to go home and celebrate
in South Africa everywhere I'm going I'm
celebrating now yeah show One More Time
come on come on make me make
me
yes got she got it she needs to teach me
how to do the dance cuz I okay hold on
okay will you teach her cuz she does she
does it all the time so
it's wait this way or this way there you
go I'll give you private
list she's like keep trying F I'm going
to give you the private lesson
congratulations
congratulations will you tell us about
the dress real quick yes so I'm wearing
custom
faace cute um I love it I love working
with them on the design and yeah it just
came out perfect I couldn't have asked
for a better outfit for my first
Grammys yeah congratulations it's it's
the hit of the year I mean everybody
loves that
song
come on you want them take over take the
mic don't say anything crazy hello we're
at the Grammys Janelle Monae and I
wonderful wonderful night you know what
I love this there is nothing better than
a family night at the Grammys and what
does it mean to have your mom here to
enjoy this well one I could not imagine
winning a Grammy in my my mom not be
there like it was so important as you
can see she's a ball of energy she's my
she's my foundation so I was like if I
win a Grammy I want my mama here so it's
a beautiful thing to have her with me
yes it is album of the H is an honor
right yes Prince will be so
happy album of the year though what is
that Progressive yes but when you put
that album together it you said you were
going to do something different and
you're going to do it your way and you
did that's what I'm saying she's
creeping up on that isn't she yeah
listen I I I try my best in my art to
represent um my community in a in a deep
way and making music and art for us and
most of the time it was rooted in
Seeking Justice for us yes this time
around I wanted joy for us Justice and
joy it can coexist and that's what the
age of pleasure was about uh making sure
that we felt safe enough to feel free
enough to be ourselves even more and un
apologetically and so I'm just so happy
that me being here represents a
community of marginalized folks who are
smiling who are happy who are working
through the pain you know uh of of of of
the the the Pains of life and and
finding Solace and finding love in one
another I think that you are one of the
voices out there especially among black
women who are telling things
authentically their way and it's been
important because you've freed up a
whole community has come out I I might
be in love with your mama I'm going to
be honest with you I love I love your M
love the real star I need my own talk
show guys I am so
funny we G to get you your own talk show
so much it is good the uh my other uh
producers who worked on the project I
want to go take some photos with them
cuz some it's their first time here I've
been here a couple times so I'm going to
run over there really fast tell me about
that dress real quick thank you it's
hermani PR Couture uh it's custom and
I'm just so I feel so good I feel so
Timeless I feel futuristic I Feel Like
Me Mama did you just touch my
Bo your mom is the great you might stay
here I might keep your mom right here I
might keep your mom I might keep your
mom right
here did you see that they were singing
your song on SNL last
night I saw the clip and I I was
watching it I was like where does the
song come in and then all of a sudden
she burst into song a capella and I was
like this is awesome there's been a
couple times that they've shouted me out
this year so thanks guys isn't that kind
of special though that people are
recognizing your music your career on
such a large platform yes well and I
mean all these years later as well like
I'm just so grateful that my music has
span kind of the test of time it's a
classic and that's what I'm going to
continue to do okay so you were
nominated tonight you guys didn't win
but it was still great to be here and be
nominated yes I mean to get nominated
once is an honor and then all this time
later for my peers to think that
something of mine is worthy to be
nominated again is is incredible so I'm
grateful and how was it working with
King and Country how was that easy it
was so easy they are the most kindest
men that I've ever met their wives as
well their whole team they've just been
so great so they were texting me earlier
today like oh we can't wait to see you
so hopefully they'll pop up here in a
second I don't know where they are but
they were amazing to work with okay so
since I've known you since you've been a
young woman when you made your last
video with your husband a very grown and
sexy video yes what was that what was
the conversation like at home to when
you decided to make that video it was
actually my idea was it yeah I was like
it's time for you to show that sexy side
that I see to the world and so I feel
like we did that and it worked it worked
it worked it worked the internet will
tell you just go to YouTube and you'll
see it worked um what does it mean to
have someone that is there to support
you and Champion you each and every day
I mean it's please don't give me
emotional I already had to like get
everything together earlier but um I've
never had someone who supports me the
way that Dana supports me he honestly
wants to see me do the best that I can
do he puts me on his shoulders every day
he's like babe what about this what
about this what about this you should do
this he encourages me when I'm like I
don't know he pushes me outside of my
comfort zone like he's a great dad he's
a great an anr he's a great manager he's
all the things a great husband yeah this
one and I always love the way he shows
the sex side between the two of you that
you you know you got children but that
ain't stopping the loving right how you
think the kids got here come
on I mean he's right he's not wrong all
right fun to be here tonight tell me
about this dress this is digmon and I
found it last minute at this amazing
showroom called The Show Must Go On and
yeah I put it on and just felt beautiful
and I felt that it represented where I
am now like I'm still a flower but don't
mess with me don't mess with you okay um
next videos what what is going to come
with the next videos go ahead babe not
me I'm taking a break I'm taking a break
y'all can have her I'm going take a
break and we'll get another love
interest or something else it's stres
about being in front of the camera can't
you see yeah that's a that's a lot he he
should be though you see this face he
should
be
[Music]
we made it
happen
[Music]
come on
on
[Music]
he
you look
amazing my guy the long all of it is
working for me you did you are you
growing it for a project or did you just
decide like let me just I don't know
well to be honest like I was when I knew
that I I was going to have a baby yeah I
always want to have like that picture of
me with long hair I don't know just you
know like holding my baby and it's like
so organic so grounded I don't know I
just I just let my hair grow because I
feel I feel grounded right now in my
life I just like it like that I love
that How is suzan how's she doing she
good oh she's gray my baby's is growing
pretty fast in her in her mom's valy
everything is doing great are you are
you I know you said everything's great
in light but are you ready for this are
you ready for father Hood well to be
honest I I don't I don't think you're
always ready you know I I would say like
kids they don't come with any manuals so
I just go with the flow I really I
really love her and I and I love what
I'm living right now I can't imagine
what's going to happen you know but
you're also having a girl and you know
what they say that does to a man like
you're done you're done yeah to be
honest that was a big Karma you know you
know I was like kind of refused when I
when I knew that I was going to become a
dad I kind of I was feeling that that
thing that I I didn't want to have a
girl you know because I knew that that
was going to be a Karma but I'm just
kidding I I love what's going on right
now she's going to have you wrapped up
so tight that little girl is going to
have you what my dad tell me too because
I have a sister and all the sisters so
she's always like my daddy's always like
wait for wait for Paris to be born man
you're going to know what's real love I
love that you guys already have decided
what her name is going to be did you was
that just always in the in the in the
world yeah the thing is that that's more
like cultural you know what I mean like
there in Colombia we think about names
before we we know that we're going to
have babies you know so I don't know and
also a crazy fact is that we actually
have had that moment in Paris so Paris
was yeah that's where is Paris yeah I
love that so much okay I know you got to
go but it just um you just recently made
history you were as the first urban uh
Urbana I can't talk Urbana artist to be
number one on both the Latin AirPlay and
also the regional Mexican charts come on
like is there nothing that you touch
that doesn't turn to Gold well yo thank
you well thank you very much I really
appr appreciate that the only thing I'm
going to say is that I'm going to miss
not winning the the Grammy you know what
I mean because I was nominated I'm
nominated today as best L album pop and
and it's I just wanted to Happ in my
arms so let's see if next year we're
going to have the chance to be nominated
again and maybe taking it home and then
you can come with Paris and your whole
family and it'll be whole family it be
nice too you know I'm not in a rush I'm
just enjoying my life enjoying the
moment that I'm living well have an
amazing time tonight it's always good to
see you my man and congratulations on
everything
okay hi Mommy hi I'm so happy for you
and you you know what I love about it h
is like you just like you radiate this
goodness and you just seem like you are
on top of the world right now is that is
that the case that is truly the case I'm
so excited to be here tonight I'm like
I'm with my boo I'm like having the
greatest time boo your boo he was just
holding hand yeah
yeah yeah I love but yeah so it's date
night y'all like you got to take these
when you can get them because now that
you're new parents you're not going to
get all those date nights anymore so
what does date night bring for you guys
oh my gosh we're so excited to see the
performances to chill and to just be
nominated is an honor so I just can't
believe I'm in this room tonight yeah
well you're here baby you're not going
anywhere who are you um excited to see
on the stage cuz there's going to be a
lot of iconic moments oh wow I'm so
excited to see everyone honestly I I
mean I heard scissors performing so I
can't wait to see that the list could go
on your color purple sister frantasia is
doing a tribute to Tina Turner tonight
be amazing how has this run been for you
I know there was I was disappointed that
there was not a best picture nomination
that there was not a best picture
nomination for you guys for The Color
Purple I think you very deserve it's one
of the best movies of the year but so
how is this ride been for you and now is
it like okay I really I kind of have the
acting bug so I'm going to do this for a
minute yeah I'm good going to keep going
I mean acting has been so much fun for
me a beautiful new outlet and I'm
excited to take on more projects so now
you're about to break the internet with
this dress cuz the people are going to
say how she just have a b look at this
how' you just s back how did you just
have a baby I mean why when you saw this
dress what was it about it that made you
say this is it for this night oh I
really love this dress Gucci made it for
me and I feel confident I'm really
excited I think I was excited to kind of
step back and wear start wearing form
fitting stuff after
pregnancy so it's it's been really fun
do you do you feel different being a
mama like is there is there an added
confidence is there just what what
changed for you yeah I definitely feel
more powerful and like more womanly you
know yeah I love
that well you guys are the cutest little
family have a good night listen you and
your sister shut down everybody here
tonight cuz she walked in here like I'm
having myff didn't she though and she
was so excited for us to call her auntie
oh yeah thank you I love it have a good
night tonight good to see you
[Music]
baby hello love how are you oh honey
these earrings great to see baby hold on
a second K they're
ridiculous okay I just feel like you and
David geta need to just do just do an
album I know I told him I said David
come on bro let's do an Al no but you
know what we're working on it seriously
you guys have the the sauce together so
we do we do but we we know it's it's a
it's a LoveHate relationship more love
but he called me his annoying little
sister and I was like excuse me if I'm
your annoying little sister then you're
my annoying older brother right there
you go you want the old monik man yeah
exactly I think maybe sometimes that's
the best way to make music you know what
I'm saying when it's like I you know you
get on my nerves you're get on my nerves
but then here comes the the magic that's
the best that's the best music yeah so
so tonight um what I love about the
Grammys are those collaborations or what
we see on happening on the stage anybody
that you're like okay this is I'm I'm
excited honestly I'm excited to see daa
I got to support her my Albanian Queen
um I'm I'm excited to see Lana I just
saw her pass by and I just think her
music's so amazing and I think it's
finally Lana's time to shine um so I'm
really excited for her honestly the
girls listen you okay you took the words
right out of my mouth I was talking to
Billy Joel ear oh my gosh how was that I
God I just cracked I had to say to him I
said um I have to admit that I'm nervous
right now because you're it's you but
he's performing for the first time in 30
years on the Grammy stage tonight and I
said to him like who do you love right
now and what he said is Olivia Rodrigo
Billy ish Taylor Swift like like du and
that's what he said he said something
about what the women are doing right now
is special is another level why do you
think that CU I believe it too I just
feel like we're in an what's the girls
doing let me think let me think about
this answer I just feel like the girls
are just doing what they want yeah you
know what I mean the more Empower that
we get the more power that we get like
like we're just kind of standing in our
own and it's time like you know I have
such like I want to see who oh it's Carl
oh I gotta go say hi but yeah but anyway
Caesar anyways sorry no but I this is
like on the I actually do have it like
on the red carpet is not good it's like
a family reunion here though it to
people you haven't seen get hang out
again I want you to enjoy every minute
of this night I love seeing you okay
tell me a little something what's the
drama you're giving us for this look all
black everything Robert wound like black
widow Vibes I'm newly
single okay call me all right are we are
we taking suitors or are we taking time
uh uh fun okay I like I like I like
single you I like single you cuz there's
a sass there's a confident you stand a
little all leg up and this face is beat
thank
you number one album in the country
you're rolling here and you you're a
superstar tonight but what does that
mean to have the number one album in the
country uh it just feel good like all my
hard work paying off and the nominations
tonight also to be recognized because we
know for a long time the Grammys will
Overlook artists right we know that but
to do the work and didn't have it
recognized what does that mean to you it
feel good it's a good feeling yeah yeah
for sure okay great collaborations right
but if you win tonight where's the party
W I'm going probably part party at my
hotel I don't really like party you
laying low yeah you laying low tonight
yeah but it's also got to be cool like
Lenny krait's right there rolling with
seeing all the stars and being would you
ever collab with Lenny yeah for sure a
legend he's a right yeah right that's
what I'm saying hold on watch wait wait
we're going to tell him we're going to
tell him right now let's tell L grait
that you need to do a collab hold on one
second we're going to tell him hold on
we're going to tell him right now cuz he
need if anybody needs to be on his next
record is you we appreciated it so so
much Nelle Nelle right thank you baby
Michelle tell Lenny 21 Savage wants to
be on your next record he's losing his
what's happening man let's do it good
yeah let's do it let's do it you too all
right man yeah for sure see see we're
we're working out things
here this is what the Grammys are about
this is a collab we're waiting for right
21 saage let C listen that's a
collaboration that we need real don't
play we need this right I'm for real all
right get it done can you do something
for me 21 can you all right tell me
about SNL oh yeah I'm doing SNL on the
24th yeah on the 24th but what do you
what do you got planned nobody goes to
SNL and just
surprise who's gonna be with you will
you have anybody with you what I'm G
have some people with me oh you're
bringing some folk yeah like who come on
I can't tell you but it'll be something
special yeah for
sure I haven't had a chance to
congratulate you first of all since the
emies I've have not seen you come on in
here come on it's a it was a family win
it
is you should have congratulated you
because no but let me tell you why you
should have congratulated you and people
didn't mention this that people told you
you couldn't do serious stuff that
people told you that you were just a
funny lady you should be off to the side
do your funny thing and stop yeah and
you said damn it I'm going to show you I
got to show you I got to show you
something and you showed the whole world
and it's been thing after not one but
it's been thing after thing after thing
after thing so I just do not make me cry
my fake eyelashes off I'm at the gramys
but I was just so happy for that moment
because you manifested that you said
I'mma go and show youall you know I had
a wonderful support system and uh and we
were able to bring home that award and
I've been I'm still floating you should
be floating by the way where is the
award at home in in the front actually
in the front door as soon as you walk
soon as you walk in it sings to you it's
like wo right there with my big bouquet
that I got from Oprah yes yes this
really is isn't your night it's your
night cuz you're the musician in the
family so what is it that makes the
Grammy so special oh being able to be
among so many amazing musicians and
artists and uh people that I've looked
up to for over the years so I'm excited
to be here Kevin I I love that I got
invited on a date normally I'm like hey
come with me to this thing and now she's
like you want to go to the gramys I'm
like
okay I'm going to take you yeah you're
my day um I also want to talk about
origin because it has been doing well in
the theaters it expanded to a to more um
audiences now why is it so important for
people to see this movie wow for such a
time as this it it it it opens your mind
it invites you to think differently and
to unlearn some things so it it's
definitely a must SE it's a must SE it
really is a movie that will change it's
not like we go to movies to escape and
have fun but this one it changes your
life forever absolutely very powerful
message I think it's a masterpiece so I
enjoyed
[Music]
it
yeah
[Music]
he
okay so first of all mom Night Out how'd
you get away and are the what are the
babies doing I was just with them they
are at home just playing together it's
so sweet I'm so feel so blessed so lucky
how is motherhood because I know you
were ready you waited you know and then
what does it mean to you to finally be a
mother especially because of the love
that you have for your mom my life just
feels so complete my husband my two
beautiful babies just feels like all my
dreams come true and I just feel so
fulfilled and just happy at life okay
Paris the DJ is here tonight though
right you are Paris the DJ what is it
what are you looking for tonight and who
are you excited to see I'm just excited
to see so many my favorite artist I'm
excited for Miley nominated six times
she is such an icon and I'm just so
excited for my second album C is
executive producing it TR what can you
okay so what can you tell me about the
album the album is mean a lot of amazing
badass females on it and a lot of
surprises and it's all about my journey
and everything that I've went through in
my life and I'm just so excited and
honored to have CA executive producing
and writing all the music with
me okay so do your kids love it when you
play music for them do you play music
for them what do you play for them my
kids love music Phoenix just got a
little piano for his first birthday so
he's been playing on the piano and he
loves stars are blind it's his favorite
love ofi since he was born man Paris
this has been such a crazy journey I
mean I can think back to way back in the
day in all the trials and tribulations
and all that stuff and when you think of
that what would you if you could whisper
in your ear and tell yourself something
what would you say say you're going to
go through a lot in life and one day
you're going to have the most beautiful
perfect life and family so keep going
girl you kept going you kept going it's
good to see you anything else Paris
that's coming up um just everything
about to release my 30th
fragrance and wa wait wait a minute your
30th 30th
yes I know what does this one smell like
it's it's just the most beautiful unique
scent I've ever smelled before it's my
favorite perfume ever won't you get into
the baby clothes business or something
doing children's stuff too yes we have
children's furniture and children's
clothing and doing a huge deal with
Walmart so everything will be out very
soon wow so when can we see that stuff
that will be out by this fall with my
new clothing line and jewelry and
Handbags damn Paris you do every you
never stop do you there is no slowing
you down is there's nothing slowing me
down can you tell us a secret about your
fashion tonight tonight oh I'm wearing
this gorgeous mermaid gown and then I
have this custom made for my handbag
line cuz I'm representing Hilton tonight
cuz they're a big part of the awards and
just wanted to represent Hilton for the
stay you really went all the way in
Queen right you will Market one thing
you will do is Market something right I
invented it
that's real actually some people copied
right some people copied you but you
it's nothing like the original how has
it been living life in the Paris Hilton
Fishbowl but you guys have a very normal
life you have kids now so everything has
to be normal it's just amazing watching
Paris be a mom we love to just stay home
play with the babies watching her mother
is pretty awesome yeah and what is Paris
Hilton the mom like uh well let's see
the other day I came home Paris was on a
motorized scooter and Phoenix was
following her around and they were doing
relay races so let's just say she's a
fun and a sliving mom sliving
mom I love it thanks have a great
day okay first of all all the
nominations how how good does it feel to
be that your peers love you it feels
incredible like I never expected four
nominations and I'm just just so happy
like I'm so excited yes okay um are you
excited for this Super Bowl commercial I
am I am shout out to Star they held it
down period what was it like shooting a
Super Bowl commercial how big is it
going to be cuz that's the biggest day
of the year the commercials are better
than game half time yeah they are um I
don't know I'm just really excited the
commercial was fun it was my second
commercial ever and um yeah it was it
was a little bit of a challenge filming
but we got why because lemon lime wasn't
actually present so I was talking to
nobody really but oh so you kind of just
talking to the green screen we was just
you know getting our little acting out
more music coming right yes album
dropping this year y 2K tune in when
when when is it dropping
2024 that's all you can tell me come on
now yes that's all okay tell me about
collabs or anybody that's on there I
can't let that be known yet but my fans
will be very pleased 2023 was an insane
year so to cap it off now with the
Grammys in 2024 what would that mean to
you it just means everything I'm just so
happy to be acknowledged and you know
it's a big deal to
me okay I don't know what was happening
I don't know what's going on there's a
lot going on there's a lot like your
2023 yeah exactly enjoy the night okay
all right and good
luck on did you know that this song was
going to blow up like it did like it was
going to take the World by storm no no I
mean one lives in Hope but uh no I had
no idea I was seeing P now I'm like ped
pam pam can you explain padam to me
please well within the within the song
it's the heartbeat you
know but Pam took on a you know a myriad
of uh of
meanings and at the time when it came
out first came out it was a greeting it
was a farewell it was who knows what
whatever you
like and it is such like people lose it
in clubs when they play it have you had
a chance to be in like do you sometimes
sneak into the club and you hear it and
everybody's goes crazy well I had a few
moments when mov were during listening
parties and just the place erupted I was
kind of faux dejing like literally just
press play but I was quite comfortable
there yeah I do what does it also mean
to stay relevant with folks in
generation after generation after
generation which is very very cool well
obviously means a lot to me but I feel
like this current moment for myself is
beyond me that others might look at what
I've achieved and and go hey that's you
know she's broken a fair number of rules
in her time and and you can it can be
done you can achieve anything you want
anytime yeah I mean of course you know
it's uh we we never stop working but
it's it's a great moment and I think
I've been doing this long enough to
really actively be cognizant that this
this is a great moment amongst the
madness
I'm I'm is it that as we get older we
start to realize how precious these
moments are is that what it is entirely
yeah so to still be here to to um to
have won tonight do you know that I won
hold are you won I
won wait a minute oh you won I didn't
not telling you this when I first like
yes I got two now
wow where where are you going to put
this Grammy next to the other one
I thought you'd build like some kind of
special place for this uh it'll it'll
come back to Australia with me okay tell
me your speech cuz we didn't get to hear
the speech so tell me there was it was
in the pre-show and I was getting ready
so I got the news in my uh robe my
dressing gown kind of ready I screamed I
cried I was shaking and I had to stop
before you went to the ugly cry just
like trying we've just she's ready don't
undo it all with with tears but I was so
were you watching were you watching the
stream or were you getting a you got a
call I I my manager came to the came to
the door and came in saying two time
Grammy that's all she got out I I I
screamed it it's all it's on my it's on
my Instagram yeah yeah you just lost it
I lost it it was a great moment and then
I had to get back to focus cuz you look
great right now so clearly you pulled it
back together and got everything I I
brought it back from the brink yeah okay
well Kylie Mano two-time Grammy winner
have an amazing night great to see you
thank you tell us about this dress yes
um well I thought I'd come Pam red and
it's do gabana my good friends and if
I'd facted in the rain I might have done
without the the train situation but just
get a little wet that's that's all right
badam badam to you
okay thank thank you all for joining us
here on ET for all of your coverage from
the 2024 Grammy Awards and never forget
you can always catch us on etonline.com
take
[Music]
care
a
[Music]
welcome back to ET coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say am I a member because I got the
memo come on now
great I got the
memo I think I think I just joined
pentatonics
everybody well y'all know first of all
y'all know that you do the music does it
for me all the time so I mean it does
it's first of all it's like music is
healing anyway but your music is so
joyous and it's just like a feast for
the ear so it just makes me happy and I
mean everybody thinks that you're here
because you're nominated again so of
course oh my gosh yes we can't believe
we're nominated for an album we put so
much heart and soul into it's a it's a
world holiday album where we celebrated
all these different cultures and learned
about their music and their culture and
how they celebrate the holidays we
collaborated with the most iconic
artists from all these different
countries and it was so fulfilling and
such a beautiful Journey making this
album so to see it celebrated by our
peers in this way way it's just surreal
is the only word I can think of do y'all
ever feel like us like if you're in the
studio you're recording something and
then you hear like oh damn we just did
that I mean seriously do you ever feel
like that D yeah sometime especially
because we're such fans of each other
too you know so like when I hear a
certain thing it's got things or Kevin
does it just inspires us to keep going
and keep pushing further and so it's
it's that we feel like kids in the
playground like they get to play in the
sandbox you know okay how do you decide
like when you hear your name called who
who gets to say who gets to spe give the
speech up oh we haven't even talked
about it now I'm creating problems we're
figuring it out right here right
now I think I'd be so nervous and like
shocked so I would probably Mama's got
diamonds so Mama should be able to do it
oh yeah M's just gonna go yeah well
hopefully they won't leave me behind
because I'm Gonna Have To Shimmy Shimmy
onto the you guys are part of the
opening ceremony for the premiere
ceremony yeah with like Jordan Sparks
and Jay IV and all of that what was that
moment oh my gosh it was so good we did
Prince Let's Go Crazy everybody was just
unbelievable it's so cool to see such
diversity of Talent on one stage and
that's what I think makes the Grammy so
just unbelievably iconic that all these
artists from completely different walks
of life can be on the same stage and
showcase their talent but it all is
working harmoniously together it's it's
just the coolest thing I feel so blessed
that we get to do this each other
everyone was so kind we were all like
hyping each other up and it was just
such a fun song and a fun way to like
start our Grammy day all right so what's
coming up next that's a great question
you know I think what we've talked about
a
lot baby
girl I Sheila E bust into your interview
come
on we just performed together just
talking about
it they were just talking about how cool
it was for all these different talents
to get together open up the ceremony
kind of celebrate music and celebrate
other oh absolutely it was amazing I had
a blast I mean I get to play with them
come on
really she she gave a master class on
energy like I it was amazing to watch
you perform and like taking the the the
mic and everything and just I did the
simp like master class thank you thank
you thank you something happens to her
when she gets on those
ter oh my gosh yes it was
unbelievable well thank you guys so much
Sheila you stick around
find each other in like a very similar G
up no we're like sparkles sparkles you
know yes and this is giving tonight so
was it when you saw it on the rack when
you put it on what was it about it this
is a custom dress by k um that was made
for me um I feel very excited to wear it
I feel very strong in it it's definitely
a heavy like metal dress I was like feel
very
jonok no but for real yeah well listen
you had a very strong year I'm having
I'm having fun so the last time I talked
to you at the Golden Globes you were
telling me about your new music and you
were saying you know this record is
about understanding your worth and
different chapters of your life so on
the 15th we're getting this song okay so
what are you what are you giving on the
15th so on the 15th like you said a new
so I mean it'll be late in the evening
on the 15th but um a new song which is
just about kind of knowing how
to it's almost like not expecting PE to
for people to like love you right yeah
you know yeah you're just like preach
baby training is over you know you're
done teaching people how to do things
right exactly come correct or don't come
at all correct or don't come at all
exactly that's the vibe that's the vibe
so much I can't wait cuz it does feel
like this record is going to be a very
personal one for you I it is and you
know I I got to do most of the record at
home in
London um I just felt like and I feel
like with every album I get to grow more
and learn more about myself and I become
more free as a songwriter and as a
performer and as an artist so this one
I'm just like digging deeper and deeper
I love it I'm I'm proud of this one
heard of you as an artist that says I'm
a little nervous because this year for
you like has been in the stratosphere as
far as music is concerned you know what
I'm saying and I mean just career in
general but is there a part of you
that's like okay now I got to follow up
with like just an incredible year that I
I mean there's always pressure yeah
there's always pressure but I think for
as long as I'm doing things that I'm
proud of things that I love things that
I feel like I'm pushing myself and
trying out something different and I'm
growing as an artist and as a person
then I'm good you know with the groomies
is also about the performances and
what's going to happen on stage so what
can we expect from oh we got something
special for you guys tonight she gives
the smile like the biggest smile I'm
really really excited about this
performance like more more so than any
three words give me in three words what
this performance is going to oh my God
we we have it's
like it's intense okay uh it's
strong and uh it's Dy okay I love it so
you you have two nominations tonight
dance the night away we're still dancing
to it so I mean when you think about
that song when you were making it did
you think okay I got I've got something
here like this is I mean I know you
didn't know what it was going to do but
but I were you like okay yeah I got
something here yeah I mean in the moment
again it goes back to that thing for as
long as I feel like I'm having fun of
making something that I'm really proud
of and I'm in the moment then I'm I'm
exactly where I'm supposed to be and I
feel that way with you know when we were
making Dance T night we were having such
a great time in the studio it felt so
good to be a part of such an incredible
project it felt so good to do it with my
friends that whole experience as a whole
was really special so um yeah I'm I'm
happy that that's like way out into the
world now and like had had its own life
and it's it's been great well finally I
was in London didn't get to talk to you
there but I was there for Argyle you
have this movie coming out it is fun fun
fun in so many ways and you get to cut
up a little bit in this movie and get a
little dancing going on I did get to do
a little bit I mean I have a a small
role but I'm I loved working on a film
set and for Matthew Vaughn to give me
that opportunity I'm so grateful for it
and I had fun with my co-stars with
Henry cavl and John Cena and are you and
John the new Hollywood Duo that we
didn't know we needed uh I don't know if
our acting career will continue together
um but I anytime I see him it's an
absolute pleasure and I I loved working
with him and he's so wonderful so who
knows he told me he was so embarrassed
because he had to sing off key to you
and he was like why am I doing this to
myself he was he's such a good sport
honestly he wasn't even off key I think
he's just so humble that he's just you
know it's it's it was wonderful
really
it was what made this year possible we
decided it before we even recorded that
it was going to be a limited time and
it's part of why we've like given so
much to this we can't sustain this level
of doing personally yeah boy Genius
opening up about their Hiatus after
winning at the 2024 Grammys the Grammy
goes
to not strong enough boy genus it's just
like
isn't
real uh yeah thank you uh thank you to
our band uh thank you to everyone that
uh contributed to the record I just want
to say well music saved my life everyone
can be in a bands love you Bo this band
is my family ahead of the award show the
trio snagged a trophy ET getting their
full reaction on the red carpet amazing
amazing we were like rushing getting
dressed when the live stream was on so I
had to play it cool I was like oh yeah
cool but it was amazing wait wait wait
shut up like you I thought someone had
like dropped a vase or something like
and we were like and then we
screamed yeah the band's Big Win comes
just days after they announced at a
secret show they're going on Hiatus
we're all just going to go chill and
it's made it like really special like
knowing that the shows are limited and
and we have a plan we have a plan to
watch Paddington 2o which everybody has
told us is amazing and we've been like
planning to watch it together for years
so we said after all this we're going to
watch Paddington 2o as for what this
means for the future of the Indie band I
mean I'm not convinced how do you know
how do you know meteor is not going to
crash into Earth tomorrow you know what
I'm saying like but I don't know we're
going to be friends just be H I'm
telling myself be Saied with like what
has happened and not just like more more
more yeah it's been a question since our
first week of promoting the album what
are you guys doing next and we're like
what do you mean it's just that like
stay here in the moment I think it's
like maybe the finitude will help people
realize that like the thing that we give
is enough the album is enough we're
proud of it it's a recording you can go
listen to it anytime yeah it's
there
Grammys I know never gets old for you
the night of this it's like it is
music's night right it's definitely
music's night and I love seeing all the
different looks come on the carpet
seeing how everybody went all out
exactly so what you know for me it's
about the collaborations that we see on
stage is there anybody that you're
looking forward to seeing perform
tonight uh oh my gosh I'm trying to
everything think who's performing that I
I guess like uh dual Lia I want to hear
just left and she said oh I got
something for y'all
tonight and as far as looks I can't wait
to see what doer cat is going to wear
you know she's GNA come with something
ivant look she might walk out here with
nothing on as far as they say it's going
to be a little art it's going to be a
work of art I can't wait to see it I
believe it I believe every minute about
it okay so what's happening with the
skateboard now you guys still performing
I know I've seen you on a few dates
where are you just staying on tours
we're putting together a tour right now
for later this summer mhm if you need
somebody else I mean Tiny's daughter if
y'all need another member killing it
right and She's Not Afraid we put her on
stage and it's a whole Arena full of
people and she can just belt it out yeah
you know the the question on everybody's
mind is what's happening in Atlanta and
are you going to be back and do we know
what I have been trying to figure that
out for myself to be honest with you and
um I don't know I'm thinking
that I'm thinking I might just say is it
time
I've been going back and forth and I
think because they gave us such a long
break I had a lot of time to do other
things and I got some big announcements
to make coming soon so yeah I was like I
mean I love the girls they're my friends
I'm still going to see them and hang out
with them and Bravo as my family I love
them as well but you know okay I'm going
to drill down are you making an
announcement right now that you are
going to take a break from Atlanta now
you done put the pressure on but I guess
yeah okay yeah cu I mean somebody asked
me recently they were like well why do
you um keep doing it and I was like to
be honest with you I think because I've
been doing it I've 14 years and so now I
feel like it's it's I do it because I
I'm used to doing it but with all the
other things that I got going on I just
like I might just yeah I don't know if I
could imagine the show without you but I
couldn't either at first but I think
when they decided you know like they
were like okay we you know we taking
this break to you know rearrange the
cast and all this other kind of stuff
and then it's like it gave me time you
know I never had time I never had time
yeah and I still was working don't get
me wrong I still had a lot of stuff
going on but it was like I had more time
to pick up my kids I had more time to be
in the studio so I've been writing a lot
and I had more time to work on these
other projects that y'all going to see
okay well listen you keep saying that so
you got to give me something cuz you
keep saying I'm going to have a big
announcement I got to work on these
other projects no I mean you know I'm
doing Broadway and I already had um you
know we have the Wiz I'll be there March
13th in New York to see the show and
I'll be there February 13th in LA to see
the show okay thank you yeah be here so
yeah um so I'm excited for that and then
I got some more things to announce in
that lane as well and you know too much
too I don't want to talk too much ahead
of time but yeah it's a great so maybe
more Broadway maybe more that but I know
you're working on that OT you said it
you manifesting it you ready to do and
I'm still I'm manifesting yeah so
something in that realm for sure like um
because I I don't want to give away too
much that I have to come I mean I'll
just say I have some big things coming
so keep stay tuned but um I do love the
franchise but it's just you know you
know when everybody kind of keeps you
like at limbo for so long you start
making other plans you're the longest
running housewife to date at this point
that's a oh Lord Jesus you know I love
the house you know I love you so I'm
getting palpitations from this I
understand it though I do get it I do
understand it and like if this is you
know Andy might say maybe it's a pause
for you yeah that's what he called me
okay and because I I've talked to him
about it and he said well I don't he's
like I don't know how I feel about this
and I said well honestly I don't know
how I feel about it either but he was
like well well you do realize this are
this is your family like if you just
want to just come back next year that's
fine and I'm like I mean I love you guys
and I appreciate like it's it's my
family you know what I mean so yeah I'm
always a part of them you know they're
always a part of me you have given you
I'm gagging right now I'm giving I
love come on come on
[Music]
yeah
hello how are you my goodness I have not
seen you in so long and you come through
here looking like the supermodel that
you are you look stunning here I'm going
bring you turn you around a little bit
more like this so we can see your whole
face okay you look stunning tell me
about this look from head to toe tonight
head to toe it's just Seline Mama it's
all all Seline Head To Toe with my my
own jewelry and um covered all the
tattoos I was going to say Paris I know
you have tattoos and I don't see
anything what did how long did that take
took a few hours it took a few hours
yeah why did you do it was it because
you just wanted to go like super Glam
tonight super Chic tonight well I like
switching things up I love my tattoos I
love my piercings I love all the body
modification stuff art and also
sometimes I don't want it to distract
from the art that is the fashion I'm
wearing and I kind of it just gives it
gives the dress its own moment it's
giving for sure I wondered cuz you have
you've got new music coming out um and
it's uh just a couple couple months um
so I haven't decided when yet but when I
was on tour with Incubus uh I dropped a
single that I just did with Linda Perry
and so she and I just she's like my
Aries twin flame so we're we want to
keep working together and sometimes
talking to a lot of other um celebrities
or children of celebrities where they
really want to kind of figure out their
own lane and don't want to you know they
love parent and love everything theyve
done but they want to figure out their
own lane and make their own path well it
depends on how meta you're getting if
you want to go on a much Universal
Collective Consciousness thing I think
we're all one so depends on how how far
you want to go with that like okay so
what is this new music what is it giving
like what are what um what were you in
what era were you in when you were
making it or what like what's your
inspiration um inspo is usually um pain
and love and the space between um but my
record exact Monty thinks that Linda is
my muse soind can't go wrong with Linda
Perry for Dar I love that we cannot wait
for this new music who are you looking
forward to seeing getting on this Grammy
stage tonight every single human every
single one every single one you want it
all all right thisis thank you so much I
appreciate it
okay okay first of all um you're DJing
at the Super Bowl right all week long
you have a residency in Vegas so what do
I need to do to get tickets to get in to
see you right uh be my best friend and I
can get you in how exciting is that
though because the town will be buzzing
especially this week but to be in Vegas
that's a lot of energy it is I love
Vegas and I have a home with the wind
now I'll actually be playing there all
year long and I'm just so grateful to
them they've really like treated me like
family and there's no better place to be
in Vegas than the wi okay tell me about
the podcast and what actually goes on
because there are things y'all can tell
people and there are things you know so
how far do you go in this podcast we go
pretty good do you you know what I so
it's called sorry we're stoned for a
reason although she does not partake so
she keeps us all together so if I'm
starting to spill too much tea she's
like Mom zip it pull it in Pull It in
rain it in Miley is performing tonight I
think flowers is such a little Bop and
people love that song but it feels like
it also tells a lot about her life and
her story when you listen to that song
what do you know that I don't know you
know what you gotta disect those lyrics
I think the fans know more than anybody
knows they absolutely do they dissected
that pretty well for us I think I did I
I mean people opened up those lyrics
like they were reading a book like it
was a memoir you know what there were
some taken pretty far so I like yeah
over overall like I think Miley had so
much fun making that song and like she
you know she says it over and over like
no expectations of it just from her
heart putting it out and to see it see
its success has been so incredible you
know and also there's just so much talk
about how this is like the next
iteration of Miley you know and so it's
like she continues to have success at
every level as she grows how cool is
that to watch her success it is so
incredible but as her mom it's watching
her grow into this woman she's become at
30 and once she just 30 remember that
just 30 exactly 31 but it's so crazy to
think she's only 31 and everything that
she's achieved but as a person she's
just the most incredible human being I
I'm so proud of her okay real quick how
many Miley songs do you play during your
DJ set minimum three a minimum of three
minimum of three I like to rep the
family okay do you have a favorite
family song um I mean right now flowers
just goes off so hard also Noah did a
song with Diplo a couple years ago and I
played that one quite a bit also otel
Road's always a hit like Metro station I
play Shake It The Crowd Goes Crazy it
really I I like to represent my family
y'all got hits y'all got y'all got hits
all right remember when I'm standing at
the door I'm calling your name I'm
calling you all right for super for
Super Bowl
[Music]
weekend listen we're here celebrating
though because you guys have already won
six nominations tonight you've already
won one does it take a little like you
can exhale a little bit and just go into
the rest of it like no 100% I was like
okay okay we're good like that's fine if
if nothing else happens the rest of the
night that's I'm 100% fine with that I
am so like excited for all the nominees
I'm like happy to be here we got one
we're out it's all good we're great if
we hadn't it would have been fine too
we're chill do you still get nervous do
y'all still get nervous we always joke
that like you kind of you kind of are
like you know what everyone's amazing
you know whoever wins as CRA but they're
like the not like they're like
congratulations apprciate you man oh my
God you um um anyway they say they say
the award goes to and your heart starts
you know pounding moment it's like
everything before that is like we're
chill and then it's like the moment that
like envelope or like the yeah the
Grammy goes to it's it's like it's like
in your throat it's ask you this cuz um
you know swarm was my thing like I loved
it so for real and I'm like this girl is
good like will there ever be a time
where you say Let me let me stop with
music for a second and really kind of
dig deep into the acting for sure okay
is it happening soon I don't know girl
because listen well but a critic's
choice you said to us yes I got music
coming I don't know how much I can talk
about it yet but I have music coming I
do have that that is for sure on the way
very very soon didn't you say it's about
85% done oh no it's it's like
99 it's right there yeah I know we've
been saying that for for a long time but
we can't give too many details cuz then
people get excited then they get mad
okay then just give me three words of
the vibe of the
album it
is that's not that's not alol
musical no it's like I was saying the
other day that it's like a I think it's
a perfect representation of like natural
progression of
like I don't know of you are so oh you
are so terrible of where you are okay
well where are you in life maybe that'll
give me a CH an indication of where the
music yes is it like you're chill are
you chill are you like in a real happy
era a real it's all over the place it's
a lot of feeling it's a lot of um it's
like some whatever relax girl jeez all
right listen Okay so we've got you can't
take a break because after the Grammys
we have the Oscars you guys are
nominated will you be
performing I mean I think we're required
too well I don't know you could say no I
don't want to but hell yeah no way dude
I'm are you kidding me performing at the
Oscar is like I'm I'm literally like
please like I'm yeah it's the coolest
thing in the world I mean y'all could
just have a whole Barbie section because
Ry Ryan said he wanted to perform too oh
yeah I can't wait to hear yeah God all
right so do we think have we already
started thinking about this like what's
going to go into this performance what
it'll look like what it'll feel like for
the Oscars you've been working on the
Grammy performance we're here working on
that one Grammy one yeah I mean it's
just you know we're here we're doing
Barbie we're doing we're doing it you
are you are I love you guys
congratulations have a great night I
can't wait to see what you do by the way
besides your performance tonight anybody
you just can't wait to see on that stage
honestly I don't even know like who's
even all here which I'm I'm
soundchecking that was tight can't wait
so excited I'm I'm geeked to see Luke
Holmes and Tracy Chapman get on stage
and do fast car together like that for
me cuz that's my I'm dating myself but
that's like my My Generation uh-huh yeah
I'm excited I like try not to know
what's going to happen because I like to
be surprised so we'll
see there is so much still to come from
the Grammy Awards stick with ET we have
so much more coming after the
[Music]
break
St
[Music]
the glitz the Glam and the outrageous
listen the Grammy Awards red carpet it
never disappoints there always something
that will surprise you yes indeed and
here are a few of our favorite moments
from the night did the rain wreck your
look because we know let's be honest
that rain will wreck a hair dude
absolutely not you know the best things
happen when I'm Singing in the Rain so
maybe it's a good luck charm okay five
nominations I mean I hear you were
asleep on the plane when the nominations
came through and you had no idea I was
fully asleep and I thought that by the
time I landed that's when I would find
out because that's when it would be
announced I completely got the time
change wrong I woke up to my phone
blowing up with text messages and that's
when I knew but I was the last to know
what did that feel that moment feel like
when you started looking at the phone
and seeing the nomination after
nomination after nomination what really
took me out was the five everyone kept
mentioning five five five I was like
what does that mean and when I finally
landed and I got to call people back
that's when I just lost it that's got to
be a great moment though it's got to be
a great it's so beautiful um it's just
refreshing to see you reap the benefits
of all the time you know your hard work
you you worked hard this isn't a you
know overnight success story you worked
your butt off so that's got to be that's
got to it feels great to have not given
up but also it feels better to promote a
timeline that took a while you know I'm
not I'm not afraid of that I'm not
ashamed of that and I want to continue
to give younger black women this
reminder that if it takes a lot of time
that doesn't reflect on your value it
doesn't reflect on your worth it doesn't
reflect on the possibility of you still
getting where you need to go just let
time be time and you do you and you do
you okay tell me about this dress cuz
it's a dress this is a dress right here
um I'm really really happy that I got to
wear something that reflects me I'm
sparkly on the inside and um I just want
to shine tonight and I want to be in the
moment and just feel everything around
me Coco you always shine whenever you
shine thank you so much all right I'm
going to ask you a couple I'm going to
ask I'm going to name a couple of song
titles you tell me whether there is a
Taylor Swift song or a candle scent okay
or a candle scent okay okay sure ready
with this first one how about this one
endless weekend that's a candle scent
damn it you're good okay hold on let's I
got another one for you how about this
one
Afterglow that's a Taylor Swift song
okay hold on okay you're on fire right
now how about Wildest Dreams Taylor
Swifts okay how about thousand wishes
candle scent you cannot fool Coco all
right let's do a song together
babe hello to you hello to you I am a
little nervous if I am if I'm being
honest because there is a legend
standing in front of me right now
where really
can I see I just had to be honest okay
listen I heard part of the song the
other day I didn't get the whole thing
they would give me the whole thing but
it it made me feel so good it is
quintessential Billy Joel Piano Man
Brilliance why now since you haven't
released a song for us since
2007 basically because it all came
together very recently and uh I've
resisted it for a long time and this
time I just said ah what the hell I who
am I to fight this yeah and you're going
to give us a you're going to get on that
stage tonight now are we are you just
doing the new song or is did we get a
medley what is it what do we what are we
going to get well I know I'm doing the
new song I don't know if I'm doing
anything else yet okay you can make up
your mind just make it up on
the what are they gonna do throw me off
I do another one never ever so you've
been nominated 23 times you've won six
times what is Grammy night like for
those nominees those young nominees who
you know maybe it's their first time
there do you remember the your first
nomination I was in Paris when I won my
first Grammy and we won two that night
and they kept waking me up in
Paris uh which was fun it was a nice
place to be and you're you just
announced that your residency at Madison
Square Garden is going to end in July in
July yeah is there a chance you could
extend is there a chance that we could
get more are you saying like I I I'm
good well I never said I'm never going
to play the garden again it was just in
this particular run of the
residency that's the end of that for now
we could do the garden again I could
play other venues in New York where I
haven't played for the last 10 years so
it opens up a whole new world um there's
so many artists who look to you that
you've been inspiration for them one of
them is Olivia Rodrigo she came by your
show last year and sang a couple D she
really is you know who is there anybody
in today's music that you look at and
you say I I really like what they're
doing like in Olivia it's a lot of
people I like what um Olivia is doing I
like what Taylor Swift is doing I like
what Billy Alish is doing it's like a
women's thing now women are really
coming to the front speaking of women
when she walks out in this dress and
looking like this what do you
say
yeah you said yeah you said turn turn
those lights off that's what you say not
back on turn those lights off that's
what I love it you look amazing I can't
even imagine how many diamonds are in
this necklace it's all on loan from
Camila Deets collection in New York and
I'm very thankful to them okay tell us
this does Billy Joel listen to Billy
Joel at home no we do not our children
do so we have a lot of Taylor Swift
Billy Joel Olivia Rodrigo but there his
biggest fan so yeah they want to hear it
all the time you know what I dig that so
much because you know so many times we
think our kids we embarrass our kids and
that but your kids thinking that you are
the coolest and like loving your music
and playing your music that's got a feel
maybe they're doing it because they dig
it but I think they're doing it to annoy
me they keep playing piano man it drives
me nuts I can never hear Piano Man Too
Much
you said that you were bringing your mom
to the Grammys and you made good on that
promise you know what we hired a woman
to play my mom she couldn't make it but
she's here how cool is it to come with
your child just the Grammy Awards of all
places it is unbelievable right and I
made him promise me when he was 12 so I
15 years later I'm like it's my time so
were you there last night for the
performance at Clive Davis yes and he
was fantastic I was so nervous for you
oh my God it was great how was that
watching him perform and knowing that
the crowd was vibing loved it I was
thrilled and just I was so proud and he
you did such a great job thanks Mama
Clive Davis party launches stars that is
the place for stars to be launched so
how important was it to be last night
and now to hear that people loved you
well it's always tough to go look out
into a crowd and see Forest Gump looking
back at you um it puts a little bit of
added pressure on uh but I just had fun
I knew my mom was there and I knew that
you know the people there wanted to see
something good and I tried to do my best
to make that happen for them and I had
so much fun and um I was nervous but
just being surrounded by Legends and
honor like that was a dream come true
and I got a meet Green Day which was
sick was there a moment for you when you
were on was there a moment where you
just like oh my God yeah the the very
beginning I was like close to pissing my
pants like for real like it was it was
almost bad uh but once I was halfway
through I was like oh my gosh I'm just
performing again and it felt like I was
on stage at an open mic in front of
nobody else it was you did your thing
and you did your thing I did my best I
hear Olivia Rodrigo wants to duet with
you have you talked to her about that
Olivia and I have spoken about that uh
we've kind of played some back and forth
in the Press but uh I think we both just
want to make sure the time is right and
that it's something that we both can
truly cherish and I would love to work
in the room with Olivia because she's
such a talented writer so that was the
press release answer now tell me the
real answer what's going on behind the
scenes is it going to happen hell yeah
I'm hitting her up we're making it
happen I got you we're going to make it
I'm sure she'll be here in a few minutes
so if you see Olivia if we see her we'll
set it up okay Mom what do you looking
forward to tonight and how will it be
what when you hear your child's name
called in there when they announce the
best new artist well Noah's already won
in my mind so whatever happens tonight
is is just going to be extra special but
I'm just so excited to hear the music
and see the people and I'm thrilled to
be here and by the way there was a show
where they had the moms of rock stars
you know they were talking about their
lives what is one moment when you knew
that your child was different and
special I think he's always been playing
music his entire life but I think it's
when I saw him perform and other people
were kind of freaking out and then I was
like wow he is really good you
know no congratulations you've already
won you brought your mom that's the win
that is the
win last time I saw you we were golfing
golfing I'm not going to say who golfed
better but we were golf right right
right right right I will say this who
would have thought we'd have went from
Top Golf to the Grammy red carpet okay
you said that it's going to be an
emotional night for you it's going to be
an emotional will it it's emotional if I
lose you know just being here this is
unreal man being recognized by the
academy and uh being here to represent
Nashville and being here to represent
country music and my slice of America
that's often not spoken for it's a lot
of people that have never been
represented that are represented here
tonight we didn't come to win we came to
represent baby and you talked about that
that you came to represent your
community how many folks did you bring
with you and how many folks are at home
watching well I I I would hope there's a
lot watching but most importantly I
brought my daughter my 16-year-old
daughter Bailey and my wife Bunny's
behind us um we're walking this red
carpet together which is just makes a a
dream even better this is uh special
Louis Vuitton right from forel Custom
Louis Vuitton from forel baby I couldn't
believe it P P dressed me himself man
it's the first time I've ever wore a
designer come on come on it's cool man
you talked about your mom when you got
these nominations will she be watching
tonight she's watching dude she wanted
to come but we just couldn't I I was
worried her having a wheelchair getting
her in and out and the carpet and stuff
but um she's watching from home man and
and and I mean she's CU she's FaceTiming
10 times today already really she's
fired up come on come on face let's
FaceTime come on can we FaceTime your
mom let's FaceTime your mom let's
FaceTime your mom right now she'll
answer she'll answer she'll love it too
okay she's on she's going on we're going
to put her on ET right
now
oh no there we go hey Mama I'm on the
red carpet with ET how you doing
Mom how are you we are good we wish you
were here tonight I do I wish I could
have been there too everybody's asking
about you it down she says she's in
Nashville holding it down I love you
I'll FaceTime you later
Mama
bye come on that is pretty cool she
waiting on that FaceTime all day I've
been FaceTiming her all day she's
excited yeah she's excited okay she's
excited about the Grammys I also I mean
I'm hearing that you're in a Super Bowl
commercial with some folks oh man listen
the rumor is true now I can't tell you
the folks but I can tell you I am in a
Super Bowl commercial and shout out to
uat and let me just tell you something
we know who the folks are and there's
some there's some big big folks in that
one to be in that kind of company for
Bowl commercial it's huge to be in that
kind of company now what what does that
say you know you know cuz you think
about those folks that you're in there
with and they're saying you are on par
you're a superstar too right I think
it's unreal just to even some of the
conversations I'm having and some of the
people that even know I'm a human is
unreal man this is just
unbelievable and also you talk about how
far you've come and how you've changed
and how you're helping to change people
you were just talking about Fentanyl and
pushing that and trying to give people
help that you continue to help folks why
is that so important I mean God has
blessed me so much I just want to be a
blessing you know I think that's the
that's the Pay It Forward mentality man
I came from a place where there wasn't a
lot of blessings so to be blessed now I
want to bless as many people as I can
all right I got to let you go but
where's the jelly jelly roll party
tonight if you win oh dude listen if I
win if I'm going to all the parties if I
lose but if I win I'm having one party
at the Rainbow Bar and Grill come see me
I'm serious I'll be there at the rainbow
with jelly roll
rolling
there
[Music]
over
come on come
[Music]
on
who is June Carter Cash she's about us
I've never known a life different than
Show Business Johnny Cash was not Johnny
Cash without June Carter she was an
incredible artist in her own
[Music]
right you look stunning you look
stunning man listen you didn't come to
play with us tonight on this red car
Best New Artist nominee what a weird
sentence I mean how has the morning been
how are you feeling are you good are you
settled I feel mellow I feel just so
overwhelmed to be in this room but I I
did not expect to be included this year
at all and so to be in this room
screaming for my friends who are up for
awards um screaming for my heroes that
are performing that have been gracing us
with their presence forever I just am so
I'm so I feel so blessed to be here we
were just talking about the best new
artist category and I don't know if I've
ever seen it so stacked I can't call it
you all like and but I guess that's the
great thing about music and what you've
all been doing like anybody you can't be
like oh man I can't believe that
everybody is just phenomenal and there's
somehow like even better people than
they are artists I really mean it like I
I haven't gotten to meet all of them but
over the past week I think that's what's
been the most spectacular part for me
selfishly about this week is is getting
to cross paths with the other artists in
this category and getting to you know
learn about them as human beings and
they are so kind and it feels like no
like true support of one another who did
you get to meet this I've well Noah KH
is a friend who I really love and um
Warren
treaty I I'm obsessed with them and they
are they were so warm and so generous
and so kind and Coco Jones who I I
literally fell I fell in love with her
watching her like w mag ASMR last week
fell in love with her and met her
yesterday and um got to tell her that to
her face I'd love to hear that I just
really I'm just I'm just everyone's
biggest fan the gammies for me are also
about the collaborations that we see on
stage which I think are cool so is there
anybody you're looking forward to seeing
that you've heard that's performing I
mean Joanie Mitchell is my like North
Star artist um I have been uh I I I
don't there's not been a day that I
haven't listened to her music since I
learned about her as a small child so I
I'm just really nervous I'm that's what
I keep like getting a hot flash about
it's going to be a moment the first time
in 24 years she's been battling her way
back and she's gracing that stage
tonight I I can't
imagine what that's going to we're just
so lucky we're just so lucky so I know
your girl Taylor will be here tonight
you'll get to reunite with her and hang
out with her now you know swifties are
going crazy right now because her
website has been shut down and they
believe that reputation TV is going to
be announced
wow wow she
says I love her fan base dearly they are
the greatest and I was lucky enough to
get to know them up close and personally
this summer um they have the greatest
imaginations of any group of people I've
ever known can we have a little fun play
a little game before I lose you love
okay so because everybody loves all
things Taylor and we think there could
be an announcement we're going to play a
little game it's called a popular Taylor
Swift song or a popular candle scent so
I will say one to you and you will tell
me if it's a Taylor song or a candle
scent I think you might be good at this
I better
be okay Wildest Dreams oh that's a
Taylor song it is last kiss that's a
Taylor song that is a Taylor song
endless weekend that is not a tailor
song that is a scent right forever
winter that is also not a Taylor song
that is a Taylor song no stop
it what yes thousand wishes I'm never
allowed back on the ARs tour we'll edit
that one thousand wishes that that isn't
a tailor song no it's a scent great in
the Stars that's also a scent that's a
scent yes Chasing Fireflies that has to
be a scent that's a scent yes also are
these real scents yes like can real I'm
going to like seek that out tomorrow
morning and after glow oh that's Taylor
all day she's perfect everybody no she's
Taylor is not
me I'm saying congratulations all right
we celebrating yes yes we are
celebrating yes indeed how does that
feel now like it's is it an exhale
moment yes yes I think I'm still
processing the fact that I've won a
Grammy it's it's very very bizarre but
so cool how how did you find out were
you at the ceremony already okay so you
were there yeah I was at the
pre-ceremony I performed uh my song and
then right after that it was announced
so it was a maybe the most stressful six
minutes of my life but um but now the
most exciting six minutes of my life
what was that moment like when they
opened the envelope and right before you
here what does that mean I think I
blacked out I don't really remember it I
was just still running on such a high
from the performance um but it was so
cool so wild and this is well this is
Chanel tonight now was this done for you
no this is um it is not dumb for me but
it is still very pretty you so you are
performing with Billy Joel tonight okay
he was just here and I was saying to him
like he hasn't had a done music for us
since 2007 new music for us so why was
now the time and now I think are you
processing how much of an iconic moment
this is to be on stage it's again just a
string of iconic moments today but yeah
to get to play with Billy and I'm
playing cello so I kind of get to you
know take put the singing to to the side
and just do kind of what I practice
growing up is so special I was telling
him hearing the new song it is so
quintessential Piano Man Billy Joel
comfort music for me it's so it's so
incredible to to get to play with him
and he is just such a good musician like
I think one forgets like how much craft
these musicians put into their work and
practice and just seeing him play and
even just like jamming in between and
rehearsal just jamming in between and
rehearsals is just very inspiring this
is his first Grammy performance in 30
years so how did it come about that you
number one were able to do this
performance with him and I
mean well um my friend Freddy Wexler uh
co-wrote a song on my album that uh just
won the Grammy and um he wrote the and
produced the a song with Billy Joel so
he he was like do you want to Play
You're a chalous right do you want to
play and I was like that's what I went
to school for so let's put it to work
mean sis I cannot wait to see this I
love this for you this is a huge night
for you you're a winner already and now
you're about to step on the stage with
an icon and do a performance it's a I
mean you don't have to do anything else
I I already feel like I've won life at
this point I love it so wonderful to
meet you you look beautiful you as you I
love it enjoy every minute of this night
really enjoy
[Music]
this I haven't had a chance to
congratulate you first of all since the
Emy I've not seen you come on in here
come on it's a it was a family win it
is you should have congratulated you
because no but let me tell you why you
should have congratulated you and people
didn't mention this that people told you
you couldn't do serious stuff that
people people told you that you were
just a funny lady you should be off to
the side do your funny thing and stop
yeah and you said damn it I'm going to
show you I got to show you I got to show
you something and you showed the whole
world and it's been thing after not one
but it's been thing after thing after
thing after thing so I just do not make
me cry my fake eyelashes off I'm at the
Grammys but I was just so happy for that
moment because you manifested that you
said I'm going go and show y'all you
know I have a wonderful support system
and uh and we were able to bring home
that award and I've been I'm still
floating you should be Float by the way
where is the award at home in in the
front actually in the front door soon as
you walk soon as you walk here it sings
to you it's like wo right there with my
big bouquet that I got from Oprah yes
yes this really isn't your night it's
your night cuz you're the musician in
the family so what is it that makes the
grand me so special oh being able to be
among so many amazing musicians and
artists and uh people that I've looked
up to for over the year so I'm excited
to be here Kevin I I love that I got
invited on a date normally I'm like hey
come with me to this thing and now she's
like you want to go to the gramy I'm
like
okay I'm going to take you yeah yeah
you're my dck um I also want to talk
about origin because it has been doing
well in the theaters it expanded to a to
more um audiences now why is it so
important for people to see this movie
wow for such a time as this it it it it
opens your mind it invites you to think
differently and to unlearn some things
so it it's definitely a must SE it's a
must SE it really is a movie that will
change it's not like we go to movies to
escape and have fun but this one it
changes your life forever absolutely
very powerful message I think it's a
masterpiece so I enjoyed it
thank you all for joining us here on ET
for all of your coverage from the 2024
Grammy Awards and never forget you can
always catch us on etonline.com take
[Music]
care
people are always coming up with new
ways to hurt themselves especially
around
here
we got to get him out
now don't make me write you up for
insubordination you're not my boss no
I'm not your
boss if it was my life in someone else's
hands you are the only person I would
trust to do this we got a snake on the
plane
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Music]
thanks for joining us tonight on ET and
we are bringing you the very best from
the Grammy red carpet right yes indeed
we are we had some fantastic moments
with music's biggest stars so check it
out I do not want to cry I you have
worked so hard and giving so much of
yourself to this industry for so long
while quietly being in your absolute own
League we've talked about this happening
since the day we met and over many tour
bus sleepovers we did it is the greatest
joy to see the goodness you have poured
into others into your collaborators I am
so incredibly lucky to be one of them
over the years pouring right back into
you happy does not begin to cover it
this is your mother jumping moment
mother jump oh my God I love you Ari if
you're hearing this I love you so much
thank you for being a Believer and
supporting me from the very beginning um
you knew things that other people didn't
know and saw things of me that other
people didn't see and you've just been
so Bri or die so this is my love letter
to you thank you so much I'm going to
tell you in person obviously but I love
you
mama are matching tonight thank you so
much this is her nap time but she'll
appreciate it later okay well we about
to celebrate cuz you won two already you
have won two cies already I found out in
the car on the way here and I'm shook
I'm like wow what a great start to the
night my song just went number one on
rhythmic radio today I'm like what a day
I mean you are the hardest working quote
unquote overnight success because I know
you've been in the game grinding it's
been long that's a long night right
there and like right next to you here
Verdine right so Verdine I'm
interrupting because Victoria's right
they did the song together you look
[Music]
amaz how you
doing you look amazing she was the first
one that turned me on to you you did a
moment cover I loved you since '90s
babies oh my god oh that's long thank
you yeah know congratulations best
album I'm bring out thank you so much
this is good huh it worked out didn't it
I know I I know I know this is good huh
yeah I know
exced oh she's over there she just went
that way she's like na time I'm ready to
get out of
here all right so little mama just went
this way and that way I know you said
she knows the word Grammy she been
working on her poses how dides she do it
was nap time so it's very like you have
to get her at a specific point in her
day like right after sugar not nap time
so this was like right in that window
where she's like uhuh she's two I get
I'd be like I'm like that and I'm 48
yeah yeah same it's it's interesting to
me because in this day and time I mean I
know you couldn't have even predicted
the success number one of the album and
then on my mama but then the viral
sensation
you know what I always want to be one of
those people who had a song that
eventually annoys people cuz it's played
so much and I think I don't know maybe
we're like maybe a month out from that
place you're like turn on my mama off
you know what I mean but I'm so happy my
radio team has been killing it my
manager and I really attribute a lot of
the success to the dance um the viral
dances so Sean Bankhead um Aza the
dancers that were in the music video
really brought it to life and everyone
who decided to recreate it and like do
it with their families that's what makes
it a collaborative effort with the fans
um to make it feel very very big so I
appreciate see R&B singers and
especially women anymore sing and dance
I mean it hearkens me to the Janet
Jackson and those like when I watch You
artist yes seriously thank you is that
what did you come into this thinking
like I want to I want to be R like I
want to hearken back to those R&B people
that I love and that we loved that did
it I really think it's just what I grew
up on I feel like even Whitney Houston
the vocalist that she was had some
performances where she was danc she was
hitting some moves so I feel like didn't
have a real one two step but she tried
she did she did she had some energy on
that stage and certain stage presence
and so I value artists who really um
just put that effort in I I just a huge
fan of dance um it's part of what
performances I adore the most um so
Michael Janet Beyonce uh Chris Brown
Usher like performers who just kind of
incorpor movement into it and I know how
much breath work it takes and stamina
and how much work goes into it so I just
always really appreciate it didn't you
get a little gift from Miss Beyonce she
did send me flowers I looked at that
card and I was like no no no no no no
and I love white flowers and they were
all white flowers I know she sent it to
a few people who attended her
Renaissance film um Premiere but it's
still the most valuable thing in my home
so just you know I saved the bowl the
flowers didn't make it but I saved the
bowl it's now my fruit bowl my Beyonce
fruit bowl I love it I'm trying to re
the fruits right now I know that you've
got like 50 million things to do and
you're being pulled in 8 million
directions what what is it that keeps
you grounded what is it that keeps you
like good so you don't you know fall off
that Cliff or get too much or have too
much you know what I just really love to
do this I think that um it's not it's
just what I do I guess maybe if it was
more of like a um I don't know something
that I felt braggadocious about like
having it's not really like something
that I have it's something that I am so
I just around existing and loving music
and just wanting to do more you know
okay when you are deciding your dress
tonight and hey was it always we're
going to match I I did know that I did
know that from the beginning oh look at
the tears she's so she wants her mama
you want Mama come John she can come to
her you come to Mama come to Mama
hi pretty hi pretty all anyone with a
2-year-old understand absolutely but
before I let you go these dresses you
guys oh my God custom Versace styled by
Colin Carter he's right here he's the
man um I'm so appreciative we're wearing
Bulgari um jewelry and I'm so thankful
that they were willing to do both of our
dresses mommy daughter doess look pretty
thank
you
first of all how is it being out I mean
did you escape tonight where's the baby
yes I did Escape because I'm always on
Auntie Duty so I can always Escape I can
be like sis yeah you know so I know he's
in good hands right now how is that
though being cuz you two are so close
you and your sister are so close yes
we're like this thick as thieves and to
be able to be with her every step of the
process she is just such an incredible
mom I so proud of her I'm so proud of
her tonight for her nomination for Angel
so I am just here as proud big sis how'
y'all keep this secret for so long how
did y'all do it just like we keep all of
our other
Secrets sister
Z you had new music is there more coming
yes there's more coming coachella's
coming a lot of exciting things so what
do you got planned for Coachella tell me
about the performance what do you cuz
usually you have performances yes going
all out doing the most of course and you
know just dancing and singing my heart
out really yes all right so your sister
didn't come but you came she's still
going to be here she she's on the way
she's on the way she's on the way yes
all right we can't wait to see your
sister we cannot wait to it's so great
to you can't wait to see Coachella
anything you can anything else you want
to tell us the preview or anything else
like oh man I'm just here as a proud big
sis tonight Angel for the win Angel for
Auntie Chloe what we doing what are we
doing no you see you see auntie auntie I
was like I was like what we doing Auntie
do I no no this is the grown Mermaid The
Little Mermaid is your sister this is a
grown mermaid it's a grown
mermaid the gro no but for real when you
saw this was you like what was it about
that you said okay I'm about to step on
some some necks my tummy is out today
and so I was like okay yeah let's do it
and it feels very effortless and like I
feel like a Bronze
Goddess yes who made this dress oh yes
so Timothy he styled it and it's like I
love it because it just feels like
molten gold you know that's why I love
it and the hair tone to match yes yes
thank you thank you
guys how you doing I'm doing real good
I'm just grateful to live this moment
yeah this is a big moment for you
tonight yes indeed so how have you been
all day is it are you nervous or there
excitement are you just chill we've been
chilling in the hotel we've been um
getting ready and real I mean I'm real
I'm saying about the nomination you won
I won you yeah we're celebrating come on
smile smile bigger than that you we are
smiling we are smiling so how does it
feel to be a Grammy winner it it feels
great it feels awesome it's a dream come
true now you can exhale and just have
fun tonight right yes yes we're
celebrating that with my beautiful
girlfriend right here and you look
amazing you didn't want to come up here
look she didn't want to come up here but
she look so good when she walked out
what were you like
no she uh she looks amazing you looks
amazing oh thank you so much thank you
so this is um you had your first tour in
the US last year with I I don't know
what like 50 something sold out shows
yeah it was it was a great tour and this
tour is going to be bigger I what is
that like when you walk out and you see
the house is just so full and they're
there for you I don't know I'm just real
thankful with people that hears and
supports my music every day and and I
know they're waiting for a for a for a
new album and for new music so wait what
are you going to do at Coachella what
can they expect from that performance
it's going to look great it's going to
look awesome you have to be there yeah
yes so I know people are waiting for new
music are you in the studio are you
writing are you are you recording
already I'm doing everything at the same
time I'm I'm just working and keep
grinding and I think it says here that
your third album Genesis was the most
streamed um first Day music Urbana album
on Spotify already like you had the most
streams yeah I think so yeah I'm just
I'm just happy to be here you know well
I mean there's so much happening for you
this year now time has Time Magazine has
named you one of the 100 next big
artists so do is there a pressure to
like live up to all of these things that
are happening no pressure no pressure at
all I'm just living my life loving to
make music okay who's on the
collaboration front for you now who's
the next person person you say okay I'm
I want to do something the person I'm
going standing next to so do you get it
do you make music together yes we make
music together sis come on and it's a
song coming out what is the song's name
oh you have to wait for oh look see
there you go you have a good you're
going to have to wait for
that Taylor where's Travis tonight
where's Travis Taylor you look
incredible can we get away
[Music]
t
[Applause]
[Music]
t
l
said
[Music]
t t
tayor Taylor to your right to your right
Tay mean she's
married
[Music]
way
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say fin here yeah okay so you can
exhale now how does it feel we
celebrating tonight yeah yeah it feel
good you know what I'm saying finally
the make it here um and be here for my
own purpose what say you I mean you've
been nominated four times you win
tonight now can you just relax and enjoy
the show and what are you most looking
forward to seeing um I'm just here to
experience it I'm saying it just feel
good to be here got my wife with me it's
VI I mean when she walks out looking
like this what do what are what are we
saying cuz good God never let go of
hand I love that so much is there
anybody that you know that's performing
tonight that you're that you like are
excited to see um I'm I'm honestly uh
excited about the whole show you know
what I'm saying it's like I say it feel
good to be here yeah you you were just
in Kanye and taala sign's video right so
I mean when you're making music with
them like I what's the what's the
process like um just to sum it all up
Evil Genius because it's the lead single
to his upcoming album so you've seen it
and I mean he's been teasing what we're
going to get and he is I think those are
great words for him evil genus Evil
Genius Evil Genius sh out exactly he
recently posted on IG I think tell Dirk
to activate tell Dirk to activate his IG
it's time to drive I'm a couple days
late but since we got the good news I
had to yeah yeah yeah so what what did
you did you post already I'm post I got
to post I got to post these outfits
tonight uh the wars tonight so I'm
feeling good tonight I was going to say
what does the night bring cuz y'all look
too good to just go home um it's a
change of plan we got to go back to the
drwing board since we won right it was
going to be low ke but now you like no I
got to celebrate my
baby yes yes I love that so much so good
to see you congratulations what's the
next I mean you know you've got yay and
Ty do but who's the next collab or who's
the next person on your list somebody
that we wouldn't think that you would
want to work with that you really want
to work with um I want to say who y'all
think I wouldn't but I'll say Morgan
wall really that is somebody I didn't
think you would say yeah it's going to
be a cab album soon okay so you guys are
going to work together that's
interesting vibs so so so that mean I'll
see you again next year know you see
what I'm saying Come on talk your stuff
I love it so much you guys have a great
night tonight who okay who did this look
by the way
L shout out La Roach Oh La Roach did it
love it love it well you look
spectacular good luck have a great night
tonight guys okay good to see y'all
okay hold on you just won yes I just won
what the heck like it's crazy it's crazy
okay what does this mean though to win
this award for a song that everyone
loves I mean this one over
here
always right look
look what' I tell you it's amazing it's
I'm so proud of myself so proud of South
Africa Africa it's a win for us all so
I'm just super blessed have any has
anybody called you yet from Africa that
is watching from South Africa everybody
blowing you up my phone
it's it's crazy my phone is blowing up
really yeah it's blowing up everybody
calling everyone celebrating it's a huge
moments amazing did you just see JT Jam
in the water did you see that that
Justus Timberlake was I never see that
yes yes he
was everybody loves this song Justus
Timberlake I'm saying JT yes I did see
that that's crazy that's crazy you saw
it yeah I saw it it's amazing I I I
can't believe it I'm a lost for Words
Janet Jackson was vibing to it Oprah
like it's gone it's gone okay when you
made this song what did you think when
you made the song when I made it I knew
it was special I knew like I loved it my
family loved it I had a dream about the
song so I feel like I knew in my spirit
that this was the one how are you
celebrating tonight hey I'm going
out we have to we have you have to and
then you have to go home and celebrate
in South Africa everywhere I'm going I'm
celebrating now yeah show One More Time
come on come on me make
me yes you got she got it she needs to
teach me how to do the dance cuz I want
okay hold on okay will you teach her cuz
she does she does it all the time so
it's oh
oh wait this way or this way there you
go I'll give you private lesson she's
like keep trying this I'm going give you
the private lesson congratulations
congratulations thank you will you tell
us about the dress real quick yes so I'm
wearing custom
faace cute um I love it I L working with
them on the design and yeah I just came
out perfect I couldn't have asked for a
better outfit for my first
Grammys yeah congratulations it's it's
the hit of the year I mean everybody
loves that
song come on you want them take over
take the mic don't say anything crazy
hello we're at the Grammys Janelle Monae
and I wonderful wonderful night you know
what I love this there's nothing better
than a family night at the Grammys and
what does it mean to have your mom here
to enjoy this well one I could not
imagine winning a Grammy and my mom not
be there like it was so important as you
can see she's a ball of energy she's my
she's my foundation so I was like if I
win a Grammy I want my mama here so it's
a beautiful thing to have her with me
yes it is album of the it's an honor
right yes Prince will be so
happy album of the year though what is
that Progressive yes but when you put
that album together it you said you
going to do something different and
you're going to do it your way and you
did that's what I'm saying she's
creeping up on that isn't she yeah
listen I I I try my best in my art to
represent um my community in a in a deep
way and making music and art for us and
most of the time it was rooted in
Seeking Justice for us yes this time
around I wanted joy for us just Justice
and joy it can coexist and that's what
the age of pleasure was about uh making
sure that we felt safe enough to feel
free enough to be ourselves even more
and unapologetically and so I'm just so
happy that me being here represents a
community of marginalized folks who are
smiling who are happy who are working
through the pain you know uh of of of of
the the the Pains of life and and
finding Solace and finding love in one
another I think that you are one of the
voices out there especially among black
women who are telling things
authentically their way and it's been
important because you freed up a whole
Community has come out I I might be in
love with your mama I'm going be honest
with you I love I love your M the real
star I need my own talk show guys I am
so
funny we going to get you your own talk
show so it is the uh my other uh
producers who worked on the project I
want to go take some photos with them
cuz some it's their first time here I've
been here a couple times so I'm going
run over there really fast tell me about
that dress real quick thank you it's
Herman PR Couture uh it's custom and I'm
just so I feel so good I feel so
Timeless I feel futuristic I Feel Like
Me Mama did you just touch my
boo your mom is the great you might stay
here I might keep your mom right here I
might keep your mom I might keep your
mom right
here did you see that they were singing
your song on SNL
night I saw the clip and I I was
watching and I was like where does the
song come in and then all of a sudden
she burst into song a capella and I was
like this is awesome there's been a
couple times that they've shouted me out
this year so thanks guys isn't that kind
of special though that people are
recognizing your music your career on
such a large platform yes well and I
mean all these years later as well like
I'm just so grateful that my music has
spanned kind of the test of time it's a
classic and that's what I'm going to
continue to do okay so you were
nominated tonight you guys didn't win
but it was still great to be here and be
nominated yes I mean to get nominated
once is an honor and then all this time
later for my peers to think that
something of mine is worthy to be
nominated again is is incredible so I'm
grateful and how was it working with
King and Country how was that easy it
was so easy they are the most kindest
men that I've ever met their wives as
well their whole team they've just been
so great so they were texting me earlier
today like oh we can't wait to see you
so hopefully they'll pop up here in a
second I don't know where they are but
they were amazing to work with okay so
since I've known you since you've been a
young woman when you made your last
video with your husband a very grown and
sexy video yes what was that what was
the conversation like at home to when
you decided to make that video it was
actually my idea was it yeah I was like
it's time for you to show that sexy side
that I see to the world and so I feel
like we did that and it worked it worked
it worked it worked the internet will
tell you just go to YouTube and you'll
see it worked um what does it mean to
have someone that is there to support
you and Champion you each and every day
I mean it's please don't get me
emotional I already had to like get
everything together earlier but um I've
never had someone who supports me the
way that Dana supports me he honestly
wants to see me do the best that I can
do he puts me on his shoulders every day
he's like babe what about this what
about this what about this you should do
this he encourages me when I'm like I
don't know he pushes me outside of my
comfort zone like he a great dad he's a
great anr he's a great manager he's all
the things a great husband yeah this one
keep and I always love the way he shows
the sexy side between the two of you
that you you know you got children but
that ain't stopping the loving right how
you think the kids got here come
on I mean he's right he's not wrong all
right fun to be here tonight tell me
about this dress this is z mom and I
found it last minute at this amazing
showroom called The Show Must Go On on
and yeah I put it on and just felt
beautiful and I felt that it represented
where I am now like I'm still a flower
but don't mess with me don't mess with
you okay um next videos what what is
going to come with the next videos go
ahead babe not me I I'm taking a break
I'm taking a break y'all can have her
I'mma take a break and we'll get another
love interest or something else it's Str
not being in front of the camera can't
you see yeah that's a that's a lot he he
should be though you see this face he
should be
[Music]
we made it
happen we had
AO
r come on come
[Music]
on
you look amazing my guy the long all of
it is working for me you did you did are
you growing it for a project or did you
just decide like let me just I don't
know well to be honest like I was when I
knew that I I was going to have a baby
yeah I always wanted to have like that
picture of me with long hair I don't
know just you know like holding my baby
and it's like so organic so grounded I
don't know I just I just let my hair
grow because I feel I feel grounded
right now in my life I just like it like
that I love that How is suzan how's she
doing she good oh she's great my baby's
is growing pretty fast in her in her
mom's belly everything is doing great
are you are you I know you said
everything's great in life but are you
ready for this are you ready for
fatherhood well to be honest I I don't I
don't think you're always ready you know
I I would say like kids they don't come
with any manual so I just go with the
flow I really I really love her and I
and I love what I'm living right now I
can't imagine what's going to happen you
know but you're also having a girl and
you know what they say that does to a
man like you're done you're done yeah to
be honest that was a big Karma you know
you know I was like kind of refused when
I when I knew that I was going to become
a dad I kind of I was feeling that that
thing that I I didn't want to have girl
you know because I knew that that was
going to be a Karma but I'm just kidding
I I love what's going on right now she's
going to have you wrapped up so tight
that little girl is going to have you
that's what my dad tell me to because I
have a sister and all the sisters so
she's always like my daddy's always like
wait for wait for Paris to be born man
you're going to know what's real love I
love that you guys already have decided
what her name is going to be did you was
that just always in the in the in the
world yeah the thing is that that's more
like cultural you know what I mean like
there in Colombia we think about names
before we we know that we're going to
have babies you know so I don't know and
also a crazy fact is that we actually
had that moment in Paris so Paris was
yeah that's what is Paris yeah I love
that so much okay I know you got to go
but it just um you just recently made
history you were as the first urban
Urbana I can't talk Urbana artist to be
number one on both the Latin airpl and
also the regional Mexican charts come on
like is there nothing that you touch
that doesn't turn to Gold well yo thank
you well thank you very much I really
appreciate that the only thing I'm going
to say is that I'm going to means not
winning the the Grammy you know what I
mean because I was nominated I'm
nominated today as be L album pop and
and it's I just wanted to Happ in my arm
so let's see if next year we're going to
have the chance to be nominated again
and maybe taking it home and then you
can come with per and your whole family
and it'll be family going be nice too
you know I'm not in a rush I'm just
enjoying my life enjoying the moment
that I'm living well have an amazing
time tonight it's always good to see you
my man and congratulations on everything
okay hi Mommy hi so I'm so happy for you
and you you know what I love about it h
is like you just like you radiate this
goodness and you just seem like you are
on top of the world right now is that is
that the case that is truly the case I'm
so excited to be here tonight I'm like
I'm with my boo I'm like having the
greatest time you boo he was just
holding hand yeah yeah yeah I love but
yeah so it's date night y'all like you
got to take these when you can get them
because now that you're new parents
you're not going to get all those date
nights anymore so what does date night
bring for you guys oh my gosh we're so
excited to see the performances to chill
and to just be nominated is an honor so
I just can't believe believe I'm in this
room tonight yeah well you here baby
you're not going anywhere who are you um
excited to see on the stage cuz there's
going to be a lot of iconic moments oh
wow I'm so excited to see everyone
honestly I mean I heard scissors
performing so I can't wait to see that
the list could go on your color purple
sister frantasia is doing a tribute to
Tina Turner tonight be amazing how has
this run been for you I know there was I
was disappointed that there was not a
best picture nomination that there was
not a best picture nomination for you
guys for the color purple I think you
very deserve it's one of the best movies
of the year but so how has this ride
been for you and now is it like okay I
really I kind of have the acting bug so
I'm going to do this for a minute yeah
I'm going to keep going I mean acting
has been so much fun for me a beautiful
new outlet and I'm excited to take on
more projects though now you're about to
break the internet with this dress cuz
the people are going to say how she just
have a b look at this how did you just
St back how did you just have a baby I
mean why when you saw this dress what
was it about it that made you say this
is it for this night oh I really love
the stress Gucci made it for me and I
feel confident I'm really excited I
think I was excited to kind of step back
and wear start wearing formfitting stuff
after pregnancy so it's it's been really
fun do you do you feel different being a
mama like is there is there an added
confidence is there just what what
changed for you yeah I definitely feel
more powerful and like more womanly you
know yeah I love
that well you guys are the cutest little
family have a good night listen you and
your sister shut down everybody here
tonight cuz she walked in here like I'm
having my stuff amazing didn't she
though and she was so excited for us to
call her auntie oh yeah thank you I love
it have a good night tonight good to see
you
[Music]
baby hello love how are you oh honey
these earrings great to see baby hold on
a second M I'm just kidding they're
ridiculous okay I just feel like you and
David geta need to just do just do an
album I know I told him I said David
come on bro let's do an no but you know
what we're working on it seriously you
guys have the the sauce together we do
we do but we we know it's it's a it's a
LoveHate relationship more love but he
called me his annoying little sister and
I was like excuse me if I'm your
annoying little sister then you're my
annoying older brother right there you
go you want the old monik man yeah
I think maybe sometimes that's the best
way to make music you know what I'm
saying when it's like you know you get
on my nerves you get on my nerves but
then here comes the magic that's the
best that's the best music yeah yeah I
love it so much so tonight um what I
love about the Grammys are those
collaborations or what we see on happen
on the stage anybody that you're like
okay this is I'm I'm excited honestly
I'm excited to see daa I got to support
her my Albanian Queen um I'm I'm excited
to see Lana I just saw her pass by and I
just think her music's so amazing I
think it's finally Lana's time to shine
um so I'm really excited for her
honestly the girls listen you okay you
took the words right out of my mouth I
was talking to Billy Joel ear oh my gosh
how is that well first of all I God I
just cracked I had to say to him I said
um I have to admit that I'm nervous
right now because you're it's you but
he's performing for the first time in 30
years on the Grammy stage tonight and I
said to him like who do you love right
now and what he said is Olivia Rodrigo
Billy iish Taylor Swift like
and that's what he said he said
something about what the women are doing
right now is special is another level
why do you think that because I believe
it too I just feel like we're in an ER
you what's the girls doing let me think
let me think about this answer I just
feel like the girls are just doing what
they want yeah you know what I mean the
more empowered that we get the more
power that we get like like we're just
kind of standing in our own and it's
time like you know I have such like I
want to see who oh it's Carol oh I gotta
go say hi but yeah but anyway
Caesar anyways love sorry no but I this
is like on I actually do have it like on
the red carpet is not good it's like a
family reunion here though really is you
get to see people you haven't seen you
get to hang out again I I want you to
enjoy every minute of this night I love
seeing you okay tell me a little
something what's the drama you're giving
us for this look H all black everything
Robert W like black widow Vibes I'm
newly
single okay call me all right are we are
we taking suitors are we taking time uh
uh fun okay I like I like I like single
you I like single you cuz there's a sass
there's a confident you stand a little
tall leg up and this face is beat thank
you number one album in the country
you're rolling here and you you your a
superstar tonight but what does that
mean to have the number one album in the
country uh it just feel good like I my
hard work paying off and the nominations
tonight also to be recognized because we
know for a long time the Grammys will
Overlook artists right right we know
that but to do the work and then have it
recognized what does that mean to you it
feel good it's a good feeling yeah yeah
for sure okay great collaborations right
but if you win tonight where's the party
W I'm going probably party at my hotel I
don't really like party you lay low you
laying low tonight yeah but it's also
got to be cool like Lenny krait's right
there rolling with seeing all the stars
and with everybody would you ever collab
with Lenny yeah for sure a legend he's a
right right that's what I'm saying hold
on watch wait wait we're going to tell
him we're going to tell him right now
let's tell Lenny gra did you need to do
a collab hold on one second we're going
to tell him hold on we're going to tell
him right now cuz he need if anybody
needs to be on his next record is you we
appreciated it so so much Nelle right
thank you B Nelle tell Lenny 21 Savage
wants to be on your next record he's
losing what's happening man let's do it
good yeah let's do it man that's good
you too all right man yeah for sure see
we're we're working out things
here this is what the Grammys are about
this is a collab we're waiting for right
21 Savage and L KRA sure that's a
collaboration that we need don't play we
need this right I'm for real all right
get it done can you do something for me
21 can you
all right tell me about SNL oh yeah I'm
doing SNL on the 24th yeah on the 24th
but what do you what do you got planned
nobody goes to SNL and just
surprise who's going to be with you will
you have anybody with you what I'm going
have some people with me oh you're
bringing some folks yeah like who come
on I can't tell you but it'll be
something special yeah for
sure I haven't had a chance to
congratulate you first of all since the
EM I've not seen you come on in here
come on it's a it was a family
win you should have congratulated you
because no but let me tell you why you
should have congratulated you and people
didn't mention this that people told you
you couldn't do serious stuff the people
told you that you were just a funny lady
you should be off to the side do your
funny thing and stop yeah and you said
damn it I'm going to show you I got to
show you I got to show you something and
you showed the whole world and it's been
thing after not one but it's been thing
after thing after thing after thing so I
just do not make me cry my fake
eyelashes off I'm at the Grammys but I
was just so happy for that moment
because you manifested that you said I'm
going go and show youall you know I had
a wonderful support system and uh and we
were able to bring home that award and
I've been I'm still floating you should
be floating by the way where is the
award at home in in the front actually
in the front door soon as you walk soon
as you walk in it sings to you it's like
wo right there with my big bouquet that
I got from Oprah yes yes this really
isn't your night it's your night cuz
you're the musician in the family so
what is it that makes the Grammy so
special oh being able to be among so
many amazing musicians and artists and
uh people that I've looked up to for
over the years so I'm excited to be here
Kevin I I love that I got invited on a
date normally I'm like hey come with me
to this thing and now she's like you
want to go to the gramys I'm like
okay I'm going to take you yeah you're
my day um I also want to talk about
origin because it has been doing well in
the theaters it expanded to a to more um
audiences now why is it so important for
people to see this movie wow for such a
time as this it it it it opens your mind
it invites you to think differently and
to unlearn some things so it it's
definitely a musty it's a must SE it
really is a movie that will change it's
not like we go to movies to escape and
have fun but this one it changes your
life forever absolutely very powerful
message I think it's a masterpiece so I
enjoyed
[Music]
it
e
[Music]
okay so first of all mom Night Out how'd
you get away and are what are the babies
doing I was just with them they are at
home just playing together it's so sweet
and so feel so blessed and so lucky how
is motherhood because I know you were
ready you waited you know and then what
does it mean to you to finally be a
mother especially because of the love
that you have for your mom my life just
feels so complete my husband my two
beautiful babies just feels like all my
dreams come true and I just feel so
fulfilled and just happy at life okay
Paris the DJ is here tonight though
right you're Paris the DJ what is it
what are you looking for tonight who are
you excited to see I'm just excited to
see so many of my favorite artists
excited for Miley nominated six times
she is such an icon and I'm just so
excited for my second album ca's
executive producing it track what can
you okay so what can you tell me about
the album the album is mean a lot of
amazing badass females on it and a lot
of surprises and it's all about my
journey and everything that I've went
through in my life and I'm just so
excited and honored to have CA executive
producing and writing all the music with
me okay so do your kids love it when you
play music for them do you play music
for them what do you play for them my
kids love music Phoenix just got a
little piano for his first birthday he's
been playing on the piano and he loves
stars are blind it's his favorite lull
ofi he was born man Paris this has been
such a crazy journey I mean I can think
back to way back in the day and all the
trials and tribulations and all that
stuff and when you think of that what
would you if you could whisper in your
ear and tell yourself something what
would you say say you're going to go
through a lot in life but one day you're
going to have the most beautiful perfect
life and family so keep going
girl you kept going you kept going it's
good to see you anything else parents
that's coming up um just everything
about about to release my 30th
fragrance and wa wait a minute your 30th
30th
yes I know what does this one smell like
it's just the most beautiful unique
scent I've ever smelled before it's my
favorite perfume ever won't you get into
the baby clothes business or something
doing children's stuff too yes we have
children's furniture and children's
clothing and doing a huge deal with
Walmart so everything will be out very
soon wow so when can we see that stuff
that will be out by this fall with my
new clothing line and jewelry and
Handbags damn Paris you do ever you
never stop do you there is no slowing
you down is there there's nothing
slowing me down can you tell us a secret
about your fashion tonight tonight well
I'm wearing this gorgeous mermaid gown
and then I have this custom made for my
handbag line cuz I'm representing Hilton
tonight CU they're a big part of the
awards and just wanted to represent
Hilton for the
day you really went all the way in Queen
right you will Market one thing you will
do is Market something right I invented
it that's real actually some people
copied right some people copied you but
you it's nothing like the original how
has it been living life in the Paris
Hilton Fishbowl but you guys have a very
normal life you have kids now so
everything has to be normal it's just
amazing watching Paris be a mom mom we
love to just stay home play with the
babies watching her mother is pretty
awesome yeah and what is Paris Hilton
the mom like uh well let's see the other
day I came home Paris was on a motorized
scooter and Phoenix was following her
around and they were doing relay races
so let's just say she's a fun and a
sliving mom living
Mom I love it thanks have a great
day okay first of all all the
nominations how how good does it feel to
be
that your peers love you it feels
incredible like I never expected four
nominations and I'm just just so happy
like I'm so excited yes okay um are you
excited for this Super Bowl commercial I
am I am shout out to Star they held it
down period what was it like shooting a
Super Bowl commercial how big is it
going to be cuz that's the biggest day
of the year the commercials are better
than game half time yeah they are um I
don't know I'm just really excited the
commercial was fun it was my second
commercial ever and um yeah it was it
was a little bit of a challenge filming
but we got why because lemon lime wasn't
actually present so I was talking to
nobody really but oh so you kind of just
talking to the green screen yeah we was
just you know getting our little acting
out more music coming right yes album
dropping this year Y2K tune in on when
when when is it dropping
2024 that's all you can tell me come on
now yes that's all okay tell me about
collabs or anybody that's on there I
can't let that be known yet but but my
fans will be very pleased 2023 was an
insane year so to cap it off now with
the Grammys in 2024 what would that mean
to you it just means everything I'm just
so happy to be acknowledged and you know
it's a big deal to
me okay I don't know what was happening
I don't know what's going on there's a
lot going on there's a lot like your
2023 yeah exactly enjoy the night okay
all right and good
luck on did you know that this song
was going to blow up like it did like he
was going to take the World by storm no
no I mean one lives in Hope but uh no I
had no idea I was seeing P now I'm like
Pam R pam pam can you explain padam to
me please well within the within the
song it's the heartbeat you
know but Pam took on a you know a
mirriad of uh of
meanings and at the time when it came
out first came out it was a greeting it
was a farewell it was who knows what
whatever you
like and it is such like people lose it
in clubs when they play it have you had
a chance to be in like do you sometimes
sneak into the club and you hear it and
everybody's goes crazy well I had a few
moments when we were doing listening
parties and just the place erupted I was
kind of faux DJing like literally just
press play but I was quite comfortable
there yeah AR it what does it also mean
to stay relevant with folks in
generation after generation after
generation which is very very cool well
obviously means a lot to me but I feel
like this current moment for myself is
beyond me that others might look at what
I've achieved and and go hey that's you
know she's broken a fair number of rules
in her time and and you can it can be
done you can achieve anything you want
any time yeah I mean of course you know
it's uh we we never stop working but
it's it's a great moment and I think
I've been doing this long enough to
really actively be cognizant that this
this is a great moment amongst the
madness I'm I'm is it that as we get
older we start to realize how precious
these moments are is that what it is
entirely yeah so to still be here to to
um to have won tonight do you know that
I won hold on you won I
won wait a minute oh you won well I
didn't know you this when I first like
yes I got two
now
wow where where are you going to put
this Grammy next to the other
one I thought you'd build like some kind
of special place for this uh it'll it'll
come back to Australia with me okay tell
me your speech cuz we didn't get to hear
the speech so tell me there was it was
in the pre-show and I was getting ready
so I got the news in my uh robe my
dressing gown kind of ready I screamed I
cried I was shaking and I had to stop
before you went to the ugly cry just
like trying we've just she's ready don't
undo it all with with tears but I was so
were you watching were you watching the
stream or were you getting a you got a
call I I my manager came to the came to
the door and came in saying two time
Grammy that's all she got out I I I
screamed it it's all it's on my it's on
my Instagram yeah yeah you just lost it
I lost it it was a great moment and then
I had to get back to focus cuz you look
great right now so clearly you pulled it
back together and got everything I I
brought it back from the brink yeah okay
well Kylie Mano two-time Grammy winner
have an amazing night great to see you
thank you tell us about this dress yes
um well I thought I'd come Pam red and
it's do abana my good friends and if IID
factored in the rain I might have done
without the the train situation but just
get a little wet that's that's all right
badam padam to you
okay thank you all for joining us here
on ET for all of your coverage from the
2024 Grammy Awards and never forget you
can always catch us on etonline.com take
[Music]
care
a
[Music]
e
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say am I a member because I got the
memo come on now this
great I got the
memo I think I think I just join
pentatonics
everybody well y'all know first of all
y'all know that you do the music does it
for me all the time so I mean it does
it's first of all it's like music is
healing anyway but your music is so
joyous and it's just like a feast for
the ear so it just makes me happy and I
mean everybody thinks that you're here
because you're nominated again so of
course oh my gosh yes we can't believe
we're nominated for an album we put so
much heart and soul into it's a it's a
world holiday album where we celebrated
all these different cultures and learned
about their music and their culture and
how they celebrate the holidays we
collaborated with the most iconic
artists from all these different
countries and it was so fulfilling and
such a beautiful Journey making this
album so to see it celebrated by our
peers in this way it's just surreal it's
the only word I can think of do y'all
ever feel like us like if you're in the
studio you're recording something and
then you hear it like oh damn we just
did that I mean seriously do you ever
feel like
that yeah sometime especially because
we're such fans of each other too you
know so like when I hear a certain thing
it's not things Kevin it just inspires
they keep going and keep pushing further
and so it's it's like we feel like kids
in the playground like they get to play
in the sandbox you know okay how do you
decide like when you hear your name
called who gets to say who gets to speak
give the speech up oh we talked about it
now I'm creating problems we're figuring
it out right here right
now I think I'd be so nervous and like
shocked so I would probably Mama's got
diamonds so Mama should be able to do it
oh yeah Mama just going to go
well hopefully they won't leave me
behind because I'm going to have to
Shimmy Shimmy onto the guys are part of
the opening ceremony for the premier
ceremony yeah with like Jordan Sparks
and Jay Ivy and all of that what was
that moment oh my gosh it was so good we
did Prince Let's Go Crazy everybody was
just unbelievable it's so cool to see
such diversity of Talent on one stage
and that's what I think makes the Grammy
so just unbelievably iconic that all
these artists from completely different
walks of life can be on the same stage
and showcase their talent but it all is
working harmoniously together it's it's
just the coolest thing I feel so blessed
that we get to do this each other
everyone was so kind we were all like
hyping each other up and it was just
such a fun song and a fun way to like
start our Grammy day all right so what's
coming up next that's a great question
you know I think what we've talked about
a
lot baby
girl I had Sheila E bust into your
interview come
on because we just performed
just talking
about they were just talking about how
cool it was for all these different
talents to get together open up the
ceremony kind of celebrate music and
celebrate each other oh absolutely it
was amazing I had a blast I mean I get
to play with them come on
really she she gave a master class on
energy like I it was amazing to watch
you perform and like taking the the the
mic and everything it just I did the
simp like master class thank you thank
you thank you happens to her when she
gets on
those oh my gosh yes it was
unbelievable well thank you guys so much
Sheila you stick
around find each other in like a very
similar Gap we're like sparkles sparkles
you know yes and this is giving tonight
so was it when you saw it on the rack
when you put it on what was it about it
this is a custom dress by k um that was
made for me um um I feel very excited to
wear it I feel very strong in it it's
definitely a heavy like metal dress I
was like feel very
jonok no but for real yeah well listen
you had a very strong year I'm having
I'm having fun so the last time I talked
to you at the Golden Globes you were
telling me about your new music and you
were saying you know this record is
about understanding your worth and
different chapters of your life so on
the 15th we're getting this on okay so
what are you what are you giving on the
so on the 15
like you said a new S I mean it'll be
late in the evening on the 15th but um a
new song which is just about kind of
knowing how
to it's almost like not expecting PE to
for people to like love you right yeah
you know yeah you're just like preach
baby training's over you know you're
done teaching people how to do things
right exactly come correct or don't come
at all correct or don't come at all
exactly that's the vibe that's the vibe
so much I can't wait cuz it does feel
like this record is going to be a very
personal one for you it is and you know
I I got to do most of the record at home
in
London um I just felt like and I feel
like with every album I get to grow more
and learn more about myself and I become
more free as a songwriter and as a
performer and as an artist so this one
I'm just like digging deeper and deeper
I love it I'm I'm proud of this one
heard of you as an artist that says I'm
a little nervous because this year for
you like has been in the stratosphere as
far as music is concerned you know what
I'm saying and I mean just career in
general but is there a part of you
that's like okay now I got to follow up
with like just an incredible year that
I've I mean there's always pressure yeah
there's always pressure but I think for
as long as I'm doing things that I'm
proud of things that I love things that
I feel like I'm pushing myself and
trying out something different and I'm
growing as an artist and as a person
then I'm good you know the grammies is
also about the performances and what's
going to happen on stage so what can we
expect oh we got something special for
you guys tonight she gives the smile
like the biggest smile I'm really really
excited about this performance like more
more so than any three words give me in
three words what this performance is
going to oh my God we we have it's
like it's intense okay uh it's
strong and uh it's dcy okay I love it so
you you have two nominations tonight
dance the night away we're still dancing
to it so I mean when you think about
that song when you were making it did
you think okay I got I got something
here like this is I mean I know you
didn't know what it was going to do but
but were you like okay yeah I got
something here yeah I mean in the moment
again it goes back to that thing for as
long as I feel like I'm having fun of
making something that I'm really proud
of and I'm in the moment then I'm I'm
exactly where I'm supposed to be and I
feel that way with you know when we were
making Dan night we were having such a
great time in the studio it felt so good
to be a part of such an inred incredible
project it felt so good to do it with my
friends that whole experience as a whole
was really special so um yeah I'm I'm
happy that that's like way out into the
world now and like had its own life and
it's it's been great well finally I was
in London didn't get to talk to you
there but I was there for Argy you have
this movie coming out it is fun fun fun
in so many ways and you get to cut up a
little bit in this movie and get a
little dancing going on I did get to do
a little bit of I mean I have a a small
role but I'm I loved working on the film
set and for Matthew Vaughn to give me
that opportunity I'm so grateful for it
and I had fun with my co-stars with
Henry caval and John Cena and are you
and John the new Hollywood Duo that we
didn't know we needed uh I don't know if
our acting career will continue together
um but I anytime I see him it's an
absolute pleasure and I I loved working
with him and he's so wonderful so who
knows he told me he was so embarrassed
because he had to sing off key to you
and he was like why am I doing this this
to myself he was he's such a good sport
honestly he wasn't even off key I think
he's just so humble that he's just you
know it's it's it was wonderful
really it was what made this year
possible we decided it before we even
recorded that it was going to be a
limited time and it's part of why we've
like given so much to this we can't
sustain this level of doing personally
yeah boy Genius opening up about their
Hiatus after winning at the 2024 gramys
the Grammy goes
to not strong
enough it's just like isn't
real uh yeah thank you uh thank you to
our band uh thank you to everyone that
uh contributed to the record I just want
to say well music save my life everyone
can be in new bands this band is my
family ahead of the award show the trio
snagged a trophy ET getting their full
reaction on the red carpet amazing
amazing we were like rushing getting
dressed when the live stream was on so I
had to play it cool I was like oh yeah
cool but it was amazing like wait wait
wait shut up like you I thought someone
had like dropped a vase or something
like and we were like and then we
screamed yeah the band's Big Win comes
just days after they announced at a
secret show they're going on hiatus
we're all just going to go chill and
it's made it like really special like
knowing that the shows are limited and
and we have a plan we have a plan to
watch Paddington too which everybody has
told us is amazing and we've been like
planning to watch it together for years
so we said after all this we're going to
watch Paddington too as for what this
means for the future of the Indie band I
mean I'm not convinced how do you know
how do you know a meteor is not going to
crash into Earth tomorrow you know what
I'm saying like but I don't know we're
going to be friends just be H I'm
telling myself
Bei with like what has happened and not
just like more more more yeah it's been
a question since our first week of
promoting the album what are you guys
doing next and we're like what do you
mean it's just that like stay here in
the moment I think it's like maybe the
finitude will help people realize that
like the thing that we give is enough
the album is enough we're proud of it
it's a recording you can go listen to it
anytime yeah it's
there Grammys I know never gets old for
you the night of this it's like it is
music's night right it's definitely
music's night and I love seeing all the
different looks come on the carpet
seeing how everybody went all out
exactly so what you know for me it's
about the collaborations that we see on
stage is there anybody that you're
looking forward to seeing perform
tonight uh oh my gosh I'm trying to
think who's performing that I I guess
like uh duala I want to hear she just
left and she said oh I got something for
y'all
tonight and as far as looks I can't wait
to see what DOA cat is going to wear you
know she's gonna come with something
iant guard look she might walk out here
with nothing on as far as they say it's
going to be a little art it's going to
be a work of art I can't wait to see it
I believe it I believe every minute
about it okay so what's happening with
Escape right now you guys still
performing I know I've seen you on a few
dates where are you just staying on
tours we're putting together a tour
right now for later this summer M if you
need somebody else I mean Tiny's
daughter if y'all need another member
killing it right and She's Not Afraid we
put her on stage and it's a whole Arena
full of people and she can just belt it
out yeah you know the the question on
everybody's mind is what's happening in
Atlanta and are you going to be back and
do we know what I have I've been trying
to figure that out for myself to be
honest with you and um I don't know I'm
thinking
that I'm thinking I might just say is it
time I me going back and forth and I
think because they gave us such a long
break I had a lot of time to do other
things and I got some big announcements
to make coming soon so yeah I was like I
mean I love the girls they're my friends
I'm still going to see them and hang out
with them and Bravo as my family I love
them as well but you know okay I'm going
to drill down are you making an
announcement right now that you are
going to take a break from Atlanta now
you done put the pressure on but I guess
yeah okay yeah CU I mean somebody asked
me recently they were like well why do
you um keep doing it and I was like to
be honest with you I think because I've
been doing it I 14 years and so now I
feel like it's it's I do it because I
I'm used to doing it but with all the
other things that I got going on I just
like I might just yeah I don't know if I
could imagine the show without you but I
couldn't either at first but I think
when they decided you know like they
were like okay we you know we taking
this break to you know rearrange the
cast and all the stuff that kind of
stuff and then it's like it gave me time
you know I never had time I never had
time yeah and I still was working don't
get me wrong I still had a lot of stuff
going on but it was like I had more time
to pick up my kids I had more time to be
in the studio so I've been writing a lot
and I have more time to work on these
other projects that y'all going to see
okay well listen you keep saying that so
you got to give me something CU you keep
saying I'm G have a big announcement I
got to work on these other projects oh I
mean you know I'm doing Broadway and I
already had um you know we have the Wiz
I'll be there March 13th in New York to
see the show and I'll be there February
13th in LA to see the show thank you
I'll be here so yeah um so I'm excited
for that and then I got some more things
to announce in that lane as well and you
know too much too I don't want to talk
too much ahead of time but yeah it's a
great so maybe more Broadway maybe more
that but I know you're working on that
OT you said it you manifesting it you
ready to do and I'm still I'm
manifesting yeah so so something in that
realm for sure like um because I I don't
want to give away too much that I have
to come I mean I'll just say I have some
big things coming so keep stay tuned but
um I do love the franchise but it's just
you know you know when everybody kind of
keeps you like at limbo for so long you
start making other plans you're the
longest running housewife to date at
this point that's a oh Lord Jesus you
know I love the house you know I love
you so I'm getting palpitations from
this I understand it though I do get it
I do understand it and like if this is
you know Andy might say maybe it's a
pause for you yeah that's what he called
me okay and cuz I I've talked to him
about it and he said well I don't he's
like I don't know how I feel about this
and I said well honestly I don't know
how I feel about it either but he was
like well you do realize this are this
is your family like if you just want to
just come back next year that's fine and
I'm like I mean I love you guys and I
appreciate like it's it's my family you
know what I mean so yeah I'm always a
part of them you know okay they're
always a part of me you have given you
I'm gaging right now I'm giving I
[Music]
love
hello how are you my goodness I have not
seen you in so long and you come through
here looking like the supermodel that
you are you look stunning here I'm going
bring you turn you around a little bit
more like this so we can see your whole
face okay you look stunning tell me
about this look from head to toe tonight
head to toe it's just Seline Mama it's
all all Seline Head To Toe with my my
own jewelry and um covered all the
tattoos I was gonna say Paris I know you
have tattoos and I don't see anything
what did how long did that take took a
few hours it took a few hours yeah why
did you do it was it because you just
wanted to go like super Glam tonight
super Chic tonight well I like switching
things up I love my tattoos I love my
piercings I love all the body
modification stuff art and also
sometimes I don't want it to distract
from the art that is the fashion I'm
wearing and I kind of it just gives it
gives the dress its own moment it's
giving for sure um I wondered because
you have You' got new music coming out
um and it's uh just a couple a couple
months um so I haven't decided when yet
but when I was on tour with Incubus I
dropped a single that I just did with
Linda Perry and so she and I just she's
like my Aries twin flame so we're we
want to keep working together sometimes
talking to a lot of other um celebrities
or children of celebrities they really
want to kind of figure out their own
lane and don't want to you know they
love their parent and love everything
they've done but they want to figure out
their own lane and make their own path
well depends on how meta you're getting
if you want to go on a much Universal
Collective Consciousness thing I think
we're all one so depends on how how far
you want to go with that that's what I
like okay so what is this new music what
is it giving like what are what um what
were you in what era were you in when
you were making it or what like what's
your inspiration um inspo is usually um
pain and love and the space between um
but my record exact Monty thinks that
Linda is my muse so can't go wrong with
Linda Perry that's for I love that we
cannot wait for this new music who are
you looking forward to seeing getting on
this Grammy stage tonight every single
human every single one every single one
you want it all all right s thank thank
you so much I appreciate it
okay okay first of all um you're DJing
at the Super Bowl right all week long
you have a residency in Vegas so what do
I need to do to get tickets to get in to
see you right uh be my best friend and I
can get you in how exciting is that
though because the town will be buzzing
especially this week but to be in Vegas
that's a lot of energy it is I love
Vegas and I have a home at the wind now
I'll actually be playing there all year
long and I am just so grateful to them
they've really like treated me like
family and there's no better place to be
in Vegas than the wi okay tell me about
the podcast and what actually goes on
because there are things y'all can tell
people and there are things you know so
how far do you go in this podcast we go
pretty good do you you know what I so
it's called sorry we're stoned for a
reason although she does not partake so
she keeps us all together so if I'm
starting to spill too much tea she's
like Mom zip it pull it in Pull It in
rain it
yeah Miley's performing tonight I think
flowers is such a little Bop and people
love that song but it feels like it also
tells a lot about her life and her story
when you listen to that song what do you
know that I don't know you know what you
got to dissect those lyrics I think the
fans know more than anybody knows they
absolutely do they dissected that pretty
well for us I think I did I I mean
people opened up those lyrics like they
were reading a book like it was a memoir
you know what the there were some taken
pretty far so I like yeah but over
overall like I think Miley had so much
fun making that song and like she you
know she says it over and over like no
expectations of it just from her heart
putting it out and to see it see its
success has been so incredible you know
and also there's just so much talk about
how this is like the next iteration of
Miley you know and so it's like she
continues to have success at every level
as she grows how cool is that to watch
her success it is so incredible but as
her mom it's watching her grow into this
woman she's become at 30 and once she
just 30 remember that just 30 exactly 31
but it's so crazy to think she's only 31
and everything that she's achieved but
as a person she's just the most
incredible human being I I'm so proud of
her okay real quick how many Miley songs
do you play during your DJ set minimum
three a minimum of three minimum of
three I like to the family okay do you
have a favorite family song um I mean
right now flowers just goes off so hard
also Noah did a song with Diplo a couple
years ago and I play that one quite a
bit also otel Road's always a hit like
Metro station I play Shake It The Crowd
Goes Crazy it really I I like to
represent my family y'all got hits y'all
got y'all got hits all right remember
when I'm standing at the door I'm
calling your name I'm calling you all
right for super for Super Bowl
[Music]
weekend
listen we're here celebrating though
because you guys have already won six
nominations tonight you've already won
one does it take a little like now you
can exhale a little bit and just go into
the rest of it like no 100% I was like
okay okay we're good like that's fine if
if nothing else happens the rest of the
night that's I'm 100% fine with that I
am so like excited for all the nominees
I'm like happy to be here we got one
we're out it's all good we're great if
we hadn't it would have been fine too
too right we're chill do you still get
nervous do y'all still get nervous we
always joke that like you kind of you
kind of are like you know what
everyone's amazing you know whoever wins
that's crazy but they're like the not
they're like they're like
congratulations dudk you
soate man oh my God you um um anyway
they say they say the award goes to and
your heart starts you know pounding
moment it's like everything before that
is like we're chill and then it's like
the moment that like envelope
or like the yeah the Grammy goes to it's
it's like it's like in your throat it's
let me ask you this cuz um you know
swarm was my thing like I loved it so
for real and I'm like this girl's good
like will there ever be a time where you
say Let me let me stop with music for a
second and really kind of dig deep into
the acting for
sure is it happening soon I don't know
girl because listen time well but a
critic's choice you said to us yes I got
music coming I don't know how much I can
talk about it yet but I have music music
coming I do have that that is for sure
on the way very very soon didn't you say
it's about 85% done oh no it's it's like
99 it's right there yeah I know we've
been saying that for a long time but we
can't give too many details cuz then
people get excited then they get mad
okay then just give me three words of
the vibe of the
album it
is that's not that's not
musical no it's like I was saying the
other day that it's like a I think it's
a perfect representation of like natural
progression of
like I don't know oh wait you are so oh
you are so terrible of where you are
okay well where are you in life maybe
that'll give me a CH an indication of
where the music yes is it like you're
chill are you chill are you like in a
real happy era a real it's all over the
place it's a lot of feeling it's a lot
of um it's like some whatever relax girl
jeez all right listen Okay so we've got
you can't take a break because after the
Grammys we have the Oscars you guys are
nominated will you be
performing I mean I think we're required
to well I don't know you could say no I
don't want to but oh yeah no way dude
I'm are you kidding me performing at the
Oscars is like I'm I'm literally like
please like I'm yeah it's the coolest
thing in the world I mean y'all could
just have a whole Barbie section because
Ry Ryan said he wanted to perform too oh
yeah and can't wait
to God all right so do we think have we
already started thinking about this like
what's going to go into this performance
what it'll look like what it'll feel
like for the Oscars you've been working
on the Grammy performance we're here
working on that one Grammy one yeah I
mean it's you know we're here we're
doing Barbie we're doing we're doing it
you are you are I love you guys
congratulations have a great night I
can't wait to see what you do by the way
besides your performance tonight anybody
you just can't wait to see on that stage
honestly I don't even know like who's
even all here which I'm sounding that
was tight can't wait so excited I'm I'm
geeked to see Luke Holmes and Tracy
Chapman get on stage and do fast car
together like that for me cuz that's my
I'm dating myself but that's like my My
Generation uhhuh yeah I'm excited I like
try not to know what's going to happen
because I like to be surprised so we'll
see there is so much still to come from
the Grammy Awards stick with each we
have so much more coming after the
[Music]
break
thanks for joining us tonight on ET and
we are bringing you the very best from
the Grammy red carpet right yes indeed
we are we had some fantastic moments
with music's biggest stars so check it
out I do not want to cry I you have
worked so hard and given so much of
yourself to this industry for so long
while quietly being in your absolute own
League oh my God we've talked about this
happening since the day we met and over
many tour bus sleepovers we did it is
the greatest joy to see the goodness you
have poured into others into your
collaborators I am so incredibly lucky
to be one of them over the years pouring
right back into you happy does not begin
to cover this is your mother jumping
moment mother jump oh my God I love you
Ari if you're hearing this I love you so
much thank you for being a Believer and
supporting me from the very beginning um
you knew things that other people didn't
know and saw things of me that other
people didn't see and you've just been
so bright or die so this is my love
letter to you thank you so much I'm
going to tell you in person obviously
but I love
you Mama are matching tonight thank you
so much this is her nap time but she'll
appreciate it later okay well we about
to celebrate cuz you won two already you
have won two babies already I found out
in the car on the way here and I'm shook
I'm like wow what a great start to the
night my song just went number one on
rhythmic radio today I'm like what a day
I mean you are the hardest working quote
unquote overnight success because I know
you've been in the game grinding been
long that's a long night right there and
like right next to you here Verdine
right so Verdine I'm interrupting
because Victoria's right they did the
song
Together how you doing
myce toet
you you look amazing she was the first
one that turned me on to you did a
moment
I loved you since '90s babies oh my God
that's thank you yeah know
congratulations best
Al I'm bring out thank you so much this
is good huh it worked out didn't
it I know I know this is good huh yeah I
know
exced oh she's over there she just went
that way holding up terrible she's like
na time I'm ready to get out of
here she is like
all right so little mama just went this
way and that way I know you said she she
knows the word Grammy she been working
on her poses how does she do it was nap
time so it's very like you have to get
her at a specific point in her day like
right after sugar not nap time so this
was like right in that window where
she's like uhuh she's two I get I'd be
like I'm like that and I'm 48 yeah yeah
same it's it's interesting to me because
because in this day and time I mean I
know you couldn't have even predicted
the success number one of the album and
then on my mama but then the viral
sensation of it as well I mean I can't
turn my head anywhere without hearing it
yeah you know what I always did want to
be one of those people who had a song
that eventually annoys people cuz it's
played so much and I think I don't know
maybe we're like maybe a month out from
that place you're like turn on my mom
off you know what I mean but I'm so
happy my radio team has been killing it
my manager and I really attribute a lot
of the success to the dance um the viral
dances so Sean Bankhead um Aza the
dancers that were in the music video
really brought it to life and everyone
who decided to recreate it and like do
it with their families that's what makes
it a collaborative effort with the fans
um to make it feel very very big so I
appreciate see R&B singers and
especially women anymore sing and dance
I mean it hearkens me to the Janet
Jackson and those like when I watch youv
artist yes seriously thank you is that
what did you come into just thinking
like I want to I want to be r& like I
want to hearken back to those R&B people
that I love and that we loved that did
it all I really think it's just what I
grew up on I feel like even Whitney
Houston the vocalist that she was had
some performances where she was dancing
she was hitting some moves so I feel
didn't have a real one two step but she
tried she did she did she had some
energy on that stage and certain stage
presence and so I value artists who
really um just put that effort in I I
just a huge fan of dance um it's part of
what performances I the most um so
Michael Janet Beyonce uh Chris Brown
Usher like performers who just kind of
incorporate movement into it and I know
how much breath work it takes and
stamina and how much work goes into it
so I just always really appreciate it
didn't you get a little gift from Miss
Beyonce she did send me flowers I looked
at that card and I was like no no no no
no no and I love white flowers and they
were all white flowers I know she sent
it to a few people who attended her
Renaissance film um Premiere but it's
still the most valuable thing in my home
so just you know I save the bowl the
flowers didn't make it but I save the
bowl it's now my fruit bowl my Beyonce
fruit bowl I love it I'm trying to re
the fruits right now I know that you've
got like 50 million things to do and
you're being pulled in 8 million
directions what what is it that keeps
you grounded what is it that keeps you
like good so you don't you know fall off
that Cliff or get too much or have too
much you know what I just really love to
do this I think that um it's not it's
just what I do I guess maybe if it was
more of like a um I don't know something
that I felt braggadocious about like
having it's not really like something
that I have it's something that I am so
I just around existing and loving music
and just wanting to do more you know
okay when you are deciding your dress
tonight and hey was it always we're
going to
match I did know that I did know that
from the beginning oh look at the tears
she's so she wants her mama you want
Mama come John
she can come to
her you come to Mama to
Mama Hi pry hi pretty all right anyone
with a two-year-old understands
absolutely before I let you these
dresses you guys oh my God custom
Versace styled by Colin Carter he's
right here he's the man um I'm so
appreciative we're wearing Bulgari um
jewelry and I'm so thank thankful that
they were willing to do both of our
dresses mommy daughter do you look
pretty thank
[Music]
you first of all how is it being out I
mean did you escape tonight where's the
baby yes I did Escape because I'm always
on Auntie Duty so I can always Escape I
can be like sis yeah you know so I know
he's in good hands right now how is that
though being a cuz you two are so close
you and your sister are so close yes
we're like this thick as thieves and to
be able to be with her every step of the
process she is just such an incredible
mom I am so proud of her I'm so proud of
her tonight for her nomination for Angel
so I am just here as proud big sis how'
y'all keep this secret for so long how
did y'all do it just like we keep all of
our other
Secrets sisters do
best you had new music is there more
coming yes there's more coming
coachella's coming a lot of exciting
things so what do you got planned for
Coachella tell me about the performance
what do you cuz usually you have
performances yes going all out doing the
most of course and you know just dancing
and singing my heart out really yes all
right so your sister didn't come but you
came she's still going to be here she's
she's on the way she's on the way she's
on the way yes all right we can't wait
to see your sister we cannot wait to
it's so great to you can't wait to see
Coachella anything you can anything else
you want to tell us the preview or
anything else like oh man I'm just here
as a PR big sis tonight Angel for the
win Angel for the win Auntie Chloe what
we doing what are we doing no you see
you see auntie auntie I was like I was
like what we do Auntie do I no no this
is the grown Mermaid The Little Mermaid
is your sister this is a grown mermaid a
grown
mermaid the grown no but for real when
you saw this was you like what was it
about that you said okay I'm about to
step on some some necks my tummy is out
today and so I was like okay yeah let's
do it and it feels very effortless and
like I feel like a Bronze
Goddess yes who made this dress oh yes
so Timothy styled it and it's like I
love it because it just feels like
molten gold you know that's why I love
it and the hair tone to
match yes thank you thank you
guys how you doing I'm doing real good
I'm just grateful to live this moment
yeah this is a big moment for you
tonight yes indeed so how have you been
all day is it are you nervous or the
excitement are you just chill we've been
chilling in the hotel we've been um
getting ready and real I mean I'm real
I'm saying about the nomination you won
I won you yeah we're celebrating come on
smile smile bigger than that you are we
are smiling we are smiling so how does
it feel to be a Grammy winner it it
feels great it feels awesome it's a
dream come true now you can exhale and
just have fun tonight right yes yes
we're celebrating with my beautiful
girlfriend right here and you look
amazing you didn't want to come up here
look she didn't want to come up here but
she look so good when she walked out
what were you like no she uh she looks
amazing you looks amazing oh thank you
so much thank you so this is um you had
your first tour in the US last year with
I I don't know what like 50s something
soldout shows yeah it was it was a great
tour and this tour is going to be bigger
I what is that like when you walk out
and you see the house is just so full
and they're there for you I don't know
I'm just real thankful with people that
hears and supports my music every day
and and I know they're waiting for a for
a for a new album and for new music so
wait what are you going to do at
Coachella what can they expect from that
performance it's going to look great
it's going to look awesome you have to
be there yeah yes so I know people are
waiting for new music are you in the
studio are you writing are you are you
recording already I'm doing everything
at the same time I'm I'm just working
and keep grinding and I think it says
here that your third album Genesis was
the most streamed um first day musical
Urbana album on Spotify already like you
had the most streams yeah I think so
yeah I'm I'm just I'm just happy to be
here you know well I mean there's so
much happening for you this year now
time has Time Magazine has named you one
of the 100 next big artists so do is
there a pressure to like live up to all
of these things that are happening no
pressure no pressure at all I'm just
living my life loving to make music okay
who's on the collaboration front for you
now who's the next person you say okay
I'm I want to do something the person
I'm going standing next to so do you get
it do you make music together yes we
make music together sis come on and it's
a song coming out what is the song's
name oh you have to wait for oh look see
there you go you have a good you're
going to have to wait for
that
Taylor where's Travis tonight where's
Travis Taylor you look Inc can we get
[Music]
away
[Applause]
left
[Music]
she literally said
Dr
oh yeah I I can set that
[Music]
up
tayor Taylor to your right to your right
Tay Tay
she's
marri
[Music]
way
he
[Music]
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say finally here yeah okay so you can
exhale now how does it feel we're
celebrating tonight yeah yeah it feel
good you know what I'm saying finally to
make it here um and be here for my own
purpose you I mean you've been nominated
four times you win tonight now can you
just relax and enjoy the show and what
are you most looking forward to seeing
um I'm just here to experience it what
I'm saying it feel good to be here got
my wife with me it's VI I mean when she
walks out looking like this what do what
are what are we saying cuz good God
never let go of hand
[Laughter]
I love that so much is there anybody
that you know that's performing tonight
that you're that you like are excited to
see um I'm honestly uh excited about the
whole show you know what I'm saying like
I say it feel good to be here yeah you
you were just in Kanye and ta doala
signs video right so I mean when you're
making music with them like I what's the
what's the process like um just to sum
it all up evil genus cuz it's the lead
single to his upcoming album so you've
seen
and I mean he's been teasing what we're
going to get and he is I think those are
great words for him evil genus Evil
Genius Evil Genius sh
out he recently posted on IG I think
tell Dirk to activate tell Dirk to
activate his IG it's time to drop I'm a
couple days late but since we got the
good news I had to yeah yeah yeah so
what what did you did you post already
I'm post I got to post I got to post
these outfits tonight uh the wars
tonight so I'm feeling good tonight I
was going to say what does the night
bring cuz y'all look too good to just go
home um it's a change of plan we got to
go back to the drwing board since we won
right it was going to be ke but now you
like no I got to celebrate my
baby yes yes I love that so much so good
to see you congratulations what's the
next I mean you know you've got yay and
Ty do but who's the next collab or who's
the next person on your list somebody
that we wouldn't think that you would
want to work with that you really want
to work with um I want to say who y'all
think I wouldn't but I say Morgan W
really that is somebody I didn't think
you would say yeah it's going to be a
collab album soon okay so you guys are
going to work together that's
interesting vibs so so so that mean I'll
see you again next year know you see
what I'm saying Come on talk your stuff
I love it so much you guys have a great
night tonight who okay who did this look
by the way
L LA shout out La Roach Oh La Roach did
it love it love it well you look
spectacular good luck have a great night
tonight guys okay good to see y'all
okay
hold on you just won yes I just won what
the heck like it's crazy it's crazy okay
what does this mean though to win this
award for a song that everyone loves I
mean this one over
here
always right look
look what' I tell you oh it's amazing
it's I'm so proud of myself so proud of
South Africa Africa it's a win for us
all so I'm just super blessed have any
has anybody called you yet from Africa
that is watching from South Africa
everybody blowing you up my phone it's
it's crazy my phone is blowing up really
yeah it's blowing up everybody calling
everyone celebrating it's a huge moment
it's amazing did you just see JT Jam in
the water did you see that that Justus
Timberlake was I never see that yes yes
he
was everybody loves this song justtin T
like I'm sing JT is yes I did see that
that's crazy that's crazy you saw it
yeah I saw it it's amazing I I I can't
believe it I'm a lost for words Janet
Jackson was vibing to it Oprah like it's
gone it's gone okay when you made this
song what did you think when you made
the song when I made it I knew it was
special I knew like I loved it my family
loved it I had a dream about the song so
I feel like I knew in my spirit that
this was the one how are you celebrating
tonight hey I'm going
out we have to we have you have to and
then you have to go home and celebrate
in South Africa everywhere I'm going I'm
celebrating now yeah show One More Time
come on come on me make
me yes you got she got it she needs to
teach me how to do the dance cuz I want
okay hold on okay will you teach her cuz
she does she does it all the time
so
it's wait this way or this way there you
go I'll give you private
lesson she's like keep trying this I'm
going give you the private lesson
congratulations
congratulations will you tell us about
the dress real quick yes so I'm wearing
custom for
sa cute um I love it I loved working
with them on the design and yeah it just
came out perfect I couldn't have asked
for a better outfit for my first
Grammys yeah congratulations it's it's
the hit of the year I mean everybody
loves that
song come on you want them take over
take the mic don't say anything crazy
hello we're at the Grammys Janelle Monae
and I wonderful wonderful night you know
what I love this there is nothing better
than a family night at the Grammys and
what does it mean to have your mom here
to enjoy this well one I could not
imagine winning a Grammy and my mom not
be there like it was so important as you
can see she's a ball of energy she's my
she's my foundation so I was like if I
win a Grammy I want my mama here so it's
a beautiful thing to have with me yes it
is album of the it's an honor right yes
Prince will be so
happy album of the year though what is
that Progressive yes but when you put
that album together it you said you're
going to do something different and
you're going to do it your way and you
did that's what I'm saying she's
creeping up on that isn't she yeah
listen I I I try my best in my art to
represent um my community in a in a deep
way and making music and art for us and
most of the time it was rooted in
Seeking Justice for us yes this time
around I wanted joy for us Justice and
joy it can coexist and that's what the
age of pleasure was about uh making sure
that we felt safe enough to feel free
enough to be ourselves even more and
unapologetically and so I'm just so
happy that me being here represents a
community of marginalized folks who are
smiling who are happy who are working
through the pain you know uh of of of of
the the the Pains of life and and
finding Solace and finding love in one
another I think that you are one of the
voices out there especially among black
women who are telling things
authentically their way and it's been
important because you freed up a whole
Community has come out I I might be in
love with your mama I'm going to be
honest with you I love I love your star
the real star I need my own talk show
guys I am so
funny you we going to get you your own
talk show so much it is good the uh my
other uh producers who worked on the
project I want to go take some photos
with them cuz some it's their first time
here I've been here a couple times so
I'm going run over there really fast
tell me about that dress real quick
thank you it's Herman PR Couture uh it's
custom and I'm just so I feel so good I
feel so Timeless I feel futuristic I
Feel Like Me Mama did you just touch my
Bo your mom is the great you might stay
here I might keep your mom right here I
might keep your mom I might give your
mom right
here did you see that they were singing
your song on SNL last
night I saw the clip and I I was
watching and I was like where does the
song come in and then all of a sudden
she burst into song a capella and I was
like this is awesome there's been a
couple times that they've shouted me out
this year so thanks guys isn't that kind
of special though that people are
recognizing your music your career on
such a large platform yes well and I
mean all these years later as well like
I'm just so grateful that my music has
spanned kind of the test of time it's a
classic and that's what I'm going to
continue to do okay so you were
nominated tonight you guys didn't win
but it was still great to be here and be
nominated yes I mean to get nominated
once is an honor and then all this time
later for my peers to think that
something of mine is worthy to be
nominated again is is incredible so I'm
grateful and how was it working with
King and Country how was that easy it
was so easy they are the most kindest
men that I've ever met wives as well
their whole team they've just been so
great so they were texting me earlier
today like oh we can't wait to see you
so hopefully they'll pop up here in a
second I don't know where they are but
they were amazing to work with okay so
since I've known you since you've been a
young woman when you made your last
video with your husband a very grown in
sexy video yes what was that what was
the conversation like at home to when
you decided to make that video it was
actually my idea was it yeah I was like
it's time for you to show that sexy side
that I see to the world and so I feel
like we did that and it worked it worked
it worked it worked the internet will
tell you just go to YouTube and you'll
see it worked um what does it mean to
have someone that is there to support
you and Champion you each and every day
I mean it's please don't get me
emotional I already had to like get
everything together earlier but um I've
never had someone who supports me the
way that Dana supports me he honestly
wants to see me do the best that I can
do he puts me on a shoulders every day
he's like babe what about this what
about this what about this you should do
this he encourages me when I'm like I
don't know he pushes me outside of my
comfort zone like he's a great dad he's
a great an anr he's a great manager he's
all the things a great husband yeah this
one yeah keep and I always love the way
he shows the sexy side between the two
of you that you know you got children
but that ain't stopping the loving right
how you think the kids got here like
come
on I mean he's right he's not WR all
right fun to be here tonight tell me
about this dress this is dig mom and I
found it last minute at this amazing
showroom called The Show Must Go On and
yeah I put it on and just felt beautiful
and I felt that it represented where I
am now like I'm still a flower but don't
mess with me don't mess with you okay um
next videos what what is going to come
with the next videos go ahead babe not
me I I'm taking a break I'm taking a
break y'all can have her I'm going to
take a break and we'll get another love
interest or something else it stresses
not being in front of the camera can't
you see yeah that's that's a lie he he
should be though you see this face he
should
[Music]
be we made it happen
guys
[Music]
come on come
on
[Music]
you look amazing my guy the long all of
it is working for me you did you are you
growing it for a project or did you just
decide like let me just I don't know
well to be honest like I was when I knew
that I I was going to have a baby yeah I
always wanted to have like that picture
of me with long hair I don't know just
you know like holding my baby and it's
like so organic so grounded I don't know
I just I just let my hair grow because I
feel I feel grounded right now in my
life I just like it like that I love the
How is suzan how's she doing she good oh
she's great my baby's is growing pretty
fast in her in her mom's belly
everything is doing great thank you are
you I know you said everything's great
in light but are you ready for this are
you ready for fatherhood well to be
honest I I don't I don't think you're
always ready you know I I would say like
kids they don't come with any manual so
I just go with the flow I really I
really love her and I and I love what
I'm living right now I can't imagine
what's going to happen you know but
you're also having a girl and you know
what they say that does to a man like
you're done you're done yeah to be
honest that was a big Karma you know you
know I was like kind of refused when I
when I knew that I was going to become a
dad I kind of I was feeling that that
thing that I I didn't want to have a
girl you know because I knew that that
was going to be a Karma but I'm just
kidding I I love what's going on right
now she's going to have you wrapped up
so tight that little girl is going to
have you that's what my dad tell me to
because I have a sister and all the
sisters so she's always like my dad's
always like way for wait for Paris to be
born man you're going to know what's
real love I love that you guys already
have decided what her name is going to
be did you was that just always in the
in the in the yeah the thing is that
that's more like cultural you know what
I mean like they're in Colombia we think
about names before we we know that we're
going to have babies you know so I don't
know and also a crazy fact is that we
actually had that moment in Paris so
Paris was yeah that's what is Paris yeah
I love that so much okay I know you got
to go but it just um you just recently
made history you were as the first urban
uh
Urbana I can't talk Urbana artist to be
number one on both the Latin AirPlay and
also the regional Mexican charts come on
like is there nothing that you touch
that doesn't turn to Gold well yo thank
you well thank you very much I really
appreciate that the only thing I'm going
to say is that I'm going to means not
winning the the Grammy you know what I
mean because I was nominated I'm
nominated today as b l album pop and and
it's I just wanted to have in my arms so
let's see if next year we're going to
have the chance to be nominated again
and maybe taken it home and then you can
come with Paris and your whole family
and it'll be whole family going be nice
too you know I'm not in a rush I'm just
enjoying my life enjoying the moment
that I'm living well have an amazing
time tonight it's always good to see you
my man and congratulations on everything
[Music]
okay hi Mommy hi I'm so I'm so happy for
you and you you know what I love about
it how is like you just like you radiate
this goodness and you just seem like you
are on top of the world right now is
that is that the case that is truly the
case I'm so excited to be here tonight
I'm like I'm with my boo I'm like having
the greatest boo your boo he was just
holding hand yeah yeah yeah I love but
yeah so it's date night y'all like you
got to take these when you can get them
because now that you're new parents
you're not going to get all those date
nights anymore so what is date night
bring for you guys oh my gosh we're so
excited to see the performances to chill
and to just be nominated is an honor so
I just can't believe I'm in this room
tonight yeah well you're here baby
you're not going anywhere who are you um
excited to see on the stage CU there's
going to be a lot of iconic moment oh
wow I'm so excited to see everyone
honestly I mean I heard scissors
performing so I can't wait to see that
the list could go on your color purple
sister fontasia is doing a tribute to
Tina Turner tonight be amazing how is
this run bin for you I know there was I
was disappointed that there was not a
best picture nomination that there was
not a best picture nomination for you
guys for The Color Purple I think you
very deserve it's one of the best movies
of the year but so how has this ride
been for you and now is it like okay I
really I kind of have the acting bug so
I'm going to do this for a minute yeah
I'm GNA keep going I mean acting has
been so much fun for me a beautiful new
outlet and I'm excited to take on more
projects so now you're about to break
the internet with this dress cuz the
people are gonna say how she just have a
b look at this how you just St back how
did you just have a baby I mean why when
you saw this dress what was it about it
that made you say this is it for this
night oh I really love this dress Gucci
made it for me and I feel confident I'm
really excited I think I was excited to
kind of step back and wear start wearing
form fitting stuff after pregnancy so
it's it's been really fun do you do you
feel different being a mama like is
there is there an added confidence is
there just what what changed for yeah I
definitely feel more powerful and like
more womanly you know yeah I love
that well you guys are the cutest little
family have a good night listen you and
your sister shut down everybody here
tonight cuz she walked in here like I'm
having my amazing didn't she though and
she was Al so excited for us to call her
auntie oh yeah thank you I love it have
a good night tonight good to see you
[Music]
baby
hello love how are you oh honey these
earrings great to see baby hold on a
second I'm just kidding they're
ridiculous okay I just feel like you and
David geta need to just do just do an
album I know I told him I said David
come on bro let's do an Al no but you
know what we're working on it seriously
you guys have the the sauce together so
we do we do but we you know it's it's a
it's a LoveHate relationship more in
love but he called me his annoying
little sister and I was like excuse me
if I'm your annoying little sister then
you're my annoying older brother right
there you go you want the old Monica man
yeah exactly I think maybe sometimes
that's the best way to make music you
know what I'm saying when it's like you
know you're get on my nerves you're get
on my nerves but then here comes the the
magic that's the best that's the best
music yeah yeah I love it so so tonight
um what I love about the Grammys are
those collaborations or what we see on
is happening on the stage anybody that
you're like okay this is I'm just I'm
excited honestly I'm excited to see do I
got to support her my Albanian Queen um
I'm I'm excited to see Lana I just saw
her pass by and I just think her music's
so amazing and I think it's finally
Lana's time to shine um so I'm really
excited for her honestly the girls
listen you okay you took the words right
out of my mouth I was talking to Billy
Joel oh my gosh how was that well first
of all I God I just cracked I had to say
to him I said um I have to admit that
I'm nervous right now because you're
it's you but he's performing for the
first time in 30 years on the Grammy
stage tonight amaz and I said to him
like who do you love right now and what
he said is Olivia Rodrigo Billy ish
Taylor Swift like like d and that's what
he said he said something about what the
women are doing right now is special is
another level why do you think that
because I believe it too I just feel
like we're in an what you what's the
girls doing let me think let me think
about this answer I just feel like the
girls are just doing what they want yeah
you know what I mean the more empowered
that we get the more power that we get
like like we're just kind of standing in
our own and it's time like you know I
have such like I want to see who oh it's
Carol oh I got to go say hi but yeah but
anyway
Caesar anyways sorry no but I this is
like on the I actually do have it like
on the red carpet is not good it's like
a family reunion here though is you get
to see people you haven't seen you get
to hang out
again I want you to enjoy every minute
of this night I love seeing you okay
tell me a little something what's the
drama you're giving us for this look h
everything Robert wound like black widow
Vibes I'm newly
single okay call me all right are we are
we taking suitors are we taking time uh
uh fun okay I like I like I like single
you I like single you cuz there's a sass
there's a confident you stand a little
tall leg up and this face is beat thank
you number one album in the country
you're rolling here and you you're a
superstar tonight what does that mean to
have the number one album in the country
uh it just feel good like got my hard
work paying off and the nominations
tonight also to be recognized because we
know for a long time the Grammys will
Overlook artists right right we know
that but to do the work and then have it
recognized what does that mean to you it
feel good it's a good feeling yeah yeah
for sure okay great collaborations right
but if you win tonight where's the party
W I'mma probably party at my hotel I
don't really like party you lay low yeah
you laying low tonight yeah yeah but
it's also got to be cool like Lenny
krait's right there rolling with seeing
all the stars and with everybody would
you ever collab with Lenny yeah for sure
a legend he's a right right that's what
I'm saying hold on watch wait wait we're
going to tell him we're going to tell
him right now let's tell Lenny grait
that you need to do a collab hold on one
second we're going to tell him hold on
we're going to tell him right now cuz he
need if any anybody needs to be on his
next record is you we appreciated it so
so much Nelle Nelle right thank you
Nelle tell Lenny 21 Savage wants to be
on your next record he's losing his
what's happening man let's do it good
yeah let's do it man good you too all
right man yeah for sure see we're we're
working out things
here this is what the Grammys are about
this is a collab we're waiting for right
21 Savage and ly KRA for sure that's a
collaboration that we need
don't play we need this right I'm for
real all right get it done can you do
something for me 21 can all right tell
me about SNL oh yeah I'm doing SNL on
the 24th yeah on the 24th but what do
you what do you got planned nobody goes
to SNL and just
surprise who's going to be with you will
you have anybody with you what I'm going
have some people with me oh you're
bringing some fol yeah like who come on
I can't tell you but it'll be something
special yeah for sure
I haven't had a chance to congratulate
you first of all since the Emmy I've not
seen you come on in here come on it's a
it was a family win yes it
is you should have congratulated you
because no but let me tell you why you
should have congratulated you and people
didn't mention this that people told you
you couldn't do serious stuff the people
told you that you were just a funny lady
you should be off to the side do your
funny thing and stop yeah and you said
damn it I'm going to show you I got to
show you I got to show you something and
you showed the whole world and it's been
thing after not one but it's been thing
after thing after thing after thing so I
just do not make me cry my fake
eyelashes off I'm at the gramys but I
was just so happy for that moment
because you manifested that you said I'm
going go and show youall you know I had
a wonderful support system and uh and we
were able to bring home that award and
I've been I'm still floating you should
be floating by the way where is the
award at home in in the front actually
in the front door as soon as you walk
soon as you walk in it sings to you it's
like wo right there with my big bouquet
that I got from Oprah yes yes this
really isn't your night it's your night
cuz you're the musician in the family so
what is it that makes the Grammy so
special oh being able to be among so
many amazing music I and artists and uh
people that I've looked up to for over
the years so I'm excited to be here
Kevin I I love that I got invited on a
date normally I'm like hey come with me
to this thing and now she's like you
want to go to the gramys I'm like
okay I'm going to take you yeah you're
my day um I also want to talk about
origin because it has been doing well in
the theaters it expanded to a to more um
audiences now why is it so important for
people to see this this movie wow for
such a time as this it it it it opens
your mind it invites you to think
differently and to unlearn some things
so it it's definitely a must SE it's a
must SE it really is a movie that will
change it's not like we go to movies to
escape and have fun but this one it
changes your life forever absolutely
very powerful message I think it's a
masterpiece so I enjoyed
it
[Music]
come on
on
[Music]
okay so first of all mom Night Out how'd
you get away and are the what are the
babies doing I was just with them they
are at home just playing together it's
so sweet I'm so feel so blessed and so
lucky how is motherhood because I know
you were ready you waited you know and
then what does it mean to you to finally
be a mother especially because of the
love that you have for your mom my life
just feels so so complete my husband my
two beautiful babies just feels like all
my dreams come true and I just feel so
fulfilled and just happy at life okay
Paris the DJ is here tonight though
right you're Paris the DJ what is it
what are you looking for tonight who are
you excited to see I'm just excited to
see so many of my favorite artists
excited for Miley's nominated six times
she is such an icon and I'm just so
excited for my second album ca's
executive producing it
what can you okay so what can you tell
me about the album the album is mean a
lot of amazing badass females on it and
a lot of surprises and it's all about my
journey and everything that I've went
through in my life and I'm just so
excited and honored to have CA executive
producing and writing all the music with
me okay so do your kids love it when you
play music for them do you play music
for them what do you play for them my
kids love music Phoenix just got a
little piano for his first birthday so
he's been playing on the piano and he
loves stars are blind it's his favorite
L ofi since he was born man Paris this
has been such a crazy journey I mean I
can think back to way back in the day
and all the trials and tribulations and
all that stuff and when you think of
that what would you if you could whisper
in your ear and tell yourself something
what would you say say you're going to
go through a lot in life but one day
you're going to have the most beautiful
perfect life and family so so keep going
girl you kept going you kept going it's
good to see you anything else parents
that's coming up um just everything I'm
about to release my 30th
fragrance and wa wait wait a minute your
30th 30th
yes I know what does this one smell like
it's just the most beautiful unique
scent I've ever smelled before it's my
favorite perfume ever won't you get into
the baby clothes business or something
doing children's stuff too yes we have
children's furniture and children's
clothing and doing a huge deal with
Walmart so everything will be out very
soon wow so when can we see that stuff
that will be out by this fall with my
new clothing line and jewelry and
Handbags damn Paris you do ever you
never stop do you there is no slowing
you down is there there's nothing
slowing me down can you tell us a secret
about your fashion tonight tonight well
I'm wearing this gorgeous mermaid gown
and then I had this custom made for my
handbag line
cuz I'm representing Hilton tonight CU
they're a big part of the awards and
just wanted to represent Hilton for the
stay you really went all the way in
Queen right you will Market one thing
you will do is Market something right I
invented
it that's real actually some people
copied right some people copied you but
you it's nothing like the original how
has it been living life life in the
Paris Hilton Fishbowl but you guys have
a very normal life you have kids now so
everything has to be normal it's just
amazing watching Paris be a mom we love
to just stay home play with the babies
watching her mother is pretty awesome
yeah and what is Paris Hilton the mom
like uh well let's see the other day I
came home Paris was on a motorized
scooter and Phoenix was following her
around and they were doing relay races
so let's just say she's a fun and a sing
mom sing
Mom I love it thanks have a great day
okay first of all all the nominations
how how good does it feel to be that
your peers love you it feels incredible
like I never expected four nominations
and I'm just just so happy like I'm so
excited yes okay um are you excited for
the Super Bowl commercial I am I am
shout out to stari they held it down
period what was it like shooting a Super
Bowl commercial how big is it going to
be cuz that's the biggest day of the
year the commercials are better than Gam
half time yeah they are um I don't know
I'm just really excited the commercial
was fun it was my second commercial ever
and um yeah it was it was a little bit
of a challenge filming but we got why
because lemon lime wasn't actually
present so I was talking to nobody
really but oh so you kind of just
talking to the green screen yeah we was
just you know getting our little acting
out more music coming right yes album
dropping this year Y2K tune in when when
when is it dropping
2024 that's all all you can tell me come
on now yes that's all okay tell me about
collabs or anybody that's on there I
can't let that be known yet but my fans
will be very pleased 2023 was an insane
year so to cap it off now with the
Grammys in 2024 what would that mean to
you oh it just means everything I'm just
so happy to be acknowledged and you know
it's a big deal to
me okay I don't know what was happening
I don't know what's going on there's a
lot going on there's a lot like your
2023 yeah exactly enjoy the night okay
all right and good
luck on did you know that this song was
going to blow up like it did like it was
going to take the World by storm no no I
mean one lives in Hope but uh no I had
no idea I was saying P now I'm like Pam
red pam pam can you explain padam to me
please well within the within the song
it's the heartbeat you
know but Pam took on a you know a myriad
of uh of
meanings and at the time when it came
out first came out it was a greeting it
was a farewell it was who knows what
whatever you
like and it is such like people lose it
in clubs when they play it have you had
a chance to be in like do you sometimes
sneak into the club and you hear it and
everybody's goes crazy well I had a few
moments when we were doing listening
parties and just the place erupted I was
kind of faux dejing like literally just
press play but I was quite comfortable
there yeah I do what does it also mean
to stay relevant with folks in
generation after generation after
generation which is very very cool well
obviously means a lot to me but I feel
like this current moment for myself is
beyond me that others might look at what
I've achieved and and go hey that's you
know she's broken a fair number of rules
in her time and and you can it can be
done you can achieve anything you want
any time yeah I mean of course you know
it's uh we we never stop working but
it's it's a great moment and I think
I've been doing this long enough to
really actively be cognizant that this
this is a great moment amongst the
madness I'm I'm is it that as we get
older we start to realize how precious
these moments are is that what it is
entirely yeah so to still be here to to
um to won tonight do you know that I won
hold on you won I
won wait a minute oh you won well I
didn't not you this when I first like
yes I got two
now
wow where where are you going to put
this Grammy next to the other
one I thought you'd build like some kind
of special place for this uh it'll it'll
come back to Australia with me okay tell
me your speech cuz we didn't get to hear
the speech so tell me there was it was
in the pre show and I was getting ready
so I got the news in my uh robe my
dressing gown kind of ready I screamed I
cried I was shaking and I had to stop
before you went to the ugly cry just
like trying we've just she's ready don't
undo it all with with tears but I was so
were you watching were you watching the
stream or were you getting a you got a
call he I my manager came to the came to
the door and came in saying two time
Grammy that all she got out I I I
screamed it it's all it's on my it's on
my Instagram yeah yeah you just lost it
I lost it it was a great moment and then
I had to get back to focus cuz you look
great right now so clearly you pulled it
back together and got everything I I
brought it back from the brink yeah okay
well Kylie Mano two-time Grammy winner
have an amazing night great to see you
thank you tell us about this dress yes
um well I thought I'd come put d red and
it's do kabana my good friends and if ID
factored in the rain I might have done
without the the train situation but just
get a little wet that's that's all right
badam badam to you
okay thank you all for joining us here
on ET for all of your coverage from the
2024 Grammy Awards and never forget you
can always catch us on etonline.com take
care
come on come
[Music]
on
the glitz the Glam and the outrageous
listen the Grammy Awards red carpet it
never disappoints there always something
that will surprise you yes indeed and
here are a few of our favorite moments
from the night did the rain wreck your
look because we know let's be honest
that rain will wreck a hair dude
absolutely not you know the best things
happen when I'm Singing in the Rain so
maybe it's a good luck charm okay five
nominations I mean I hear you were
asleep on the plane when the nominations
came through and you had no idea I was
fully asleep and I thought that by the
time I landed that's when I would find
out cuz that's when it would be
announced I completely got the time
change wrong I woke up to my phone
blowing up with text messages and that's
when I knew but I was the last to know
what did that feel that moment feel like
when you started looking at the phone
and seeing the nomination after
nomination after nomination what really
took me out was the five everyone kept
mentioning five five five I was like
what does that mean and when I finally
landed and I got to call people back
that's when I just lost it that's got to
be a great moment though it's got to be
a great it's so beautiful um it's just
refreshing to see you reap the benefits
of all the time you know your hard work
you you worked hard this isn't a you
know overnight success story you worked
your butt off so that's got to be that's
got it feels great to have not given up
but also it feels better to promote a
timeline that took a while you know I'm
not I'm not afraid of that I'm not
ashamed of that and I want to continue
to give younger black women this
reminder that if it takes a lot of time
that doesn't reflect on your value it
doesn't reflect on your worth it doesn't
reflect on the possibility of you still
getting where you need to go just let
time be time and you do you and you do
you okay tell me about this dress cuz
it's a dress this is a dress right here
um I'm really really happy that I got to
wear something that reflects me I'm
sparkly on the inside and um I just want
to shine tonight and I want to be in the
moment and just feel everything around
me Coco you always shine whenever you
shine thank you so much all right I'm
going to ask you a couple I'm going to
ask I'm going to name a couple of song
titles you tell me whether there is a
Taylor Swift song or a candle scent okay
or candle scent okay okay sure ready
with this first one how about this one
endless weekend that's a candle scent
damn it you're good okay hold on let's I
got another one for you how about this
one
Afterglow that's a Taylor Swift song
okay hold on okay you're on fire right
now how about Wildest Dreams Taylor
Swifts okay how about thousand wishes
candle scent you cannot fool Coco all
right let's do a song together babe
hello to you hello to you I am a little
nervous if I am if I'm being honest
because there is a legend standing in
front of me right now
where
really can I see I I just had to be
honest okay listen I heard part of the
song the other day I didn't get the
whole thing they would give me the whole
thing but it it made me feel so good it
is Quint essential Billy Joel Piano Man
Brilliance why now since you haven't
released a song for us since
2007 basically CU it all came together
very recently and uh I've resisted it
for a long time and this time I just
said ah what the hell I who am I to
fight this yeah and you're going to give
us a you're going to get on that stage
tonight now are we are you just doing
the new song or is did we get a medley
what is it what do we what are we going
to get well I know I'm doing the new
song I don't know if I'm doing anything
else yet okay you can make up your mind
just make it up on
the what are they going to do throw me
off I do another one never ever so
you've been nominated 23 times you've
won six times what is Grammy KN like for
those nominees those young nominees who
you know maybe it's their first time
there do you remember the your first
nomination I was in Paris when I won my
first Grammy and we won two that night
and they kept waking me up in
Paris uh which was fun it was a nice
place to be and you're you just
announced that your residency at Madison
Square Garden is going to end in July in
July yeah is there a chance you could
extend is there a chance that we could
get more are you saying like I I'm I'm
good well I never said I'm never going
to play the garden again it was just in
this particular run of the
residency that's the end of that for now
we could do the garden again I could
play other venues in New York where I
haven't played for the last 10 years so
it opens up a whole new world um there's
so many artists who look to you that
you've been inspiration for them one of
them is Olivia Rodrigo she came by your
show last year and sang a couple D she
really is you know who is there anybody
in today's music that you look at and
you say I I really like what they're
doing like in Olivia it's a lot of
people I like what um Olivia is doing I
like what Taylor Swift is doing I like
what Billy Alish is doing it's like a
woman wom's thing now women are really
coming to the front speaking of women
when she walks out in this dress and
looking like this what do you
say
yeah you say yeah you say turn turn
those lights off that's what you say not
back on turn those lights off that's I
love it you look amazing I can't even
imagine how many diamonds are in this
necklace it's all on loan from Mill's
collection in New York and I'm very
thankful to them okay tell us this does
Billy Joel listen to Billy Joel at home
no we do not our children do so we have
a lot of Taylor Swift Billy Joel Olivia
Rodrigo but they're his biggest fans so
yeah they want to hear it all the time
you know what I dig that so much because
you know so many times we think our kids
we embarrass our kids and that but your
kids thinking that you are the coolest
and like loving your music and playing
your music that's got of
maybe they're doing it cuz they dig it
but I think they're doing it to annoy
me they keep playing piano man it drives
me nuts I can never hear Piano Man Too
Much you said that you were bringing
your mom to the Grammys and you made
good on that promise you know what we
hired a woman to play my mom she
couldn't make it but she's here how cool
is it to come with your child just the
Grammy W of all places it is
unbelievable right and I made him
promise me when he was 12 so I 15 years
later I'm like it's my time so were you
there last night for the performance at
Clive Davis yes and he was fantastic I
was so nervous for you oh my God it was
great how was that watching him perform
and knowing that the crowd was vibing
loved it I was thrilled and just I was
so proud and he you did such a great job
thanks Mama cly Davis party launches
stars that is the place for stars to be
launched so how important was it to be
last night and now to hear that people
loved you well it's always tough to go
look out into a crowd and see Forest
Gump looking back at you um it puts a
little bit of added pressure on uh but I
just had fun I knew my mom was there and
I knew that you know the people there
wanted to see something good and I tried
to do my best to make that happen for
them and I had so much fun and um I was
nervous but just being surrounded by
Legends and honored like that was a
dream come true and I got to meet Green
Day which was sick was there a moment
for you when you were on was there a
moment where you're just like oh my God
yeah the the very beginning I was like
close to pissing my pants like for real
like it was it was almost bad uh but
once I was halfway through I was like oh
my gosh I'm just performing again and it
felt like I was on stage at an open mic
in front of nobody else it was you did
your thing you did your thing I did my
best I hear Olivia Rodrigo wants to duet
with you have you talked to her about
that Olivia and I have spoken about that
uh we've kind of played some back in
forth in the Press but uh I think we
both just want to make sure the time is
right and that it's something that we
both can truly cherish and I would love
to work in the room with Olivia cuz she
such a talented writer so that was the
press release answer now tell me the
real answer what's going on behind the
scenes is it going to happen hell yeah
I'm hitting her up we're making it
happen I got you we're gonna make it
happen I'm sure she'll be here in a few
minutes so if you see Olivia if we see
her we'll set it up okay Mom what are
you looking forward to tonight and how
will it be what when you hear your
child's name called in there when they
announce the best new artist well Noah's
already won in my mind so whatever
happens tonight is is just going to be
extra special but I'm just so excited to
hear the music and see the people and
I'm thrilled to be here and by the way
there was a show where they had the moms
of rockars you know they were talking
about their lives what is one moment
when you knew that your child was
different and
special I think he's always been playing
music his entire life but I think it's
when I saw him perform and other people
were kind of freaking out and then I was
like wow he is really good you
know congratulations you've already won
you brought your mom that's the win that
is the
win last time I saw you we were golfing
we were golfing I'm not going to say who
golf better but we were golfing right
right right right right I will say this
who would have thought we'd have went
from Top Golf to the Grammy red carpet
okay you said that it's going to be an
emotional night for you it's going to be
an emotional will it it's emotional if I
lose you know just being here this is
unreal man being recognized by the
academy and uh being here to represent
Nashville and being here to represent
country music and my slice of America
that's often not spoken for it's a lot
of people that have never been
represented that are represented here
tonight we didn't come to win we came to
represent baby and you talked about that
that you came to represent your
community how many folks did you bring
with you and how many folks are at home
watching well I I would hope there's a
lot watching but most importantly I
brought my daughter my 16-year-old
daughter Bailey and my wife Bunny's
behind us um we're walking this red
carpet together which is just makes a a
dream even better this is uh special
Louis Vuitton right from forel custom
Louis Vuitton from forel baby I couldn't
believe it P P dressed me himself man
this the first time I've ever wore
designer come on come on it's cool man
you talked about your mom when you got
these nominations will she be watching
tonight she's watching dude she wanted
to come but we just couldn't I I was
worried her having a wheelchair getting
her in and out and the carpet and stuff
but um she's watching from home man and
and and I mean she's she's FaceTime me
10 times today already really she's
fired up come on come on face let's
FaceTime come on can we FaceTime your
mom face FaceTime your mom let's
FaceTime your mom right now she'll
answer she'll answer she'll love it too
okay she's on she's going on we're going
to put her on ET right
now oh no there we go hey Mama I'm on
the red carpet with ET how you doing
Mom are we are good we wish you were
here tonight
I do too I wish I could have been there
too everybody's asking about
you she say she's a nasville holding it
down I love you I'll FaceTime you later
Mama
bye come on that is pretty cool she's
been waiting on that FaceTime all day
I've been FaceTiming her all day she's
excited yeah she's excited okay she's
excited about the Grammys I also I mean
I'm hearing that you're in a Super Bowl
commercial with some folks oh man listen
the rumor is true now I can't tell you
the folks but I can tell you I am in a
Super Bowl commercial and shout out to
UB and let me just tell you something we
know who the folks are and there's some
there's some big big folks in that one
to be in that kind of company Bowl
commercial it's huge to be in that kind
of company now what what does that say
you know CU you think about those folks
that you're in there with and they're
saying you are on par you're a superstar
too right I think it's unreal just to
even some of the conversations I'm
having and some of the people that even
know I'm a human is unreal man this is
just
unbelievable and also you talk about how
far you've come and how you've changed
and how you're helping to change people
you were just talking about Fentanyl and
pushing that and trying to give people
help that you continue to help folks why
is that so important I mean God has
blessed me so much I just want to be a
blessing you know I think that's the
that's the pay forward mentality man I
came from a place where there wasn't a
lot of blessings so to be blessed now I
want to bless as many people as I can
all right I got to let you go but
where's the JY jelly roll party tonight
if you win oh dude listen if I win if
I'm going to all the parties if I lose
but if I win win I'm having one party at
the Rainbow Bar and Grill come see me
I'm serious I'll be there at the rainbow
with jelly roll
rolling
[Music]
face
come on come
on
[Music]
a
e
[Music]
who is June Carter Cash she's about us
I've never known a life different than
Show Business Johnny Cash was not Johnny
Cash without June Carter she was an
incredible artist in her own
[Music]
right you look stunning you look stun
man listen you didn't come to play with
us tonight on this red car Best New
Artist nominee what a weird sentence I
mean how is the morning been how are you
feeling are you good are you settled I
feel mellow I feel just so overwhelmed
to be in this room but I I did not
expect to be included this year at all
and so to be in this room screaming for
my friends who are up for awards um
screaming for my heroes that are
performing that have been gracing us
with their presents forever I just am so
I'm so I feel so blessed to be here we
were just talking about the best new
artist category and I don't know if I've
ever seen it so stacked I can't call it
you all like and but that I guess that's
the great thing about music and what
you've all been doing like anybody you
can't be like oh man I can't believe
that everybody is just phenomenal and
they're somehow like even better people
than they are artists I really mean it
like I I haven't gotten to meet all of
them but over the past week I think
that's what's been the most spectacular
part for me selfishly about this week is
is getting to cross paths with the other
artists in this category and getting to
you know learn about them as human
beings and they are so mind and it feels
like no like true support of one who did
you get to meet this I've well Noah con
is a friend who I really love and um war
in
treaty I I'm obsessed with them and they
are they were so warm and so generous
and so kind and coko Jones who I I
literally fell I fell in love with her
watching her like w mag ASMR last week
fell in love with her and met her
yesterday and um got to tell her that to
her face I'd love to hear that I just
just really I'm just I'm just everyone's
biggest fan the grammies for me are also
about the collaborations that we see on
stage which I think are cool so is there
anybody you're looking forward to seeing
that you've heard that's performed I
mean Joanie Mitchell is my like North
Star artist um I have
been uh I I I don't there's not been a
day that I haven't listened to her music
since I learned about her as a small
child so I I'm just really nervous I'm
that's what I keep like getting a hot
flash about be a moment the first time
in 24 years she's been battling her way
back and she's gracing that stage
tonight I I can't
imagine what that's going to be we're
just so lucky we're just so lucky so I
know your girl Taylor will be here
tonight you'll get to reunite with her
and hang out with her now you know
swifties are going crazy right now
because her website has been shut down
and they believe that reputation TV is
going to be announced
wow wow she says
I love her fan basee dearly they are the
greatest and I was lucky enough to get
to know them up close and personally
this summer um they have the greatest
imaginations of any group of people I've
ever known can we have a little fun play
a little game before I leave you I would
love game okay so because everybody
loves all things Taylor and we think
there could be an announcement we're
going to play a little game it's called
a popular Taylor Swift song or a popular
candle scent so I will say one to you
and you will tell me if it's a Taylor
song or candles I think you might be
good at this I better
be okay Wildest Dream oh that's a Taylor
song it is last kiss that's a Taylor
song that is a Taylor song endless
weekend that is not a Taylor song that
is a scent right forever winter that is
also not a Taylor song that is a Taylor
song no stop
it what yes thousand wishes I'm never
allowed back on the ARs tour we'll edit
that one thousand wishes that that isn't
a tailor song no it's a scent great in
the Stars that's also a scent it's a
scent yes Chasing Fireflies that has to
be a scent it's a scent also also are
these real scents yes like can real C
I'm going to like seek that out tomorrow
morning and Afterglow oh that's Taylor
all day she's perfect everybody no she's
Taylor is not
me I'm saying congratulations all right
we celebrating yes we are celebrating
yes indeed how does that feel now like
it's is it an exhale moment yes yes I
think I'm still processing the fact that
I've won a Grammy it's it's very very
bizarre but so cool how how did you find
out were you at the ceremony already
okay so you were there yeah I was at the
pre- ceremony I performed uh my song and
then right after that it was announced
so it was a maybe the most stressful six
minutes of my life but um but now the
most exciting six minutes of my life
what was that moment like when they open
the envelope and right before you here
what does that mean I think I blacked
out I don't really remember it I was
just still running on such a high from
the performance um but it was so cool so
wild and this is well this is Chanel
tonight now was this done for you no
this is um it is not dumb for me but it
is still very pretty you so you are
performing with Billy Joel tonight okay
he was just here and I was saying to him
like he hasn't had a done music for us
since 2007 new music for us so why was
now the time and now I think are you
processing how much of an iconic moment
this is to be on stage it's again just a
string of iconic moments today but yeah
to get to play with Billy and I'm
playing cello so I kind of get to you
know take put the singing to to the side
and just do kind of what I practice
growing up is so special I was telling
him hearing the new song it is so
quintessential Piano Man Billy Joel
comfort music for me it's so it's so
incredible to to get to play with him
and he is just such a good musician like
I think one forgets like how much craft
these musicians put into their work and
practice and just seeing him play and
even just like jamming in between and
rehearsal just jamming in between and
rehearsals is just very inspiring this
is his first Grammy performance in 30
years so how did it come about that you
number one were able to do this
performance with him and I
mean well um my friend Freddy Wexler uh
co-wrote a song on my album that I just
won the Grammy and um he wrote the and
produced the a song with Billy Joel so
he he was like do you want to play
You're a chalis right do you want to
play and I was like that's what I went
to school for so let's put it to work
sis I cannot wait to see this I love
this for you this is a huge night for
you you're a winner already and now
you're about to step on the stage with
an icon and do a performance it's a I
mean you don't have to do anything else
I I already feel like I've won life at
this point I love it so wonderful to
meet you you look beautiful you as you I
love it enjoy every minute of this night
really enjoy
[Music]
this I haven't had a chance to
congratulate you first of all since the
Em's I've not seen you come on in here
come on it's a it was a family win
it you should have congratulated you
because no but let me tell you why you
should have congratulated you and people
didn't mention this that people told you
you couldn't do serious stuff the people
told you that you were just a funny lady
you should be off to the side do your
funny thing and stop yeah and you said
damn it I'm going to show you I got to
show you I got to show you something and
you showed the whole world and it's been
thing after now one but it's been thing
after thing after thing after thing so I
just do not make me cry my fake
eyelashes off I'm at the Grammys but I
was just so happy for that moment
because you manifested that you said I'm
going go and show youall you know I have
a wonderful support system and uh and we
were able to bring home that award and
I've been I'm still floating you should
be Float by the way where is the award
at home in in the front actually in the
door soon as you soon as you walk in it
sings to you it's like w right there
with my big bouquet that I got from
Oprah yes yes this really isn't your
night it's your night cuz you're the
musician in the family so what is it
that makes the Grammy so special oh
being able to be among so many amazing
musicians and artists and uh people that
I've looked up to for over the years so
I'm excited to be here Kevin I I love
that I got invited on a date normally
I'm like hey come with me to this thing
and now she's like you want to go to the
gramy I'm like
okay I'm going to take you yeah you're
my day um I also want to talk about
origin because it has been doing well in
the theaters it expanded to a to more um
audiences now why is it so important for
people to see this movie wow for such a
time as this it it it it opens your mind
it invites you to think differently and
to unlearn some things so it it's
definitely a must SE it's a my seat it
really is a movie that will change it's
not like we go to movies to escape and
have fun but this one it changes your
life forever absolutely very powerful
message I think it's a masterpiece so I
enjoyed
it thank you all for joining us here on
ET for all of your coverage from the
2024 Grammy Awards and never forget you
can always catch us on etonline.com take
[Music]
care
you're going to
survive your name is Jessica right Jesse
Jesse I'm cter by the way hi let's get
you home
come I don't know how to repay you just
a reward money is fine I believe it was
Grand I'm a professional this is how I
make my living you collect rewards right
sounds cool it is cool actually very
cool all right team time this up the
essence I need addresses just got to
know where to look that's the
trick Mr sh you've got quite a
collection of
scars cter and ple the F you know what
the problem with you is cter Shaw you're
so damn
interesting thank
you you strong swimmer so so so so so
so's
okay tracker part of CBS Premier week
after Super Bowl 58 on CBS and streaming
on Paramount
[Music]
plus thanks for joining us tonight on ET
and we are bringing you the very best
from the Grammy red carpet right yes
indeed we are we had some fantastic
moments with music's biggest stars so
check it out
I do not want to cry you have worked so
hard and given so much of yourself to
this industry for so long while quietly
being in your absolute own League oh my
God we've talked about this happening
since the day we met and over many tour
bus sleepovers we did it is the greatest
joy to see the goodness you have poured
into others into your collaborators I am
so incredibly lucky to be one of them
over the years pouring right back into
you happy does not begin to cover it
this is your mother jumping moment
mother jump oh my God I love you Ari if
you're hearing this I love you so much
thank you for being a Believer and
supporting me from the very beginning um
you knew things that other people didn't
know and saw things of me that other
people didn't see and you've just been
so bright or die so this is my love
letter to you thank you so much I'm
going to tell you in person obviously
but I love
you Mama are matching tonight thank you
so much this is her nap time but she'll
appreciate it later okay well we're
about to celebrate cuz you've won two
already you have won two babies already
I found out in the car on the way here
and I'm shook I'm like wow what a great
start to the night my song just went
number one on rhythmic radio today I'm
like what a day I mean you are the
hardest working quote unquote overnight
success because I know you've been in
the game grindy it's been long that's a
long night right there and like right
next to you here Verdine right so
Verdine I'm interrupting because
Victoria's right they did the song
together you look
amazing how you doing Victorious my
grand oh my God nice to meet
you you look amazing she was the first
one that turned me on to you guys did a
moment I have loved you since '90s
babies oh my god oh that's thank you
yeah you know congratulations best
album I'm out thank you so much this is
good huh it worked out didn't it doing I
I know I know this is good huh yeah I
know excited
oh she over there she just went that way
terrible she's like na time I'm ready to
get out of
here she
is all right so little mama just went
this way and that way I know you said
she she knows the word Grammy she been
working on her poses how does she do it
was nap time so it's very like you have
to get her at a specific point in her
day like right after sugar not nap time
so this was like right in that window
where she's like uhuh she's too I get
I'd be like I'm like that and I'm 48
yeah yeah same it's it's interesting to
me because in this day and time I mean I
know you couldn't have even predicted
the success number one of the album and
then on my mama but then the viral
sensation of it as well I mean I can't
turn my head anywhere without hearing it
yeah you know what I always did want to
be one of those people who had a song
that eventually annoys people cuz it's
played so much and I think I don't know
maybe we're like maybe a month out out
from that place you're like turn all my
mama off you know what I mean but I'm so
happy my radio team has been killing it
my manager and I really attribute a lot
of the success to the dance um the viral
dances so Sean Bankhead um Aza the
dancers that were in the music video
really brought it to life and everyone
who decided to recreate it and like do
it with their families that's what makes
it a collaborative effort with the fans
um to make it feel very very big so I
appreciate see R&B singers and
especially women anymore sing and Dance
I mean it hearkens me to the Janet
Jackson and those like when I watch You
artist yes seriously thank you is that
what did you come into this thinking
like I want to I want to be r& like I
want to hearken back to those R&B people
that I Lov and that we loved that did it
all I really think it's just what I grew
up on I feel like even Whitney Houston
the vocalist that she was had some
performances where she was dancing she
was hitting some move so I feel didn't
have a real one two step but she tried
she did she did she had some energy on
that stage on a certain stage pres and
so I value artists who really um just
put that effort in I I'm just a huge fan
of dance um it's part of what
performances I adore the most um so
Michael Janet Beyonce uh Chris Brown
Usher like performers who just kind of
incorporate movement into it and I know
how much breath work it takes and
stamina and how much work goes into it
so I just always really appreciate it
didn't you get a little gift from Miss
Beyonce she did s me flowers I looked at
that card and I was like no no no no no
no and love white flowers and they were
all white flowers I know she sent it to
a few people who attended her
Renaissance film um Premiere but it's
still the most valuable thing in my home
so just you know I save the bowl the
flowers didn't make it but I save the
bowl it's now my fruit bowl my beyon
fruit bowl I love it I'm trying to re
the fruits right now I know that you've
got like 50 million things to do and
you're being pulled in 8 million
directions what what is it that keeps
you grounded what is it that keeps you
like good so you don't you know fall off
off that Cliff or get too much or have
too much you know what I just really
love to do this I think that um it's not
it's just what I do I guess maybe if it
was more of like a um I don't know
something that I felt braggadocious
about like having it's not really like
something that I have it's something
that I am so I just around existing and
loving music and just wanting to do more
you know okay when you are deciding your
dressed tonight and hey was it always
we're going to match I know that I did
know that from the beginning oh look at
the tears she's so she wants her mama
you want Mama come John she can come to
her you come to Mama come to
Mama Hi Pretty hi pretty all right
anyone with a 2-year-old understand
abolutely but before I you go these
dresses you guys oh my God Versace
styled by Colin Carter he's right here
he's the man um I'm so appreciative
we're wearing Bulgari um jewelry and I'm
so thankful that they were willing to do
both of our dresses mommy daughter doess
pretty thank
[Music]
you first of all how is it being out I
mean did you escape tonight where's the
baab yes I did Escape because I'm always
on Auntie Duty so I can always Escape I
can be like s
yeah you know so I know he's in good
hands right now how is that though being
a cuz you two are so close you and your
sister are so close yes we're like this
thick as thieves and to be able to be
with her every step of the process she
is just such an incredible mom I am so
proud of her I'm so proud of her tonight
for her nomination for Angel so I am
just here as proud big sis how' y'all
keep this secret for so long how did
y'all do it just like we keep all of our
other
Secrets sisters do
best you had new music is there more
coming yes there is more coming
coachella's coming a lot of exciting
things so what do you got planned for
Coachella tell me about the performance
what do you cuz usually you have
performances yes going all out doing the
most of course and you know just dancing
and singing my heart out really yes all
right so your sister didn't come but you
came she's still going to be here she
she's on the way she's on the way she's
on the way yes all right we can't wait
to see your sister we cannot wait to
it's so great to you can't wait to see
Coachella anything you can anything else
you want to tell us the preview or
anything else like oh man I'm just here
as a prixus tonight Angel for the win
Angel for the win Auntie Chloe what we
doing what are we doing you see you see
auntie auntie I was like I was like what
we do Auntie do I no no this is the
grown Mermaid The Little Mermaid is your
sister this is a grown mermaid it's a
grown
mermaid the grown no but for real when
you saw this was you like what was it
about that you said okay I'm about to
step on some some necks my tummy is out
today and so I was like okay yeah let's
do it and it feels very effortless and
like I feel like a Bronze
Goddess yes who made this dress oh yes
so Timothy styled it and it's like I
love it because it just feels like
molten gold you know that's why I love
it and the hair tone to
match yes thank you thank you
guys
how you doing I'm doing real good I'm
just grateful to live this moment yeah
this is a big moment for you tonight yes
indeed so how have you been all day is
it are you nervous or there excitement
are you just chill we've been chilling
in the hotel we've been um getting ready
and real I mean I'm real I'm saying
about the nomination you won I won you
yeah we're celebrating come on smile
smile bigger than that you are we are
smiling we are smiling so how does it
feel to be a Grammy winner it it feels
great it feels awesome it's a dream come
true now you can exhale and just have
fun tonight right yes yes we're
celebrating now with my beautiful
girlfriend right here and you look
amazing you didn't want to come up here
look she didn't want to come up here but
she look so good when she walked out
what were you like no she uh she looks
amazing you looks amazing oh thank you
so much thank you so this is um you had
your first tour in the US last year with
I I don't know what like 50s something
soldout show
yeah it was it was a great tour and this
tour is going to be bigger what is that
like when you walk out and you see the
house is just so full and they're there
for you I don't know I'm just real
thankful with people that hears and
supports my music every day and and I
know they're waiting for a for a for a
new album and for new music so wait what
are you going to do at Coachella what
can they expect from that performance
it's going to look great it's going to
look awesome you have to be there yeah
yes so I know people are waiting for new
music are you in the studio are you
writing are you are you recording
already I'm doing everything at the same
time I'm I'm just working and keep
grinding and I think it says here that
your third album Genesis was the most
streamed um first day musical Urbana
album on Spotify already like you had
the most streams yeah I think so yeah
I'm I'm just I'm just happy to be here
you know well I mean there's so much
happening for you this year now time has
Time Magazine has named you
one of the 100 next big artists so do is
there a pressure to like live up to all
of these things that are happening no
pressure no pressure at all I'm just
living my life loving to make music yes
okay who's on the collaboration front
for you now who's the next person you
say okay I'm I want to do something the
person I'm standing next to so do you
get it do you make music together yes we
made music together sis come on and it's
a song coming out what is the song's
name oh you have to wait for that look
see there you go you have a good you're
going to have to wait for
that Taylor where's Travis tonight
where's Travis Taylor you look Inc can
we get
[Music]
away
T
[Applause]
CH
[Music]
head
GR
come
[Music]
right right
Taylor Taylor to your right tayor Taylor
to your right to your right tayor
[Music]
Tay
a
[Music]
welcome back to coverage of the Grammy
Awards red carpet you know we always
have great conversations with some of
the biggest stars yes and tonight was no
exception they had a lot to say finally
here yeah okay so you can exhale now how
does it feel we're celebrating tonight
yeah yeah it feel good you know what I'm
saying finally to make it here um and be
here for my own purpose you I mean
you've been nominated four times you win
tonight now can you just relax and enjoy
the show and what are you most looking
forward to seeing um I'm just here to
experience it what I'm saying it feel
good to be here got my wife with me this
bad I mean when she walks out looking
like this what do what are what are we
saying cuz good God never let go of
him I love that so much is there anybody
that you know that's performing tonight
that you're that you like are excited to
see oh I'm honestly uh excited about the
whole show you know what I'm saying like
I say it feel good to be here yeah you
you were just in Kanye and ta DOA signs
video right so I mean when you're making
music with them like I what's the what's
the process process like um just to sum
it all up Evil Genius cuz it's the lead
single to his upcoming album so you've
seen it and I mean he's been teasing
what we're going to get and he is I
think those are great words for him Evil
Genius Evil Genius Evil Genius shout
outly he recently posted on IG I think
tell Dirk to activate tell Dirk to
activate his IG it's time to dve I'm a
couple days late but since we got the
good news I had to yeah yeah yeah so
what what did you did you post already
I'm post I got to post I got to post
these outfits tonight uh the wars
tonight so I'm feeling good tonight I
was going to say what does the night
bring cuz y'all look too good to just go
home um it's a change of plan we got to
go back to the drwing board since we won
right it was going to be low ke but now
you like no I got to celebrate my
baby yes I love that so much so good to
see you congratulations what's the next
I mean you know youve got yay and Ty do
but who's the next collab or who's the
next person on your list somebody that
we wouldn't think that you would want to
work with that you really want to work
with um I want to say who y'all think
think I wouldn't but I'll say Morgan W
really that is somebody I didn't think
you would say yeah it's going to be a
collab album soon okay so you guys are
going to work together that's
interesting vibs so so so that mean I'll
see you again next year you see what I'm
saying Come on talk your stuff I love it
so much you guys have a great night
tonight who okay who did this look by
the way
L LA shout out La Roach Oh La Roach did
it love it love it well you look
spectacular good luck have a great night
tonight guys okay good to see y'all
okay hold on you just won yes I just won
what the heck like it's crazy it's crazy
okay what does this mean though to win
this award for a song that everyone
loves I mean this one over here right
always right look look I
told what I tell are you H it's amazing
it's I'm so proud of myself so proud of
South Africa Africa it's a win for us
all so I'm just super blessed have any
has anybody called you yet from Africa
that is watching from South Africa
everybody blowing you up my phone it's
it's crazy my phone is blowing up really
yeah it's blowing up everybody calling
everyone celebrating it's a huge moment
it's amazing did you just see JT Jam in
the water did you see that that just
Timberlake was yeah I never see that yes
yes he
was everybody loves this song justtin
somebody like I'm sing JT yes I did see
that that's crazy that's crazy you saw
it yeah I saw it it's amazing I I I
can't believe it I'm a loss for words
Janet Jackson was vibing to it Oprah
like it's gone it's gone okay when you
made this song what did you think when
you made the song when I made it I knew
it was special I knew like like I loved
it my family loved it I had a dream
about the song so I feel like I knew in
my spirit that this was the one how are
you celebrating tonight hey I'm going
out we have to we have you have to and
then you have to go home and celebrate
in South Africa too everywhere I'm going
I'm celebrating now yeah show One More
Time come on come on me make
me yes
she got it she needs to teach me how to
do the dance cuz I want okay hold on
okay will you teach her cuz she does she
does it all the time so
it's wait this way or this way there you
go I'll give you private lesson she's
like keep trying six I'm G give you the
private lesson
congratulations
congratulations will you tell us about
the dress real quick yes so I'm wearing
custom
faace cute um I love it I loved working
with them on the design and yeah just
came out perfect I couldn't have asked
for a better outfit for my first
Grammys yeah congratulations it's it's
the hit of the year I mean everybody
loves that
song
come on you want them take over take the
M don't say anything crazy hello we're
at the Grammys Janelle Monae and I
wonderful wonderful night you know what
I love this there is nothing better than
a family night at the gramys and what
does it mean to have your mom here to
enjoy this well one I could not imagine
winning a Grammy and my mom not be there
like it was so important as you can see
she's a ball of energy she's my she's my
foundation so I was like if I win a
Grammy I want my mama here so it's a
beautiful thing to have her with me yes
it is album of the it's an honor right
yes Prince will be so
happy album of the year though what is
that Progressive yes but when you put
that album together it you said you
going to do something different and
you're going to do it your way and you
did that's what I'm saying she's
creeping up on that isn't she yeah
listen I I I try my best in my art to
represent um my community in a in a deep
way and making music and art for us and
most of the time it was rooted in
Seeking Justice for us yes this time
around I wanted joy for us Justice and
joy it can coexist and that's what the
age of pleasure was about uh making sure
that we felt safe enough to feel free
enough to be ourselves even more and
unapologetically and so I'm just so
happy that me being here represents a
community of marginalized folks who are
smiling who are happy who are working
through the pain you know uh of of of of
the the the Pains of life and and
finding Solace and finding love in one
another I think that you are one of the
voices out there especially among black
women who are telling things
authentically their way and it's been
important because you freed up a whole
Community has come out I I might be in
love with your mama I be honest with you
I love I love
your real star I need my own talk show
guys I am so
funny we G to get you your own talk show
so much it is good the uh my other uh
producers who worked on the project I
want to go take some photos with them CU
some it's their first time here I've
been here a couple times so I'm going
run over there really fast tell me about
that dress real quick thank you it's
Herman PR Couture uh it's custom and I'm
just so I feel so good I feel so
Timeless I feel futuristic I feel like
me Mama did you just touch my
Bo your mom is the great you might stay
here I might keep your mom right here I
might keep your mom I might keep your
mom right
here did you see that they were singing
your song on SNL last
night I saw the clip and I I was
watching and I was like where does the
song come in and then all of a sudden
she burst into song a capella and I was
like this is awesome there's been a
couple times that they've shouted me out
this year so thanks guys isn't that kind
of special though that people are
recognizing your music your career on
such a large platform yes well and I
mean all these years later as well like
I'm just so grateful that my music has
spanned kind of the test of time it's a
classic and that's what I'm going to
continue to do okay so you were
nominated tonight you guys didn't win
but it was still great to be here and be
nominated yes I mean to get nominated
once is an honor and then all this time
later for my peers to think that
something of mine is worthy to be
nominated again is is incredible so I'm
grateful and how was it working with
King and Country how was that easy it
was so easy they are the most kindest
men that I've ever met their wives as
well their whole team they've just been
so great so they were texting me earlier
today like oh we can't wait to see you
so hopefully they'll pop up here in a
second I don't know where they are but
they were amazing to work with okay so
since I've known you since you've been a
young woman when you made your last
video with your husband a very grown in
sexy video yes what was that what was
the conversation like at home to when
you decided to make that video it was
actually my idea was it yeah I was like
it's time for you to show that sexy side
that I see to the world and so I feel
like we did that and it worked it worked
it worked it worked the internet will
tell you just go to YouTube and you'll
see it worked um what does it mean to
have someone that is there to support
you and Champion you each and every day
I mean it's please don't get me
emotional I already had to like get
everything together earlier but um I've
never had someone who supports me the
way that Dana supports me he honestly
wants to see me do the best that I can
do he puts me on his shoulders every day
he's like babe what about this what
about this what about this you should do
this he encourages me when I'm like I
don't know he pushes me outside of my
comfort zone like he's a great dad he's
a great an anr he's a great manager he's
all the things a great husband yeah this
one yeah and I always love the way he
shows the sexy side between the two of
you that you you know you got children
but that ain't stopping the loving right
how you think the kids got here like
come
on I mean he's right he's not wrong all
right fun to be here tonight tell me
about this dress this is dig mom and I
found it last minute at this amazing
showroom called The Show Must Go On and
yeah I put it on and just felt beautiful
and I felt that it represented where I
am now like I'm still a flower but don't
mess with me don't mess with you okay um
next videos what what is going to come
with the next videos go go ahead babe
not me I I'm taking a break I'm taking a
break y'all can have her I'm going to
take a break and we'll get another love
interest or something else it's stress
about being in front of the camera can't
you see yeah that's a that's a liot he
he should be though you see this face he
should
be
[Music]
one we made it
happen
[Music]
come on come
on
[Music]
he
you look amazing my guy the long all of
it is working for me you did you did are
you growing it for a project or did you
just decide like let me just I don't
know well to be honest like I was when I
knew that I I was going to have a baby
yeah I always wanted to have like that
picture of me with long hair I don't
know just you know like holding my baby
and it's like so organic so grounded I
don't know I just I just let my hair
grow because I feel I feel grounded
right now in my life I just like it like
that I love the how suzan how's she
doing she good she's gray my baby's is
growing pretty fast in her in her mom's
belly everything is doing great thank
you are you are you I know you said
everything's great in light but are you
ready for this are you ready for
fatherhood well to be honest I I don't I
don't think you're always ready you know
I I would say like kids they don't come
with any manual so I just go with the
flow I really I really love her and I
and I love what I'm living right now I
can't imagine what's going to happen you
know but you're also having a girl and
and you know what they say that does to
a man like you're done sir you're done
yeah to be honest that was a big Karma
you know you know I was like kind of
refused when I when I knew that I was
going to become a dad I kind of I was
feeling that that thing that I I didn't
want to have a girl you know because I
knew that that was going to be a Karma
but I'm just kidding I I love what's
going on right now she's going to have
you wrapped up so tight that little girl
is going to have you that's what my dad
tell me to because I have a sister and
all the sisters so she's always like my
dad's always like wait for wait for
Paris to be born man you're going to
know what's real love I love that you
guys already have decided what her name
is going to be did you was that just
always in the in the in the world yeah
the thing is that that's more like
cultural you know what I mean like
they're in Colombia we think about names
before we we know that we're going to
have babies you know so I don't know and
also a crazy fact is that we actually
had that moment in Paris so Paris was
yeah that's what is Paris yeah I love
that so much okay I know you got to go
but it just um you just recently made
history you were as the first urban uh
Urbana I can't talk Urbana artist to be
number one on both the Latin AirPlay and
also the regional Mexican charts come on
like is there nothing that you touch
that doesn't turn to Gold well yo thank
you well thank you very much I really
appreciate that the only thing I'm going
to say is that I'm vames not winning the
the Grammy you know what I mean because
I was nominated I'm nominated today as
best L album pop and and it's I just
wanted to Happ in my arms so let's see
if next year we're going to have the
chance to be nominated again and maybe
taken at home and then you can come with
Paris and your whole family and it'll be
all family going be nice too you know
I'm not in a rush I'm just enjoying my
life enjoying the moment that I'm living
well have an amazing time tonight it's
always good to see you my man and
congratulations on everything
okay
hi Mommy hi so I'm so happy for you and
you you know what I love about it how is
like you just like you radiate this
goodness and you just seem like you are
on top of the world right now is that is
that the case that is truly the case I'm
so excited to be here tonight I'm like
I'm with my boo I'm like having the
greatest time boo you boo he was just
holding hand yeah yeah yeah I love but
yeah so it's date night y'all like you
got to take these when you can get them
because now that you're new parents
you're not going to get all those date
nights anymore so what do date night
bring for you guys oh my gosh we're so
excited to see the performances to chill
and to just be nominated is an honor so
I just can't believe I'm in this room
tonight yeah well you here baby you're
not going anywhere who are you um
excited to see on the stage cuz there's
going to be a lot of iconic moment oh
wow I'm so excited to see everyone
honestly I mean I heard sciss it's
performing so I can't wait to see that
the list could go on your color purple
sister frantasia is doing a tribute to
Tina Turner tonight be amazing how is
this run been for you I know there was I
was disappointed that there was not a
best picture nomination that there was
not a best picture nomination for you
guys for The Color Purple I think you
very deserve it's one of the best movies
of the year but so how has this ride
been for you and now is it like okay I
really I kind of have the acting bug so
I'm going to do this for a minute yeah
I'm going to keep going I mean acting
has been so much fun for me beautiful
new outlet and I'm excited to take on
more projects so now you're about to
break the internet with this dress cuz
the people are going to say how she just
have a b look at this how you just s
back how did you just have a baby I mean
why when you saw this dress what was it
about it that made you say this is it
for this night oh I really love this
dress Gucci made it for me and I feel
confident I'm really excited I think I
was excited to kind of step back and
wear start wearing form fitting stuff
after pregnancy so it's it's been really
fun do you do you feel different being a
mama like is there is there an added
confidence is there just what what
changed for you yeah I definitely feel
more powerful and like more womanly you
know yeah I love that love well you guys
are the cutest little family have a good
night listen you and your sister shut
down everybody here tonight cuz she
walked in here like I'm having my
amazing didn't she though and she was Al
so excited for us to call her auntie oh
yeah thank you I love it have a good
night tonight good to see you
[Music]
baby hello love how are you oh honey
these earrings great to see baby hold on
a second M I'm just kidding they're
ridiculous okay I just feel like you and
David geta need to just do just do an
album I know I told him I said David
come on bro let's do an out no but you
know what we're working on it seriously
you guys have the the sauce together so
we do we do but we we know it's it's a
it's a LoveHate relationship more in
love but he called me his annoying
little sister and I was like excuse me
if I'm your annoying little sister then
you're my annoying older brother right
there you go you want the old Monica man
yeah exactly I think maybe sometimes
that's the best way to make music you
know what I'm saying when it's like uh
you know you get on my nerves you're get
on my nerves but then here comes the the
magic that's the best that's the best
music yeah yeah I love it so much so
tonight um what I love about the Grammy
are those collaborations or what we see
happening on the stage anybody that
you're like okay this is I'm excited
honestly I'm excited to see Dua I got to
support her my Albanian Queen um I'm I'm
excited to see Lana I just saw her pass
by and I just think her music's so
amazing and I think it's finally Lana's
time to shine um so I'm really excited
for her honestly the girls listen you
okay you took the words right out of my
mouth I was talking Billy Joel oh my
gosh how was that well first of all I
God I just cracked I had to say to him I
said um I have to admit that I'm nervous
right now because you're it's you but
he's performing for the first time in 30
years on the Grammy stage tonight and I
said to him like who do you love right
now and what he said is Olivia Rodrigo
Billy ish Taylor Swift like like doal
and that's what he said he said
something about what the women are doing
right now is special is another level
why do you think that CU I believe it
too I just feel like we're in an are you
what's the girls doing let me think let
me think about this answer I just feel
like the girls are just doing what they
want yeah you know what I mean the more
empowered that we get the more power
that we get like like we're just kind of
standing in our own and it's time like
you know I have such like I want to see
who oh it's Carol oh I gotta go say hi
but yeah but any
Caesar anyways sorry no but I this is
like on the I actually do have it like
on the red carpet is not good it's like
a family reunion here though it really
is you get to see the people you haven't
seen you get to hang out again not I
want you to enjoy every minute of this
night I love seeing you okay tell me a
little something what's the drama you're
giving us for this look honey all black
everything Robert W like black widow
Vibes I'm newly
single okay call me all right are we are
we taking suitors are we taking time uh
uh fun okay I like I like I like single
you I like single you cuz there's a sass
there's a confident you stand a little
tall leg up and this face is beat thank
you
number one album in the country you're
rolling here and you you're a superstar
tonight what does that mean to have the
number one album in the country uh it
just feel good like got my hard work
paying off and the nominations tonight
also to be recognized because we know
for a long time the Grammys will
Overlook artists right right we know
that but to do the work and then have it
recognized what does that mean to you it
feel good it's a good feeling yeah yeah
for sure okay great collaborations right
but if you win tonight where's the party
W I'm going probably party at my hotel I
don't really like party you lay low yeah
you laying low tonight yeah but it's
also got to be cool like Lenny krait's
right there rolling with seeing all the
stars and with everybody would you ever
collab with Lenny yeah for sure you're a
legend he's a right right that's what
I'm saying hold on watch wait wait we
going to tell him we're going to tell
him right now let's tell Lenny grait
that you need to do a collab hold on one
second we're going to tell him hold on
we're going to tell him right now cuz he
need if anybody needs to be on his next
record is you we appreciated it so so
much Nelle Nelle right thank you B Nelle
tell Lenny 21 Savage wants to be on your
next record he's
losing what's happening man let's do it
good yeah let's do it man let's do it
you too all right man yeah for see we're
we're working out things here this is
what the Grammys are about this is a
collab we're waiting for right 21 Savage
and lny KRA for sure that's a
collaboration that we need don't play we
need this right I'm for real all right
get it done can you do something for me
21 can you all right tell me about SNL
oh yeah I'm doing SNL on the 24th yeah
on the 24th but what do you what do you
got planned nobody goes to SNL and just
surprise who's going to be with you will
you have anybody with you what have some
people with me oh you're bringing some
folk yeah like who come on I can't tell
you but it'll be something special yeah
for
sure I haven't had a chance to
congratulate you first of all since the
Emmy I've not seen you come on in here
come on it's a it was a family win
it you should have congratulated you
because no but let me tell you why you
should have congratulated you and people
didn't mention
that people told you you couldn't do
serious stuff that people told you that
you were just a funny lady you should be
off to the side do your funny thing and
stop yeah and you said damn it I'm going
to show you I got to show you I got to
show you something and you showed the
whole world and it's been thing after
not one but it's been thing after thing
after thing after thing so I just do not
make me cry my fake eyelashes off I'm at
the grammy but I was just so happy for
that moment because you manifested that
you said I'm I'm going go and show
youall you know I had a wonderful
support system and uh and we were able
to bring home that award and I've been
I'm still floating you should be
floating by the way where is the award
at home in in the front actually in the
front door soon as you walk soon as you
walk in it sings to you it's like wo
right there with my big bouquet that I
got from Oprah yes yes this really isn't
your night it's your night cuz you're
the music position in the family so what
is it that makes the Grammy so special
oh being able to be among so many
amazing musicians and artists and uh
people that I've looked up to for over
the years so I'm excited to be here
Kevin I I love that I got invited on a
date normally I'm like hey come with me
to this thing and now she's like you
want to go to the gramy I'm like
okay I'm gonna take you yeah you're my
day um I also want to talk about origin
because it has been doing well in the
theaters it expanded to a to more um
audiences now why is it so important for
people to see this movie wow for such a
time as this it it it it opens your mind
it invites you to think differently and
to unlearn some things so it it's
definitely a must SE it's a must SE it
really is a movie that will change it's
not like we go to movies to escape and
have fun but this one it changes your
life forever absolutely very powerful
message I think it's a masterpiece so I
enjoyed
[Music]
it
okay so first of all mom Night Out how'd
you get away and are what are the babies
doing I was just with them they are at
home just playing together it's so sweet
so feel so blessed and so lucky how is
motherhood because I know you were ready
you waited you know and then what does
it mean to you to finally be a mother
especially because of the love that you
have for your mom my life just feels so
complete my husband my two beautiful
babies just feels like all my dreams
come true and I just feel so fulfilled
and just happy at life okay Paris the DJ
is here tonight though right you're
Paris the DJ what is it what are you
looking for tonight who are you excited
to see I'm just excited to see so many
of my favorite artists excited for
Miley's nominated times she is such an
icon and I'm just so excited for my
second album C is executive producing it
what can you okay so what can you tell
me about the album the album is mean a
lot of amazing badass femals on it and a
lot of surprises and it's all about my
journey and everything that I've went
through in my life and I'm just so
excited and honored to have CA executive
producing and writing all the music with
me
okay so do your kids love it when you
play music for them do you play music
for them what do you play for them my
kids love music Phoenix just got a
little piano for his first birthday so
he's been playing on the piano and he
loves stars are blind it's his favorite
love of eyes since he was born man Paris
this has been such a crazy journey I
mean I can think back to way back in the
day and all the trials and tribulations
and all that stuff and when you think of
that what would you if you could whisper
in your ear and tell yourself something
what would you say
say you're going to go through a lot in
life one day you're going to have the
most beautiful perfect life and family
so keep going
girl you kept going you kept going it's
good to see you anything else parents
that's coming up um just everything
about to release my 30th
fragrance and wait wait a minute your
30th 30th
yes I know what does this one smell like
it's just the most beautiful unique
scent I've ever ever smelled before it's
my favorite perfume ever won't you get
into the baby clothes business or
something doing children's stuff too yes
we have children's furniture and
children's clothing and doing a huge
deal with Walmart so everything will be
out very soon wow so when can we see
that stuff that will be out by this fall
with my new clothing line and jewelry
and
Handbags damn Paris you do ever you
never stop do you there is no slowing
you down is there there's nothing
slowing me down can you tell us a secret
about your fashion tonight tonight well
I'm wearing this gorgeous mermaid gown
and then I had this custom made for my
handbag line CU I'm representing Hilton
tonight CU they're a big part of the
awards and just wanted to represent
Hilton for the
stay you really went all the way in
Queen right you will Market one thing
you will do is Market something right I
invented
it that's real actually so some people
copied right some people copied you but
you it's nothing like the original how
has it been living life in the Paris
Hilton Fishbowl but you guys have a very
normal life you have kids now so
everything has to be normal it's just
amazing watching Paris be a mom we love
to just stay home play with the babies
watching her mother is pretty awesome
yeah and what is Paris Hilton the mom
like uh well let's see the other day I
came home Paris was on a motorized
scooter and Phoenix was following her
around and they were doing relay racing
so let's just say she's a fun and a
sliving mom sliving
mom I love it thanks have a great
day okay first of all all the
nominations how how good does it feel to
be that your peers love you it feels
incredible like I never expected four
nominations and I'm just just so happy
like I'm so excited yes okay um are you
excited for the Super Bowl commercial I
am I am shout out to Star sorry they
held it down period what was it like
shooting a Super Bowl commercial how big
is it going to be cuz that's the biggest
day of the year the commercials are
better than game half time yeah they are
um I don't know I'm just really excited
the commercial was fun it was my second
commercial ever and um yeah it was it
was a little bit of a challenge filming
but we got why because lemon lime wasn't
actually present so I was talking to
nobody really but also you kind of just
talking to the green screen we was just
you know getting our little acting out
more music coming right yes album
dropping this year y 2K tune in when
when when is it dropping
2024 that's all you can tell me come on
now yes that's all okay tell me about
collabs or anybody that's on there I
can't let that be known yet but my fans
will be very pleased 2023 was an insane
year so to cap it off now with the
Grammys in 2024 what would that mean to
you it just means everything I'm just so
happy to be acknowledged and you know
it's a big deal to
me
okay I don't know what was happening I
don't know what's going on there's a lot
going on there's a lot like your 2023
yeah exactly enjoy the night okay all
right and good
luck on did you know that this song was
going to blow up like it did like it was
going to take the World by storm no no I
mean one lives in Hope but uh no I had
no idea I was seeing P now I'm like Pam
red pam pam can you explain padam to me
please well within the within the song
it's the heartbeat you
know but PM took on a you know a myriad
of uh of
meanings and at the time when it came
out first came out it was a greeting it
was a farewell it was who knows what
whatever you
like and it is such like people lose it
in clubs when they play it have you had
a chance to be in like do you sometimes
sneak into the club and you hear it and
everybody's goes crazy well I had a few
moments when we were doing listening
parties and just the place erupted I was
kind of faux DJing like literally just
press play but I was quite comfortable
there yeah I do what does it also mean
to stay relevant with folks in
generation after generation after
generation which is very very cool well
obviously means a lot to me but I feel
like this current moment for myself is
beyond me that others might look at what
I've achieved and go hey that's you know
she's broken a fair number of rules in
her time and and you can it can be done
you can achieve anything you want
anytime yeah I mean of course you know
it's uh we we never stop working but
it's it's a great moment and I think
I've been doing this long enough to
really actively be cognizant that this
this is a great moment amongst the
madness I'm I'm is it that as we get
older we start to realize how precious
these moments are is that what it is
entirely yeah so to still be here to to
um to have won tonight do you know that
I won hold on you won I
won wait a minute oh you won well I
didn't know telling you this when I
first like yes I got two
now
wow where where are you going to put
this Grammy next to the other
one I thought you'd build like some kind
of special place for this uh it'll it'll
come back to Australia with me okay tell
me your speech cuz we didn't get to hear
the speech so tell me was it was in the
pre-show and I was getting ready so I
got the news in my uh robe my dressing
gown kind of ready I screamed I cried I
was shaking and I had to stop before you
went to the ugly cry just like trying
we've just she's ready don't undo it all
with with tears but I was so were you
watching were you watching the Stream
dream or were you getting a you got a
call I I my manager came to the came to
the door and came in saying two time
Grammy that's all she got out I I I
screamed it it's all it's on my it's on
my Instagram yeah yeah you just lost it
I lost it it was a great moment and then
I had to get back to focus cuz you look
great right now so clearly you pulled it
back together and got everything I I
brought it back from the brink yeah okay
well Kylie Mano two-time Grammy winner
have an amazing night great to see you
thank you tell us about this dress yes
um well I thought I'd come P red and
it's do abana my good friends and if ID
facted in the rain I might have done
without the the train situation but just
get a little wet that's that's all right
badam padam to you
okay thank you all for joining us here
on ET for all of your coverage from the
2024 Grammy Awards and never forget you
can always catch us on etonline.com take
[Music]
care
know when I get nervous I tell the
truth um um but outside of that outside
of that you know we got to keep showing
up and forget the Grammys for a second
just in
life as I as my daughter sits and stares
at me nervous as I am nervous but
looking beautiful and so grown up it's
pretty amazing on Sunday Blue Ivy Carter
made a surprise appearance at the 66
annual Grammy Awards the 12-year-old
daughter of Jay-Z and Beyonce snuck in
just before the in Memorial tribute and
was first spotted on camera during
Fantasia tribute to Tina Turner when it
was time for Jay-Z to hit the stage to
receive the Dr Dre Global impact award
he encouraged his first born to join him
as Beyonce looked on with pride thank
you thank you very
much
um I used to say it's a sippy cup for
blue but Blue's grown up now she doesn't
take sippy cup and she has her own
gramys yes blue the proud dad referring
to Blue Ivy's win for best music mus
video for her mom Beyonce's hit song
brown skin
[Music]
girl very inspiring looking composed
alongside her dad blue stunned in a
white off the-shoulder gown with
matching boots in clutch she rocked
individual braids a soft makeup look and
a red lip you know she's just blossoming
and and turning into her mother as for
Jay speed
he got some things off his chest calling
out the gramys because he thinks they
haven't always gotten it right we want y
to get it right he even referenced the
year he famously boycotted the ceremony
in 1998 out of respect to the late
rapper Dian X who was snubbed after
having two number one albums we love
y'all we want y'all to get it right at
least get it close to right things got
even more personal when Jay mentioned
his wife Beyonce I don't want to
embarrass this young lady but she has
more Grammys than every W and never one
album of the year so even by your own
metrics that doesn't
work think about that the most Grammys
never won an album of the year that
doesn't work and the truth bombs just
kept coming some of you going to go home
tonight and feel like you've been
robbed some of you may get
robbed some of you don't belong in the
category but Jay ended his speech with a
dose of inspiration ing fans to never
give up no when I get nervous I tell the
truth um but outside of that outside of
that you know we got to keep showing up
and forget the Grammys for a second just
in
life as I as my daughter sits and stares
at me nervous as I am
um um just in life you got to keep
showing up just keep showing up forget
the Grammys you got to keep showing up
until until they give you all those
accolades you feel you
[Music]
deserve I started to cry then
remember oh I
cany Miley Cyrus celebrating her first
Grammy win with a performance oh my God
I just got stuck in the rain and traffic
and thought I was going to miss this
moment the singer taking home the first
award of the night winning over Taylor
Swift DOA cat Billy ish and Olivia
Rodrigo for best pop solo performance
for her song flowers This MC is going to
stand by This MC for this because this
is just too iconic yeah Miley kicked off
her speech with a shout out to Mariah
Carey who presented her the trophy oh my
God I just got stuck in the rain and
traffic and thought I was going to miss
this moment and I could have Miss the
award that's fine but not Mariah
Carey I just saw you at the Hollywood
Bowl it was everything after accepting
the award Miley took the stage to
perform the now Grammy winning song we
were good
we kind
dream
be at one point the singer called out
the audience why are you acting like you
don't know this song but Taylor Swift
she didn't need
reminding for
hour see things you don't understand
that's Tay Tay jamming with Kelsey
ballerini I think Miley had so much fun
making that song and like she you know
she says it over and over like no
expectations of it just from her heart
putting it out and to see see its
success has been so incredible you know
Miley's mom Tish and sister Brandy
couldn't help but gush about her to ET
the two couldn't be prouder of where
she's at in her career it is so
incredible but as her mom it's watching
her grow into this woman she's become at
and once she just 30 remember that just
30 exactly 31 but it's so crazy to think
she's only 31 and everything that she's
achieved but as a person she's just the
most incredible human being I I'm so
proud of
[Music]
her Taylor Swift totally jamming out as
Olivia Rodrigo delivers a bloody good
performance at the 2024
[Music]
Grammys just to be here and perform up
on that stage is just uh s honor Olivia
dazzling the audience with her rendition
of vampire getting Taylor on her feet
and dancing as she sings along with the
20-year-old pop star I've made some real
big mistak
I just have a great time with these
things the track from lives sophomore
album guts earned three of her six
nominations for the big night including
best solo pop performance song of the
year and record of the Year
congratulations on six Grammy
nominations is that crazy I'm I still
can't believe it I'm I'm feel so lucky
as for her performance Liv took a
literal approach smearing blood on her
face as rivers of the stuff flowed
behind
[Music]
her I'm so ready I'm so excited I'm I'm
such a big fan of the gramy and earning
a standing ovation from Taylor in the
audience amazing loving it Olivia
returning the positivity cheering Taylor
on as she announced her new album
tortured poets
Department
yeah nothing to see here just two queens
supporting each other I'm just so
grateful to everyone who has supported
me this year and uh excited for what's
to
[Music]
come what is I made for
Billy ish getting emotional performing
her award-winning song What Was I made
for at the 2024 gramys I mean it's just
you know we're here we're doing Barbie
we're doing we're doing it the singer
accompanied by her brother Phineas the
siblings co-wrote the track for the
Barbie soundtrack I
don't how to
feel but I
want Billy and Phineas earning a
standing o from the crowd and again
after the two snagged their second Award
of the Night song of the year which took
Billy by surprise whoa literally like I
was looking at everybody's faces and I
leaned over and I was like not a chance
thank you to my brother who's my best
friend in the world and makes me the
person that I am today um thank you to
graa Gerwig for making the best movie of
the year I am so like excited for all
the nominees like happy to be here we
got one we're out it's all good we're
great if we hadn't it would have been
fine too we're chill it won't be long
till fans get more music from the
brother sister Duo they've got an album
in the works didn't you say it's about
85% done no it's it's like
99 it's right there yeah I know we've
been saying that for a long time but we
can't give too many details cuz then
people get excited then they get mad as
for what to expect well Billy and
Phineas teased as much as they could to
ET Musical
no it's like I was saying the other day
that it's like a I think it's a perfect
representation of like natural
progression of
like I don't know it's all over the
place it's a lot of
[Music]
feeling not the best
idea
girl
[Music]
siza taking over the Grammy stage as the
biggest nominee on music's biggest
night I think
scissor she really knows how to tie
words together I'll say that and Phoebe
Bridgers who's collabed with siza was
totally living for it
[Music]
I I mean I heard s's performing so I
can't wait to see that siza performed
two of her biggest hits with snooze
cutting to her breakup Anthem
literally sounding that was
tight so excited well she might not have
a license to Kill Bill but that didn't
stop siza from slaying it with nine
nominations and a performance to die for
tell me about working with s what was
that like was an amazing experience
she's like a force of nature you know
she came in ready to work and was having
so much fun she really broke the ice
well and you know just coming up with
this record uh was just an amazing
process because she really understood
how to tell this story over the musical
landscape that we created
[Music]
and
he
[Music]
who is June Carter Cash she's about us
I've never known a life different than
Show Business Johny cash was not Johnny
Cash without June Carter she was an
incredible artist in her own right
[Music]
dualipa debuting new music at the 2024
Grammys oh we got something special for
you guys tonight that's something
special kicking off the show with
training season the second single off
her upcoming third studio
[Music]
[Applause]
album really excited about this
performance it's
intense uh it's
strong and uh it's Dy oh the performance
was super Dancy du a bringing all the
electricity while performing Houdini let
go me all
the DU track dance the night off the
Barbie soundtrack also got a little nod
during her medley it's the song that
earned her two nominations on music's
biggest
[Music]
night for as long as I feel like I'm
having fun and making something that I'm
really proud of and I'm in the moment
then I'm I'm exactly where I'm supposed
to be yeah win or lose do is just happy
she got a special memory out of the song
I feel that way with you know when we
were making dan t night we were having
such a great time in the studio it felt
so good to be a part of such an
incredible project it felt so good to do
it with my friends that whole experience
as a whole was really special so um yeah
I'm I'm happy that that's like way out
into the world now and like had its own
life and it's it's been
great
[Applause]
[Music]
the Grammy's crowd on top of the world
after bry's surprise appearance hitting
music's biggest stage with burnaboy and
21 Savage on Sunday night I feel
honored it's
[Music]
youry the difference when you're my baby
how it
is the trio joining forces to sing bnab
boy sitting on top of the world
featuring 21
[Music]
Savage it feel good it's a good feeling
yeah yeah for sure the song from bur
boy's 2023 album I told
[Music]
them
it samples bry's 1998 hit top of the
world onp
[Music]
world world on to of the world of the
world of the world singing is the best
way I can express myself it's it's the
way I I I get everything out you know
everything every emotion I can I can
emote through through through song
Meanwhile it was a history making for
bnab boy who became the first afro
Fusion artist to perform at the show a
guy from Paco Nigeria you know it's a
[Music]
blessing
at
sides Joanie Mitchell making her
Grammy's performance debut at 80 years
old I hope I'm a good influence on on
music the nine-time Grammy winner was
joined by Brandy Carlile for a rendition
of both sides now Brandy holding it down
on the guitar and providing backup
vocals I
[Music]
like plus Joanie treated the audience to
a little can
[Music]
ography Joan's performance was an
exciting moment for all of her fans
including her industry peers who
couldn't wait to see her take that stage
is there anybody you're looking forward
to seeing I mean Joanie Mitchell is my
like North Star artist there's not been
a day that I haven't listened to her
music since I learned about her as a
small child so I I'm just really nervous
I'm that's what I keep like getting a
hot flash about we're just so lucky
we're just so lucky Joanie Mitchell it
was like we I mean we would line up in
the bathroom and take turns singing
Joanie Mitchell songs Joanie Mitchell is
playing which is going to be amazing I
mean Joanie Mitchell is one of my
songwriting Heroes so that's amazing and
Joanie more than lived up to the hype
can you dig
it maybe not I don't
know proving that her longevity is no
coincidence and that true star power is
Ageless I looked at love from both
[Music]
Tina's voice continues to speak to all
of us and tonight to honor Tina
Turner her memory with her own
empowering voice joined by Adam
Blackstone this is Fantasia bin no to
move your for turna
[Music]
[Applause]
a Fantasia burino belting out an epic
cover of Proud Mary in a tribute to Tina
Turner Sunday night at the
[Music]
gramys watch as the singer delivers an
uplifting rendition of the icon song
[Applause]
[Music]
represent good music represent one of
the queens of Soul music pop music R&B
Tina Turner and uh it's a showstopping
it's a showstopping number she is our
forever goddess of rock and
roll who inspired Millions a moving
symbol of Grace and grit soul and power
Tina's tribute was one of a few
highlighted during the shows in Memorial
Stevie Wonder also honoring the late
Tony Bennett I remember hearing Tony
Bennett singing for once in my life when
I was like 13 to 14 years
old and then I went in the studio when I
did the song the writer of the song said
what are you doing to my song was for
once in my life but what's amazing is I
was able to actually sing the song with
someone that I admired for so long not
just because of his voice which was
incredible but because of his art his
love for art performing a duet of for
once in my life alongside Bennett via a
video recording it's like it's amazing
Tony I'm going to miss you forever I
love you always and God bless that God
allowed us to have you and have us in
this time and space in our lives any l
also paying tribute to sheno Conor with
a tearful delivery of nothing compares
to you go away and Clarence Avant was
honored with John batiste's gospel
infused rendition of Bill withers's
Ain't No Sunshine Lenny Kravitz sharing
a few words about the black
Godfather Clarence aot was a trusted
mentor and believer in the likes of
Quincy Jones and Bill Withers to name
just a few whose lives he changed
forever as a musical family we mourn the
loss of our Godfather and celebrate the
inspiring life he shared with his
beloved wife
[Music]
[Applause]
Jacqueline
thank you
all I love you right
back Selen Deion's unannounced
appearance closes out the Grammy Awards
when I say that um I'm happy to be
here I really mean it from my heart I'm
alive we have to live one day at a time
the music icon supported on stage by her
son Renee Charles met with roaring
Applause and a standing ovation stepping
out in public amid her private struggle
with stiff person syndrome she's a
five-time Grammy winner and one of the
great voices of the world what an
absolute honor to welcome the one the
only Cel indion Taylor Swift singing
along to the power of love moments
before joining Seline on stage Taylor
Swift
the two singers taking this photo
backstage after ta's album of the Year
win life imposes things on you you you
have no choice you have to deal with
them this comes days after announcing
her documentary I am Selen Deion I'm
working hard every day a candid look at
her ongoing Health Battle and seline's
wish to perform again for her fans I
would be lying if I said I'm fine it's
something she got emotional over on
Sunday
those who have been blessed enough to be
he the Grammy
Awards must never take for granted the
tremendous love and
joy that music brings to our lives and
to people all around the
[Music]
world
a feeling could
be Tracy Chapman makes a rare appearance
to perform her 1988 hit fast car and
it's all thanks to Luke coms you want it
to be worth the way you know what I mean
such a cool full circle moment for me
just to be associated with her in any
way is super humbling for me the two hit
the Grammy stage Sunday night for a duet
of the
track
fly got
decision it's a song Luke covered on his
latest album getting old and one that
for him has special meaning behind
it my dad would play me that Tracy
Chapman self-titled album that song
fastar it was my favorite song before I
even knew what a favorite song was I've
been playing that song since I could
play guitar honestly I just love that
song so when I went into the studio to
record my most recent record which was
getting old and I was like what if we
just did this cover of Fast Car you know
just cuz I want to do it I'm not doing
it for anybody else I'm just doing it
for me and during the performance it was
clear how big of a deal it was for Luke
as he watched Tracy and mouthed the
words while she
[Music]
saying I try to bring
that energy into everything that I do
Tracy's obviously written one of the
best songs for a few Generations you
hear it's already iconic before you've
even heard the words once you finally
get to that
course right like everybody's screaming
Tracy is such an icon and I mean one of
the best songwriters that I think any of
us will ever be around to
[Music]
see
you thank the champagne folks yes I did
there's so many other people I'm like I
don't know what I said can anybody tell
me did I thank my mom you thanked your
mom okay good you didn't thank your
husband or your daughter I didn't thinkk
oh my God thank you so much John um it's
only you who understands the amount of
sacrifice it takes to take care of a
household while Mommy's away working you
know all the long hours that I have um
thank you so much Hazel for your
resilience and patience with Mommy for
being away so many nights it takes a
community it really takes a tribe so
what was going through your mind as you
walked up there because it was you were
so emotional oh my God as soon as I I I
just didn't expect it there's so many
great artists in the category and I know
the gramms it's it's just so hard to be
um recognized it's like there's
superstars in each category so I just
wasn't expecting it and I was blown away
by what God is doing for me in my life
and I'm I could cry all over again I'm
going to spare you
but yes you did talk about being
planting your seeds and having roots
that people didn't see for a long time
but there were certain people who did
and what does that mean to you to have
people who believed in you and now show
them this moment well I look at them as
Visionaries I look at them as people who
can see beyond what the world is seeing
and I think those people are super
important the people that you know um
you know pour into you before the world
thinks it's cool the people who are
uplifting you before it's popular to do
so those that's your tribe and those are
the people who you can stand by through
and through um it's very easy to you
know give someone accolades or or praise
when everyone's doing it but when No One
Believes and that one person is like you
know what we're going to rock together
that's who you got to rock with how are
you celebrating tonight I'mma eat you
know I've been starving trying to look
them for the carpet right now but I'm
going to go eat I want carbs bread you
know a little bit of you know alcohol
hul you will you know I'm trying to
celebrate how about you no I'm going
home I got to be up early in the morning
God I love that we're going home yeah we
got to be up early I like your style
truly we got to work oh it where's your
mom oh your mom's right there hold on
mom come here come here come
here oh look look look
look I told her to come on the stage and
she just didn't she I was like where
were you I like it was improper for me
to walk up the left side when they were
going up the right you know old country
girl you know okay well what what did
that moment mean to you and especially
the beautiful words your daughter said
about you you know I'm so grateful for
everything that she's
done just to see her not give up when
things look like they just weren't going
to work and for her to just be able to
talk to herself with affirmations of
positivity to say I look fly I look good
I look good it doesn't matter and I put
it on my mom cuz when you put something
on your mama you mean
it so I'm just so proud of her I'm so
thankful for everything that she's done
she blossom into the star that we all
thought that she would be and she's
going to continue to do things and you
know God gives us gifts yeah if we don't
grab it she grabbed it and she's doing
it as a mama I love that too she's doing
it she's doing it I'm so proud of you
okay y'all GNA go out and party tonight
though
righty thank you so much I love this
bedazzle mic that's really nice this the
first time of many times that we will
see you in interview with this bedazzle
Mike thank you so much I'm so
excited congratulations first of all was
that a shout out little shout out to
Greta there thank you to Greta Gerwig
for making
the best movie of the year of course my
God it's it's all because of Greta she
deserves it as much as we do okay the
little dance with Miley you had a little
fun right when Miley came out did you
all say anything did you have any oh she
was just not to to blow up her spot but
she was saying like she was asking me if
I also feel like when I get on stage I
say the dumbest I could possibly
say and I was like absolutely 100% she's
like why was I saying all that sorry
Miley but I feel the same I always get
up there and I like just poop out of my
[Music]
mouth really disgusting Sor where will
you party tonight how will you celebrate
this one uh I'm going to see it's it's
really like Trevor had a pre-taped intro
to that show where he was like La
survived a little rain he filmed that
days ago it's really raining actually so
hard right now so my big celebration my
friend texted me this morning he goes
are you nervous I was like I'm much more
nervous about my house flooding than
straight up um the rain or than the
Grammy so again like I'm going to
celebrate if if I don't have if I can
sleep in my bed and I don't have like a
big puddle in the bed dud four years ago
right now I remember so fondly seeing
you after I won gramy do you remember
that and I was crying and it was
honestly like truly one of the most
incredible nights of my life and I think
about you frequently cuz cuz I saw you
right after and I was I remember you
were like Billy you did it and I did
that's cool I was standing under the
stage it was a moment it was a moment
100% that's wild did you remember that
of we had the tunnel
the tunnel is cool did anybody get a
tunnel win tonight I love a tunnel win
oh the tunnel I for I don't even think
they had a tunnel tonight think so I
don't think so new stage design yeah no
but you yeah you couldn't you couldn't
stop crying you were trying to pull it
together that was that was that was a
ridiculous experience it was insane it
was insane and tonight was insane I
please I mean we'll see at the Oscars
performing
yeah I mean yeah yeah who knows who
knows don't don't you have I don't know
whatever I'm sure I don't know I
honestly don't know
love you Oscars I'm excited get out of
here before your house floods cuz that's
what we're trying to do
too congratulations what does this mean
that this moment to win a Grammy yeah
it's hard to describe I I'm literally
trying to keep it together you know I'm
almost almost done um but it it's just
hard to describe it's so surreal your
mom's here
would you like to share with come here
Mama come here come here it's Mama's
Night go how happy how proud are you of
this young
woman this is so amazing she's a Grammy
winner she is a Grammy my daughter want
a Grammy
tonight that's my girl so amazing I
think that like as a parent you feel
it's more exciting for you to see her
you just want them to win you would give
anything so that they could be happy
they're your babies they're your kids
you just want them to win and she was
always so happy doing this that I just
knew I could not we couldn't stop we
couldn't stop and today my daughter want
a
Grammy okay who's getting a Grammy by
the way oh I'm getting it you know the
answer there you go there you go where
will you celebrate tonight um we're
going to have a couple things the dinner
and um probably a party I'm going to
celebrate with my de Jam high standards
label team and and um who knows from
there COC go enjoy thank you so much all
[Music]
right what does it mean win a Grammy oh
my God I'm like just trying to calm down
a little bit because I am so nervous uh
I came with no expectation it is my
first time being in Grammys and just to
have the opportunity to VIs is arounded
from a lot of Legends that I admire is
such a gift and this next I am super
happy I don't know I like I just want to
call to my father and say like poy we
did it and have you talked have you
talked to your family yet no yet like
they bring me just straight away to here
but I'm just stopping like my cries and
and waiting from every interview right
now you got to call him call him call
goad call him I'm going to call I'm
going to call
him where is he he's in Colombia in my I
I'm from AG in colia yeah oh my God no
maybe I'm not going to be that good to
stop my chist if he
answers let's see I bet they're up
waiting to hear from you I bet too there
it is now it's
right well there he
go like what
put in my cute for my
[Music]
father
Bobby I heard your dad yelling how cool
how cool is that how emotional does that
make you hearing them screaming and you
being here and thinking of them
celebrating no it's crazy because I
always say when I have the opportunity I
will share like my testimony to all the
parents that can see this interview like
for me it was like everything that my
father always trust in me even the
moments that I never trust myself he was
like pushing me and hey you can do it
you're the best you're a you're a
warrior you're everything so for me the
90% of this achievement is my dad and my
family like putting that yeah support on
me so Dad believe in your kids support
them they're great awesome are you going
to take that Grammy home to them oh for
sure they keep all my Awards in their
home yeah they give they sto all my
Awards but they deserve it they deserve
it congratulations thank
you come on come
[Music]
on
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say okay hold on hold On's up man the
clock the clock it's always ticking
what's going on tonight oh yo man
tonight a whole lot of grammy winning is
going on tonight you know how have you
been what's been going on what's
Happening update me hey well I've been
chilling man you know what I'm saying I
just released a single call everywhere
man and the reason why is because Flavor
Flav is everywhere man flavor you going
to the Super Bowl are you going
featuring my partner Chuck D you know
how to shout out my partner partner
Chuck but um I don't have actual
tickets but I told the NFL if I don't
get no tickets I'm sneaking in let's
just let's let's clarify something
flavor flave has to have tickets to the
Super Bowl if he wants to go that's
right and I live in Vegas you know what
I'm saying but if I don't go to the
actual Super Bowl I'll be there for all
the festivities and FL makees make sure
that we call each other but also flave
how come on in here come on in man I
just want to just bust it all in I want
to mess up the whole
interview see see every chance I get to
just attack somebody I want to rush
somebody
love man I'm good man we were just
talking about you we were just talking
about finishing your tour and still oh
yeah the tour everything's happening
yeah what earth wind in fire earth wind
in Fire and on top of that we've got
this doc this out called lest night and
pop y hey well guess what you got your
host for the tour right
here now you heard it here now let's
take flave on the road got the host for
the tour right here flavor flave yo Lio
good to see
you
twin Where Have You
Been first of all I'm obsessed with you
and your music I feel like mun I don't
know if you feel but like you just you
make me feel like '90s R&B you know
that's saying if it don't make you feel
like '90s R&B you don't want it but you
and I think there's a lot of women like
you right now s in R&B that sing that's
making us really feel the music again
that's singing about stuff again you
know what I'm saying it's about the
lyrics The Melody the vocal not all the
extra although we love that too um but
yeah definitely it's intentional I want
you to think about my talent I want you
to focus on the music and not what I'm
wearing even though you know we going to
give you a little look come on you know
but we are do you ever go down the
rabbit like the Tik Tock rabbit hole and
see cuz I can't open up my feed without
seeing somebody recreating twins right
now um like all the videos they're
hilarious definitely my guilty pleasure
like when I'm supposed to be sleeping um
at 2 a.m. I'm scrolling through all the
I see everything I read all the comments
so yes and it feels like that Everything
You Touch turn to Gold I mean hours and
hours first now twin like I don't know
if it's just it's your voice it's what
you're doing I'm not sure what it is
that everybody is just you have us in a
choke hold right now you know I was just
talking to my manager about that I
really do think I have have a really
close relationship and conversation
language with my fan base my supporters
um on top of the fact that it is
actually really well-made music um the
quality of it but I actually like have
people who want to see me win and I
think that's what it is I really do is
there somebody out there that's like I
have to see I have to collaborate with
them I want to they're on my list it's
going to happen and maybe somebody that
we wouldn't think you would well I
honestly have a lot of those I would
love to work with like Ed Sheeran but
Mariah Carey that's like my mother I
love her so much and of course
everybody's going to say Beyonce um I
just want to work with people who are
excited about music I love that and I
love this for you I love this time for
you I really really do I'm a big fan and
so I'm rooting for you that's for sure
okay tell me a secret when was you were
we doing old Hollywood glamour tonight
what was the thinking going into the you
know I think my team just pulled me
together I really just wanted to give
like she's here okay you know she's here
and she's here to
stay on did you know that this song was
going to blow up like it did like it was
going to take the World by storm no no I
mean one lives in Hope but uh no I had
no idea I was seeing P now I'm like Pam
red pam pam can you explain badam to me
please well within the within the song
it's the heartbeat you
know but Pam took on a you know a myriad
of uh of
meanings and at the time when it came
out first came out it was a greeting it
was a farewell it was who knows what
whatever you
like and it is such like people lose it
in clubs when they play it have you had
a chance to be in like do you sometimes
sneak in to the club and you hear it and
everybody's goes crazy well I had a few
moments when we were doing listening
parties and just the place erupted I was
kind of faux DJing like literally just
press play but I was quite comfortable
there yeah I do what does it also mean
to stay relevant with folks in
generation after generation after
generation which is very very cool well
obviously means a lot to me but I feel
like this current moment for myself is
beyond me that others might look at what
I've achieved and and go hey that's you
know she's broken a fair number of rules
in her time and and you can it can be
done you can achieve anything you want
anytime yeah I mean of course you know
it's uh we we never stop working but
it's it's a great moment and I think
I've been doing this long enough to
really actively be cognizant that this
this is a great moment amongst the
madness I'm I'm is it that as we get
older we start to realize how precious
these moments are is that what it is
entirely yeah so to still be here to to
um to have won tonight do you know that
I won hold are you won I
won wait a minute oh you won well I
didn't know telling you this when I
first like yes I got two
now
wow where where are you going to put
this Grammy next to the other one
I thought you'd build like some kind of
special place for this uh it'll it'll
come back to Australia with me okay tell
me your speech cuz we didn't get to hear
the speech so tell me there was it was
in the pre-show and I was getting ready
so I got the news in my uh robe my
dressing gown kind of ready I screamed I
cried I was shaking and I had to stop
before you went to the ugly cry just
like try and we've just she's ready
don't undo it all with with tears but I
was so were you watching were you
watching the stream or were you getting
a you got a call I I my manager came to
the came to the door and came in saying
two time Grammy that's all she got out I
I I
screamed it it's all it's on my it's on
my Instagram yeah yeah you just lost it
I lost it it was a great moment and then
I had to get back to focus cuz you look
great right now so clearly you pulled it
back together and got everything I I
brought it back from the brink yeah okay
well Kylie two-time Grammy winner have
an amazing night great to see you thank
you tell us about this dress yes um well
I thought i' come Pam red and it's do
gabana my good friends and if IID facted
in the rain I might have done without
the the train situation but just get a
little wet that's that's all right badam
padam to you
okay okay so first of all mom Night Out
how'd you get away and are what are the
babies doing I was just with them they
are at home just playing together it's
so sweet I'm so feel so blessed and so
lucky how is motherhood because I know
you were ready you waited you know and
then what does it mean to you to finally
be a mother especially because of the
love that you have for your mom my life
just feels so complete my husband my two
beautiful babies just feels like all my
dreams come true and I just feel so
fulfilled and just happy at life okay
okay Paris the DJ is here tonight though
right you're Paris the DJ what is it
what are you looking for tonight and who
are you excited to see I'm excited to
see so many of my favorite artists
excited for Miley nominated six times
she is such an icon and I'm so excited
for my second album CA is executive
producing it track what can you okay so
what can you tell me about the album the
album is mean a lot of amazing badass
females on it and a lot of surprises and
it's all about my journey and everything
that I've went through in my life and
I'm just so excited and honored to have
CA executive producing and writing all
the music with
me okay so do your kids love it when you
play do you play music for them what do
you play for them my kids love music
Phoenix just got a little piano for his
first birthday he's in playing on the
piano and he loves and it's his favorite
L ofi since he was born man Paris this
has been such a crazy journey I mean I
can think back to way back in the day
and all the trials and tribulations and
all that stuff and when you think of
that what would you if you could whisper
in your ear and tell yourself something
what would you say say you're going to
go through a lot in life one day you're
going to have the most beautiful perfect
life and family so keep going
girl you kept going you kept going it's
good to see you anything else Paris
that's coming up um just everything I'm
about to release my 30th fragrance
and wa wait a minute your 30th 30th
yes I know what does this one smell like
it's just the most beautiful unique
scent I've ever smelled before it's my
favorite perfume ever won't you get into
the baby clothes business or something
doing children's stuff too yes we have
children's furniture and children's
clothing and doing a huge deal with
Walmart so everything will be out very
soon wow so when can we see that stuff
that will be out by by this fall with my
new clothing line and jewelry and
Handbags damn Paris you do every you
never stop do you there is no slowing
you down is there there's nothing
slowing me down can you tell us a secret
about your fashion tonight tonight oh
I'm wearing this gorgeous mermaid gown
and then I have this custom made for my
handbag line cuz I'm representing Hilton
tonight as they're a big part of the
awards and just wanted to represent
Hilton for the
stay
you really went all the way in Queen
right you will Market one thing you will
do is Market something right I invented
it that's real actually some people
copied right some people copied you but
you it's nothing like the original how
has it been living life in the Paris
Hilton Fishbowl but you guys have a very
normal life you have kids now so
everything has to be normal it's just
amazing watching Paris be a mom we love
to just stay home play play with the
babies watching her mother is pretty
awesome yeah and what is Paris Hilton
the mom like uh well let's see the other
day I came home Paris was on a motorized
scooter and Phoenix was following her
around and they were doing relay races
so let's just say she's a fun and a
sliving mom sliving
mom I love it thanks have a great
day okay first of all all the
nominations how how good does it feel to
be that your peers love you H it feels
incredible like I never expected four
nominations and I'm just just so happy
like I'm so excited yes okay um are you
excited for this Super Bowl commercial I
am I am shout out to stari they held it
down period what was it like shooting a
Super Bowl commercial how big is it
going to be cuz that's the biggest day
of the year the commercials are better
than game half time yeah they are um I
don't know I'm just really excited the
commercial was fun it was my second
commercial ever and um yeah it was it
was a little bit of a challenge filming
but we got why because lemon lime wasn't
actually present so I was talking to
nobody really but oh so you kind of just
talking to the green screen we was just
you know getting our little acting out
more music coming right yes album
dropping this year y 2K tune in on when
when when is it dropping
2024 that's all you can tell me come on
now yes that's all okay tell me about
collabs or anybody that's on there I
can't let that be known yet but my fans
will be very pleased 2023 was an insane
year so to cap it off now with the
Grammys in 2024 what would that mean to
you it just means everything I'm just so
happy to be acknowledged and you know
it's a big deal to
me okay I don't know what was happening
I don't know what's going on there's a
lot going on there's a lot like your
2023 yeah exactly enjoy the night okay
all right and good
luck come on come on
[Music]
he
welcome back to et's coverage of the
Grammy Awards red carpet you know we
always have great conversations with
some of the biggest stars yes and
tonight was no exception they had a lot
to say am I a member because I got the
memo come on now this
great I got the
memo I think I think I just joined
pentatonics
everybody well y'all know first of all
y'all know that you do the music does it
for me all the time so I mean it does
it's first of all it's like music is
healing anyway but your music is so
joyous and it's just like a feast for
the ear so it just makes me happy and I
mean everybody thinks that you're here
because you're nominated again so of
course oh my gosh yes we can't believe
we're nominated for an album we put so
much heart and soul into it's a it's a
world holiday album where we celebrated
all these different cultures and learned
about their music and their culture and
how they celebrate the holidays we
collaborated with the most iconic
artists from all these different
countries and it was so fulfilling and
such a beautiful Journey making this
album so to see it celebrated by our
peers in this way it's just surreal it's
the only word I can think of do y'all
ever feel like us like if you're in the
studio you're recording something and
then you hear it like oh damn we just
did that I mean seriously do you ever
feel like that D yeah some sometimes
especially because we're such fans of
each other too you know so like when I
hear a certain thing it's got things
Kevin it just inspires us to keep going
and keep pushing further and so it's
it's like we feel like kids in the
playground like they get to play in the
sandbox you know okay how do you decide
like when you hear your name called who
gets to say who gets to speak give the
speech of them oh we haven't even talked
about it now I'm creating problems we're
figuring it out right here right
now I think I'd be so nervous and like
shocked so I would probably Mama's got
diamonds so Mama should be able to do it
oh yeah Mama just gonna go here well
hopefully they won't leave me behind
because I'm G to have to Shimmy Shimmy
onto the these are part of the opening
ceremony for the premere cereem
yeah with like Jordan Sparks and Jay Ivy
and all of that what was that moment oh
my gosh it was so good we did Prince
Let's Go Crazy everybody was just
unbelievable it's so cool to see such
diversity of Talent on one stage and
that's what I think makes the Grammy so
just unbelievably iconic that all these
artists from completely different walks
of life can be on the same stage and
showcase their talent but it all is
working harmoniously together it's it's
just the coolest thing I feel so blessed
that we get to do this each other
everyone was so kind we were all like
hyping each other up and it was just
such a fun song and a fun way to like
start our Grammy day all right so what's
coming up next that's a great question
you know I think what we've talked about
a
lot baby
girl Sheila E bust into your interview
come
on we just performed together just
talking about
it we were just talking about how cool
it was for all these different talents
to get together open up this ceremony
kind of celebrate music and celebrate
each other oh absolutely it was amazing
I had a blast I mean I get to play with
them come on
really she she gave a master class on
energy like I it was amazing to watch
you perform and like taking the the the
mic and everything it just I did the
simp like master class thank you thank
you thank you something happens to her
when she gets on those
turns oh my gosh yes it was
unbelievable well thank you guys guys so
much Sheila you stick
around find each other in like a very
similar Gap no we're like sparkles
sparkles you know yes and this is giving
tonight so was it when you saw it on the
rack when you put it on what was it
about it this is a custom dress by k um
that was made for me um I feel very
excited to wear it I feel very strong in
it it's definitely a heavy like metal
dress I was like feel very
jonok
no but for real yeah well listen you had
a very strong year I'm having I'm having
fun so the last time I talked to you at
the Golden Globes you were telling me
about your new music and you were saying
you know this record is about
understanding your worth and different
chapters of your life so on the 15th
we're getting a song okay so what are
you what are you giving on the 15th so
on the 15th like you said a new so I
mean it'll be late in the evening on the
15th but um a new song which is just
about kind of knowing
how
to it's almost like not expecting to for
people to like love you right yeah you
know yeah you're just like preach baby
training people's over you know you're
done teaching people how to do things
right exactly come correct or don't come
at all corre or don't come at all
exactly that's the vibe that's the vibe
so much I can't wait because it does
feel like this record is going to be a
very personal one for you it is and it
you know I I got to do most of the
record at home in London
um I just felt like and I feel like with
every album I get to grow more and learn
more about myself and I become more free
as a songwriter and as a performer and
as an artist so this one I'm just like
digging deeper and deeper I love it I'm
I'm proud of this one heard of you as an
artist that says I'm a little nervous
because this year for you like has been
in the stratosphere as far as music is
concerned you know what I'm saying and I
mean just career in general but is there
a part of you that's like okay now I got
to follow up with like just an
incredible year that I I mean there's
always pressure yeah there's always
pressure but I think for as long as I'm
doing things that I'm proud of things
that I love things that I feel like I'm
pushing myself and trying out something
different and I'm growing as an artist
and as a person then I'm good you know
the Grammys is also about the
performances and what's going to happen
on stage so what can we expect oh we got
something special for you guys tonight
she gives the smile like the biggest
smile I'm really really excited about
this performance like more more so than
any three words give me in three words
what this performance is gonna oh my God
we we have it's
like it's intense okay uh it's
strong and uh it's Dy okay I love it so
you you have two nominations tonight
dance the night away we're still dancing
to it so I mean when you think about
that song when you were making it did
you think okay I got I got something
here like this is I mean I mean I know
you didn't know what it was going to do
but but were you like okay yeah I got
something here yeah I mean in the moment
again it goes back to that thing of for
as long as I feel like I'm having fun or
making something that I'm really proud
of and I'm in the moment then I'm I'm
exactly where I'm supposed to be and I
feel that way with you know when we were
making D night we were having such a
great time in the studio it felt so good
to be a part of such an incredible
project it felt so good to do it with my
friends that whole experience as a whole
was really special so um yeah I'm I'm
happy that's like way out into the world
now and like had its own life and it's
it's been great well finally I was in
London didn't get to talk to you there
but I was there for arile you have this
movie coming out it is fun fun fun in so
many ways and you get to cut up a little
bit in this movie and get a little
dancing going on I did get to do a
little bit of I mean I have a a small
role but I'm I loved working on a film
set and for Matthew vaugh to give me
that opportunity I'm so grateful for it
and I had fun with my co-stars with
Henry caval and John Cena are you and
John the new Hollywood Duo that we
didn't know we needed uh I don't know if
our acting career will continue together
um but I anytime I see him it's an
absolute pleasure and I I loved working
with him and he's so wonderful so who
knows he told me he was so embarrassed
because he had to sing off key to you
and he was like why am I doing this to
myself he was he's such a good sport
honestly he wasn't even off key I think
he's just so humble that he's just you
know it's it's it was wonderful
really it was what made this year
possible we decided it before we even
recorded that it was going to be a
limited time and it's part of why we've
like given so much to this we can't
sustain this level of doing personally
yeah boy Genius opening up about their
Hiatus after winning at the 2024 gramys
the Grammy goes
to not strong enough
boy it's just like isn't
real uh yeah thank you uh thank you to
our band uh thank you to everyone that
uh contributed to the record I just want
to say well music saved my life everyone
can be in the band love this band is my
family ahead of the award show the trio
snagged a trophy ET getting their full
reaction on the red carpet amazing
amazing we were like rushing getting
dressed when the live stream was on so I
had to play it cool I was like oh yeah
cool but it was amazing like wait wait
wait shut up like you I thought someone
had like dropped a vase or something
like and we were like and then we
screamed yeah the band's Big Win comes
just days after they announced at a
secret show they're going on Hiatus
we're all just going to go chill and
it's made it like really special like
knowing that the shows are limited and
and we have a plan we have a plan to
watch Paddington 2 which everybody has
told us is amazing and we've been like
planning to watch it together for years
so we said after all this we're going to
watch Paddington too as for what this
means for the future of the Indie band I
mean not convinced how do you know how
do you know meteor is not going to crash
into Earth tomorrow you know what I'm
saying like but well I don't know we
just be H I'm telling myself be
satisfied with like what has happened
and not just like more more more yeah
it's been a question since our first
week of promoting the album what are you
guys doing next and we're like what do
you mean it's just that like stay here
in the moment yeah I think it's like
maybe the finitude will help people
realize that like the thing that we give
is enough the album is enough we're
proud of it it's a recording you can go
listen to it anytime yeah it's
there
Grammys I know never gets old for you
the night of this it's like it is
music's night right it's definitely
music's night and I love seeing all the
different looks come on the carpet
seeing how everybody went all out
exactly so what you know for me it's
about the collaborations that we see on
stage is there anybody that you're
looking forward to seeing perform
tonight uh oh my gosh I'm trying to
think who's performing that I I guess
like uh doal Lia I want to hear she just
left and she said oh I got something for
y'all
tonight and as far as looks I can't wait
to see what DOA cat is going to wear you
know she's gonna come with something
iant look she might walk out here with
nothing on as far as they say it's going
to be a little art it's going to be a
work of art I can't wait to see it I
believe it I believe every minute about
it okay so what's happening with the
skape right now you guys still
performing I know I've seen you on a few
dates where are you just staying on
tours we're putting together a tour
right now for later this summer mhm if
you need somebody else I mean Tiny's
daughter if y'all need another member
killing it right and She's Not Afraid we
put her on stage and it's a whole Arena
full of people and she can just belt it
out yeah you know the the question on
everybody's mind is what's happening in
Atlanta and are you going to be back and
do we know what I have been trying to
figure that out for myself to be honest
with you and um I don't know I'm
thinking
that I'm thinking might just say is it
time I been going back and forth and I
think because they gave us such a long
break I had a lot of time to do other
things and I got some big announcements
to make coming soon so yeah I was like I
mean I love the girls they're my friends
I'm still going to see them and hang out
with them and Bravo is my family I love
them as well but you know okay I'm going
to drill down are you making an
announcement right now that you are
going to take a break from Atlanta now
you done put the pressure on but I guess
yeah okay yeah cuz I mean somebody asked
me recently they were like well why do
you um keep doing it and I was like to
be honest with you I think because I've
been doing it 14 years and so now I feel
like it's it's I do it because I I'm
used to doing it but with all the other
things that I got going on I just like I
might just yeah I don't know if I could
imagine the show without you but I I
couldn't either first but I think when
they decided you know like they were
like okay we you know we taking this
break to you know rearrange the cast and
all this other kind of stuff and then
it's like it gave me time you know I
never had time I never had
time yeah and I still was working don't
get me wrong I still had a lot of stuff
going on but it was like I had more time
to pick up my kids I had more time to be
in the studio so I've been writing a lot
and I had more time to work on these
other projects that y'all going to see
okay well listen you keep saying that so
you got to give me something because you
keep saying I'm going to have a big
announcement I got to work on these
other projects oh I mean you know I'm
doing Broadway and I already had um you
know we have the whz that's I'll be
there March 13th uh in New York to see
the show and I'll be there February 13th
in LA to see the show okay thank you
I'll be here so yeah um so I'm excited
for that and then I got some more things
to announce in that lane as well and you
know too much too I don't want to talk
too much ahead of time but yeah it's a
great maybe more Broadway maybe more
that but I know you're working on that
OT you said it you manifesting it you
ready to do and I'm still I'm
manifesting yeah so so something in that
realm for sure like um because I I don't
want to give away too much that I have
to come I mean I'll just say I have some
big things coming so keep stay tuned but
um I do love the franchise but it's just
you know you know when everybody kind of
keeps you like at limbo for so long you
start making other plans you're the
longest running housewife to date at
this point that's a oh Lord Jesus you
know I love the house you know I love
you so I'm getting palpitations from
this I understand it though I do get it
I do understand it and like if this is
you know Andy might say maybe it's a
pause for you yeah that's what he called
me okay and because I I've talked to him
about it and he said well I don't he's
like I don't know how I feel about this
and I said well honestly I don't know
how feel about it either but he was like
well you do realize this are this is
your family like if you just want to
just come back next year that's fine and
I'm like I mean I love you guys and I
appreciate like it's it's my family you
know what I mean so yeah I'm always a
part of them you know okay they're
always a part of me you have given you
I'm gagging right now I'm giving I
love
come on come
[Music]
on
hello how are you my goodness I have not
seen you in so long and you come through
here looking like the supermodel that
you are you look stunning here I'm going
bring you turn you around a little bit
more like this so we can see your whole
face okay you look stunning tell me
about this look from head to toe tonight
head to toe it's just Seline Mama it's
all all Seline Head To Toe with my my
own jewelry and um covered all the
tattoos I was going to say Paris I know
you have tattoos and I don't see
anything what did how long did that take
it took a few hours it took a few hours
yeah why did you do it was it because
you just wanted to go like super Glam
tonight super Chic tonight well I like
switching things up I love my tattoos I
love my piercings I love all the body
modification stuff art and also
sometimes I don't want it to distract
from the art that is the fashion I'm
wearing and I kind of it just gives it
gives the dress it's own moment this
giving for sure um I wonder cuz you have
You' got new music coming out um and
it's uh just a couple couple months um
so I haven't decided when yet but when I
was on tour with Incubus I dropped a
single that I just did with Linda Perry
and so she and I just she's like my
Aries twin flame so we're we want to
keep working together and sometimes
talking to a lot of other um celebrities
or children of celebrities they really
want to kind of figure out their own
lane and don't want to you know they
love their parent and love everything
theyve done but they want to figure out
their own lane and make their own path
well depends on how meta you're getting
if you want to go on a much Universal
Collective Consciousness thing I think
we're all one so depends on how how far
you want to go with that I like okay so
what is this new music what is it giving
like what are what um what were you in
what era were you in when you were
making it or what like what's your
inspiration um inspo is usually um pain
and love and the space between um but my
record exact Monty thinks that Linda is
my muse so can't go wrong with Linda
Perry that's for I love that we cannot
wait for this new music who are you
looking forward to seeing getting on
this Grammy stage tonight every single
human every single one every single one
you want it all all right sis thank you
so much I appreciate it
okay okay first of all um you're DJing
at the Super Bowl right all week long
you have a residency in Vegas so what do
I need to do to get tickets to get in to
see you right uh be my best friend and I
can get you in how exciting is that
though because the town will be buzzing
especially this week but to be in Vegas
that's a lot of energy it is I love
Vegas and I have a home at the wind now
I'll actually be playing there all year
long and I am just so grateful to them
they've really like treated me like
family and there's no better place to be
in Vegas than the wi okay tell me about
the podcast and what actually goes on
because there are things y'all can tell
people and there are things you know so
how far do you go in this podcast we go
pretty good do you you know what H so
it's called sorry we're stoned for a
reason although she does not partake so
she keeps us all together so if I'm
starting to spill too much tea she's
like Mom zip it pull it in Pull It in
rain it in Miley's performing tonight I
think flowers is such a little Bop and
people love that song but it feels like
it also tells a lot about her life and
her story when you listen to that song
what do you know that I don't know you
know what you gotta dissect those lyrics
I think the fans know more than anybody
knows they absolutely do they dissected
that pretty well for us I think I did I
I mean people opened up those lyrics
like they were reading a book like it
was a memoir you know what there were
some taken pretty far so like yeah but
over overall like I think Miley had so
much fun making that song and like she
you know she says it over and over like
no expectations of it just from her
heart putting it out and to see it see
its success has been so incredible you
know and also there's just so much talk
about how this is like the next
iteration of Miley you know and so it's
like she continues to have success at
every level as she grows how cool is
that to watch her success it is so
incredible but as her mom it's watching
her grow into this woman she's become at
30 and once she just 30 remember that
just 30 exactly 31 but it's so crazy to
think she's only 31 and everything that
she's achieved but as a person she's
just the most incredible human being I
I'm so proud of her okay real quick how
many Miley songs do you play during your
DJ set minimum three a minimum of three
minimum of three I like to rep the
family okay do you have a favorite
family song um I mean right now flowers
just goes off so hard also Noah did a
song with Diplo a couple years ago and I
play that one quite a bit also otel
Road's always a hit like Metro station I
play Shake It The Crowd Goes Crazy it
really I I like to represent my family
y'all got hits y'all got y'all got hits
all right remember when I'm standing at
the door I'm calling your name I'm
calling you all right for super for
Super Bowl
[Music]
weekend listen we're here celebrating
though because you guys have already won
six nominations tonight you've already
one does it take a little like now you
can exhale a little bit and just go into
the rest of it like no 100% I was like
okay okay we're good like that's fine if
if nothing else happens the rest of the
night that's I'm 100% fine with that I
am so like excited for all the nominees
I'm like happy to be here we got one
we're out it's all good we're great if
we hadn't it would have been fine too
right we're chill do you still get
nervous do y'all still get nerv we
always joke that like you kind of you
kind of are like you know what
everyone's amazing you know whoever wins
as C but they're like the not they're
like they're like congratulations on
dude
soate man oh my God you um um anyway
they say they say the award goes to and
your heart starts you know pound moment
it's like everything before that is like
we're chill and then it's like the
moment that like envelope or like the
yeah the Grammy goes to it's it's like
it's like in your throat it's let me ask
you this cuz um you know swarm was my
thing like I love so for real and I'm
like this girl's good like will there
ever be a time where you say Let me let
me stop with music for a second and
really kind of dig deep into the acting
for
sure is it happening soon I don't know
girl because listen well but critic's
choice you said to us yes I got music
coming I don't know how much I can talk
about it yet but I have music coming I
do have that that is for sure on the way
very very soon didn't you say it's about
85% done oh no it's it's like 99 it's
right there yeah I know we've been
saying that for a long time but we can't
give too many details because then
people get excited then they get mad
okay then just give me three words of
the vibe of the
album it
is that's not that's not
musical no it's like I was saying the
other day that it's like a I think it's
a perfect representation of like natural
progression of
like I don't know wait you are so oh you
are so terrible of where you are okay
well where are you in life maybe that'll
give me a CH an indication of where the
music yes is it like you're chill are
you chill are you like in a real happy
era a real it's all over the place it's
a lot of feeling it's a lot of um it's
like some whatever relax girl jeez all
right listen Okay so we've got you can't
take a break because after the Grammys
we have the Oscars you guys are
nominated will you be performing
I mean I think we're required to well I
don't know you could say no I don't want
to but oh yeah no way dude I'm are you
kidding me performing at the Oscars is
like I'm I'm literally like please like
I'm yeah it's the coolest thing in the
world I mean y'all could just have a
whole Barbie section because Ry Ryan
said he wanted to perform too oh yeah I
can't wait to hear yeah God all right so
do we think have we already started
thinking about this like what's going to
go into this performance what it'll look
like what it'll feel like for the Oscars
you've been working on the Grammy
performance we're here working on that
one Grammy one yeah I mean it's you know
we're here we're doing Barbie we're
doing we're doing it you are you are I
love you guys congratulations have a
great night I can't wait to see what you
by the way besides your performance
tonight anybody you just can't wait to
see on that stage honestly I don't even
know like who's even all here which I'm
I'm soundchecking that was
tight so excited I'm I'm geeked to see
Luke Holmes and Tracy Chapman get on
stage and do fast car together like that
for me cuz that's my I'm dating myself
but that's like my My Generation uhhuh
yeah I'm excited I like try not to know
what's going to happen because I like to
be surprised so we'll
see there is so much still to come from
the Grammy Awards stick with ET we have
so much more coming after the
[Music]
break
the glitz the Glam and the outrageous
listen the Grammy Awards red carpet it
never disappoints there's always
something that will surprise you yes
indeed and here are a few of our
favorite moments from the night did the
rain wreck your look because we know
let's be honest that rain will wreck a
hair absolutely not you know the best
things happen when I'm Singing in the
Rain so maybe it's a good luck charm
okay five nominations I mean I hear you
are asleep on the plane when the
nominations came through and you had no
idea I was fully asleep and I thought
that by the time I landed that's when I
would find out cuz that's when it would
be announced I completely got the time
change wrong I woke up to my phone
blowing up with text messages and that's
when I knew but I was the last to know
what did that feel that moment feel like
when you started looking at the phone
and seeing the nomination after
nomination after nomination what really
took me out was the five everyone kept
mentioning five five five I was like
what does that mean and when I finally
land and I got to call people back
that's when I just lost it that's got to
be a great moment though it's got to be
a great it's so beautiful um it's just
refreshing to see you reap the benefits
of all the time you know your hard work
you you worked hard this isn't a you
know overnight success story you worked
your butt off so that's got to be that's
got it feels great to have not given up
but also it feels better to promote a
Time timeline that took a while you know
I'm not I'm not afraid of that I'm not
ashamed of that and I want to continue
to give younger black women this
reminder that if it takes a lot of time
that doesn't reflect on your value it
doesn't reflect on your worth it doesn't
reflect on the possibility of you still
getting where you need to go just let
time be time and you do you and you do
you okay tell me about this dress cuz
it's a dress this is a dress right here
um I'm really really happy that I got to
wear something that reflects me I'm
sparkly on the inside and um I just want
to shine tonight and I want to be in the
moment and just feel everything around
me Coco you always shine whenever you
shine thank you so much all right I'm
going to ask you a couple I'm going to
ask I'm going to name a couple of song
titles you tell me whether there is a
Taylor Swift song or a candle scent okay
or a candle scent okay okay sure ready
with this first one how about this one
endless weekend that's a candle scent
damn it you're good okay hold on let's I
got another one for you how about this
one Afterglow
that's a Taylor Swift song okay hold on
okay you're on fire right now how about
Wildest Dreams Taylor Swifts okay how
about thousand wishes candle Cent you
cannot fool Coco let's do a song
together
babe hello to you hello to you I am a
little nervous if I am if I'm being
honest because there is a legend
standing in front of me right now where
really can I see I I just had to be
honest okay listen I heard part of the
song the other day I didn't get the
whole thing they would give me the whole
thing but it it made me feel so good it
is quintessential Billy Joel Piano Man
Brilliance why now since you haven't
released a song for us since
2007 basically cuz it all came together
very recently and uh I've resisted it
for a long time and